the basic concepts on SEO Google tag
manager Google ads social media
marketing Facebook ads YouTube Instagram
and Twitter marketing content marketing
email marketing affiliate marketing
marketing hacks digital marketing skills
careers and much more for this video we
have our experts Rob and Rahul taking us
through all the topics so without
further Ado let's start by talking about
digital marketing before we begin make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn
meet Joey a digital marketer he works as
the head of digital marketing for Amazon
but how did Joey get here a few years
ago Joey began to see a large number of
opportunities popping up in the field of
digital marketing to begin his entry
into the field he needed to understand
what exactly digital marketing was and
what was so great about it first Joey
learned that digital marketing was a
form of marketing through which you
could advertise to people digitally
digital marketing leveraged different
channels like search engines websites
social media platforms emails and mobile
applications it would give marketers the
opportunity to interact with and
understand their audience better and to
increase the trust in their Grant
digital marketing would also show
marketers advertisements to People based
on their actions and preferences on the
internet while being less expensive than
traditional forms of advertising after
understanding the main concepts of
digital marketing Joey realized there
was more to digital marketing than he
initially thought there are also many
types of digital marketing types like
content marketing search engine
optimization pay-per-click social media
marketing email marketing and affiliate
marketing and once he understood those
types he set up a digital marketing
campaign for his uncle's e-commerce
website let's have a look at what he
came up with first Joey created content
like blogs videos infographics and case
studies so that he could generate
audience interest in the Brand's
products or services
this was content marketing next he
needed his audience to actually see his
content the first step was to create
content on specific Search keywords that
were relevant to the target audience
Joey would make optimizations on the
website and have credible websites
linking back to the content and lo and
behold the website began ranking on the
first page of the search results by
continuous optimizations Joey would
continue to improve the ranking and
ultimately make the website rank at the
first position this was SEO or search
engine optimization and Joey could do
all of this without spending a single
penny he could also Drive traffic to the
website with advertisements but for this
he would have to pay a certain fee each
time the ads were clicked he could have
text ads that show up in search engine
results image ads and video ads that
show up in websites and much more
this was possible with the help of PPC
or pay-per-click however Joey wasn't
done yet to reach a larger audience he
needed to tap into social media
platforms
he would use social media platforms like
LinkedIn YouTube Facebook and Instagram
to advertise the Brand's content he
would use these platforms to advertise
the Brand's products or services with
posts images videos and more to bring
out the Brand's story and engage with
the Brand's audience who spend a lot of
time on social media like PBC he could
use the platform to advertise the
Brand's products or services with text
image and video ads which needed to be
paid for that's social media marketing
Joey realized that a large amount of the
audience weren't visiting the Brand's
website a second time he needed to keep
them engaged nurture them to make sure
they purchased the product for this he
would send them emails that help them
better understand the products they
visited on the website and assist them
in the buying process he would also send
emails to advertisers products or
services to potential customers that is
with email marketing and finally
although Joey was able to grow the
Brand's funnel he wanted more traffic
from third-party websites this could be
achieved with affiliate marketing
Affiliates would promote the brand or
product to their audiences for a fee
with the help of email signups
registrations conversions subscriptions
Etc
after setting all of this up Joey had
the hardest part of the process to get
through the wait
although Joey had worked really hard on
each of these forms of digital marketing
he only had moderate success that's when
Joey realized he had to gain more
knowledge and experience so he decided
to get certified and get ahead in his
career with the help of Simply learn he
took up simply learns digital marketing
certification and got the skills and
training he needed to become an expert
digital marketer and now you know where
he is you too can do the same and grow
in your career by clicking on the top
right corner and with that we've given
you an introduction to all the major
concepts of digital marketing greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders and today
we're going to talk about what is
digital marketing so thanks for joining
us here at simply learn and let's get
started let's start talking about why
digital marketing is important so let's
start there on the Y so if we're just a
fly on the wall and we're in an office
environment we're looking at two friends
having a conversation about digital
marketing so so really if we're
listening in everybody every marketer is
using digital marketing for his or her
business now does your marketing has
become more popular than traditional
marketing that's not a surprise so in
response hey over the past few decades
digital marketing has evolved at a rapid
Pace these days a lot of people spend
most their time on the internet so what
happens in the internet every 60 seconds
well a lot happens every 60 seconds so
according to Social Media today I mean
there's a lot of snaps there's a lot of
clicks there's a lot of text there's a
lot of videos watched there's a lot of
pictures being taken there's a lot of
voice activated activity going on a lot
of tweets emails swipes there's a lot
going on here in 60 seconds so there's a
lot of activity on the internet a lot
and and so the one gentleman says hey
can you also mention a few differences
between digital and traditional
marketing systems and then the expert
responds of course I can certainly
clarify a few differences between
digital and traditional and so he goes
on to say what the differences are
between traditional and digital and
let's look at that okay so on
traditional marketing we're talking
about print radio billboard newspaper TV
anything that's not on your mobile or
laptop so we know what traditional
marketing reaches limited with digital
marketing reaches maximum and what we
mean by that is hey when you print
something you're printed it for x amount
of people if you're trying to promote an
event and you basically create a
thousand Flyers okay you figure that's
going to a thousand people maybe it'll
share it so you're looking about 2 000
people maybe just to be generous well
digital marketing we're promoting that
we can promote it to a whole lot of
people depending on the platform so 2000
is nothing when you're targeting an
audience on Facebook or Google search
traditional marketing non-versatile and
with digital marketing very versatile so
again going back to our flyer printing
an eight and a half by eleven okay
that's it you know with with digital
marketing running display banners you
have 468 by 60 200 by 200 250 by 250 300
by 300 I mean the list goes on on the
types of different display sizes not to
mention text ads not to mention video or
multimedia so there's a lot you can do
to get your message out there okay with
traditional it's always delayed
communication okay so meaning if you're
trying to get that TV spot there might
not be a spot open until one in the
morning okay well with digital marketing
there is no hours okay you can certainly
get your point out there and have people
see it instantaneously so with
traditional marketing there's a lack of
real-time results I mean this seems like
uh it's obvious but you know digital
marketing that's one of the biggest
benefits instant real-time results
instant okay nowadays we're going to
analytics you can look at real time
reporting okay so we could see real time
results okay traditional marketing can
be very costly I mean if you're not only
doing postcards and printing postcards
but you have to mail those postcards so
there's postage fees we're with digital
marketing it's very very very cost
efficient I mean meaning you could pick
and choose who you want to Target one
you want to Target where you want to
Target what you want to Target and if
you're doing search you can put your
bidding in place you can put your hours
in place you can really control how much
you actually spend so that to me is one
of the biggest advantages to digital
marketing not only do you get real-time
results but but you can control costs
and then obviously optimize based on the
amount of cost you're spending based on
those real-time results okay with
traditional marketing it's difficult to
reach a target audience you know with
digital marketing it's easy to reach a
target audience I mean you know I don't
want to bash traditional marketing too
much I mean if you're going to put a TV
ad in place you know you're going to do
it on a TV show that tends to gear more
towards your target audience but that
doesn't guarantee anything here we can
simply go to Facebook or Twitter or
LinkedIn and just pick and choose
specifically who we want to Target when
we want to Target them so it just
becomes a lot easier to reach a targeted
audience on a digital marketing platform
and then with traditional marketing poor
campaign measurement with digital you
have easy to measure optimize campaigns
and what we really mean by that is
because you get instant time results
because you can control costs because
you can reach your target audience more
easily all those a result of okay you
can measure and optimize based on what
our audience is seeing and how much
they're spending to see it we can
quickly make adjustments in order to
optimize the campaign for better
performance so that's generally that
means that's a culmination of pretty
much everything that we've listed as a
benefit for digital marketing okay so
now why digital marketing has been
answered with all the benefits that it
carries let's talk about the what is
digital marketing so you know that you
know you want to do digital marketing so
how do we go about that what what is it
exactly well let's just Define it
digital marketing it's just the act of
promoting a company's product or an
individual's product or service with the
help of a device or technology and so
obviously when we talk about device
we're talking about maybe a laptop we're
talking about a mobile device and we
talk about technology it could be an app
it could be you know a cloud-based
platform okay it could be a piece of
software okay so a lot going on on the
digital side in terms of variations and
what you can do but that's in a nutshell
what digital marketing is you're really
just using technology to promote your
product or service so we know because of
the benefits in digital marketing you
can promote your campaign on different
platforms okay so all those benefits we
mentioned about instant real-time
results cost efficiency optimizing
campaigns you could do that on search
you could do it on social via email on
mobile apps Etc so that's what we mean
by with the help of digital advisors in
technology well these digital devices
and Technology come in the form of
search engines and emails and mobile
apps Etc so when we want to go and
promote our product or service using a
campaign we have different options so
there are different types of digital
marketing channels that we can choose
from and what's Cisco through that list
of digital marketing channels and the
first one is what I consider the king of
them all and that's SEO so SEO stands
for search engine optimization there's
search engine marketing there's email
marketing affiliate marketing social
content mobile and then we can get into
subsets of each of these digital
marketing channels but really we'll
start with SEO because that's the king
and to me that's basically increasing
the quality and quantity of relevant
organic traffic on the search engines
including Google so depending on where
you're located in the US market Google
tends more has a large market share so
you want your pages on your website to
be found and clicked on organically and
so that means that somebody types in a
keyword you want that relevant page to
show up first on Google so somebody can
click on that link okay and we know that
millions of people specifically in the
US but we're why do you search on a
daily basis so if you're ranking for
those relevant keywords you can imagine
how much traffic you can get okay so
that's SEO okay and here's an example so
you type in online shopping well you can
see the first listing here is a paid
search ad I'm going to get to that in a
minute the second organically is Amazon
okay so online shopping you think maybe
Walmart you think maybe Alibaba or
you're thinking probably Amazon okay so
no surprise Amazon's ranking for the
keyword online shopping and so if
somebody clicked on their listing that's
traffic for Amazon let's move on to
search engine marketing you know known
as sem or pay per click or cost per
click or PPC or CPC or sponsored search
or Google ads I mean there's a lot of
different names synonymous with sem so
search engine marketing is really just
using paid ads on search engines just as
we saw the previous example if you want
to be found for keyword you don't have
to worry about organic if you're willing
to pay for it you just bid on that
keyword and voila you have the
opportunity to appear number one in the
search results at the top of the page
for that keyword now when somebody
clicks on it you have to pay Google if
it's Google you're advertising on but
that's the beauty of search engine
marketing you can bid on keywords and
appear at the top of the search results
for that keyword example here if we go
back to online shopping well myus.com is
bidding on that keyword online shopping
so they're actually appearing above
Amazon's organic listing but that's what
they want to do they want to be found
for that keyword so if they're not
ranking for it organically well they're
bidding on it and if somebody happened
to clicked on that listing then and
myus.com is going to pay Google
something depending on what the cost per
click is and so that could be anywhere
from one penny to a hundred dollars it
depends depends on the keyword depends
on who else is bidding on the keyword
depends on the location depends on the
time of day depends on quality score
there's a lot of factors involved and
regarding what you pay however the
benefit of sem is visibility and getting
traffic to your website for keywords
you're not found for so that's why sem's
such a popular choice for a lot of
companies okay let's talk about digital
marketing that's it traditional type of
digital marketing channel it's been
around a long time you know we all send
emails on a daily basis and we probably
all receive emails on a daily basis this
is an effective way to capture leads and
convert them to customers because with
email you can personalize your emails
and you can send your emails to a
segmented audience okay so if you have
emails from females who are 35 years of
age to 44 that live and say this
southern part of the United States you
can segment that send them an email and
cater that email directly to that
audience and of course you can put some
nice call to action in there you can
design it really snazzy and you could
track it just like you can any other
digital marketing channel so email is a
very effective way to really reach a
target audience because everybody for
the most part has a functioning email
account so basically here's an example
of an email that could go out if you're
selling a product and the products
promotion is about to end well you know
get that email out to your target
audience let them know hey you have
until tonight to purchase the product
and if you purchase it you're gonna get
30 off and you can put the coupon code
right in there with a nice call to
action and you can measure how many
people click on that email go to that
web page and purchase the product using
that coupon code so that's an example of
email marketing okay we have affiliate
marketing so affiliate marketing is an
effective way for digital marketers to
basically create a sales force of people
so basically what you're doing is you're
getting Merchants to promote your
products and services and you're using
usually a third-party broker like
Commission Junction or cj.com as an
example to introduce you the the person
selling the product the merchant with
the affiliate so that affiliate could
likely be a merchant him or himself and
they can basically be a good partner of
yours by publishing your product or
service on their website so that they
can sell in order to get commissions so
it's all based on a commission so you
basically are going to use a third-party
affiliate like CJ get all these
Affiliates to work for you they're going
to promote your product or service if
they do sell your product or service
you're going to pay them a commission
that's more or less how it works with
affiliate marketing and you know with
affiliate marketing to me it's a good
way to you know really promote your
product or service and you can pick and
choose the Affiliates or the Publishers
of whom you want to work with so here's
an example of affiliate marketing at
work okay you basically see a banner
basically you can see earn up to 12
advertising fees with a trusted
e-commerce leader okay so if somebody
clicked on that purchased for example or
joined you could pay off that commission
okay let's turn our attention to social
media marketing so social media
marketing you know I wouldn't say it's
fairly new I mean if I think about it
we're in 2019 and I remember talking
about Facebook back in two thousand six
so you're talking about 13 14 15 years
of social media it's definitely evolved
over the years and but the concept
Remains the Same and involves creating
different types of content depending on
the platform okay so you could be on
Pinterest or Instagram and be dealing
with photos or you could be on Twitter
tweeting out certain characters up to a
limit okay so it really depends on the
social media platform uh that really
drives the type of content you're going
to promote but we know social media can
be effective because people use social
media I mean Facebook is one of the more
popular platforms and if you want to get
your product or service out there you
could certainly pay to have an ad on
Facebook or you could just post your
content organically okay that's the
beauty of social most of your Social
platforms like LinkedIn and Twitter and
Facebook and Pinterest and Instagram
they'll have a paid form of advertising
that you can use to promote your product
or service or you can go the organic
route and you know post content
organically in hopes of driving traffic
back to your website so with social you
do have two options here but social is
interesting because a lot of different
social media platforms out there it
really depends on your product or
service okay so an example of social
media marketing especially on Facebook
with Facebook you got mobile and desktop
and you obviously have the opportunity
to post something organically and have
that liked or commented on or shared or
you can post an ad and get that liked
commented or shared or clicked and have
people go back to your website and
fulfill the goal of what you want them
to do so moving on to content marketing
it's a Content marketing is really an
effective way of really Distributing
valuable content online and when we talk
about content marketing you know we're
talking about different types of assets
so it could be simply text in the form
of a blog post or it could be a video or
it could be an infographic or it could
be an image okay there are lots of ways
to create content these days especially
in digital marketing and the great thing
about content marketing is you're
writing content for a targeted audience
so if you're trying to Target an
audience on say Instagram then you know
who your audience is and you know what
the type of content you're going to post
on there so it could be in the form of a
video or infographic or just a graphic
and so that's the beauty of content
marketing really putting yourself out
there and depending on the platform
putting yourself out there with various
types of content so for example if we
look at YouTube you can see this video
here about digital marketing certified
associate well hey you don't need to
always write the content you can produce
the content in the form of a video and
post it on YouTube this is a form of
content marketing so that's content
marketing and then let's talk about
mobile marketing so content marketing
again different types but if we go now
to mobile marketing you can kind of
segue from content to mobile because the
only difference here is with mobile it's
strictly on mobile phone it's not
desktop so mobile marketing is really a
strategy on its own that helps you the
company promoting your product or
service to reach your target audience
through a mobile device and that
includes tablets and how you could do
that is via messaging you could do it
via email or you could be do it via an
app okay so you have different ways of
getting your content out there to people
okay so as an example you can use base
basically SMS or instant messaging via
mobile devices to promote your product
or service here's another example of a
mobile marketing via app install and so
you can even compound that by running a
say Google ad as an example and running
your Google ad on say just mobile you
could do a bit adjustment just for
mobile and the goal could be app
installs okay so and you can even do a
mobile or app extension so there's lots
of ways to really promote your app or
your product or your service Via mobile
marketing okay let's talk about the
customer life cycle so we know why we
want to do digital marketing we want to
know we want we know what the digital
marketing channels are because we just
talked about them from SEO to social to
affiliate to mobile the content to sem
okay you have a lot of different digital
marketing channels at your disposal so
now how do we go ahead and approach our
customers so that's what we're going to
talk about first so we're going to talk
about different stages of the customer
life cycle okay and the first one is the
awareness stage so we need to get our
customers aware of what we're selling or
what we're promoting okay so the
awareness stage is really what product
does your brand offer that's a question
we want to get out there and we want to
answer okay what does a customer need
your product or excuse me why does a
customer need your product that's a
question we want to answer with digital
marketing okay what solution does your
product provide okay that's an answer to
a question we want to make sure people
understand so these are questions that
we want to be able to answer in the form
of digital marketing whether that be
mobile or content okay so getting our
information out there that answers these
essential questions and if we could do
that then somebody's going to become
aware of our our product or service okay
so what product does our brand offer why
does a customer need it and what
solution does it provide okay those are
some key questions that people tend to
ask themselves when they look at a brand
okay and when they look at a product hey
do I really need this is it going to
help me in my life okay and who who is
selling this I mean who is this brand I
mean that's those are just things that
run through people's mind intuitively
that with the right messaging the right
channel the right type of asset the
right targeted audience you can quickly
make somebody aware of your Brand's
product or service in this stage it's
help potential customers discover your
brand with the help of these different
marketing channels so in the awareness
stage you know content is key so it's to
me if we have a website we need a Blog
because if somebody does come to our
blog from say organic search SEO then we
can write about that product service via
blog and talk to our customer talk
directly to our targeted audience
through that blog and if we're not
ranking organically we can use paid
search to promote it because paid search
on Google for example basically we can
be right at the top of the search
results and so somebody can actually see
it when they do a search because we know
millions of people you search on a daily
basis you could do social media
marketing okay so you can publish that
product or service on Facebook why
you're building your community and you
can use affiliate marketing to help get
the word out by using cj.com as an
example build up a sales force of people
these Publishers that are going to put
your product or service out there so to
me in the awareness stage these are the
digital marketing channels you can focus
on now I will say one thing about
display ads display is part of search
engine marketing you could use display
because you can reach a large number of
people so even though it's listed here
low priority in the awareness stage
display ADS mean that if you're on
Google's Display Network you could pick
and choose your sites your demographics
keywords topics and audience you can
focus on all those different
demographics to really attract a large
number of people so low priority but
it's probably also good to focus on in
the awareness stage okay so content
marketing you must create a high quality
content that people are searching for
without content it's hard to get found
and so to me this is you know where the
blog comes in SEO take that content get
it optimized okay sem if we're not
ranking organically we can make sure
we're at the top of the paid search
results or the the search results for a
particular keyword we want to be found
for and then social media marketing
using different channels depending on
the channel for sale selling you know
training like simply learn does you know
LinkedIn is a good platform for us okay
and then affiliate you know basically
building up a nice network of Publishers
to get the word out so these are all
good channels that we can focus in on so
traffic sources may include paid unpaid
social referral display email or direct
so they they could come in the awareness
stage from all different types of
channels even though you're focused on
content I mean you could still get
traffic from mobile or email so now that
we got the word out via all these
different marketing channels there's
that consideration stage so you know
people are aware of us now they're
considering us and that's kind of the
next stage in the process okay so a few
essential questions to address on the
consideration stage hey what features
make your product valuable to others and
how will I increase customer engagement
towards my product so those are answers
to questions you want to ask okay what
features make your product valuable you
want to basically separate yourself from
the competition basically that's what
you're trying to answer okay so if
you're promoting your product or service
on paid search and other people are
bidding on the same keyword how are you
going to stand out and then how will I
increase customer engagement towards my
product so for example if you're on
Facebook okay and you're trying to get
people over to your site to purchase
your product then how are you going to
improve that engagement you got to
create something really snazzy or really
it's going to be attention grabbing or
something that's going to get them to
become aware of it that's going to
separate your post from all the other
posts that are in somebody's Facebook
news feed okay so you really have to
work hard to really convince somebody to
get their consideration towards your
product or service so in this stage your
customer considers your product so help
them understand how your product is
valuable okay to me email works really
good here because if you have a targeted
audience this gives you the opportunity
to really answer these questions in that
particular Channel email you can support
that with a promotion and display I
think display is a good option here too
because even though you know people are
trying to become aware you know you can
really hone in and really get them to
take that next step okay with display
you can even do remarketing so if
somebody's been to your site because
they're aware of your product they're
curious you can cookie them and remark
it to them via display so display to me
is a good a good channel to use here
okay so you have email mobile display
you know sem these are all you know good
channels to use on the consideration
stage especially on search because
somebody's looking for something and
they're aware of your brand then you
have the good opportunity to get them to
click on your ad especially if you're
offering them motion and get them to
convert the goal here is to increase our
engagement so people are aware we're
moving them further along the funnel
with email marketing we have the
opportunity to promote the product by
sending an email directly to our
audience so with this stage plan your
campaigns around welcoming emails
newsletters we can talk about product
descriptions add ratings and reviews in
the email you know we really just want
to encourage people to purchase the
product that's we're trying to sway them
over so email is a good source to allow
us to do that okay so with mobile
marketing we can promote the products by
setting relevant messages to our target
audience display again retargeting
because we can retarget an audience that
has been to our website I already did
some research about our brand our
product or service and now we're going
to reach back out to them to sway them
so remember we want to encourage
customers to buy a product by creating
detailed articles about the product that
always helps and that's content okay we
want to opt for a customer testimonial
okay that helps sway people and add some
guest blogging okay we can have
ambassadors blog on our behalf or we can
go out and blog on somebody else's site
okay so blogging works both ways it's
ways of of showing yourself and telling
people hey we know you're looking for
this product here's why you want to
choose us okay moving on from the
consideration to the purchase stage so
they're aware of you they're considering
you and now we're on to the purchase
stage so the questions we want to really
make sure we address here are how are my
prices compared to my competitors and is
my brand more credible than others okay
so they're considering you but that
price point and it may not even be the
price it could be the shipping for
example the price could be good but the
shipping cost could be high so you
really want to do some due diligence and
research on what your competitors are
doing credibility that goes back to the
consideration stage and testimonials you
want to make sure you have reviews and
testimonials to really Elevate what
you're trying to tell customers and that
that is hey I have a good brand I have a
good product I have a good service come
buy my stuff come by my product and
service but you really need to support
that claim you just can't go out and say
it and so supporting that comes in the
form of what other people say and that
can be reviews that could be comments on
a social media platform it could be you
know stars on say Yelp or Google my
business you know make sure you do your
due diligence and make sure you get
people to you know review you or provide
testimonials because people are going to
do their due diligence before they
purchase especially if it's on Google my
business or Yelp or TripAdvisor or
whatever it is you're trying to sell
they're going to be able to see those
reviews and so do your due diligence to
get the reviews and if it is a negative
review hey that's okay you can't please
everyone you're gonna get them that's
the world we live in just make sure you
show your upper hand and respond even to
the negative as well as the positive
reviews that you get that actually bodes
well to some people because hey it shows
that I made a mistake and you're willing
to correct it and so people actually see
that that could be the Tipping Point to
getting them to purchase say look hey
this brand really cares because they're
really responding to people they're not
ignoring negativity okay just those
small things that can get people to
change their mind now with the purchase
stage according to e-consultancy 83 of
the online audience require
encouragement to complete a purchase
encouragement what does that mean well
it could mean provide providing a promo
giving them that extra incentive you
know if you don't offer promo consider
it especially on the email and the
example we looked at earlier sending out
an email means that if the promo is
going to end at midnight send that email
out and tell people they have until
midnight and if they purchase today
you'll even increase it to 20 percent
and email is a good channel for that
mobile can reach a lot of people through
sms okay social media reaching people
instantaneously and then you know really
with the purchase stage it gets
prospects an offer to help them make
that purchase so you have plenty of
channels to choose from in fact most of
these channels the only one really that
doesn't fit the instantaneous mode is
SEO but you can really focus on
affiliate even though that's a little
priority here you can really you know
coordinate with your Publishers who
especially those Publishers that have
proven their worth and have sold your
products in the past you get get them to
help promote it and incentivize Their
audience so let's move on from the
purchase to the purse post purchase
stage so this is after somebody
purchases
okay so some essential questions we want
to be able to address here so what
additional product could my customer buy
now that they're my customer what else
could I sell them what you know without
being too pushy could if they buy a coat
well a hat work or a pair of gloves or
you know blouse you know you want to be
able to you know push a product on your
customer but think about how you can
complement that purchases that
purchasers or customers products and
then how to improve the customer buying
experience so again this goes back to
you know what we just said about reviews
get somebody to offer a review and if
they don't give you a full complement of
five stars they only give you three and
a half stars then you know what that's
great feedback because then you can
learn from that and then the other
question is will the customer refer us
to others and if so why so that's
definitely something you want to be able
to address in the post purchasing so
let's take a look here so with post
purchasing stage you know to me emails
at the top of this list because if
somebody purchases something you can
send a nice thank you email because if
they purchase they're giving you their
email in return because you're likely
going to be sending them the receipt via
email so email to me is a nice Channel
you can send out a nice message even you
know social media you know you can thank
your community for supporting you on
this recent campaign that you ran you
know even throw in an extra five or ten
percent on a future purchase as a thank
you and that's easily done on social
media you know you could even post a
blog you know promoting you know the
success of a product and then offering a
promotion okay so there's a lot of
things you could be doing here on the
post purchasing stage so to me even
looking at content again you could even
you know put a survey together you could
even put a survey together for your
Affiliates okay you could even post a
poll on Facebook so it's just working in
with these different channels to get
some feedback about your product and
service so with email mobile you can
engage customers with follow-up emails
or customer care content you know with
mobile if you have somebody's mobile
number hey text them a simple thank you
goes a long way you know you could say
hey look if you're satisfied let us know
give us a call you can even in the ee
mobile text message you can put a link
to a survey send emails to active
subscribers give rewards for customer
feedback so if somebody does provide
feedback give them an extra 10 off you
know you want to be able to reward
loyalty loyalty comes in the form of a
partnership if you're giving somebody
discounts and you have a good product or
service then they're going to recognize
that they're going to say hey look I
really like this product and they're
giving me 10 I'm going to go ahead and
purchase from these guys again so get
those discounts those active customers
or on the affiliate Network get referral
opportunities to your customers so if
it's an affiliate publisher hey if
they're getting people to your site you
know reward them or if it's an email and
you put a four to a friend get an extra
10 off it doesn't hurt because you're
incentivizing people to help you sell
your product so with social display and
content use those banner ads or use that
content that you display on social or
the blog you're gonna write to give
customers advice in order to maximize is
the value of the purchase so again you
can use these platforms to also enhance
what they purchased so hey you just
purchased this product thank you very
much did you know you could do this this
and this with it and so that's the idea
of a post-purchase stage is to maximize
these channels to be able to answer
those essential questions about what
else could they purchase you know do
they like how do I get these people to
become loyal customers okay so with the
first purchase stage if a customer has
bought a pair of sports shoes for
example running shoes you can recommend
cross product sale across sale it could
be a pair of shorts or a water bottle or
an accessory with an exclusive discount
so that's another example what you can
do on the post purchase date greetings
everyone this is Rob Sanders from Simply
learn happy New Year and today we're
going to talk about digital marketing
skills
so digital marketing allows business
owners regardless of the business
non-profit for-profit large or small
National local International to really
expand their business allows them to
personalize their content they could
save money and most importantly they can
measure the results and so that's what
we're going to focus on today when we
talk about digital marketing skills
focusing on measuring those results so
suppose anybody wants to work in
marketing or grow a company or help grow
an individuals company or ensure to keep
up with the appropriate skills this is
what we're going to cover today so we're
going to cover a few channels and so
let's get right to it today we're going
to start off with search engine
optimization or SEO
also known as organic search so SEO is
an interesting channel it's probably the
premier channel for most companies in
fact HubSpot confirms that 57 of B2B
marketers stated that SEO generates more
leads than any other marketing
initiative
so it's really important for not only
just generating traffic but it's also
important for generating leads and and
generating more business
including e-commerce and so what does
SEO entail and what skills should you
acquire in order to manage SEO as a
marketing channel
well if you think about it SEO is really
divvied up into two pies one pie is
called on page the other pie is called
off Pitch and so on page consists of
things you can do to the website to help
you
be found in organic search
so what are those things well it could
be anything from you know page load
speed to four or four errors to sitemaps
and so the point here is if you're going
to manage SEO and you know that you got
to make sure your website's in Tip-Top
shape or your clients websites and good
enough shape for Google to recognize it
as a legitimate site you have to have
some technical skills now I'm not saying
you have to be developer but at the same
time you have to know what a 4-4 error
is you know have to know where and how
to generate a site map and upload that
sitemap you need to know how to edit a
robot's text file so those are you know
what I call soft technical skills but
they're all valid for SEO so you have to
have some technical background staying
in the on page pie
okay you need to make sure you have not
only skills to write content but skills
to optimize content so you need to be
aware of all the different elements on a
page in order to optimize that page
so again that entails you know some
copywriting skills but more importantly
and probably more challenging is to take
those copywriting skills and enhance
them for SEO okay so making sure that
you're able to understand what it is
that you need to do to get a page
optimized so it can rank higher in these
search engine results
so those are on page skills
and then you got the other piece of the
pie which is off page so understanding
you know what it takes to make sure your
site is relevant so it's understanding
different metrics off page metrics like
page Authority domain Authority external
links internal links and so generally
most SEO managers have a third-party SEO
platform that they work with like
semrush or Moz so it's understanding how
to work with those platforms to measure
off-page results so we always say that
SEO as a digital marketing channel is an
800 pound gorilla well it is because you
have on page and off page to worry about
so the two of those together
you know is is quite a task in order to
rank
and so what brings SEO and all digital
marketing channels is understanding the
metrics and understanding what you're
seeing in order to measure results and
improve upon those results okay so
that's really the theme for all these
digital marketing channels we're going
to talk about today it's really about
okay what metrics and how do I measure
the results and so when we look at SEO
in terms of measuring results
on the on page side okay you're gonna
have to do some keyword analysis you're
gonna have to understand okay what
volume is you're going to understand how
to get the competition numbers okay and
you're going to have to understand what
keywords to choose okay so that in
itself is a skill being able to choose
keywords based on several metrics then
you're going to have to be able to
ascertain you know what pages and what
keywords are driving traffic and how
those pages are performing
okay and then again the off page you got
different metrics like domain Authority
or page Authority
we have external links internal links
you have no follow and follows and and
you allow these little metrics related
to off Pages yes you're gonna have to
understand what those metrics mean and
if you can understand what those metrics
mean and then more importantly act on
those metrics then that's what's going
to help you improve your results in
terms of SEO so again that's going to be
the common theme here so I'm just going
to highlight again those metrics that
you're going to need to understand in
order to better manage seo's a channel
get on the on-page side you need to
understand the technicalities involved
but for example page load what's a good
page load time what's a bad page load
time from a keyword perspective what's
good volume what's bad volume what's
good competition what's bad competition
so if you can understand the intricacies
of the measurements related to SEO then
that'll help you improve upon this big
Channel called organic search so SEO is
the practice of getting relevant traffic
to the website okay from organic search
results so it really is essential to
stay up to date
and have a complete knowledge of the
latest algorithm updates and factors
that affect search engine ranking
so that's SEO let's transition to search
engine marketing also known as paid
search sponsored search Google ads Bing
ads pay-per-click cost per click a lot
of acronyms a lot of ways to describe it
at the end of the day search engine
marketing means that hey you as an
Advertiser have the ability and have the
opportunity to rank at the very top of
the Google search results
now it's different than SEO because
you're actually paying for the placement
and so to be found at the top of the
search engine results
as a paid placement or sponsored ad
means that if somebody clicks on your ad
you're gonna pay Google X amount okay so
unlike SEO sem is very fast moving
and so when we talk about fast moving we
mean that you're collecting a lot of
data very quickly so sticking with the
theme of what skills should I have for
search engine marketing well if you're
going to collect data then that means
you need to measure the results of that
data and so sticking with our theme of
measuring results you need to understand
first and foremost what all the
different metrics mean related to
Central engine marketing okay so I'm
just gonna rattle off if you will a few
of the metrics but the commonality here
is
yes you can learn what those metrics
mean but you have to act on those
metrics so one of the the main metrics
involved with search engine marketing is
Impressions so impression is just
basically how many people have seen your
ad okay so if your ad shows up on the
search results page regardless of
whether somebody clicks on it or not
you're going to get an impression okay
so if you're getting a lot of
Impressions that means a lot of people
have seen your ad what's a lot of
impressions well it's objective okay so
it could be a thousand Impressions or
ten thousand Impressions at the end of
the day that's how many people have seen
your ad
now more importantly
you have another metric called clicks
clicks means how many people actually
saw your ad and then clicked on your ad
okay so if you have 100 people that have
seen your ad and one person who clicked
on your ad then you have a click through
rate of one percent
now when it comes to Google ads and
search engine Marketing in general you
want to have a high click-through rate
especially on Google because that does
impact quality score so quality score is
another metric you need to be aware of
okay it's a quality score simply a
number between 1 and 10 that's assigned
to each keyword okay so what impacts
quality score click-through rate is one
of the factors that impact quality score
so if you have
200 or 300 or 500 or a thousand
Impressions and very little clicks that
means your click the rate is going to be
low and if your click-through rate it's
going to be low then your quality score
is going to be low
and in order to pay less to Google you
need to make sure that your quality
score is good so you need to understand
the factors involve a quality score you
need to understand Impressions clicks
click-through rate because if you don't
have a good click-through rate
then how do you improve that so it's
about measuring the results and acting
upon the results those are the skills
involved with search engine marketing
and that's just on the click side you
got the conversion side of the house so
you need to be able to understand how to
get conversions
and how to maintain a high conversion
rate so for example if you have a
hundred clicks and only one conversion
that is a one percent conversion rate
okay fair enough but what are you paying
per conversion what's the cost per
conversion okay and if that number is
high like say twenty dollars and you're
only selling a product that's say ten
dollars well then you got a problem and
so there's a lot of different metrics
involved with search engine marketing
you're collecting this data very quickly
so you need to be able to react to the
data that you see so that's the skill
set really involves search engine
marketing if you're getting the data if
it's a low click-through rate or low
conversion rate or high cost per
conversion
or very low Impressions you need to be
able to understand how to react to what
you're seeing and what your data you're
collecting that to me is the primary
skill bottom line with search engine
marketing and there are other skill sets
involved don't get me wrong I mean it's
nice to be able to write copy because
with search engine marketing
typically the ads have very few
characters involved so you need to be
able to write a compelling ad to
convince somebody to click on your ad
and so writing coffee being able to
understand your target audience
um those are all things involved with
managing search engine marketing but
really the key component here is again
measuring the results okay let's switch
over to a traditional marketing channel
email marketing you know one of my
favorites you know listen we're all
bombarded with emails
uh and you know what it's it becomes
cumbersome at times I mean it's easy to
just just regard an email and so to me
the key here if you're going to do email
marketing
you need to have a certain set of skill
sets and so what that skill set is is
really understanding your audience
because if you send an email to a
certain set of recipients
you need to hope that that email is
relevant to that audience okay so you
need to be able to really identify who
it is we're sending this email to
and a recent study done by statista
stated that 49 of consumers really like
to receive promotional emails from their
favorite Brands so if you have a very
strong brand then email marketing is
probably a good channel for you if you
don't have a strong brand or nobody
really knows about your brand or your
product or your business then email
marketing could be a little bit of a
steeper Hill to climb if you will but
really email marketing is it involves
emails that promote the brands products
and services and if you could Target the
Right audience or making sure you have
the Right audience then you got a good
chance of having successful email
marketing campaigns
but when it comes to emails
you know it's like having a blank canvas
you can be as creative as you want as
long as you're talking to the audience
so the big skill set here again is
copywriting and having some you know
creativity involved with that
copyrighted saying the right things but
not saying too much at the same time
making the email aesthetically pleasing
as possible so that when somebody does
open the email they're going to be able
to react to it so you know writing copy
with strong call to action or really
relevant copy that really talks to the
audience I mean those are all keys for
email marketing in my opinion
also one thing we didn't bring up in
search engine marketing but it certainly
holds true with search engine marketing
as well as email marketing and that's a
b testing and so A B test and it's
simply taking an original and creating a
variant and testing the two to see which
one performs
well you could certainly do AV testing
with email marketing that means taking a
subject line
that has traditionally worked for you or
is relevant for that audience and then
creating
a variant or different subject line so
if I'm going to send an email to 100
people I'm going to send 50
people one subject line and then the
other 50 is going to get my variance
subject line and why is this important
because I want to be able to see what
people react to
okay so if I see the open rates higher
for the variant
versus the traditional or
the original subject line then I know
that this subject line works and
therefore I'm going to apply this
subject line moving forward and then
what am I going to do I'm going to take
it and test it against another variant
so you should always do a b testing on
subject lines so the concept of a b
testing should not be lost on any
digital marketer okay whether that be
SEO search engine marketing or email
marketing so you should have an
understanding of a b testing and of
course going back to measuring results
with email you have a different set of
metrics we already mentioned open rates
so if you send out
100 emails how many people open the
email okay you want that open rate to be
as high as possible and then when they
open the email the people click on that
CTA or any of those links in the email
okay so you want a high click-through
rate and then more importantly when they
click on a link in the email they're
gonna go to a landing page
you want that person to engage with that
landing page so what's the engagement
rate of the landing page from the email
okay so it's really important that you
have an understanding of all the
different metrics involved with email
marketing and again
how to react to that data so if you're
getting a low open rate could it be the
subject line isn't that good possibly
that's why you have to do testing if
you're getting a low click they're right
on the emails
that could be because the copy may not
be that great or the design or the call
to action or it's not compelling enough
for the recipient of the email and then
again the engagement on the landing page
if you have a low engagement rate a low
conversion rate
you got to look at that and figure out
how to improve that okay so you can
apply a B test in the landing pitch so
there are always ways to react to the
data regardless of what campaign or
regardless of what digital marketing
channel you're working in
okay so that's the commonality here one
point on email marketing is if you're
going to measure the results of the
campaign whether you're using you know
vertical response or MailChimp or you
know some other email marketing platform
you want to make sure you have what we
call a UTM tracking and if you're using
Google analytics having UTM tracking or
understanding what UTM tracking is
allows you to measure the results of
that email marketing campaign in Google
analytics so that's another skill set
you should have being able to apply you
know tracking to your digital marketing
campaigns including email
okay because if you don't it's going to
be hard to measure the results in Google
analytics so let's focus on one more
marketing channel here and that's social
media so we all know social media isn't
going anywhere it's becoming more and
more popular
in fact you know offshoot of social
media is really influencer marketing uh
you know if somebody an influencer has
millions of likes on say tick tock or
Instagram you might want to engage with
that influencer and help you promote
your brand or your product
in that really what social media is it's
a platform whether that be you know
Facebook or Twitter it's a it's a
platform to help you promote your brand
your product your services and it's a
chance for you to get to message your
user base your community prospective
clients people who don't even know about
your brand it's a chance to build
awareness so social media holds a lot of
different uh strategies if you will in
fact nearly almost 4 billion of the
world's population uses social media let
me say there's seven something billion
people in the world well that's a large
percentage a majority of the percentage
of the world uses a social media
platform okay in fact
just like SEO where you need an SEO
platform there are plenty of social
media platforms there's later there's
Sprouts social there's HootSuite there's
buffer in fact buffer confirms that 73
percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business and that's promising because
social media in my opinion
having been in this industry a while it
can be a very fickle Channel I mean if
you're trying to promote a product or
service on Facebook
and it's very very gonna be very hard to
pull that person away who's engaged with
their Facebook feed
not only just to get them away from the
Facebook feed onto your website but then
to turn around and allow that person to
try and convert
okay based on what you have on your
website so it's challenging enough just
to get them away from the social media
platform let alone converting so that's
why when I say very fickle but you know
it's someone encouraging if Buffer's
telling us that marketers believe that
social media marketing can be effective
and it can be effective you just have to
have the right strategy so to me one of
the skill sets you should have if you're
going to be a social media marketing
manager is being able to understand you
know what is the strategy here what are
we trying to achieve
when we set up a social media platform
or enact a social media campaign
okay and so that's really the first
thing it's really understanding what
platforms what's the strategy here
because if the strategy is brand
awareness then what channels or social
media platforms if you will work best
for us is that Twitter is that Facebook
so it's being able to kind of formulate
a strategy a plan if you will for social
media marketing because the last thing
you want to do as a marketer is
endlessly just post content for the sake
of just posting content
because just like any other marketing
channel you're going to have metrics and
social media is not shy on the metric
front Okay so you have reach
you have Impressions you have engagement
rate in fact every social media channel
has its own set of specific metrics
whether that be likes followers shares
uh uh reviews Stars if you will so it
really depends on the social media
platform that you're using but at the
end of the day you need to be able to
measure the results if you're posting
let's just say on Facebook
and your whole
job or strategy is to entice engagement
meaning get people to share that
particular post or act on that post then
you need to be able to measure the
engagement how many people saw the post
how many people engage with the post
okay and so just like any other
marketing channel you're collecting data
and you need to react to that data but
more importantly it's about being able
to you know put a strategy together
first
and then I would you know a skill set I
would recommend you have is
understanding all the different social
media platforms that are out there you
know I just named buffer or HootSuite or
Sprout social they're all good in their
own right but they're all going to have
different features so to me
understanding what social media platform
works best for you you want to choose a
social media platform that you know
allows you to control what posts you
schedule when you schedule them how
they're scheduled what platform they're
scheduled on
at the same time you want a social media
platform that's going to help you
understand the engagement that you're
getting from that platform
and you'll probably want a social media
platform that allows you to quote
unquote listen in if you will on what
users are you know reacting to in terms
of hashtags or what's trending on that
particular platform
okay so you want to listen until if you
will as part of that social media
platform so it's understanding what
platform you want to use when it comes
to social media marketing it's
understanding what strategy that that
platform is going to help you when they
enact okay and then it's also that
social media platform that's going to
help you understand the data so you can
react to the data
so those are all to me the skill sets
you need as a social media manager and
then
an offshoot of social media is paid
social so just like search engine
marketing you can advertise on say
Twitter LinkedIn Facebook on a cost per
click basis meaning if you're showing
your ad on LinkedIn and somebody clicks
on it you're gonna pay
for that click you're going to pay
LinkedIn or you're going to pay Twitter
you're going to play Facebook so it's
understanding you know the skill sets
involved with paid socials understanding
what assets you can have when
advertising on these platforms you know
can you use video on LinkedIn or
Facebook
um you know can you use what type of
images and you know how big do those
images need to be and can you have
wording on those images or what are the
guidelines involved with having images
as part of your ads
so having a full understanding of the
types of assets that you can run in
terms of your advertising on social
media is very important in my opinion
because it's always changing and you
want to be able to put the best asset
the best message you want to put your
best foot forward when advertising on
social media and of course when you do
advertise again a whole nother set of
metrics you know how many people saw
you're at how many people clicked on
your ad how many people engage with the
landing page how many people converted
what was the cost per conversion so all
of those are metrics that we covered in
search engine marketing they apply with
paid social
so you have the opportunity on paid
social you have the opportunity on
social media
to really get your message out there
it's really understanding what kind of
data you're collecting what are the
results of the ad or the post and how do
you react to that and that's really the
common theme with digital marketing
skills if you're not a big fan of
numbers you're not a big fan of excel if
you will or spreadsheets if looking at a
mountain of data scares you
well then you might want to think
otherwise when going into digital
marketing but if you want to embrace the
data
then digital marketing is really a great
career because if you can get the data
and you know how to react to the data
then you can be successful in any
campaign you run right that should do it
for today thanks for joining look
forward to reaching out to you for more
of these webinars feel free to email us
or go check out our website at
simplylearn.com thank you so much and
I'll see you soon
foreign
marketing let's have a look at some
stats related to mobile marketing
first off mobile devices are used for
over 40 percent of online transactions
next we have marketers and advertisers
put 51 percent of their budget into
Mobile ads
and finally mobile is responsible for an
average of more than 40 percent of
Revenue in leading B2B organizations so
so what is mobile marketing
mobile marketing is a digital marketing
strategy that started all the way in
1992. remember SMS is that advertise
stuff that's what mobile marketing
started off as the main objective with
mobile marketing is to advertise
products and services to a target
audience through multiple channels on
smartphones tablets and other mobile
devices
this is done through websites emails SMS
social media in-app notifications and
other applications
so here are key concepts related to
mobile marketing first we have focusing
on the customer and personalized
marketing in mobile marketing the
primary focus is on the customer want
them to increase brand loyalty give
customers special offers or show them
personalized ads based on their location
and purchase history
basically by focusing on the customer it
gives them the feeling that the brand is
directly interacting with them and as a
result their loyalty towards the brand
greatly increases
next we have identifying Trends with
data by leveraging data different Trends
can be identified from there you can
create customer profiles and then with
predictive and behavior analysis you get
an understanding of what will better
grab the attention of a customer
then we have testing
testing provides insights and learnings
that would be extremely important to the
success of the campaign for example say
you do an A B test with that you'll get
the optimal variant of the two as well
as further understanding of what works
and what isn't
and finally understanding mobile
analytics having some experience with
mobile analytics with some of the
metrics that need to be focused on like
engagement ratio cost per install and
average revenue per user are very
important for mobile marketing
experience with mobile analytics tools
can also help with insights that would
help future decisions and experiments
so if you're interested in getting
certified in mobile marketing you have
options like mobile app marketing 2020
ASO advertising and monetization by
udemy and you also have digital
marketing specialist certification by
simply learn
now let's go to number nine CRM or
customer relationship management
here are some interesting stats
it is stated that towards the end of
2019 86 percent of customers are willing
to pay 25 percent more for better
customer experience
also CRA marketing will be worth 73
billion dollars in 2020.
finally businesses that leverage CRM
software see sales increase by 29 sales
productivity increased by 34 and sales
forecast accuracy increased by 42
percent
now that we have looked into these stats
let's understand what CRM is all about
CRM is a technology with which an
organization's relationships and
interactions with existing or potential
customers are managed
it's basically a ction of strategies
tools and Technologies and crms aim to
develop new customer relationships
retain them or acquire new ones
along with that it also helps companies
with sales marketing and service
management
crm's mainly store data like purchase
history personal information and
purchasing patterns
areas to focus in CRM
first we have data analytics crms
provide a number of different metrics
that can be analyzed and whose results
can be incorporated into forthcoming
campaigns now although what metric you
focus on entirely depends on your
requirements here are some of the
commonly used metrics
this customer shown which is basically
customer attrition there's NPS which is
a measure of how satisfied your
customers are less customer retention
cost and first Contact resolution rate
which is the percentage of customers
support tickets that get resolved at the
first short
next understanding how different CRM
tools work
there are loads of options to choose
from when it comes to crms best
Salesforce HubSpot CRM Zoho CRM
Microsoft Dynamics and much more
it is really important to have
experienced at least the most commonly
used ones since each of them have their
own nuances advantages and disadvantages
now let's have a look at some of the
certifications
we have options like Salesforce
administrator certification training
course by simply learn Dynamics 365 by
Microsoft and finally HubSpot Academy
sales professional credential by HubSpot
so now let's go to number eight
at number eight we have designing
like usual let's have a look at some of
the stats
did you know that 32 percent of
marketers say visual images are the most
important form of content for their
business with blogging in second
well 70 of companies in Western content
marketing which could include visual
marketing strategies
so now let's take a closer look at
designing
with designing the objective is to
communicate as well as promote the
products or Services the brand is
advertising in a visually appealing
manner
designing goes hand in hand with a great
copy though
even if you had the best looking
creative in your ad it's possible it
won't catch on if the copy accompanying
it isn't good you might wonder what does
designing have to do with digital
marketing plenty actually if you have an
understanding of Designing yourself in
the scenario where graphic designers are
unable to bring your idea to life you
could do it yourself Desiring for
yourself what the content will convey
not only that you might be able to
provide some insight in the designing of
the creator for the ad
next let's have a look at Key concepts
of Designing
firstly a basic understanding of design
philosophies are necessary which means
you need to know about Concepts like
using attention grabbing and relevant
images the golden Point Rule and much
more
then there needs to be an understanding
of tools like Adobe Photoshop and after
effects
these are some of the most commonly used
tools for creating creatives and even
the basic experience with these software
could be extremely useful later on
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have certifications like graphic
design by Coursera introduction to
graphic design by LinkedIn and
fundamentals of graphic design Again by
Coursera
next at number seven we have listening
now let's talk about social listening
social listening is a method through
which a brand can learn about what
customers are saying about them and the
industry online by monitoring digital
conversations
the brand social media channels can
track analyze and respond to
conversations and feedback improving
their relationship with the users who
may become potential customers and thus
increasing loyalty of present customers
and it's a proven fact that customers
are drawn towards brands that are prompt
in response
now let's have a look at some key
Concepts understanding how different
social media platforms work how is each
platform different from the other
whereas most of your audience come from
which platform is better suited for your
content those are the questions that
need to be answered
then experience with popular social
listening tools like HubSpot and
HootSuite these platforms can help with
a number of different situations like PR
crisis respond to customer complaints
find user generated content to obtain
competitive intelligence take
suggestions and much more
next at number six we have copywriting
first let's have a look at some stats
it is stated that 64 percent of B2B
marketers Outsource their demanding copy
needs
next It also says that a compelling copy
draws 7.8 times more side traffic and
reduces brand recall which brings higher
engagement rates
now let's talk about what is copywriting
copywriting is an act of creating
promotional texts that could be
advertised in brochures notifications
Billboards emails and so on
the primary objective here is that the
written content called copy or sales
copy increases brand awareness and
Pursuits individuals to take a
particular action be it signing up to a
website by a product and so on
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of copywriting
first understanding the customers and
the competition so from the customers
several bits of Vital Information can be
obtained like what kind of writing gets
the maximum amount of Engagement what
kind they dislike and much more likewise
from the competition you can find out
what kind of writing they have success
with what they are doing better from
your brand and so on
this one goes without saying but to have
success with copywriting you need to be
well versed with grammar and have
sufficiently good writing skills
let's have a look at some certifications
now
here we have the Creator copywriter
Academy then we have the IDM award and
digital copywriting by The Institute of
data and marketing and finally we have
American Writers and artists copywriting
course
next up number five email marketing
first let's have a look at some stats
according to statista in 2019 Global
email users amounted to 3.9 Million by
2023 this is set to grow to 4.3 billion
next it also states that 81 smbs rely on
email as their primary customer
acquisition Channel and 80 for retention
next Again by statista it states that 49
of consumers would like to receive
promotional emails from their favorite
brands
so now let's have a look at email
marketing
email marketing is a method for
performing digital marketing by using
emails to promote products and services
to a highly targeted audience in a way
email marketing could nurture the
relationship with your customers or
completely drive them away
with email marketing customers can be
communicated with directly with
personalized emails helping them stay
updated with items or offers
it also serves a purpose of informing
people about your brand or keeping
existing customers engaged between
purchases
now let's have a look at Key Concepts
first we have focusing on
personalization and automation emails
can be set up in such a way that
customers are regularly sent emails on a
regular basis to keep in touch with them
inform them about new products and other
forms of Engagement
then we have complying with data privacy
rules
privacy has been the talking point for a
while now most recently the gdpr brought
about a number of restrictions that have
to be adhered to by organizations
so it's absolutely necessary that these
privacy guidelines are followed or would
you rather spend 10 million pounds
next experimenting with different kinds
of content
emails can have images gifs or videos
attached to them I each of them can
impact your customer base in a different
manner depending on their requirements
so different kinds of content need to be
experimented with to determine the one
that works best for you
and finally understanding popular tools
and metrics to be successful at email
marketing it is absolutely necessary to
be experienced with tools like HubSpot
and MailChimp
these platforms come with a number of
features like contact segmenting
autoresponders service and app
integration a b testing and much more
next up we have certifications
here we have certifications like HubSpot
Academy email marketing by HubSpot then
email and affiliate marketing Mastermind
by udemy and finally Advanced email
marketing certification training by
simply learn
so now that we have reached Midway I
have a question for you guys what do you
guys think is in the number one section
let me know in the live chat I'd like to
know what you guys think
if you enjoy watching informative Tech
videos like this one consider
subscribing to Simply lunch channel to
stay up to date on the trending
Technologies and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update in the future
now back to number four social media
marketing
before we go in let's have a look at
some stats
according to statista nearly 50 of the
world's population uses social media
73 percent of marketers believe social
media marketing has been somewhat
effective or very effective for their
business
lastly 90.4 percent of Millennials 77.5
of Generation X and 48.2 percent of baby
boomers are active social media users
so now let's have a look at Social Media
Marketing
social media marketing involves the
usage of social media platforms to build
a brand Drive traffic to your website
and increase sales
this helps marketers achieve their
marketing and branding goals by creating
and sharing content on social media
activities like text and image updates
video and other content that can drive
engagement social media marketing also
enables marketers to perform paid
advertising with this your Brand's
content like articles videos and images
are exposed to a high quality targeted
audience
next let's have a look at some key
concepts of social media marketing
first understanding how to work with
different social media platforms is
necessary
every social media platform comes with
its own kind of audience nuances
advantages and disadvantages so it's
important to have experience with them
so that the one that best suits your
requirements can be selected
next we have monetization
on YouTube which is also a social media
platform you could monetize your videos
to get some income out of them other
options include affiliate marketing
influencer marketing events and much
more then we have analytics experience
with social media marketing tools like
buffer and bassumo can help
organizations by providing anodes based
on keywords brand names links domain and
much more
among other things it also attracts
competitors and analyzes their content
to determine what they are doing better
then we have knowing your Brand's user
base and optimizing your content it's
important to understand your Brand's
user base to determine what they like
the most on your social media page and
then optimize it
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have advanced social media
certification training by simply learn
then we have social media marketing on
LinkedIn learning and finally HootSuite
social marketing certification by
HootSuite
and now for the top three number three
paper flake or PPC first let's have a
look at some stats
33 percent of people click on paid
search ad because it directly answers
their search query
it also states that paid ads have a
11.38 CTR on Google
and finally according to google
businesses make an average of two
dollars in income for every one dollar
they spend in Google ads
now let's talk about PPC
it is a form of online advertising in
which advertisers spend a certain amount
of money each time their advertisement
is clicked this process if done properly
can drive people to your website without
having to get them organically
search engine marketing is one of the
most popular methods to perform PPC
for PPC most search engines are part of
an automated process performed by the
search engine to determine how relevant
and valid they are to appear in the
search engine result page
now let's have a look at some key
concepts of PPC
first it's important how different
search engines and their advertising
works each of them have their own but
somewhat similar rules prices
restrictions and so on
then we have Google ads one of the most
popular and lucrative layers among the
search engines Google ads provides
marketers with a sizeable chunk of the
internet to advertise to
it is important to properly understand
how Google ADS works and how its many
features and functionalities can be used
efficiently
for more on Google ads why don't you
check our introductory video on it I
link it in the chat
next analytics different metrics like
CPC or cost per click clicks
click-through rate and quality score
need to be understood so that optimal
and well-informed decisions can be made
finally we have copywriting and visual
design ability as I mentioned earlier
either of these don't work without the
other which means the experience in both
these Concepts would be greatly
beneficial for the individual and the
organization
now let's have a look at some
certifications
we have Google ads certifications by
Google then Advanced pay per click PPC
certification training by simply learn
and finally we have Microsoft and
Excellence program by Microsoft
now for the top two search engine
optimization
let's first look at some stats
according to zero limit web on the first
page alone the first five organic
results account for 67.60 of all the
clicks
and according to Google where to buy
Plus near me mobile queries have grown
by over 200 percent in the past two
years
and finally according to HubSpot 57 of
B2B marketers stated that SEO generates
more leads than any other marketing
initiative
so what exactly is search engine
optimization
search engine optimization or SEO refers
to the method adopted by an organization
to grow the quality and quantity of
website traffic by making it more
visible to the users of a particular web
search engine
this is possible with the help of
organic search results SEO improves
unpaid results and doesn't count traffic
obtained from Paid ads
next let's have a look at some key
concept of SEO
technical SEO the technical side of SEO
like server side settings site Maps
server Response Code rewrites and so on
will help you take advantage of both
page level and server level optimization
to ensure they are found by search
engines this by extension helps generate
traffic and conversions
next content marketing it is important
to be well versed in content marketing
as both SEO and content marketing cannot
exist without the other
content marketing provides high quality
content and SEO provides the appropriate
keywords that would help it get noticed
by search engines
next link building
process of search engine optimization
can only be successful it is a
combination of both external link
building and internal link optimization
one builds links with credible websites
and the other performs link optimization
on your own properties and social media
platforms
now we have site usability SEO must
focus on good site usability this is an
indication of how objects are placed in
your website and if the information
provided is useful for the users
it also indicates if the site is easy to
use and navigate
then you need to have experience with
tools like Moz and Google analytics to
take appropriate inferences from the
data obtained
and finally we have Google analytics and
Google webmaster
Google analytics will help with tracking
and Reporting website traffic Google
webmaster will help track your website
search performance with the help of
Google search console and additional
resources
now let's have a look at some
certifications
here we have SEO training course by Moz
which is provided by udemy and we have
search engine optimization training
course by simply learn and finally we
have HubSpot SEO training course
provided by HubSpot
finally number one it's data analytics
data analysis is a process which looks
into collecting and organizing data by
doing so helpful conclusions are drawn
these conclusions can be incorporated
into the upcoming campaigns of the
organization
the information that is analyzed is
collected with the help of analytical
and logical reasoning
here are some key concepts of data
analysis first understanding popular
data analytics tools like Apache Spa
Tableau and SAS can be greatly helpful
in the process of data analysis
then we have Google analytics Google
analytics is a tool that helps
businesses analyze their website it
records activities of users visiting
your website along with additional
information like their age gender and
interests
this is then sent to the Google
analytics server and then can be used by
you to make decisions regarding upcoming
campaigns
then we have data visualization
data visualization enables data to be
translated into a chart graph or other
visual component understanding data
visualization would help with
understanding data in a quick and clean
manner it enables Brands to identify
emergent Trends and to respond to it
quickly
with it the Brand Story can also be
shared with others thanks to being able
to create a narrator with graphics and
diagrams
and finally a clear understanding of
data structures fundamentals and basic
statistics can greatly ease the process
of data analysis
now let's have a look at some
certifications here we have introduction
to data analytics for business by kosera
then we have data analyst Masters
program by simply learn and finally we
have micromasters program and marketing
analytics by edx today I'm going to tell
you how you can become a digital
marketer so first off let's answer the
most important question who is a digital
marketer now a digital marketer is
responsible for several things let's go
through some of them first off they're
responsible to develop as well as manage
marketing campaigns to ensure that the
goals of the organization are fulfilled
they need to create a marketing strategy
which is based on analyzing their
competition as well as the benchmarks
within the industry they need to drive
website traffic as well as acquire leads
which are then worked upon by the
organization or the business they need
to utilize web analytics tools so that
they can measure and optimize a campaign
which is basically figuring out how well
the campaign is doing and if it's not
doing well how they can make it better
and finally they need to be able to
enhance brand awareness which is just
letting people know that the brand
exists and how the brand can make their
lives better next up let's talk about
how to become a digital marketer to
become a digital marketer you need a
certain set of skills skills like search
engine optimization search engine
marketing or sem email marketing social
media marketing affiliate marketing
content marketing and finally mobile
marketing so the first step you need to
take to become a digital marketer is to
learn SEO so SEO or search engine
optimization is the process of
increasing the quality of your organic
traffic which is nothing but the traffic
that comes to your website without
having seen any paid advertisements just
because your website is one of the first
few results when they search a
particular query on a search engine SEO
involves on-page SEO as well as off-page
SEO so how to do on-page SEO first off
you need to do keyword research keyword
research is one of the most important
steps when when it comes to SEO it is
the process of identifying popular words
and phrases used on search engines by
users you need to be able to identify
keywords with high search volume higher
relevancy and low competition next up we
have technical audit so search engines
around the world have internet Bots
performing a particular process known as
crawling in this process the search
engine internet Bots these search engine
Bots also known as spiders scan a
website and copy the entire website's
content and store it within the search
engine for it to index now you need to
ensure your site is being crawled and
indexed next you have on-site
optimization you need to develop high
quality content meta tags URL and site
maps and finally user experience you
need to provide good website
architecture as well as internal linking
structure next up let's talk about how
to do off-page SEO this is made possible
with the help of Link building this is
the process of navigating links from
other websites to your own and by
building external links to your website
your organic search ranking can be
improved now let's talk about some SEO
tools you have Mars Google Keyword
Planner semrush and ahrefs now let's
talk about the next step required to
become a digital marketer which is to
learn sem or search engine marketing
search engine marketing is a practice of
marketing a business using paid
advertisements on search engines and
other websites so basically this is a
way of attracting users towards your
website or a particular product that you
are offering so how can you do sem or
search engine marketing first off you
need to determine your goal and Define a
budget you need to ensure that you have
a goal in mind for example do you want
more leads do you want to increase
traffic or improve brand awareness and
much more after you're done with that
you need to define a budget how much
money are you ready to spend to achieve
this goal then you need to choose a list
of relevant keywords which is keywords
on which you'll be bidding to advertise
you need to find analyze your keywords
and then bid on them which is basically
are you ready to pay for how many clicks
you're getting or for acquiring
customers or making them leads and so on
you need to create a compelling headline
for your ad campaign you need to monitor
the performance of campaigns and measure
results which is basically finding out
whether the campaign is working out well
and if it's not to optimize it so that
it works the next time and you need to
Target your audience with remarketing
campaigns for example if a customer does
not go through with the conversion
process they can be added to the
remarketing audience so that they can be
advertised to again some of the popular
sem tools are Google AdWords editor FB
ads manager Bing ads and AD role now for
the next step to become a digital
marketer you have to learn email
marketing now email marketing is really
efficient as well as inexpensive way to
generate High return on investment it
can be used to convert prospects into
customers by sending personalized emails
to a targeted audience so how do you
perform email marketing first off you
need to discover your target audience
and create segments in which you can
divide them depending on their behavior
you need to select and create your type
of campaign depending on the goals you
want to achieve you need to select a
suitable design for your campaign you
need to have a compelling subject line
and email content which is very
important when it comes to email
marketing you need to send campaigns
immediately or schedule an email and
finally you need to measure results such
as open trade click-through rate
response rate and so on you also need to
perform a b testing to find out what
works and what doesn't some of the
popular email marketing tools are
MailChimp HubSpot Marketo send in blue
and so on and now for the next step you
need to learn social media marketing
social media marketing involves the
promotion of your product and services
on different social media platforms
using different types of content now
this could be just sponsored posts video
advertisements images articles and so on
now how can you do social media
marketing first off you need to choose a
suitable social media platform for your
business it could be Facebook YouTube
Twitter LinkedIn and so on next up you
need to find your target audience now
each of these platforms has a particular
Niche that occupies it now for example
Facebook requires an active social media
marketing strategy Pinterest is usually
used by females LinkedIn can be used for
employee networking and YouTube is a
platform where people create as well as
share video content and that's the only
content that works on YouTube you need
to create as well as curate engaging
content because without your content
being engaging nobody's going to be
interested in your product or service
then you need to choose a social media
management tool and finally you need to
test evaluate and optimize your results
now let's talk about some popular social
media marketing tools we have HootSuite
tweet deck buffer Sprout social and so
many more now for your next step to
becoming a digital marketer you need to
learn affiliate marketing now affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves two players a merchant as
well as an affiliate now a merchant is
an individual who pays a commission to
the affiliate who could be a third party
site or entity to drive sales bring
leads or new customers with the help of
referrals now how can you do affiliate
marketing first off you need to choose a
tool through which you can find
Affiliates who can advertise your
product now you need to choose affiliate
on the basis of how much traffic the
affiliate website gets how successful
the Affiliates previous campaigns were
and and how much commission the
affiliate asks for then you need to
specify the format that the affiliate
must use when they're advertising your
product or service you need to keep a
record of the customers who purchased
your product or service through the
affiliate and finally pay the affiliate
based on the commission rates now let's
talk about some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools there's CJ affiliate
volume has offers and even now for the
next step to becoming a digital marketer
you need to learn mobile marketing now
mobile marketing enables a business to
communicate with a targeted audience
through any mobile device this is
through SMS emails mms's and so on so
how do you do mobile marketing first off
you need to create a mobile buyer
Persona which is you know what kind of
person is using the phone you need to
set business goals like what goes
basically determining what goals you
want to achieve with the mobile
marketing campaign then you need to
conduct your campaign and reach your
target audience with a personalized
message to these users and finally you
need to monitor these metrics and
optimize them if required now let's talk
about some popular mobile marketing
tools there's slick text locality admob
Facebook mobile ads and much more now
for your next step in becoming a digital
marketer you need to learn content
marketing content marketing is a pull
marketing technique of creating as well
as sharing valuable content now this
could be blogs videos or articles which
solves the problem of the target
audience this holds their attention by
adding value to their lives and can end
up converting their interest into a
purchase so how do you do content
marketing firstly you need to Define
your goals as in what you want to
achieve you need to Define your target
audience then you need to determine what
kind of content you are creating it
could be blog posts ebooks case studies
infographics and so on you need to
brainstorm for new content ideas you
need to perform a Content audit which is
to evaluate content elements and
information assets and choose a suitable
content management system now you can
plan create publish and measure your
results all in one place using a Content
management system using a Content
management system such as the HubSpot
software next you need to promote your
content using email affiliate and social
media marketing finally you need to
measure your success and optimize your
content now let's talk about some of the
popular content marketing tools that as
LinkedIn pulse paper.li Flipboard trap
it and many many more now let's talk
about some additional resources now
there are a huge number of videos online
about digital marketing and I recommend
you go through some of them so that you
have a basic idea about their
fundamentals now this is where
simplyon's YouTube channel can help you
you can take advantage of Simply learns
digital marketing tutorials you can go
to this playlist right here and here you
have tutorials on what is SEO how you
can rank number one on Google keywords
research Facebook ads tutorial how you
can rank your YouTube videos Facebook
advertising tips and tricks social media
marketing Google tag manager Google
analytics and so much more now let's
have a look at the salaries of a digital
marketer in the United States the
average salary of a digital marketer is
approximately sixty five thousand
dollars per year similarly the average
salary for a digital marketer in India
is approximately 5 lakh rupees per year
now let's talk about how you can become
a certified digital marketer though now
there are a number of different
certifications available for you there's
the Google ads fundamental certification
the Facebook certified planning
professional certification the HubSpot
content marketing certification the
HootSuite social marketing certification
and simply learns digital marketing
specialist Masters program now here's
another way simple learn can help you
simplylearn has a number of different
digital marketing certification has a
number of different digital marketing
certifications let's talk about the
digital marketing specialist Masters
program in this program there are a
number of different certifications such
as the digital marketing certified
associate Advanced web analytics
Advanced SEO and so on the certification
also provides the omcp certification
exam voucher worth 395 dollars upon the
completion of the Masters program it has
45 plus projects and can help you get a
salary of close to 17 lakhs per annum it
is also accredited by HootSuite Facebook
the omcp and so on so now let's have a
closer look at the digital marketing
course or the digital marketing
certified associate certification
training now this certification provides
53 hours of instructor-led training 40
plus hours of self-paced videos
instructor-led online project mentoring
sessions helping you prep for
examinations from the omca Google ads
and so on it has industry accreditations
from HootSuite Facebook and the omcp and
it covers more than 35 tools such as
Facebook insights YouTube analytics
crazy egg Google Keyword Planner Google
ad manager LinkedIn ads buffer semrush
and so on so why don't you go on to
simplylearn.com so that you can get
started on your journey getting
certified and getting ahead hey guys
welcome to this video on digital
marketing career jobs resume salaries
skills roles and responsibilities
so without further Ado let's jump right
into it
the 21st century has given us many
things to be thankful for from
technology to Health Care our lives have
greatly improved for the better and many
of these things wouldn't have been
possible without the internet
not counting about the several ways it
has improved Our Lives the internet has
also made the life of marketers a whole
lot easier
earlier unless you had lots of money or
were very popular your Brand's
popularity would be limited to your
locality
but thanks to the internet you can
advertise your content to anyone
anywhere in the world the whole world is
now your Marketplace
and that is because of digital marketing
which is the process of advertising
Goods services and your brand with the
help of digital channels like websites
social media platforms search engines
and so on digital marketing has the
following types
search engine optimization content
marketing social media marketing search
engine marketing affiliate marketing
native advertising marketing Automation
and email marketing
but you might be wondering who can
ensure these digital marketing concepts
are incorporated into a Brand's
marketing campaigns to ensure the best
possible output
a digital marketer of course
so now let's talk about everything
related to a digital marketer but before
we can get started let's go to a more
familiar setting on where a digital
marketer belongs and strives the office
now let's start by talking about who is
a digital marketer
a digital marketer is someone whose
objective is used digital channels like
search engines social media platforms
Affiliates and other opportunities to
generate leads and build brand awareness
you think the digital marketer is aimed
at helping the brand grow
but that's not where his or her
responsibilities end a digital marketer
is also responsible for developing and
managing marketing campaigns this means
that the success of the entire marketing
efforts of a brand or an organization
entirely depends on how competently a
digital marketer develops the marketing
campaign the work doesn't end there
though the digital marketer also needs
to manage the campaigns
next like we mentioned earlier he or she
needs to acquire leads and drive traffic
to the Brand's website taking advantage
of the digital channels we mentioned
earlier alongside providing high quality
content
the digital marketer also needs to
perform competitive analysis and
Industry benchmarking to understand what
kind of content works best within your
industry the kind of content that your
competition posts and what works for
them
they're also responsible for using tools
like buffer HootSuite and Sprout social
to measure and optimize marketing
campaigns Based on data obtained from
the tools
and finally they are responsible for
improving brand awareness by advertising
the organizations or Brands content on
digital marketing channels
let's now talk about the skills required
to become a digital marketer
now let's have a look at the different
types of digital marketing their search
engine optimization content marketing
social media marketing search engine
optimization affiliate marketing and
email marketing
let's talk about search engine
optimization first
search engine optimization is the
process of improving the overall quality
and quantity of the organic traffic
coming to your website via search
engines
with SEO you're able to attract visitors
who would be actually interested in the
products or services that your brand is
offering without having to pay a single
penny
the process of SEO has two parts
on page and off-page SEO let's have a
look at each of them in detail
first let's have a look at on-page SEO
on page or on-site SEO is a method of
search engine optimization that involves
the optimization of elements on a
website like its content or HTML code to
help increase the amount of traffic
coming to your website and improve its
search engine rankings
it also helps users easily understand
what page is all about and whether or
not your page addresses their search
query
on page SEO is possible with the help of
keyword research technical audits
on-site optimizations and enhanced user
experiences
next we have off-page SEO off page or
off-site SEO refers to actions taken
outside your website to affect your
rankings in search engine resolve pages
it involves promotional methods to
improve search engine and user
perception of your site's popularity
relevance trustworthiness and Authority
off-page SEO can also be performed with
the help of Link building which is
getting other websites to link back to
your website
the popular SEO tools are Moz Google
Keyword Planner semrush and ahrefs
next up we have content marketing
content marketing refers to the process
of marketing that focuses on creating
and sharing valuable relevant and
consistent content like blogs videos
infographics and case studies to bring
the attention of a targeted online
audience to the Brand's products and
services
the process of content marketing
involves firstly to decide what goal you
want to achieve with your marketing
campaign do you want more subscribers
more conversions increased leads
that's what you need to decide here
then you need to set up buyer personas a
buyer Persona is a profile created based
on Research that represents the Target
customer that might enjoy your products
or services
with this you can identify the ideal
audience that might be interested in
your content
next you will need to perform a Content
audit it involves taking a look at all
the content on your website and
assessing its relative strengths and
weaknesses in order to prioritize your
future marketing activities
then you need to choose a Content
management system of your choosing there
are a number of options available like
WordPress MailChimp and square says
you'll need to keep brainstorming for
new forms of content that'll attract the
attention of new audience
you will need to focus in a particular
form of content you want to focus on and
finally you'll need to publish and
manage your content
now let's talk about popular content
marketing tools there's buffer basumu
follower wonk and HootSuite
let's now talk about the next type of
digital marketing that is social media
marketing
social media marketing refers to a form
of marketing that involves the usage of
social media platforms to connect with
your audience to build a brand to
increase sales and to drive traffic
you'll need to listen to and engage with
followers analyze results and run social
media advertisements the process of
social media marketing involves like
before you first need to determine what
goal you want to achieve you'll need to
determine whether you need increased
conversions email signups lead
generation or any other marketing goal
at this stage you'll need to determine
what your audience enjoys the most
you'll need to find out which files get
the most amount of Engagement likes or
shares
then you'll need to research about your
competition within your niche
what kinds of content they post what
content of theirs receives the most
engagement from Their audience and how
how you can make similar content
you will then need to perform a social
media audit through which you can
analyze content on your social media
profile and understand their strengths
and weaknesses to determine what kinds
of content you can post
then you will need to create an account
on a social media platform of your
choice like LinkedIn Facebook Instagram
Twitter or YouTube and start creating
marketing strategies on how to make the
most out of them
you should also take into consideration
other brands that have already
established themselves in social media
for inspiration
you can analyze what kind of content
they post and how you can replicate the
same you will then need to create a
social media calendar these are
spreadsheets or applications that will
enable you to plan your social media
posts in advance
you can plan when content will be shared
manage them and track the deadlines
finally you will need to keep testing
evaluating and making adjustments to
your marketing campaigns to finally
reach the sweet spot where you have a
perfect social media marketing campaign
here are some of the popular social
media marketing tools there is food suit
tweet deck Sprout social and buffer just
to name a few
next up let's have a look at search
engine marketing
search engine marketing or sem is a
marketing process that involves websites
increasing the amount of traffic as well
as their visibility on search engine
result Pages by taking advantage of paid
advertising
let's now take a look at the process of
search engine marketing
first off as usual is to determine what
goal you want to achieve with your sem
campaign
more leads conversions subscriptions you
decide
then you will need to research what
kinds of keywords you want to advertise
on
this is a really important decision that
carries a lot of monetary weight as
choosing the wrong keywords may have
your brand competing against larger ones
in a bidding battle you have no chance
of winning
you will then need to decide on what
keywords you want to advertise and then
start bidding on them to ensure that a
user sees your ad when they search for
that particular keyword
you will need to set up a headline for
your ad campaigns as a well-written
headline for your ad can make the
difference between a potential customer
coming to your website and buying your
products and then being completely
turned off by your brand
you will need to monitor your campaigns
and measure how well you're doing so
that you can make the appropriate
adjustments and finally you will need to
make sure you make regular optimizations
and adjustments based on the data you've
collected and retarget potential
customers to renew their interest in
your brand
some popular search engine marketing
tools are Google ads Facebook ads
manager ad role and binge ads just to
name a few next up let's take a look at
affiliate marketing
affiliate marketing is the process of
paying an affiliate who could be a
particular website or other entity to
advertise a Merchant's products the
affiliate usually promotes the product
and earns a commission for each sale
they make
this is usually done using referrals via
registrations email signups conversions
and subscriptions here's the process of
affiliate marketing first you will need
to decide the affiliate Network you want
to choose the affiliate network is like
a favor for both merchants and
Affiliates
here a merchant gets to decide which
affiliate they want to work with and
vice versa
the merchant you will need to set up
specific rules guidelines image
specifications commission costs and
other details that an affiliate needs to
accept before they can apply to
advertise for you
after this Affiliates apply to advertise
on the Merchant's behalf
the merchants decide which affiliate
they want to go with and would be the
best representation of their brand
now once an affiliate has been selected
he or she places ads on their website or
the platform of their choosing
advertising the Merchant's products
interested customers then click on these
ads and are sent to the Merchant's
website
if customers make a purchase the
affiliate Network makes a note of it the
transaction is then validated and
credited to the affiliate and finally
the affiliate is given his or her
commission and likewise the process
repeats itself
here are some of the popular affiliate
marketing tools we have CJ affiliate
volume
even and has offers just name a few
again
now we are having a look at the last
type of digital marketing and that is
email marketing email marketing is the
process of using personalized emails to
convert prospective users into potential
customers here's the process of email
marketing first you decide on what goal
you want to achieve with your email
marketing campaign then you decide what
kind of emails you want to send is it a
welcome email a newsletter a lead
nurturing email a re-engagement email
that's what you've got to decide here
next you can choose an email marketing
tool of your choosing these tools can
help you with templates for emails
create email lists Track Performance and
do much more you will then need to
attract users with a reason to subscribe
to your emails with attractive opt-in
advantages like exclusive access to
sales discounts and so on
you will need to plan emails and their
respective follow-ups with an email
calendar
you will also need to create an
attractive subject line and copy that
will attract the attention of potential
customers
but the job isn't done after creating an
attractive subject line in copy your
email also has to have an attractive
design and finally you will need to
perform a or b tests and use analytics
to measure how well your campaign is
doing
based on this you can make the
appropriate adjustments to make sure the
upcoming campaigns are a success
popular email marketing tools are
MailChimp HubSpot send in blue and
Marketo just to name a few now let's
take a look at some digital marketer
carriers
here are some of the most popular job
roles you can have we'll be talking
about the salaries of these job roles
courtesy of Glassdoor first we have
digital marketing manager a digital
marketing manager earns approximately 75
000 dollars per annum in the US in India
he or she can earn approximately 7 lakh
rupees per annum next we have SEO
manager in the United States and SEO
manager earns approximately 62 000 per
annum whereas in India and SEO manager
earns approximately 5 lakhs per annum
then we have search engine marketing or
PPC expert a PPC expert in the US earns
approximately seventy four thousand
dollars per annum whereas in India a PPC
expert can earn approximately 4 lakh
rupees per annum next up we have the
social media manager in the US a social
media manager earns approximately fifty
thousand dollars per annum in India he
or she can earn approximately 5 lakhs
per annum and finally we have the
content marketing manager a Content
marketing manager can earn approximately
sixty five thousand dollars in the
United States in India he or she can
earn approximately 5 lakh rupees per
annum let's have a look at a sample
digital marketer resume first off you
start off with the usuals like name
address and the other stuff following
this you will need to add a brief
summary three of your years of
experience and the different important
skills you have experienced with in this
case this person has two years of
experience and just about every
important type of digital marketing
your summary can vary based on the job
role you're looking for you give them
links to your socials and then add
experience this is the part where you
can highlight your achievements during
your years of work
here you can see how this person has
brought growth in just about every
channel he's gotten into the most
important part to remember here is that
the stuff you add here must be
quantitative with actual stats about how
your work brought growth to your
organization
again depending on the job role you're
applying for you can choose to elaborate
on some of your achievements over others
then you can cover the different tools
you've got experience with make sure you
add relevant tools related to this job
role you're looking for for example for
the role of a sem expert having
experience with Google ads and Google
analytics is mandatory so that has to be
a part of this list
you can add concise details about your
education and then talk about the
courses you've completed having
completed the right courses can have a
significant impact on your higher
ability today we're going to talk about
digital marketing tools so fasten your
seat belts and let's get started so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a look at some of the best digital
marketing tools for not only 2019 but
ones that have performed well in the
past that are popular and ones that we
foresee as being the go-to tools for the
future so past present and future
digital marketing tools is the way to
look at this uh with a good focus on a
lot of different marketing channels here
so we're going to focus first on SEO
talk about some of the tools related to
on page and off page we're going to
switch over to paid search talk a little
bit about paid search tools we're going
to talk about email marketing and some
of the email marketing platforms and the
tools within those platforms the center
of it all is web analytics so Google
analytics is the tool we'll be taking a
closer look at in today's webinar and
all that it has to offer okay affiliate
marketing we'll talk about some of the
tools available to you in for affiliate
marketing we'd be remiss we didn't talk
about social media and all that it has
to offer and all the metrics and tools
available all the platforms available so
we'll hone in on a couple of examples
there and then we'll also talk about
some competition tools available for you
so there's a whole Suite of tools the
one caveat being hey if you have your
favorite tool continue using it in fact
if there's a tool that we didn't mention
in today's webinar feel free to mention
it in the comment box below this video
we'd love to hear what you're using to
manage your particular digital marketing
channel okay and so the goal for today's
webinar is hey we hope you get something
out of this in terms of using new tools
there's some tools that I use some tools
that my colleagues use everybody uses
different tools so it'd be good to kind
of see what else is out there so if you
have something to share share it by all
means what we're trying to do is share
what we think are you know best
practices and some of the most popular
or most used tools out there in the
industry so that's what we're gonna do
the goal is to get you to better
understand some of the tools we're using
a little bit more detail and what we're
going to do is start out with search
engine optimization okay so search
engine optimization or organic search we
have a mixture of paid and free so
there's a lot of different platforms but
if you're focusing on SEO you certainly
need to use an SEO platform so there's
sem Rush okay you also have Google
search console which is free so if you
don't have a SEO platform you definitely
need to be using Google search that's
all and so we'll take a closer look at
that there's Google Keyword Planner
which is actually situated under Google
ads and so if you're running Google
campaigns on Google search Network or
even the Display Network you have access
to a great tool called Keyword Planner
and if you know anything about SEO
you'll know that using Google's Keyword
Planner is a good tool so we'll take a
look at that Moz is a freemium tool
meaning they have a free trial that you
can sign up for to test drive it but
it's another SEO platform and it does
cost money got a great tool in screaming
frog that's a paid version again not too
expensive we'll talk a little bit more
about that and then we have you know a
tool in hrefs that help us with all
aspects of SEO primarily focusing on off
page so these are just some examples
that we're going to hone in on but this
is just a small subset of what really is
available out there in the market so so
let's go ahead and dive a little bit
deeper and understand why we use some of
these tools well the first reason when
we talk about SEO is to find relevant
keywords not only do we want to find
relevant keywords we want to find
relevant keywords with high volume and
low competition okay we wouldn't want to
find non-relevant keywords with high
competition low volume that wouldn't
make sense so we need a tool to kind of
help us put it all together and so the
tool of choice for us is Google's
Keyword Planner and Google's Keyword
Planner helps us hone in on keywords we
may be interested in optimizing for
because not only one are they relevant
but two they're going to have high
volume and low competition so let's take
a look at an example in Google's Keyword
Planner so here I am I'm in Google's
Keyword Planner and as I mentioned
before Google's Keyword Planner is
situated under Google ads okay so you
have to have a Google Google ads account
to use Google's Keyword Planner and so
when you're in Google ads you simply go
to tools and then under Tools you're
going to select Keyword Planner so what
we want to do is look for keywords we're
focusing on organic search not
necessarily paid search so organic
search we want to hone in on some
keywords so let's just use one of the
examples that Google's given us here
meal delivery so we're going to just
type in mail delivery and get some
results so notice I can enter a domain
as a filter and so in other words hey I
could say look hone in on keywords
related to this website if I wanted to
but I'm asking Google hey just give me
something closely related to mail
delivery because that's my business so
I'm going to click click get results
notice I can add another key to it if I
wanted to but I'm just going to stick
with one keyword but there are certainly
other keywords that I can certainly hone
in on is if mail delivery is my business
and so let's just hone in on that one
keyword mail delivery we want to be
found organically for that keyword so
what Google Keyword Planner does is not
only give us the keyword and other
keywords relevant to that but it gives
us the average monthly search volumes
and this is an average over the course
of the last 12 months and notice here I
get a column for competition so I'm able
to see whether that's a very competitive
keyword or not and then just to give you
an extra Edge when you're choosing
keywords you can get a sense of what the
keyword May cost if you wanted to bid on
that for paid search so for mail
delivery I can see it's anywhere between
7.46 and at the top of the page high
range
16.61 so that should alert me to the
fact that hey if I'm gonna try and
optimize for this keyword I know it's
competitive because not only Google is
telling me it's competitive by telling
me high competition but I know that the
cost per click seems a little bit high
and what is a little bit High well you
know I could see some other keywords
here that you know a dollar to three
dollars okay I could see some other ones
that are even lower than the seven
dollars they're suggested so that's a
indication that the keyword is highly
competitive so the idea here using
Google's Keyword Planner is one we want
to get an idea of what other keywords
are out there that are relevant so it
helps stimulate some ideas for relevancy
two we can get an average monthly search
volume so we want to know on average
over the past 12 months how many search
queries I can expect from this keyword
and then three I can get a sense of the
competition how competitive is this
keyword so if I try to optimize for this
keyword and I want to rank for it
organically is it competitive if it's
competitive then it's probably going to
take me a bit longer to be found for
this keyword on page one of Google so
that's the whole idea behind Google's
Keyword Planner and note that you could
change some of the settings here so if
you want to choose a different language
okay you can hone in on a longer or
shorter period of time you can even
choose a specific location so I chose
Texas I can certainly choose the entire
United States to get a sense of what the
volume would be for the total us so you
have settings that you can change and
manipulate to get you the data you need
to choose keywords so that's the whole
idea behind Google's Keyword Planner to
find relevant keywords high volume low
competition now alternatively I can
certainly use another tool to find
keywords so I have a mods account so I
logged into Moz and Moz has a tool
called keyword Explorer so if I use that
same keyword I used in Google's Keyword
Planner mail delivery I'm going to ask
Moz to give me some data on that keyword
so this is for the entire United States
and again I can change that if I wanted
to okay so I can hone in on a specific
country or different country so what
miles is telling me hey for this keyword
in the entire United States I'm looking
at anywhere from eleven and a half
thousand to thirty thousand on monthly
volume now what Moz does is they give
you a difficulty score so a difficulty
score is a score between 1 and 100 and
so I could see this is pretty much right
down the middle in terms of difficulty
okay so if it's zero it's an easy
keyword if it's not if it's a hundred
it's very difficult and then that means
you have a lot of competitors who are
optimizing for this keyword that are
ranking for this keyword and so Moz
gives us the volume they give us the
competition in Ma just like Google's
Keyword Planner gives us some other
keywords that we can potentially hone in
on so here I could see keyword delivery
plans delivery services
Etc so I can see a lot more suggestions
than what's listed here so Moz delivers
a bunch of other analysis related to the
keyword you know they also give you some
good keyword suggestions so Moz is a
good alternative tool and we'll be
coming back to Moz related to SEO for
some other of its features but for now
if you don't want to necessarily use
Google's Keyword Planner because maybe
you're not running Google ads you can
always use Mazda remember Moz has
basically a freemium version I mean you
can sign up for a free account and you
can sign up for a free account as a test
trial and you could test it for a period
of days and leverage its tools during
that free trial to get a better sense of
how these tools work so we want to be
able to use Moz we want to be able to
use is Google's Keyword Planner not only
to search for all those relevant
keywords available to you but we want to
be able to choose keywords with high
volume and low difficulty low
competition we also want to select
primary and second keywords wisely so
remember when you optimize you're
optimizing a page for more than one
keyword so you want to be able to have a
nice portfolio of diverse relevant
keywords with high search volume and low
difficulty and then you want to be able
to identify those keywords that your
competitors are ranking for so Moz gives
you that information and so we want to
be able to leverage the tools available
to us to choose the right keywords so if
you need any more information on this we
got a nice webinar on keyword research
for SEO so take a look at that video on
YouTube to get more specific details
about using SEO tools for keyword
research and all about keyword research
in general for SEO so let's talk about
some other reasons under SEO what we
would use some of these tools available
to us well we want to be able to
understand the search engines and how
they crawl and index our site okay we
also want to check the correct format of
the site map and we want to monitor
backlinks okay we also want to analyze
linking to our web page okay which ones
are good which ones are not good okay we
also want to perform some competitor
analysis so these are some of the
reasons why other than keyword research
why would we use some of these SEO tools
so we have tools available to us some
Majestic hrefs again Moz let's take a
look at Google search console and I want
to hone in on Google search console
because it is free and it's a must if
you're going to work on SEO you need to
be where working in Google search
console and so the whole key behind
Google search console is you have a
website you need to get that site
verified once it's verified once Google
can recognize that you are associated
with this website then you're going to
be able to see some important
information so here I'm looking at a
website and what am I looking at I'm
looking at something called coverage
under index so what does coverage mean
well going back to what we just said we
want to be able to understand how
Google's crawling and indexing our pages
and so what Google does is through this
platform search console is they're
letting us know once they go to our
website and start crawling it and they
pull these Pages back to their server
they're letting us know if we actually
have any issues so here I could see I
have some issues with 112 pages and some
of those issues are listed down here so
there could be a crawl issue a 4-4 you
know redirect okay so you can see
there's some five unique issues across
112 pages so here I can see submitted
URL marked no index there's a hundred of
those pages we have some redirect errors
there's seven pages that you know fall
victim to this error and so we can
really hone in
um what the error is and address the
error okay so if Google's telling us hey
this is an issue and you want that page
indexed by Google then we should
probably address the error and so that's
the great thing here about going into
Google search console is you can under
index go to coverage and get a sense of
what Google's indexing and what they're
not indexing okay so these are the
errors I can see they've certainly were
able to crawl and index
9115 Pages they were able to crawl okay
and they excluded 54
000 plus pages and then we also have
some pages with some warnings so this is
kind of an overview of what Google Sees
when they crawl our site so when they
say crawl they're coming to our site
they're following links on the site and
every link they follow they're either
going to index that page or they're
going to report to you an error or an
issue that they found if we want these
Pages indexed we need to address the
issues the errors and so that's the
beauty of this report here is Google is
telling us firsthand what the issues are
so we also want to take a look at the
sitemap so you have an opportunity to
submit a sitemap and a site map is just
a formatted file that includes all your
website URLs and so you're going to have
this file sitting in your root directory
and you're probably going to call it or
should call it sitemap dot XML XML being
the format so once you have this file
you're just going to let Google know
that that file exists so you're going to
enter in the sitemap URL so if it's in
the root directory all you're going to
do is type in sitemap.xml and click
submit so once you've done it just like
this site is done what Google's going to
do is say hey look we see you've
submitted this and we last read it a
couple days ago and we could see that we
discovered 1 419 URLs so I can go back
under coverage and I can see some of the
issues that they found but if I go back
under sitemaps I can see that these are
the URLs they discovered via the sitemap
and so the whole point of a site map is
we want to be able to get and push the
URLs to Google not have Google come to
our site and discover them this is a
quicker faster more efficient way to
communicate with Google all the URLs
that you have on your site that you want
Google to index and so that's the beauty
of search console now while we're in
search console we might as well take a
look at some of the other features it
has and so one of the most important
features under search console is this
mobile usability report okay so Google
is a staunch believer in mobile first so
nowadays most people start and finish a
lot of their searches a lot of their
behavior on mobile so the beginning on
mobile and they may end it on mobile so
if they don't end it on mobile then you
know perhaps they'll go into a store or
perhaps they'll go via desktop but
Googled is a staunch believer and
definitely a lot of what's going on
today starts with mobile so they want
you to understand how your site fares
Via Mobile and when I say fares Via
Mobile is it mobile friendly is it
responsive is it loading quick enough
you know is it form formatted to Google
standards and so if there are any issues
Google's going to let you know what
those issues are so here I could see
Google's recognized 206 pages with four
different issues okay so here I can see
what those issues are just like the
coverage issues we can see specifically
what they are and so here I can see for
206 Pages text too small to read click
elements to close together the viewport
not set to device with and then content
wider than the screen so there's 10
pages that fit under this error and if I
actually click on it the error I can see
what those 10 pages are and so when
we're done we can actually when we
address the issues we can actually have
Google validate whether the fix has been
made so you can definitely use this as a
means of communicating directly with
Google telling Google look I see what
the issues are I'm going to fix them and
then I want you to validate them okay so
this is important because if you can
communicate with Google and let them
know hey we do recognize the errors we
are fixing the errors please validate
them you know it's going to draw
Google's attention Google's going to
validate them and get these Pages
indexed quicker
um so if you ignore the issues then the
errors especially for mobile then you
stand the chance of your pages not
getting indexed so the mobile usability
report to me is an important report
because we want to better understand
whether Google's picking up issues on
mobile and if they are we want to
address them get a little value them so
Google can index them quicker now
there's another report that is of
interest to you or may be of interest to
you in Google search console and that's
the links report so the links report in
Google search console shows us what
pages have the most links okay so here
we can see the home page is 26 000 plus
links if we hone in on interior Pages we
can see the links to those pages okay so
we can get a sense of what are the top
link pages from external links meaning
links on other websites pointing to
these pages I can also see internal
links so Google's recognizing links from
within my website from one page to
another so external links internal links
both factors for SEO when ranking so
then I can see top linking sites what
sites are linking to my site and then I
can see top linking text so Google
search console has given me kind of an
overview of what my leaking structure
looks like okay so externally I want
links from other websites pointing to
various pages on my site and I certainly
want my pages linking to one another on
my site and so I'll be able to better
understand what that structure looks
like using Google search console's links
report okay there's one more report that
I think's of interest in Google search
console and and that's the performance
report so the performance report is a
report that actually you can link up
with Google analytics so you can see the
same report and analytics if you're able
to link up Google search console with
analytics and you should be able to do
that all you need to do is make sure you
use the same email address that you use
for analytics and search console so it
needs to be the same email address you
could certainly link up to two and have
this data imported into Google analytics
so what is this data that we're talking
about well it's called performance so
what we can actually see is the queries
the actual queries people are typing in
to Google so when they're typing them
into Google we can actually see how many
Impressions the keyword queries received
and how many clicks the keyword queries
received and then I can see
click-through rate and average position
okay so here I can see for this
particular keyword third on the first
line I could see over the course of the
last three months it received 209
297 Impressions so what does that mean
that means this keyword was used or
typed in as a query at least that many
times and that's how many times my
listing appeared and the Google search
results Pages based on this particular
query and so as a result of somebody
typing in this query 209 000 plus times
this site received 120 000 plus clicks
so to get a sense of the click-through
rate all you would need to do and Google
can obviously do this for you is you
would simply just divide the 209 297
into the 120 000 397. okay so that's
really going to give you that's going to
give you your click-through rate and the
click-through rate in this case is 57 so
over half of of the clicks occur when
this listing appears for this keyword
okay so we can get a sense of the
click-through rate for each one okay and
you could simply just use the filtering
here now we can also see average
position okay so we could see a little
bit more than that too we can go from
queries to Pages we can go from pages to
countries so we get a sense of how many
Impressions and clicks I'm receiving by
country and importantly we can see by
device so here I can see a majority of
the people who conduct a search related
to my website primarily do it on desktop
now I mentioned the beauty of the Google
search console performance report is
that you can link it up to Google
analytics and when you do that all you
need to do then is go to acquisition
Google search console and then from
there you could choose landing pages
countries devices or queries so I can
see the same data that I see in search
console but this time I'm looking at it
in Google analytics and so here I can
see what my search queries are my clicks
my Impressions my clicked array bike
search query and then the average
position so that's the great thing about
that performance report is that when I
link up Google search console with
analytics I'm able to see that data in
analytics so that's an added bonus so to
speak now let's talk about some other
reasons why we're going to use these SEO
tools available to us and so we already
listed a number of different reasons
ranging from sitemaps to keyword
research but we also want to hone in on
you know what domains are driving links
to our site so I showed you an example
in search console we also want to hey
maybe identify and disavow poor
backlinks so search console is a great
tool for that because if we don't want
to be associated with a particular
website we can certainly disavow that
link we could track a number of follow
and no follow links okay we could track
our website's rankings we can measure
click-through rates and Impressions just
as we did with search console we could
track keyword ranking for desktop mobile
cross locations just as we just did with
the search console performance report we
can identify top performing gaining and
losing keywords again the performance
report so we could certainly look at the
Google search console report but if you
have a platform like Moz you can
certainly also look at a lot of that
data available so for example rankings
so if you have a Moz account we can
certainly go into rankings okay and we
can see for the keywords that we've
chosen that we want to optimize for we
could certainly see where they rank the
great thing about Moz is it's a great
tool not only for rankings and on-page
optimization but for off-page
optimization as well so if I go ahead
and take a look at a domain for example
I'm just going to type in this domain
I'm going to be able to get what they
call a domain Authority so a score out
of 1 and 100 I'm able to see how
authoritative my domain is and how
authoritative a domain is is based on
the quality of links pointing to it so
Moz gives me some good insights as to
how many linking domains how many
inbound links I have ranking keywords
and it goes into detail as well so here
if I click on the linking domains I'm
going to be actual able to see the
actual domains pointing to my site as an
external link and not only can I see the
domains I can actually see the domain
authority of those domains so if there's
a domain for example that doesn't have a
good domain Authority and the site
appears a bit scammy per se then we can
disavow that so I can certainly look at
all the domains that are linking to me
and then I can highlight the ones that
have poor domain Authority what must
even takes it a step further they also
give me a Spam score so Moz is able to
measure how spammy a website is so if I
have a combination of say a low domain
Authority and a high spam score then I
probably want to disavow myself from
that site and so I can use this report
here you can see here I was like this
particular site because it has so many
links pointing to me or it has at least
one link pointing to me that I probably
want to disavow myself because it's
probably hurting my own domain Authority
so that's the great thing about this
linking domains report is I'm able to
hone in on not only who's link linking
to me meaning domain but how many
linking domains does that domain have
what's the spam score of that domain
what's the domain authority of that
domain and then I can get into a little
bit more detail and I actually see you
know all the links pointing to that
domain so it really goes into detail
about backlinks domain Authority spam
Etc everything you need to use in order
to measure off page SEO so that's the
great thing about Moz is they have not
only on-page SEO tools but off-page SEO
tools and Moz is a freemium so to speak
so here you can see if you just go to
mods.com free Dash seo-tools you'll be
able to use some of these tools
available to you not just for SEO but
also for local SEO as well so here you
like some of these tools you can start
your free 30-day trial so I use and lean
on Moz a lot for all that it has to
offer from choosing keywords to rankings
report to checking issues on my website
to even checking who's linking to me so
this fits in the mold with everything I
need to do for SEO so in addition to
that keyword research video you could
certainly lean on some other webinars
that we've done in the past on SEO so
we've done a webinar on SEO tools and
we've also done a webinar on SEO tips
and tricks so if you want any more
information about the tools we covered
or SEO in general take a look at those
two videos and check them out and that
should kind of complement what we talked
about with using some of the tools
Google's Keyword Planner Moz and Google
search console okay let's switch over to
email marketing tools and so with email
marketing tools we have a lot available
to us in the form of reporting in the
form of Platforms in the form of you
know tools that really help us go from A
to Z on our email choosing you know what
email to send out to creating a list to
measuring how the email campaign went
and so we could start with MailChimp
because mailchimps a freemium version
when we say freemium meaning they have a
free trial available then you're
expected to upgrade but you know
MailChimp to me is a tool I use I like
the interface very easy for beginners so
we're going to take a look at MailChimp
but there are certainly many others
available you know more cat is a good
tool you know Marketo is a good toll
because if you have a business and
you're trying to funnel people through
your pipeline so to speak meaning they
they sign up as a lead and you want to
nurture that lead from the beginning to
the end meaning at the end they're
actually going to turn around and
purchase well Marketo is a good tool for
you to use because you can then set up
trip campaigns or also known as email
campaigns you know so that you're
talking and communicating with that
particular Prospect through every point
in the funnel so that's the great thing
about Marketo it has drip campaigns
available along with some other features
there's a HubSpot a very powerful tool
it does a lot from creating landing
pages to a b testing to social to you
know emails so this is another freemium
tool that you could use you have another
freemium and send in blue email platform
and then you also have convertkit
another email platform there's more
Dimension that we can't even fit on this
screen now if you have a favorite email
marketing tool that you use Constant
Contact vertical response they're plenty
out there Emma you know feel free to to
note that in the comment section below
this video I'm curious as to how many
people actually use you know different
tools because there are so literally so
so many email marketing tools out there
why because email marketing has been
around probably the longest amongst all
the other digital marketing channels and
a lot of people use email on a daily
basis so it's no wonder why there's just
so many tools available and so with
these tools you can certainly send bulk
emails now in the case of Marketo you
could send emails to a segmented
audience and so that's a actually what
you want to do as a strategy is always
send emails to a segmented audience you
know you want to use a tool where you're
going to be able to create campaigns
then send those campaigns to again
segmented contacts and then be able to
design your email around that particular
audience so you know you have a good
tool when you can do that when you can
really segment for your audience okay
you want to be able to use a tool that's
going to be able to segment your users
you know use transactional emails
meaning hey look if somebody okay go
ahead went ahead and purchased can you
follow up with an email and creating
workflows just like I mentioned with
Marketo you want a workflow set up where
hey if somebody does this you're sending
email B Etc so you want an email
marketing tool that's flexible enough to
handle what your business strategy and
goals are okay so you want to be able to
also use a tool that you know has
various email templates available okay
you don't want to be stuck with just a
vanilla template again you want to be
able to customize an email for your
audience you want to be able to manage
your list appropriately meaning if you
have 10 000 users or emails in a list
you want to be able to manage them
accordingly you know break them up or or
have sub lists so to speak and then most
importantly you want to make sure you
have a platform that not only does its
tracking on its own but will give you
some detailed insights meaning you know
what percent advantage of users opened
your email what percentage of recipients
clicked on your email what links do they
click on you know which which emails
bounce so you want some detailed
insights right in the platform that
you're using it just makes it more
simpler and easier and more effective to
manage you certainly want to create that
smart automated campaigns meaning you
don't even have to send out the email
and then you want to be able to have
some flexibility to set up email
delivery based on a specific time of day
so these tools also allow you to your
segment contacts based on geolocation
you want to be able to use a tool that
allows for multivariate testing again
you want to analyze performance and
optimize campaigns you want to trigger
automatic responses somebody purchases
something are you using a tool that will
automatically send that email out so
these are all the reasons why you would
use an email marketing tool so let's
dive in and take a look at an exam
sample and we're going to use MailChimp
as our example today so let's dive in
and take a look at MailChimp so with
MailChimp once you log in you know
you're going to be able to see some
historical campaigns that you've sent
out or are you going to be able to
create your own campaign and so this is
kind of under campaigns you can kind of
see an overview of the ones you've sent
out or if they're in draft mode you'll
be able to see they're in draft mode so
you can go ahead and edit them so here
we have one that was set up on August
26th and it's still in draft mode so we
can go ahead and edit that so if we just
click edit you know we have the
flexibility to you know pick and choose
who we're sending this to who it's from
what the subject line is and then we can
certainly design the email so if we
click design email again this is
important because with email marketing
you want to be able to cater your email
to your intended audience
so if you're selling men's shoes your
audience should be men okay so you don't
want men to receive an email about
women's shoes it sounds like it's common
sense but the point being you want to be
able to use an email platform that's
going to be able to allow you to put two
and two together the message and the
design with intended audience and so
here you can see MailChimp allows us to
do that okay you can see some of the
layouts here okay you also have themes
that you could choose from okay you
could search for different themes or you
can even just code your own so you can
just paste an error code in or you can
import it so MailChimp allows that
flexibility you're not stuck with one of
their templates and so if we go back to
the dashboard the one thing I like about
MailChimp though is the reporting okay
so yes it is easy to choose a template
and map that template to your audience
but I really like make the reports that
they have to offer so you know here you
can see there's some lists that we've
sent to and we choose one of our
audience lists then we can see some
really detailed reporting here and so
here I could see this email that was
sent out in June I could see it was sent
to 95 000 plus subscribers okay of the
subscribers this all 2000 Plus open it
and 157 clicks so I can view this report
in more detail just by clicking on view
report so again we want an email
platform that's going to be able to give
us some detailed information about how
that email campaign performed and so I
can get down really to the nitty-gritty
I can actually see you know on the
content what was clicked and what wasn't
clicked so here I sent two different
subject lines so I'm able to compare the
two against one another okay so I can
really go into detail about one of them
here so if I click view report I can
specifically see what the average for
this list is so here I'm able to compare
against the list average and it's 16 I
only had an open rate of 2.5 percent so
the industry average is 18 and so here
I'm able to see the list average for the
click rate and the industry average for
the click rate as well so then I can see
some specifics about it how many people
unsubscribed then I could see a graph I
could see the top links that were
clicked okay the top subscribers put the
most opens I can link social to it if I
want to and then I can see geographic
information so the point being is
MailChimp really goes into some nice
detail here about the email campaigns
and how they performed so the great
thing is too with the MailChimp you
could link it with a Google analytics
you can link it with e-commerce okay so
if you have an email and you're you're
selling products and somebody purchased
that product MailChimp is able to
integrate in with your shopping Commerce
platform for example woocommerce so if
somebody did purchase you can send out
that thank you email MailChimp even goes
a step further and if somebody did click
on a link go to your shopping cart add
something to the shopping cart and then
abandon the car you know MailChimp
allows you the opportunity to retarget
them via email so MailChimp is flexible
and that's what you want in a email
marketing platform you want something
that's flexible that you can cater to
your audience you can manage your
audience list and you can get detailed
reporting on your different campaigns
for that audience so that's MailChimp
and summary and so most email platforms
do a lot of similar features or have
some similar features but that's what
you ideally want to look for in an email
marketing platform so here's a tool that
doesn't get talked about enough when it
comes to email marketing and that's
Google's URL Builder and the reason why
we're going to talk about this tool
today is because most people in the US
use Google analytics as their web
Analytics tool and the one thing about
Google analytics is it allows you to
track different campaigns so if you're
doing pay-per-click campaigns outside of
Google you can certainly track the
performance right in Google analytics
and email is no different so if you're
using Google analytics and you're
sending out an email let's just say on
MailChimp or any other email marketing
platform you want to be able to append
your links with what we call UTM
tracking so for example if I have a URL
that says visit Florida and I'm going to
send out an email I have up to five
parameters that I can use Okay so so
here's my email or URL that I'm using in
the email so I have up to five
parameters that I can use to track this
particular email so let's go through
some of those parameters so the first
one is campaign source so what's the
source of the campaign well we could
certainly identify mailchamp if we're
using MailChimp as the source now the
the thing about the URL Builders you
always want to use lowercase because
Google analytics is case sensitive so as
a rule of thumb just stick with a
lowercase so our source is going to be
MailChimp because that's the platform
we're using if you're using you know
Constant Contact or vertical response or
you know some of these other one
convertkit then go ahead and put in that
platform as the source now for the
medium which is the means in which we're
driving traffic to the site let's go
ahead and put in email because that's
what we're using to drive traffic to
this particular page now what's the
campaign name well we're in summer so
we're going to call this the summer
promo so their summer promo here is
visit Florida beaches okay so we're
going to send this email out to the
masses and particularly not only the
masses but the masses in the north
because we're going to say hey look come
to Florida for the summer come visit our
beaches that's the point of the campaign
so that's what we're going to use for
the campaign name is whatever the
campaign is it's a summer promo now
notice I got an asterisk next to these
particular parameters so Google's asking
us hey these are mandatory so go ahead
and put something in there now for
campaign term and campaign content we
could certainly leave them blank because
they're not mandatory but since we're
talking about email I would certainly
recommend that you use the campaign
content parameter and why do I say that
because if we're sending an email out to
say if 10 000 recep recipients I want to
be able to split out the email into two
segments one segment that's going to get
subject line one and one segment that's
going to get subject line two so in this
case I'm going to put whatever subject
line one is and the campaign content
field so now I have four parameters and
once I've entered in my variables in
this parameter Fields I now have a
revised or appended URL so my original
URL was visit florida.com
Florida Dash beaches.html my original
URL I've now appended that with some UTM
parameters and now I see my original URL
appended with the UTM parameters based
on those variables so I can copy it just
by clicking the copy URL I can go to my
browser I can paste that URL in there
and I want to check to see if it works
so here I could see this particular page
loaded Florida beaches with my etm
parameters appended to the URL so that's
for the first subject line that's for
the audience that's going to get the
first subject line I want to do another
one for the second subject line so now
I'm going to change my campaign content
parameter to subject line underscore 2.
I'm going to copy that URL I'm going to
check it okay so I could see that the
page loads with those UTM parameters and
so now what am I going to do I'm going
to use the first URL and the second URL
in my email okay so any link that I have
in this case I'm using subject line two
so for the email with the second subject
line going to that segmented audience
this is the link I'm going to use in the
email so if you have one or two or three
links in the email this is the URL
you're going to use because when
somebody clicks on that link you're
going to be able to see that that click
in Google analytics so if I jump over to
Google analytics after I send out my
email I'm going to go to acquisition I'm
going to go to campaigns I'm going to go
to all campaigns now based on the
variables I put into my parameters
meaning Source medium campaign name
content or term that's what I'm going to
look for in Google analytics so we can
start with source and medium so if I
click on source and medium as my primary
Dimension here I can see MailChimp and
the actual dates was used as part of the
variable for for source and then what
can I see the medium being email so now
I can see for this email that was sent
out in MailChimp in May I could see how
many users how many sessions and more
importantly how many conver versions so
we could certainly hone in on that
particular email if we wanted to if we
choose some of the other parameters
available to us so here I could see the
campaign name okay so I could see
exactly what campaign what source what
email
drove in traffic and conversions and if
I'm doing subject line testing I can
choose content as my parameter so here
I'm going to change it to content and
now I can see the subject lines in this
case if I go back to my source medium
I'm going to be able to see what subject
lines from my emails generated the most
traffic and not only the most traffic
but also conversions so that's the whole
point behind using the URL Builder again
you're taking a URL that you're going to
use an email and then you're going to
pan that URL with different parameters
campaign Source campaign medium campaign
name and then optionally campaign
content or campaign term okay once
you've entered variables into those
parameters you're going to get it
appended URL which you can then use in
your email so in the email get it's sent
you're going to go back over to Google
analytics and you're going to look at
the results of that campaign of that
source of that Medium of that content
I.E subject line and so that's why the
URL Builder is so important because
MailChimp gives us some good insight as
to how the email performed in terms of
open and click rates but what we really
want to see is how that campaign
performed once it drove traffic to my
website so that's the whole idea behind
the URL Builder if you're using Google
analytics you'll be able to use the URL
Builder with whatever email platform
you're using so let's move on to web
analytics tools and this is an important
section because web analytics tools kind
of the central focal point of all
digital marketing and it starts really
with Google analytics Google analytics
is is a freemium meaning that they have
a free version that you can use there is
also a paid version of Google analytics
but given the Advent of Google it's
popular especially in the United States
a majority of users are using the free
version of Google analytics so it's a
very popular tool especially for
marketers but there are also other tools
available so it's not just Google so we
have Adobe analytics which is also
freemium you have kiss metrics you have
spring metrics you have YouTube
analytics which is part of Google but
YouTube has its own separate analytics
insights so a lot of these as you can
see are free to use they're available no
reason why you should not be using uh an
Analytics tool to measure your marketing
campaigns or website behavior and why
would we want to use these tools again
well again and we want to really measure
Behavior we want to measure what's going
on with our website so we want to be
able to identify the location of where
our website visitors are coming from and
a lot of these analytics tools use IP
address to identify the location of a
website visitor so if you're trying to
Target a specific country then you want
to be able to see that the visitors to
your website are coming from that
specific country or location we also
want to measure the engagement of our
website Behavior so we get traffic to
the website what are they doing how long
are they staying what pages are they
visiting so this is the overall nature
of really why we want to use web
analytics to measure how successful our
website is at treating our website
visitors with the same courtesy you
would if you had a brick and mortar
store somebody comes into your store you
want them to find what they're looking
for quickly you want them to be happy
with their experience you certainly want
them to pay for the products very
quickly and easily and efficiently and
you want them to come back and that's no
different than a website so we want our
website to perform in a manner that's
going to suit our audience and that's
why we want to track engagement so why
else well we want to really look at
who's coming are they returning visitors
or new visitors you know ideally you
want a nice mix between 50 new and 50
returning because you know returning
visitors are loyal there's some loyalty
to that they already know your brand
they're coming back to your website new
visitors are curious and you want new
visitors because that means more traffic
so you want a nice balance between that
analytics tools will help you measure
that you want to be able to measure
organic traffic whether you like it or
not whether you know it or not but
Google and other search engines are
indexing your pages and your pages are
being found via the search engines and
so you want to be able to measure how
much traffic you're actually generating
from those search engines we talked
about this with email marketing UTM
tracking so if you set up email
campaigns or non-google campaigns you
want to use UTM tracking and Google
analytics and other analytics tools but
specifically Google analytics will help
you see the results of your campaigns if
they're tracked with UTM tracking so
that's another good reason why to use a
web Analytics tool probably most
importantly amongst all these bullet
points is our goals our website
conversions we want to be able to see
how much traffic is coming to our
website and not only the engagement of
the traffic but how much of that traffic
is actually doing what we want them to
do I.E are they converting and we want
to optimize our sites and channels
performance so the whole idea of
collecting all this information is that
you can turn around and improve
performance so if your bounce rate is
high well how do you lower bounce rate
well we need to do something about that
in analytics tools will help us identify
what's not working from our site
perspective and from a channel
perspective and we can take action to
improve performance so that's the whole
idea behind optimizing our site's
performance so let's jump into Google
analytics and let's take a look at
everything we just talked about in those
bullet points so about improving website
performance measuring engagement looking
at our goals and conversions measuring
campaigns with UTM tracking all those
good things that we can get in a good
Analytics tool so Adobe mix panel string
metrics you know they all work in a
similar fashion and that they're really
measuring website behavior and so if
we're in Google analytics really what
we're doing is we're measuring the
performance of our website broken and
down into four components audience
acquisition behavior and conversions so
what do we want to do well we want to
look into each one of these sections so
let's start with audience and so
audience and Google analytics tells us
who is coming to our website now they're
not going to specifically tell us hey
Rob Sanders came to your website but
they are going to say that somebody from
San Francisco California came to the
website and these are the pages they
looked at and this is the language and
they came from this device and they're a
returning users so they're painting a
picture for you okay so they're not
giving you a list of names that would
not be legal but they are providing you
with a good picture of who is coming and
when I say picture we have to paint that
picture and so if we look at say
demographics for example and I go to
demographics overview here's a picture
I'm painting well well I can see that 25
to 34 year olds are the majority of the
age group that is coming to my website
okay I can see on the gender side of it
I can see that 63 percent of my traffic
and again this is year to date that I'm
looking at is coming to my website so
two-thirds of my traffic is female
one-third amount and they're between the
ages of 25 and 34. so I'm painting a
picture about you know gender and age
coming to my website well I can also
look at Geo so where specifically might
these people be coming from so if I go
to location under Geo I'm going to be
able to see a breakdown of country or I
can even hone it down to city or
specific location and here I can see
United States is the primary driver but
not by much so we have 16 almost 17
percent from the US and then 16 from
Argentina 13 from Mexico 10 percent from
India so we have a nice mix of traffic
from different locations in the world
coming to our website so that's Geo but
more importantly let's take a look at
mobile so if we go to mobile overview
how are people coming to our website are
they on a desktop or a laptop are they
using their mobile device are they using
a tablet and so Google analytics breaks
it down very nice for you and so we
could see percentages in actual numbers
by device category and so in this case I
could see year to date I could see 62
percent are coming from desktop 35
percent are coming from mobile and so
that's important because most people
start their Journey from mobile and that
is growing and that's going to continue
to grow so you want to keep an eye on
mobile so to me this is one of the more
important reports under audience because
people who come from Mobile have a
different not only experience because
the website should be responsive to the
mobile device but their mindset is going
to be different they're actively looking
for something they're probably going to
either then follow up on their desktop
or follow up in person at your store or
they're probably looking for directions
or they may just call you so the
experience is a lot different on mobile
so we want to hone in on the growth of
mobile okay so to me this is one of the
more important reports in Google
analytics especially under audience so
let's move on to acquisition so
acquisition reporting tells us how the
traffic was driven to the website so if
audience tells us who is coming to the
website acquisition tells us how that
traffic got to the website and so really
what you want to do is get a sense of
what channels what marketing channel
channels are driving traffic so remember
we talked about organic search well
those search engines are indexed in your
pages well how much of that traffic from
the search engines is actually coming to
your site and I'm a Believer in if
organic search is the primary driver of
traffic then you have a pretty healthy
website because that means the search
engines or indexing your pages people
are searching for something related to
your business you're being found you're
getting clicked and that represents the
majority of the traffic so that's always
a good thing so here we could see it
broken down by Channel if I go to all
traffic channels report I can see in my
Dimension that organic search represents
72 percent of my traffic and this is
year to date then I can see paid search
then I can see direct which means
Somebody went directly to the site I
could see referral email social then I
could see more paid search broken out so
the these are the different marketing
channels now analytics allows you to
look at a specific source and medium so
the source would be the actual website
or search engine in the medium would
differentiate how that traffic actually
got to the site so if we're talking
about a search engine did they come to
the site via paid search or do they come
to the site via organic search and so
all we need to do is change our primary
Dimension from default Channel grouping
to source and medium and we could see
specifically the breakout of the
different sources and mediums driving
traffic to the site so here I can see
Google organic at 71 percent and then
Google CPC or cost per click at 15 16 of
our traffic so then I can look down I
can see email in here Bing organic I
could see some referring sites I could
see some social in terms of mobile
Facebook okay so we can see a mix of the
different sources of mediums driving
traffic to the site okay so you don't
always have to look at Channel per se
you can look at it via source and medium
and if you're running Google ads under
acquisition analytics has a whole
section of Google ads reporting so if
you're running campaigns on Google ads
remember we looked at the Keyword
Planner in Google ads so if you're
running campaigns on Google ads you can
certainly see the performance of those
campaigns just by clicking on campaigns
we can also see campaigns other
campaigns that we're running so remember
that UTM tracking that we set up for
email well we want to be able to track
the performance of email and any other
non-google campaign with UTM tracking so
when we do that we'll be able to go to
campaigns all campaigns and we'll be
able to see the campaign performance if
we look at source and medium we'll be
able to see what what campaigns drove
traffic to the website so here I can see
vertical response email as a driver of
traffic so that's the campaign reporting
and then also if you have search
consoles so we looked at search console
earlier we talked about SEO tools well
remember I said you can link up search
console with Google analytics well
here's search console and we could see
queries devices landing pages countries
so all the performance metrics that we
could see in search console because we
have it linked up with analytics we
could see it right here so this gives us
a nice snapshot of what keywords are
driving traffic to the site organically
I could see The Impressions I could see
the clicks then I could see the clicked
array and then the average position so
in theory the higher something ranks the
more traffic you're going to get so
that's the idea behind it we want to
make sure sure that we're ranking for
our coveted keywords and if we are we
want to be able to measure how many
times our listing was seen and how many
times it was clicked so that's the great
thing about you know Google they have a
family of products and those products
tend to talk to one another in the form
of Google search console and Google ads
you can connect them directly to Google
analytics so let's move from acquisition
to behavior so here in Behavior we have
a number of different reports so
Behavior tells us what's the traffic
actually arrived at the website how are
they behaving and so really what I would
do is from there go to site content all
pages and so this gives us an idea of
how many pages were actually viewed so
site content all pages tells us what
page and how many times it was viewed
during a period of time and again we're
looking at year to day so I can see
engagement related metrics associated
with a page so this particular page here
on line one I could see how many pages
unique Pages which is equal to sessions
so I can have a session come to the
website and look at a page multiple
times in that session I could see the
average time the person has spent on a
page and I can also see the bounce rate
so a bounce rate indicates that they
arrived on the page and didn't go any
further they left the website from that
page that they arrived on and so I can
also see percentage of exits meaning
what page did people exit the site from
so these are all engagement related
metrics so here is where I want to react
and optimize my website performance so I
if I see a page now performing well
meaning it has a high bounce rate or
maybe low time on page then I'm probably
going to optimize it meaning test it or
change it to improve performance so
these are all pages but I could
certainly look at landing pages okay so
landing pages tells us the behavior of
the page when somebody landed on it so a
landing page means that somebody came
from organic search or paid search or
another Channel landed on this page so
here I could see this particular page on
line one had
4970 sessions okay and I can also see
the performance of that page so
measuring engagements against pages is
definitely important because page isn't
performing in terms of Bounce rate or
time on page then we want to be able to
make changes to that page to improve
performance okay there are some other
great reports under Behavior so we want
to go to site speed we want to look at
how fast or how slow our Pages load so
this is important from an SEO
perspective because if a page isn't
loading very fast then chances of it
getting ranked in Google are not very
good so Google's organic search
basically takes page load time seriously
so if page doesn't load very fast then
we need to be able to fix it so we can
go to page timings I can get a good
sense of the average page load time of a
particular page and what Google does
here is under speed suggestions they
actually will give me some ideas and
speed suggestions on how to address a
page that's loading very slow and so
when we load up the speed suggestions
report what Google does is say hey we
know that this page is loading very slow
the average page load time is 15 seconds
here's some suggestions we're going to
give you seven suggestions so if you
click on that what's actually going to
happen is you're going to go to another
tool called page speed insights and Page
speed inside is analyzing the page as
you can see here and when it's done
analyzing the page it's going to give
you some feedback on how to improve page
load performance not only for desktop
but for mobile so here I can see if I
scroll down this is desktop and these
are some of the opportunities that I can
address when trying to improve the page
load time of that particular page so
here I could see there's some server
response time issues image sizes
probably need to be resized I can remove
unused CSS okay so there are a lot of
different things I can do to improve the
page load time on this particular page
okay this is for desktop I can also see
mobile so mobile a lot of the same
issues so if we address these these
opportunities then we could see a lift
in page load time we see lift and Page
load time we're going to probably say a
lift in organic rankings or even user
engagement because if a page takes a
long time to load a user is probably not
going to stay on that page very long so
to me site speed is an important report
under Behavior now one more report here
that I want to point out under behavior
is events and to me events are important
so if you're trying to measure
engagement on your website you need to
make sure you have event tracking set up
and when we talk about event tracking
we're talking about measuring things
that analytics doesn't measure by
default so if you have a button on your
website if you have a PDF download if
you have a submit button on a form
submission if you have a subscribe
button if you have a video but if you
have an external link anything that is
going to trigger engagement on your
website you need to measure with event
tracking and event tracking is simply
set up by breaking out the event into a
category an action and a label and so
here we could see for our particular
website we have categories already set
up for event tracking so here for
example I can say on line six video I
could see how many people actually
watched our video okay so here's the
action video Start okay so over this
period of time I could see I had 49
unique events 50 total so that's how
many people actually watched the video
and you can always report to label and
that'll tell you what page people
watched in this case the video so event
tracking is important because we want to
be able to measure engagement so if we
go to events under behavior and you
don't see any events listed you probably
need to get that set up and that is set
up through Google tag manager so what
you want to do is you want to be able to
set up your events through to Google tag
manager which is another Google platform
but you certainly want to do that so
that's where you set up your events when
you set up your events for your website
with a category in action and label
you'll be able to measure those events
in analytics under Behavior under events
and the important thing here is you'll
be able to measure engagement so I'll be
able to see how many people came to the
site and how many people clicked on a
button downloaded a PDF submitted a form
played a video did whatever we wanted
them to do so events are important so
let's move from Behavior to conversions
and this is important because we want to
be able to measure conversions on a
website so analytics has four types of
conversions so if I go to admin down at
the bottom and then I go to go goals I
could say that I have four different
types of goals that I can use now right
now I have event related goals set up
for the website for this particular
website so we just talked about event
tracking so if you're measuring a button
click on your website you can certainly
turn that into a goal and so all you
need to do is tell analytics hey this is
the particular category this is the
particular action so for example if I
click on this particular goal and take a
look at it I can see that we have a
category set up that anything that
resembles donate now okay or donate go
ahead and fire this event as a
conversion okay so event is one type of
goal another type of goal is destination
so somebody goes to a specific page like
a confirmation page we can turn that
into a goal so here I could see if
somebody goes to Don donation Dash
confirmation then analytics is going to
fire that goal as a conversion and we're
going to see a conversion against a
different metric or different dimension
like Channel or audience okay so
destination is the second type of goal
the third type of goal is duration so
how long did somebody stay on my website
so in this example if they stayed at
least one minute and 30 seconds or more
then analytics is going to count that as
a goal conversion okay so duration is
the third type and then the fourth type
is pages per session okay so if I look
at this example here if a user came to
my website and looked at more than three
pages in that particular session then
analytics is going to fire a gold
conversion so four types of goals you
don't have to set up all four different
types my recommendation is at least have
one goal set up if you're not sure what
goal to set up then at least set up a
duration or pages per session okay so at
least you can measure how long somebody
stays on your website or how many pages
they went to okay so when you actually
do have these goals set up you can go
back into conversions we can go back
into goals we can go back into overview
and we can measure our goal completions
over this period of time so here I could
see 313 goal completions total with a
gold conversion rate of 1.88 and then I
could see it broken down by goal type so
remember the only goals I have available
and set up are event related goals so 69
newsletter signups 156 donate click
buttons I have 32 contact form
submissions 37 email click completions
and then 11 phone number click
completions so I can measure and
engagement as a goal and so goals
generally are important to the business
so you want to make sure that if you
have a goal for your website then you
want to be able to set that up as a goal
in Google analytics so that way when
you're looking at example channels if I
go back to my channels report I can then
measure Channel by goal conversion so
these are all goals but if I want to
look at for example how many people from
organic search clicked on the Donate Now
button I could see that I could see
year-to-date 10
887 users which meant 11 000 sessions 76
clicked on that donate Now button and
that comes out to 0.65 conversion rate
okay so that's important so you want to
be able to measure any Dimension whether
that be Channel Source medium keyword
Third campaign mobile device could be
demographic gender or age you want to be
able to measure any Dimension against
the goals you have set up so you can
measure performance and that also
includes Pages or landing pages as well
so that's a quick overview of what you
can expect to see in Google analytics
again audience acquisition behavior and
conversions so a lot of data in Google
analytics but you want to be able to
take advantage of the data in order to
improve website performance now let's
jump over to YouTube analytics because
if you have videos on YouTube if you
have a channel set up some playlists
you'll be able to get some really good
insights as to how your videos
performing and so here I could see I'm
in YouTube all I did was I went to my
account then I went to the beta the
studio version version of YouTube and
then from there I went to analytics so
my account YouTube Studio analytics and
analytics here is going to give me all
sorts of information about my videos
okay so here I could see over the last
28 days my videos produced over 8 600
views my watch time in minutes totaled
over 17
000 and I've netted 48 subscribers and
this is an overall okay so I can
actually see when I publish videos and I
can see the date they were published and
here I'm looking at you know total views
over this particular date range I can
also see specifics on a particular video
so I could see the top video in terms of
minutes here I could see this particular
video had 602 minutes over the last 28
days so here I could see views on a
particular video so this is is just an
overview I could certainly look at some
other information if I click on reach
viewers I could see the total impression
so how many times my video was viewed or
how many people looked at it okay and
then the click-through rate so here I
could see the different traffic sources
so 29 came externally okay here I could
see 25 came within YouTube itself I
could see how many times a video was
viewed and played via playlist via
suggested video so I could see different
ways in which the traffic found my video
and actually watched it here I could see
externally how people were able to find
my videos and I could see 46 percent
found it via Google search see some lots
of information here about sources of
traffic how the traffic got to these
videos so I could see then once the
traffic found my videos how many times
they actually saw it and viewed it and
then watched it so that's how many times
I was able to reach viewers via
different sources and then their
reaction to that how many times they saw
it and watched it here I can click on
interest viewers so again I could see
the top videos in terms of watch time I
could see the top playlist so here I
could see my partners playlist was the
top playlist so I could see some
interest here in terms of average view
duration and then here we have build an
audience so we can look at specific
audiences if we have them built in
YouTube to see how many people actually
watch my videos so here I can see 88 of
the people who watched my videos over
the last 28 days were not even
subscribed so that tells me a lot of
people are finding my videos spending
some time watching them if they're not
subscribed so we're trying to get them
to subscribe to our channel so they can
watch more so a lot of information here
in YouTube itself about how our videos
performed again this is good Insight
because ideally what you want to do is
you really want to take a look at a
specific video see how it's performing
so if I just click on one particular
video I can actually see the audience
retention over the course of the video
itself I could see the ways in which
people found the video okay again
externally or via YouTube search I could
see how many people liked it or disliked
it I could see all sorts of information
on a particular video itself or an
overview of my channel so that's all
available to you in YouTube analytics
under YouTube studio so take advantage
of this if you're publishing videos on a
regular basis you want to hone in on how
your videos are performing so if you
have any additional questions about
YouTube Analytics or YouTube in general
take a look at our video that we created
earlier this year about how to create a
YouTube channel we go into some in-depth
insights into YouTube itself especially
YouTube analytics so take a look at that
video and if you have any other insights
about YouTube analytics or analytics in
general go ahead and put a comment below
this video so let's turn our attention
to competitor spying tools very
important to keep tabs on what the
competition's doing and there are a lot
of tools out there so when it comes to
social we can use a freemium tool like
Sprout social to listen in on our
competitors we can use another freemium
tool social blade there's a popular tool
out there called spyfu that's freemium
as well Moz we looked at Moz earlier for
keyword organic Moz is a great tool for
also leveraging our competitors in terms
of backlinks and buzzsumos so that's
another framing tool get there lots of
tools out there these are just examples
of some of the tools that we use here at
simply learn I use personally and
professionally to get a sense of what
our competition is doing so why would we
want to use a competitor spine tool well
it may sound like a very straightforward
question but there are lots of reasons
why and so let's look at some of these
reasons and the first reasons we really
want to identify you know our
competitors backlinks and monitor
changes in the ranking so the reason why
we have this is the top bullet point is
because SEO organic search is a
long-term strategy on page off-page
website very tactical and creative
there's a lot going on with SEO a lot
going on and sometimes it takes a long
time to rank for something and a lot of
SEO does depend on relevancy relevancy
being how many quality backlinks are
linked to you so it's always good to
leverage what your competitors are doing
so you can see how you stack up and so
that's why this is up there as number
one we want to be able to really take a
look at what our competitors are doing
another example would be hey how much a
traffic a competitors gaining on certain
keywords this could go either way for
paid search organic search what are
competitors bidding on are they really
getting traffic from those keywords so
there are tools out there that help us
leverage what our competitions doing
okay we can also identify our
competitors top performing content for
Relevant topics okay we can determine
what our competitors website referral
traffic is okay we can pull our
competitors data and compare it with our
own campaigns so lots of tools out there
to help you do this and we may want to
track the total amount of clicks a
competitor receives and how much they
pay for each keyword so let's go ahead
and take a look at a few examples how we
can leverage all the these bullet points
that we just discussed and so we're
going to start out with Sprout social
and Sprout social is a tool I use it's a
social media platform there's a lot of
things you can do with Sprout social
definitely generate reports for your
social media platforms you could set up
post that get published at a certain
time and day but there's also one
particular tool in here called listening
and so what we could do is we just put
in for example RV rentals and Twitter so
what we're doing is we're actually
listening to see who else is tweeting
about RV rentals so we could do this for
Twitter we could do it Facebook some
other social media platforms the whole
idea here on Sprout social is to get a
sense of what our competitors are doing
so we could have easily put in a brand
name we're just going General here
because we want to rank for the keyword
RV rentals and so here we could take a
look at uh you know with some of these
particular brands are doing like go RV
rentals Cruise America RV we could see
just scroll down and we can get a sense
of in particular what people are
tweeting about what other companies are
tweeting when it comes to this
particular keyword RV rentals now if I
want to hone in on a particular
competitor I could just really refine my
search for that competitor's brand name
so RV share so here I could take a look
at you know what they're doing when
they're posting or tweeting how long ago
the time of day get an idea of what
they're actually saying what campaigns
they're promoting okay I can get a sense
of everything about this tweet and so
here I can scroll down and I can see
what's been shared by other people for
this particular brand and I can see a
lot of people are as an example
retweeting this particular giveaway and
so to me it just gives me a sense in
this particular example on Twitter
Twitter as to what our competitors doing
okay let's start our attention to SEO so
remember that first bullet point we want
to get a sense of what our competitors
are doing when it comes to backlinks and
so Moz has a great tool called link
Explorer and Link Explorer there allows
us to actually compare link profiles so
for my domain I can go ahead and put my
competitors domains in there and
definitely get a sense of you know how
many links my competitors have external
Intel internal I can get a cent I can
get a sense of page Authority linking
domains so I can really do a comparison
across my domain and my competitors
domains to get a snapshot of how I
compare against my competitors so this
gives me an overview of everything I
need to know organically now Moz also
has a another great tool under link
Explorer called link intersect and I
like Linkin intersect I use it a lot
because if our competitors really have a
number of external links and domains
pointing to their site and they have a
better domain Authority and Page
Authority then you know I want to be
able to you know see what they're doing
where they're linking who's linking to
them I want to get be able to get a
snapshot of why is their domain so much
better than ours in terms of authority
and so the link intersect actually
allows me to do that so I can go ahead
and put my competitors domains in there
and then I can find Opportunities and so
you just click on opportunities and you
can see where my site intersects with
their site and if it doesn't actually
intersect then I have an opportunity to
actually try and get a link on that
particular site so that's what the link
intersect report does it allows me to
see where my links intersect with my
competitors and if it doesn't intersect
then I have an opportunity to generate a
backlink so that's ideally what the link
intersect tool is in Moz it allows me to
really get a sense of you know where I'm
linking and where my competitors are
linking now what we can also do is also
take advantage of another report under
moz's link Explorer and the discovered
and lost report so we could put in our
domain or we could put even our
competitors domain in there and we can
get a sense of what domains were found
and linked to them so really within Moz
we can get a good snapshot of what
websites are linking to our competitors
we get a good snapshot of the overall
links to our competitor sites and
specifically what sites so the whole
idea is if it's good for our competitors
meaning they're linking from a site that
has good domain Authority and low spam
score then it's probably a site I want
to be able to tackle as well okay so you
have to discovered and lost okay you
have comparing link profiles and you
have link intersect so those are three
good reports you can leverage right in
moz's link Explorer tool now there's one
more report we can leverage in Moz and
that's the inbound links report and so
we can go ahead and type in our
competitors domain here and again we can
get a snapshot of what their domain
Authority is Page Authority for the home
page but really this is what we're after
linking domains so this particular
domain has over 9 000 linking domains so
what we can do is actually go through
and see based on domain Authority I
could sort by domain Authority where
these pages are being linked from and so
here I can see Reddit
so a lot of Reddit here which is a good
site for backlinking New York Times so
you know there's a lot of different uh
sites here Washington Post so I can get
a good snapshot of my company editor by
seeing every link that's pointing to
them now of course I don't want to go
through 9000 links I can really just
hone in on a specific link Source or
link type or link state so I can really
filter it if I wanted to I can export
the report and do some further analysis
but really the whole idea here as I
could see what URL is linking to this
particular competitor site what the
anchor text is what the page and domain
Authority is so this gives me a really
really good Insight on all the
backlinking that my competitor has and
again if I'm trying to catch my
competitor it's probably not a bad idea
to look at what they're doing and even
copy what they're doing in terms of
backlinking so if we're not on Reddit
then we probably need to be on Reddit
because if that's where our competitor
is and they're getting good link juice
from Reddit which has a domain authority
of 90. then hey if it's good for the
goose it's good for the game and or so
they say so inbound links is just
another good report you can leverage in
Moz under the link Explorer reporting
tool now if I want to get a good
snapshot as to what my competitor is
doing on search exactly well look no
further than spy food so spyfu is a
another tool that you can leverage from
a PPC SEO perspective you know from an
SEO perspective you got some backlinking
data as well just like you did in Moz
from a PPC perspective you can get some
good keyword insights and so here I just
went ahead and typed in the domain and
what this is going to do is just give me
an overall snapshot for my competitor's
domain so here I could see you know how
many organic keywords they're found for
the estimated monthly SEO clicks they're
getting based on the volume of those
keywords okay I could see here the
keywords their top competitors also rank
for the rank history 12 years so the
this particular domain's been around a
long time okay so that's on the organic
side you can flip over to the paid side
and I could see that they are doing paid
search I could see 5000 plus keywords
they're bidding on okay based on that
what they're actually paying and then I
could see you know some of the other
competitors listed here from a paid
perspective and an organic perspective I
could see the shared keyword overlap
okay now again you can pay for this
because it's freemium and get some
really good insights as to how your
domain compares to your competitors so
I'm using the free version and here the
free version spy food's just giving me
some overall data on the specific domain
I entered in and so I entered in my
competitors you can certainly enter in
your own domain to get a sense of
organic keywords and paid keywords so
you can see top keywords top paid
keywords okay this is Google ads Okay so
this is what recommendations as to what
to purchase okay here you can see some
even some at Google ads history I could
see exactly what ad copy my competitor
actually wrote and for what keyword and
then I could see some organic ranking
history here as I keep scrolling down
this overview report so I can see for RV
rent where they rank and then I can see
inbound links just like I did in Moz spy
food is providing me with some insight
as to hey what links are pointing to
them and what the domain strength is and
how many clicks they expect to receive
so this is all free data take it or
leave it but it's all free data
available to you under spy food so spy
few gives you kind of an overview for
free some really in-depth analysis if
you actually pay for it and it just
really hones in on what your competitors
are bidding for paid wise and what
they're ranking for organic wise and so
spy food is a really good tool The
Leverage if you just want to get a
snapshot of how your competitor overlaps
with you so let's turn our attention to
Google analytics because in Google
analytics under audience I can go to
benchmarking and basically the
benchmarking reports allows me to see
what the industry as a whole is doing
compared to my own website now the
caveat here on this particular report is
that it's all Anonymous data so I can't
exactly see what competitor is doing
what in this report but if I hone in on
my industry in this case autos and
vehicles and I hone in on a specific
country or adjust the size of the daily
sessions that I get then I can see hey
analytics in this case in this example
I'm sharing
8863 web properties okay so they're
sharing the data for over 8 000 web
properties and I can compare those web
properties against my own so if we're
all in the same industry it gives me a
sense here as to how I stack up against
the industry as a whole in this case as
it pertains to channels so you can see
here red not good green is good so in
the industry we're not doing as good as
others in the same industry who are
receiving the same amount of sessions
now we could certainly adjust and we can
adjust our Locale and if we do that
Google's going to be able to adjust how
many web properties are actually
contributing to the report and so when
analytics makes that adjustment we're
going to be able to see in this case
just New Zealand so we're going to
adjust for New Zealand and we're going
to go with the
4999 and so we could see there are about
you know 300 something web properties
contributing 47 web properties now
contributing to the this report so if
we're focused on the New Zealand region
and this is the amount of traffic we get
we're now comparing us against 47 other
Anonymous web properties so now if I go
back to the report after I've honed in
I'm looking at channels and I can see
how many sessions we're getting by
channels and how I compare against the
competition I can also measure up
against percentage of new sessions new
users pages per session average session
duration bounce rate but that's just
channels I can also do location and
devices so the whole idea behind this
report is yes you're not honing in on a
particular competitor but you're honing
in on your industry so you're getting a
good idea as to how you compare against
your industry just by making some
adjustments in the benchmarking report
you obviously want to make sure you're
looking at the same industry adjust for
your country or region adjust for the
site size meaning how many sessions you
actually get on a daily basis and then
analytics will do the rest they'll
compare you against those in your
industry and so I find this to be a good
tool because it allows me to stack up
our site against those in the industry
and obviously if we're not driving as
many sessions especially say from
organic then we have our work cut out
for us okay so that's the whole idea
behind the benchmarking report now if
you want to get some good insight as to
what the competitors are doing and you
don't want to use a tool well look no
farther you can always go to google.com
Okay so this is how we used to do it
back in the day before all these tools
became available you just typed in a
keyword and we're going to type in RV
rentals and now we're going to be able
to see who's bidding on that keyword so
we could see we have a number of
different uh companies bidding on the
keyword we're interested in okay here I
can see some featured Snippets okay and
then I can see some organic search
results results okay if I scroll down
I'll be able to see some other companies
bidding on that same keyword meaning
they're paying for RV rentals so if I
clicked on somebody's link here they're
actually going to pay Google for the
click and so this just gives me a good
sense of you know how many people are
actually trying to rank for this keyword
or trying to be found for this keyword
so that's all I did I just did a search
now from an organic perspective if you
really want to hone in on your
competition you can always do the syntax
all in title colon and then hit enter so
now I could see I have 163
000 results and what does that tell me
that tells me that I have a 163
000 websites with RV rentals in the
title tag so if you're trying to
optimize for the keyword RV rentals as
an example then you know that you have a
000 different listings ahead of you that
you need to jump over in order to rank
for the keyword RV rentals so using the
All in title syntax and the keyword
right after that actually just gives you
a more accurate picture of how many
sites are actually ahead of you for a
particular keywords so that's the whole
idea so if I get rid of the syntax and
you can see for RV rentals I have 132
million but that's not really accurate
because not all these listings have the
keyword RV rentals in the title Tag and
Title tag if you're working on organic
search is one of the key important
factors for ranking so you need to have
that keyword in the title tag so that's
the whole idea behind using the All
entitled syntax it gives us a good idea
as to what our competition is doing and
how many sites we have to jump over to
get to number one on Google Now if
you're running Google ads just as we did
with RV rentals we went up there and we
saw we typed that in as a query and we
saw how many advertising advisors there
were for RV rentals now if we are
running our own campaigns Google ads
actually has a good report that I really
like it's called auction insights and so
you can get to auction insights just by
clicking on campaigns and then from
campaigns click on auction insights and
when auction insights allows us to see
is what competitors or domains are
bidding on the same keywords we are and
so what Google does here is it allows us
to actually see where we stack up
against our competition for all the
keywords we're bidding on and so here
I'm looking at year to date and here we
could see us and I can see our
competitors okay so I could see
impression share so for if we're talking
about one key word every keyword has a
hundred percent impression share how
much of that impression share are you
getting and when we say impression share
meaning eyeballs when we talk about
eyeballs are we getting a majority of
the eyeballs or our competitors get a
majority they have calls so we can see
our average position I can see how often
I overlap with my competitors okay I
could see how often I'm above a
particular competitor I could see what
percentage I'm at the top of the page
versus my competitors the absolute top
of page rate and then I can see how
often I outrank my competitors and vice
versa how often my competitors outrank
me so I can see all this good insight as
to what competitors are bidding on the
same keywords I am okay so this is if
you're running Google ads okay so if
you're running Google ads okay you can
just click on the auction insights
report you can find that at the top
navigation just by clicking on campaigns
and by doing so you'll be able to gain
some insights as to where you stack up
from a paid search perspective against
your competitors so let's turn our
attention to paid marketing tools so if
you're doing some advertising on Google
Bing LinkedIn you probably want to work
within those platforms as the tool of
choice so you know if you're doing paid
search on say googlesearch.com or
display you could be doing display
advertising on you know a network like
adroll or Google or you could be doing
social media paid ads say on Facebook so
whatever it is you're doing you probably
want to work within that platform itself
to get the ideal data that you need okay
so here are some of the tools some of
the places you can go of course if
you're working Google ads you also have
Google ads editor that you can leverage
okay and I'll show you that in a couple
minutes you have Google ads Keyword
Planner of course both of these are paid
if you're running campaigns okay so Bing
if you're running campaigns on Bing okay
you get all this good data that you can
digest through some reporting okay you
also have some third-party tools out
there that you also have to pay for in
word stream okay so word streams a third
party tool that you can leverage Bing
and Google are actual advertising
Network so you would advertise on the
platform itself and get all the data you
need right in the platform and leverage
a lot of the tools that they have
available in the platform as I mentioned
you could also use Google ads editor so
Bing also has their own editor as well
so and as well as Facebook so you can
use an editor type version and I'll show
you that here in a couple minutes but
let's talk about why we want to use the
tools in the platform itself well we
want to be able to monitor how our ads
performing so which ad receives the most
traffic as an example we want to
identify keywords that are performing
for us okay so our keywords converting
not converting are they cost us a lot of
money and not netting a high enough
return for us so we want to keep an eye
on that okay so we want to monitor our
cost okay across different locations and
devices not only cost but we want to
also monitor how our ads are performing
across different locations of devices
keywords across different locations and
devices so we want to be able to measure
by device okay so we also want to
analyze competitors data and as we
showed you in the competitor section
Google as an example has auction
insights reporting analytics has
benchmarking so Google itself does
provide some information in the case of
auction insights as to how your
competitors are performing against you
on Google search so that's on the page
search side then you have display okay
so display advertisements okay you're
across a different network so there are
different types of networks out there
for example Admiral okayo seltra is
another paid version of or pay tool you
can use in wide orbit so these are some
of the paid marketing tools you can
leverage of course I like to stay if I'm
advertising on Google I like to stay on
and Google ads and measure my display
performance that way but if you're on
adroll for example then you want to
leverage ad roles reporting platform and
some of the tools they have to offer so
if we look at display why do we want to
leverage some of these tools well just
like search for example where we want to
look at keyword and AD performance same
kind of concept here we want to be able
to monitor whether we have the right
keywords and write customer engagement
so when when it comes to display we want
to be able to to make sure we're
choosing the right audience of course
that means looking at not only audience
insights but our Target insights as well
are we reaching the Right audience when
it comes to display and Google has a
good breakdown that I'm going to be able
to show you here in a couple minutes
okay so we want to improve our campaigns
by monitoring our competitors display
ads as well so there are tools available
that'll help you do that and that's on
the display side if we look at Social
okay why what tools can we use on social
well you got Facebook ads manager okay
you got ad espresso quiet tweepy you get
all these cool paid search tools again I
usually stick with where I'm advertising
so if I'm advertising on LinkedIn or
Twitter I'm going to leverage that
platform but just know that there are
other tools available for you so a
social like display it's all about
targeting our audience so for these some
of the tools like on Facebook we can
review and relaunch our ad campaigns
based on target audience we can measure
conversions and gain insights in this
example about Facebook users how are our
users interacting with our ads and then
we want to Target People based on their
activities such as purchase intent
device usage travel preferences Etc so
social allows us to do that and then
with Facebook as an example we can
monitor any a B test we run for example
if we're running call to action tests we
can measure the results that right in
Facebook and I'm going to show you an
example of that here shortly so let's
jump right into Google ads and look at
some tools available to us from the
search side of the house so if we're
running search campaigns right in Google
ads we could see campaign data we can
see keyword data we could see add data
so for example if I want to see what ads
are performing I'm just going to click
on my ads and extensions okay and here
are my ads and now I could see what ads
are performing in terms of clicks
click-through rates
Etc and so that way I can go ahead and
pause ads activate ads so that's right
here in the Google ads platform itself
now if I want to look at specific
keywords I can do that so I can see what
keywords are driving traffic and clicks
here I could just sort by clicks and now
I can see not only what keywords are
driving clicks I could see what the
click-through rate is I can see the
Impressions how many people actually
viewed my ad after click typing in a
keyword query that I'm betting on I
could see how much I've paid by keyword
and more importantly I want to be able
to see conversions or conversion rate
and then with Google ads you have
quality score so we want to be able to
measure qualities for so so this is a
Google ads keyword reporting and so the
great thing about the keyword reporting
is that there's some other features
available to me here so here I can add
negative keywords okay just by clicking
on negative keywords I can also see a
Search terms report and so when it comes
to search terms I can actually see what
specific keywords people typed in and
based on the keyword that somebody typed
in as a query I can see what match type
triggered that particular ad and so if I
see a keyword query that I don't
particularly care to be shown for or I
want my ad shown for then I can go ahead
and just select it and I can add it as a
negative keyword okay so that tool is
available to you right in Google ads
okay and then you have the auction
Insight so we've reviewed the auction
insights when we're looking at
competitive analysis and so here if we
look at the auction insights we'll be
able to adjust our date range and we'll
be able to see basically you know who
else is bidding on the keywords and what
the impression share is what their
average position is what their overlap
rate is position above rate top of page
absolute top of page right now rankings
here so once we have Google has data
then they'll be able to share that
information with you okay so that's just
key words but there's a cool tool that I
really like and I leverage it for SEO
and pay-per-click and that's Google's
Keyword Planner so if you click on tools
and then you click on Keyword Planner
we'll be able to Leverage The Keyword
Planner and the whole idea behind the
Keyword Planner is do we want to
discover new keywords or for the
keywords we have selected we can get
volume and forecast on that so here
let's type in a keyword mail delivery
and if I click get started okay so
Google's going to give me some other
keyword ideas and they're going to give
me what the average monthly searches are
for that keyword they're going to let me
know the competition they're going to
give me a range in terms of how much I
can expect to pay for that keyword so if
I happen to click on that keyword I can
add it to a plan and then once I've
added to a plan then I can go ahead and
look at that plan and measure what kind
of volume I'm going to get and how much
I can expect to pay so now once I've
added my keyword to that plan I can go
ahead and see how many clicks and
Impressions and costs and click the rate
and average cost per click I can expect
to spend so and this is based on a
maximum CPC of two dollars so I can go
ahead and adjust my plan accordingly if
I want to in order to see basically how
much I can expect to spend so that's the
whole idea behind the keyword Banner in
terms of choosing new keywords and once
you choose keywords you're interested in
bidding on you can actually do a
forecast to see exactly how much you can
expect to spend how many clicks how many
Impressions you can expect to get and if
you have conversions set up how many
conversions you can expect to receive so
that's all part of Google's keyword plan
that's viewing forecast as well as
choosing keywords so there are so many
different tools and features within
Google ads we need a whole whole segment
just on this so really I'm just going to
highlight some of the more important
tools and features so I mentioned the
Keyword Planner I imagine the campaigns
keywords and ads reports another thing I
would look at in Google ads again we
mentioned this as one of our key
defining why would we use it bullet
point and that's because of devices so
we mentioned devices why would we use
Google ads reporting tools because we
want to look at devices and we want to
be able to see what devices are driving
traffic from what campaign and then the
cool thing about Google ads is write in
Google ads platform you can go ahead and
do a bit adjustment so if I increase my
bid adjustment for example on mobile
phones then my particular ad in this
particular campaign is going to show
more than on computer so I can always
decrease it for example do a bit
adjustment on computer and that means
I'm going to show my ads less so I can
go ahead and do bid adjustments based on
device that's the cool thing of working
right in Google ads platform is you can
make adjustments right here in the
platform based on devices well you also
have locations too so we mentioned that
as one of the reasons why we want to use
some of these tools and if I see a
particular location I'm not interested
in advertising well I can always select
it and I can always just pause it or
remove it so or I can change the bit
adjustment on a location as well so I
can make a lot of different changes
right in the Google ads platform for
those seasoned and search advertising
paid search advertising especially on
Google ads you can always use Google ads
editor all you need to do is just do a
search for Google ads editor you can
download it so basically what Google ads
editor is it's a it's a tool it's the
software that you work your ca with your
campaigns on locally so you're making
changes to your campaigns on your
computer and basically when you're done
making changes you can always upload
them to Google ads to the account on
Google ads in the cloud so to speak so
that's the whole idea behind Google ads
editor it's a great tool for you to use
if you want to make household changes
really quick for example I'm looking at
an account with a bunch of campaigns so
now if I click on one of those campaigns
I could see the ad groups here okay so
for example I just wanted to turn off
all these ad groups I can just highlight
them all and just click status enable to
paused and I can revert back if I want
to okay so you can make household
changes so here I could see the campaign
the ad group level if I choose an ad
group then I can see some keywords and
again I can make changes at nauseum here
I can copy I can paste I can delete okay
so I can make a lot of changes really
quick write in Google ads editor and
that's the whole point of editor is to
go ahead and work locally while somebody
else is working locally on the same
account you could both be working
simultaneously and being more efficient
on getting things done in the campaign
now if you are working with somebody
else on the campaign you want to make
sure that you get recent change changes
so if I say get recent changes to all
campaigns what Google editor is going to
do is contact Google ads in the cloud
and download all those changes so here I
can see the changes being download and
editor from Google ads and when it's
done it's going to highlight all the
changes that have been made and so once
I'm done reviewing those changes I can
go ahead and click done and now I know I
have the recent latest changes in editor
so now I can go ahead and continue to
make some changes and when I'm done
making changes I can go ahead and post
them so that's the beauty of Google ads
editor Bing has a version Facebook has a
version it allows you to again go with
the keyword level the ad group level
okay you can look at ads itself and make
changes to the ads okay you can do a lot
of different things write an editor in
fact you could do pretty much most of
what you could do in Google ads you can
do in Google ads editor and so that's
Google ads Editor to me I would
recommend it if you're experience with
Google ads again it's software you have
to download it you're going to use it on
your computer as software but when you
make changes all you need to do is post
those changes or get recent changes that
have been made on Google ads and so
that's Google editor ads editor in
summary now let's go back into Google
ads and talk about display advertising
because display is a different network
but the platform's still the same and
some of the same tools are available
from the search Network as well as for
the Display Network right in Google ads
so if I want to take a look at a
campaign and AD group on the Display
Network I can just click on that ad
group and I can look at the ads that are
running for that particular ad group on
the Display Network so here the
difference being on the display network
is you can use image ads on the search
Network you can only use text ads so
here I can look look at image ads and I
can see how they're performing in fact
you could even go a step further and use
responsive display ads so Google has
responsive display ads meaning it's
going to respond to what's performing
best okay and so now I can see clicks
Impressions click-through rate Etc right
on on my ads and extensions report in
Google ads platform now this happens to
be retargeting campaign so if we click
on audiences we'll be able to see what
audiences we're targeting here okay so
when this report loads when you run
retargeting campaigns you're targeting a
specific audience and so we want to be
able to see okay of the audiences we
have set up what audience is performing
best okay so here I can see a Breakout
by audience again I could see the same
metrics I could see on the search side I
could see clicks and Impressions click
the rate more importantly I want to be
able to measure conversions okay so
that's the whole idea when you're in
these platforms and you're paying for
ads is you want to be able to measure
against conversions and you can also
measure against cost per conversion
conversion rate okay so those are some
key metrics to measure up against
whether it's audience keyword add
whatever the dimension is so here on the
Display Network we can get a sense of
demographics okay so unlike the search
Network the Display Network allows us to
see demographic data and so now I could
see an age breakout or an age range
breakout that Google provides us and I
can see again based on the age range
breakout which age range has the most
clicks Impressions
Etc including conversions so you also
have the opportunity on the display
networked at keywords you have the
opportunity to add topics and you have
the opportunity to see placements or run
placements so here if I click on where
ADS have shown I can actually see where
my ads have shown up for this display
campaign and Google ads allows you the
ability to go ahead and you can exclude
it from the ad group exclude a specific
placement from a campaign so you could
take action on a specific placement and
I could see the type of placement
whether it's a mobile app whether it's a
site I can go ahead and see exactly
where that placement was so that's the
placements report you have demographics
you have audiences you have keywords you
have all these different reports
available to you on the Google ads
platform so before we jump over to
social media paid search advertising I
just want to remind you we do have you
know a nice tutorial on Google ads okay
so take a look at the Google ads
tutorial we have set up on on YouTube
okay if you search for Google ads
tutorial 2019 this is a good uh tutorial
on everything related to Google ads so
check out this video because in today's
webinar we're just mentioning tools
across the board and if you are
advertising on Google ads as most people
do then you could see just how powerful
it is and all the different features
that are available so take a look at the
video it's a nice complimentary video to
this one this digital marketing tools
and this will give you a nice and deeper
insight into everything that's available
on Google ads and if you have any tools
or features on Google ads whether it's
the search Network or whether that's the
Display Network then feel free to
comment below this video happy to hear
your comments about what tools and
reports and features you specifically
use in Google ads so let's move into to
uh Facebook ads manager and show you how
the platform looks when you're running
ads on Facebook so we can look at all
the different tools and reports
available here so here we could see if
we're in the Facebook ads manager we
could see our campaigns we could see our
ad sets and we can see our ads so just
like on Google ads you have less side
navigation so we can drill down so if we
want to see ad sets for example we could
just click on ad sets that are showing
up in this particular account and here
we can see we have two ad sets that are
live so if I click on one of these ad
sets I'll be able to see an actual ad
that's running here and so for the
actual ad that's running I can then see
the results of that ad and how it's
performing for example you know how many
clicks it's received what the reach is
what the impressions are so Impressions
similar to Google ads how many people
are actually looking at the ad and I can
see the cost per click here at one
dollar as an example and so now I can go
in and I can go ahead and look at the ad
performance and go ahead and change out
that ad if it's not performing to my
expectation so if I click on more tools
and then creatives I can just simply
click on creatives and then I can
actually see the create is I actually
have running for that campaign I
selected so now I can see all the
creatives that are running and I can see
the results of those creatives so
Facebook ads manager also has a
different reporting so if I click on the
reports pull down menu you can see here
I could see some standard reports by add
ad set age and gender and then I can see
all reports here listed out by placement
by placement and device time of day
country Etc so if we just look at age
and gender we'll be able to get a
breakout age and gender here so you can
see by campaign I'm looking at all
campaigns here and I'm looking at just
age and gender I can certainly deselect
one of these and I can look at a
specific time range so now I could see
who's looking at my ad specifically so
here I could see 35 to 44 female I can
see the reach Impressions and how often
they're actually seeing my ad now this
is key for Facebook because if
somebody's seen your ad a lot they're
probably going to tune out to it so
that's what makes the frequency metric
so important on Facebook because then we
can go ahead and you know turn off that
particular age and gender if we needed
to and we could see how much we spent so
this just gives you some idea of the
type of reporting that's available in
Facebook ads manager now the great thing
about phase Facebook reporting and ads
manager is you know I can group or
ungroup uh my Dimensions if I needed to
I could change the view and arrange
columns I can get rid of columns just as
you would in Google ads reporting very
similar stature here so I have a lot of
flexibility here on how I review the
reports you know you got different
metrics that you could pick and choose
as well okay and you got lots of
different flexibility when you're
looking at the reports on how your
campaigns are performing now here I can
pick and choose I can choose campaign ad
set ads objective again I can choose
different demographics so I have a lot
of options available to me in terms of
how I want to you know view the
performance of my campaign view the
performance of my ad set or my ad now
remember if you're in Facebook you can
always go in and edit the campaign you
can edit the ad set remember in the
asset that's where a lot of your
decisions are going to be made including
how you want to drive the traffic okay
what your budget is okay you can
basically choose your audience here so
you're going to be able to choose what
type of campaign it's going to be and
based on the campaign you're going to go
ahead and choose the kind of audience
you want to focus in on you're going to
be able to choose the location the age
range the gender so all of this is going
to be set up in the ad set or the
campaign or the ad if you go ahead and
edit an ad remember you can do a b
testing as well so you have a lot of
different options and features available
to you writing ads manager when you're
managing your paid search campaigns on
Facebook so if you want some more
information about all the different
features and tools and Facebook ads
manager check out the Facebook ads
tutorial tutorial 2019 a webinar that we
did earlier this year in addition you
can also look at another one that we did
on Facebook called Facebook advertising
tips and strategies so that should give
you some sense of everything related to
Facebook ads and how to take advantage
of the Facebook ads manager platform so
if there's anything on social that we
may have missed or that you use feel
free to add a comment below the video
we'd love to hear your feedback okay
let's talk about some affiliate
marketing tools let's turn our attention
affiliate marketing a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms out there the number
one probably is Commission Junction also
known as CJ they're an affiliate
platform they have a freemium model
meaning you can have a free trial but
basically you're gonna have to move on
and pay for the platform likewise for
house offers you have volume you really
when it comes to affiliate marketing a
lot of platforms out there click Inc A1
so a lot of these are Brokers per se and
when I say Brokers like for example with
CJ you as a merchant or you as a
publisher can get in touch with a
merchant you as a merchant can get in
touch with a publisher meaning CJ helps
bridge the gap between you finding
somebody to build your network with okay
so that's what really affiliate
marketing is and you really need a
platform to kind of put it all together
and and so a lot of a lot of affiliate
marketing platforms we're actually going
to take a look at CJ and go through some
of the features in the platform here
shortly but let's just take a look at
why we need these affiliate marketing
tools well these affiliate marketing
tools identify you know Affiliates
influors employees other Advocates you
want to partner with so again you can be
on the merch inside you could be
actually selling a product and you're
going to want somebody to help you sell
that product somebody with a website
who's an influencer who drives a lot of
traffic to their own site who you know
does sell reputable brand
Etc so you need somebody to help you
introduce you to these sites okay so CJ
and some of these other marketing
platforms affiliate marketing platforms
do that okay so these tools are there to
do the introductions the brokering the
relationship so the other benefit here
is you can contract with Affiliates and
track the traffic and conversions well
what do I mean by that well if you do
use cj.com by no means am I only
endorsing that platform there are plenty
others out there but whatever platform
you use you're going to want to be able
to set up terms and conditions with that
particular affiliate so you can set up a
terms and conditions for say 10 off all
sales as an example okay well you're
getting a platform that will help you
broker that contract okay contract terms
or program terms furthermore you're
gonna need a platform to help you track
hey is this affiliate helping me drive
traffic or is this affiliate driving
traffic to my products and is this
affiliate helping me sell so you the
these platforms help you do just that
okay so you can gain High website
rankings with the help of your affiliate
meaning that hey your affiliate can be
promoting your product and if they're
promoting your product you have a chance
to show up via paid search organic
search off other websites so social so
you have a lot of benefits to working
with affiliate marketing in itself and
the tools available will help you gain
website rankings as one example we want
to be able to track certain metrics Okay
so so an affiliate marketing you have
earnings per click EPC as an example
most platforms measure EPC from a seven
day period to a three month period okay
you can also figure out what the actual
cost per click is just like you do on
say Google search you can actually
measure that in affiliate okay you want
to eliminate fraudulent clicks
Impressions and conversions so any
affiliate platform worth its weight is
going to help you understand you know
how many Impressions and clicks and
conversions you're getting and help you
manage that in terms of fraudulent
clicks or hey if you're getting a lot of
Impressions and no clicks that's a
problem too so these platforms are
really built on helping you manage your
relationship with the affiliate by
offering uh all sorts of reports and
tools you know the other big benefit
here to affiliate marketing tool is hey
we can influence our customers
throughout their buying Journey so we
could set up different promotions based
on hey did somebody go to the website
did somebody see our product does
somebody click on a product did somebody
go into the shopping cart with our
product did somebody purchase our
product so there's all sorts of steps in
the funnel so to speak and hey you can
work with an affiliate a publisher to
influence your customers throughout that
purchasing funnel throughout that
Journey so let's go ahead and log in
here so when you log in like any other
digital marketing tool any other
platform you're going to have your own
settings and whatnot so really the whole
idea behind any affiliate marketing tool
is really there to manage your
Publishers who do you want as a
publisher who do you want selling your
product you obviously want somebody
who's relevant somebody who's going to
be able to sell the product somebody who
has a targeted audience that's similar
to yours okay so we go into cj.com we're
going to log in and here you can see a
Publisher's link so we're going to click
on the Publisher's link and remember
when you sign up Publishers you have to
have program terms and so if we click on
Publishers program terms we're going to
be able to see all the different program
terms available so here we could see the
different program terms we have set up
for certain Publishers so if we just
click on that we'll be able to see
that's the default program term so
remember you could set up your own
program term for any publisher so as a
best practice if you have Publishers who
are actually performing well who are
selling your products maybe you want to
offer them a little bit more on the
commission side maybe you want to
sweeten the deal maybe you know These
Guys these Publishers get better program
terms versus say other Publishers who
don't and so here we can see the program
terms basically you can see what the
terms are the action and the different
policies here so everything you you need
to do to manage that publisher in terms
of payment is done under the program
terms now if the program terms are met
the publisher actually sells your
products CJ is the broker they're the
ones who are going to initiate the
payment based on the program terms so be
careful in the program terms you want to
be able to set them appropriately CJ has
templates CJ has some default program
terms that you could use and offer up to
different Publishers So based on the
program terms that's how your Publishers
are going to get paid and so here you
can have as many different program terms
as you want There's No Limit here you
want to be able to align and reward
program terms again based on performance
and so here we can see what Publishers
are under what program terms so again if
your publisher is performing well
sweeten the deal offer them a better
program program terms and so you can
align Publishers with different program
terms and so that's the whole idea
behind program terms is you want to be
able to align Publishers with that so
when you sign up a publisher they're
going to get a line with the program
term meaning what are they going to get
paid for selling your product now if we
want to manage by status instead of by
program terms we could see all the
different organizations we have in our
Network these are our Publishers we're
the affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cj.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search we're
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click and
in terms of Publishers now you can
select under Publishers groups now you
can group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping in them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's gonna buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more Publishers you have on board
the better the opportunity so now once
you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever makes sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers let's turn our
attention to social media marketing
tools social media always a great topic
to talk about so we're going to finish
up all our digital marketing tools with
social media we talked about SEO paid
competition affiliate email you know web
analytics it's just appropriate to
finish up with social media because
social media has so many tools available
so many okay the first one I can think
about here is HootSuite HootSuite is a
great social media marketing tool to use
okay it's a freemium okay you can set up
a free trial here you you basically a
base account and then you can use
HootSuite to do a lot of things anything
from setting up landing pages to
actually publishing content to listening
HootSuite to me is one of the most
powerful social media marketing tools
available you got buffer buffer is a
paid version but you can actually set up
a low cost or free account actually on
Buffer and then move to a paid account
okay you got tweet deck it's been around
a long time that is actually free and I
would recommend tweetdeck and we're
going to take a look at that here in a
couple minutes okay and then you got
Sprout social Sprout social is another
social marketing platform summer to
HootSuite do a lot of reporting a lot of
publishing you can a lot of listening
and so we're going to take a look at
Sprout social today as well before we do
that let's go over why these tools are
important to us from a social media
perspective you're pumping out a lot of
content so you need to be able to
smartly efficiently you know schedule
and manage your post okay so you're not
just working likely with just one
platform like Facebook you're probably
on a number of different platforms
depending on your business depending on
your bandwidth depending on what you're
selling your products Etc your audience
obviously has a lot to do with it you
know it could be Instagram Pinterest you
want to be able to consolidate all that
and manage it in one place and that's
what social media marketing tools do
they allow you to manage everything in
one place so if you can manage
everything in one place then the social
media marketing platforms need to be
able to make it easy for you to add and
manage different accounts okay so a lot
of them have the ability for you to add
you know not just one Twitter account
but multiple Twitter accounts and not
just one social media platform but
multiple social media platforms and a
good social media marketing so worth its
weight will help you monitor the results
so monitor social media posts that help
Drive leads and sales in other words
you're going to have a lot of different
metrics associated with each social
media marketing platform okay which one
is actually doing its job okay so you
want to be able to easily manage these
platforms applications and websites very
efficiently okay so instead of having to
log into each platform you just log into
one place get a sense of what's been
posted what the engagement is did they
purchase Etc and what you want to do is
be able to individually customize every
social media post across different
platforms so it just makes it a lot
easier to do that in these social media
marketing tools okay you don't want to
send out a blanket message across
different platforms you want to be able
to go ahead and customize a post
depending on what that post is depending
on what the product is what time of day
what target market what target audience
so customization is a lot easier using
these social media marketing tools you
want to be able to engage with brand
Advocates so listening is a good thing
with social media marketing tools using
the listening functionality so you can
actually see who is a brand Advocate
who's not a brand Advocate who's an
influencer who's not an influencer and
then of course you want to analyze the
behavior of your audience and optimize
individual posts on real-time data so if
for example you post something using one
of these social media marketing
platforms and you see it go viral then
you want to be able to react to that in
real time so you're going to be able to
see that in real time on these social
media marketing tools these platforms
like Sprouts social and HootSuite and
then you're going to be able to react to
that behavior and then of course
monitoring website traffic and
conversion rates that's key we always
want to monitor conversions based on our
kpis our business goals so there are
also a few important digital marketing
tools that can help you in different
ways okay so without further Ado let's
jump in and take a look at what's
available in terms of social media
marketing so just a quick reminder if
you are running ads on Facebook or
you're posting on Facebook as an example
or any platform in general that
platform's going to have its own metrics
if you will so for example Facebook has
something called Facebook Insight so
you'll be able to actually see you know
what's been posted based on you know the
last seven days in this example how many
page views you're getting engagements
recent posts so just to let you know yes
you can go into any one of these
platforms on its own and look at metrics
just like you can do if you're running
Facebook ads okay you can go right into
Facebook ads manager and view data there
okay so the whole point here though on
using a social media tool is that you
can and measure all that in one place so
if we log into sproutsocial I can set up
these accounts right into Sprout social
so I don't have to log into Twitter
individually or Facebook individually I
can link them up all within Sprout
social and then I can go to reports just
like I can with Facebook insights and
then once I'm in Facebook excuse me once
I'm in Sprout social reporting then I
can go ahead just like I can in Facebook
insights except it's all right here for
me I can jump into you know Facebook and
dig a little bit deeper as to what's
going on with my account so I don't have
to log into Facebook directly I can see
you know the Impressions the engagement
the clicks over a period of time I can
see my audience growth I can see my
publishing Behavior how often my
publishing I can see the top post
individually I could see Impressions by
day you know a lot of this same material
same information is our ready and
Facebook insights so if it's available
on Facebook insights you know you're
definitely going to have it available in
a tool like Sprout social so you want to
be able to just efficiently log in and
jump from one platform to the other so
here you know I can go to Instagram you
know and look at Instagram data or I can
look at Twitter information so you want
to be able to efficiently jump from one
platform to the other using in this
example Sprout social now as I mentioned
as part of one of the benefits of a
social media tool is that you can
publish content you want to be able to
publish content because you want to be
able to organize and schedule
accordingly you don't want to be
submitting and Publishing content right
after one another okay you want to be
able to spread it out efficiently and
effectively and so here we could see you
know we could publish and schedule
content accordingly so all we have to do
is Click compose select a profile write
whatever we need to do you could
schedule it for tomorrow at a specific
time and there you go voila scheduled so
this is on Twitter okay so you know we
could choose another platform here it's
just that easy to schedule so you want
to be able to schedule accordingly
because again when you schedule
something then you want to look at the
behavior of it so it's just as simple as
going from publishing to reporting and
then based on one something got
published you could see the reaction of
it and react to it so another thing here
that I like about it's about social heat
Suite A lot of these other platforms do
it really well you got listening tools
so you can listen in on conversations
that are being had for example uh mail
delivery you know if we do mail delivery
and Twitter search we'll be able to see
what's been tweeted about mail
deliveries you know if that's the
business we're in we can refine our
search and choose a specific location a
radius to hone in if we're local Okay so
this is Sprout's social's example of
listening here let's take a look at
another example I'm in later.com so
later very similar to sprout social in
that it does a lot of the same things
you can actually schedule content on a
particular platform and one thing I like
about later here you can actually see it
visually you can see a calendar and
what's been scheduled so I could see
today I have scheduled something
scheduled at 1 15 local time and again I
have five profiles set up for this
account so I can pick and choose the
profile that I want to publish to so it
just makes it that much easier and I can
visually see it and that's important so
here I can click on media library so the
one thing about later.com is that you
know you have a library of images that
potentially you can reuse so if I click
on this image here okay I can get a
sense of when it was used and I can view
it on a calendar I can add label for it
so that's another benefit to later is
that they have this media library here
they have conversations so I can
actually connect to a platform and
listen in on conversations that are
being hacked similar to The Listening
tool in Sprout social and they have
analytics so you can actually see right
in later.com how your particular social
media platform is performing so I could
see it here over seven days I can see
the number of followers have increased I
could see the growth rate I can see the
number of Impressions that I've received
okay so I want to be able to see how my
particular platforms performing over a
period of time so I can look at reach
the law profile views website clicks
okay so I can get a lot of good insights
here right in the analytics platform
later you can look at specific post
performance so if we posted something I
could see basically how many likes it
received how many comments impressions
the reach and then if I wanted to I can
click on details and get more specific
information on it engagement rate okay
Discovery actions comments saves Etc so
later.com goes into some nice detail
about post performance they even have
date on hashtags so if you use an
hashtag you can actually see how many
times the hashtag's been used or saved
how many Impressions it's received okay
so they really go into some nice detail
here about how your posts and how your
accounts are performing and here's a
tool I really like I've been using for a
long time and that's tweet Tech so what
tweet Tech does is connect with your
Twitter account so you can see in a
different visual so to speak of how your
Twitter account looks in terms of your
feed here I can see this is my feed here
okay I can see some notifications I can
see specific messages then on this
column I can see activity okay so I can
add different columns here if I wanted
to and basically by adding columns you
can see I can look for what's trending
as an example so I'm going to add in a
column that says trending and so now I
can go in and see okay these are all the
different things that are trending on
Twitter uh so you can actually add a
column and pay attention to something
really specific okay so for example
search okay so right now I have men's
health but I could type in let's just
say World Cup okay so I could see the
you got the Cricket World Cup you got
you know the soccer football World Cup
going on so you know we could pick a
particular topic to follow if we wanted
to so again here I'm following Men's
Health so I can now see you know
everything that's been posted on men's
health now if I click on for example one
of these hashtags here that's trending I
can actually see who's tagging are you
using that hashtag Friday feeling in
their tweets and so the whole idea
behind you know tweetdeck it serves up a
interesting overview so to speak of not
only your account but you know a
specific topic or what's trending or you
know other things that are being said so
if you really want to pay attention to
your brand or something really specific
like you know your competitors or a
specific product then you can just do a
search on that and so that's the great
thing about tweaktag it allows you to
kind of just look and listen in on
everything going on in Twitter now we do
have a good video out here on YouTube
how to start social media marketing so
if you haven't had a chance to look at
it take a look it goes over some of
these tools that we cover today like
Sprout social later.com you know
Facebook insights so it does cover in
more detail some of what we covered on
these social media marketing tools so
take a look at how to start social media
marketing so we covered a lot of
different marketing Tools digital
marketing tools everything from SEO to
email to social to paid to affiliate to
competitor but there's also a few other
digital marketing tools that you can use
in different ways like video SEO for
example so vid IQ you know we want to
use vid IQ to get a good sense of how
particular video is performing so here
if we go into YouTube you can see vid IQ
is a browser extension or browser a
plug-in if you will so I can go and take
a look at a specific a specific video
and see how many hours it's been watched
how many views minutes watch subscribers
Etc you know the great thing here I can
look at the entire entire account so I
can get good insights into my video or
my entire account here just by adding in
the vid IQ extension into my Chrome
browser so vid IQ actually does give you
some really really good insights into
not only your account but the video and
so recommend vid IQ because it's good
for video SEO okay there's also tools
related to content optimization so you
know if you're doing SEO and you have a
lot of content in your site well you
know what we want to be able to use a
tool maybe a third party tool to give
some objective reasoning as to what more
we can be doing so you got tools like
SEO site checkup or site analyzer these
are pay tools but you know if you're
really heavily invested in SEO then they
may pay dividends for you you want to be
able to make sure your content is fully
optimized to the fullest according to
you know Google's algorithms and so you
maybe you know want to invest in that
third-party tool so these are good tools
to use for Content optimization you know
there's also other key Reddit but by you
know this Keyword Planner uh in Google
there's also a word stream there's a lot
of different keyword tools out there so
you may not have a Google ads platform
and so if you don't have Google ads then
you may not be able to gain access to
Google's Keyword Planner so having a
third-party keyword tool will pay divins
and say well because those dividends pay
off in the form of not only
pay-per-click but also SEO and if you're
heavily invested in content heavily
invested in Social then you may want to
take a look at the keyword tool keyword
it and it's primarily used for Reddit we
talk about page load time so we looked
at that in Google analytics we know that
it heavily impacts SEO so there are
other tools available you got a
third-party tool here that's free
solarwinds pingdom you actually have
page speed insights by Google so these
are free tools that you could take
advantage of and determine in how you
can improve your page load time my
favorite topic conversion rate
optimization so you got a couple in here
crazy egg and zarget okay so I'm gonna
show you another tool called hot jar so
here if you log into hotshot.com you can
set up an account it's actually free and
with the free account you can have hot
chart measure the heat map not only the
heat map but the click mapping the
scrolling of a particular page and so
here you can see we're looking at a
particular page here so hot jar allows
me to you know see on that page where
people are clicking
um I can also see where people are
moving I can also see you know the
scrolling of a particular page okay so
you can see here on the page I could see
people are moving over here to the right
and that's where they're clicking mostly
if I switch over to move mode then I can
see on that particular page page where
people are actually moving their Mouse
and then I have my scroll analysis so I
could see you know how far down people
actually scroll on the page and so again
with a paid account you can measure up
to 10 000 page views with the free
version you can measure up to 2 000
pages and so 2 000 Pages allows you to
get some insight as to what people are
clicking on or where they're moving or
how they're scrolling on a particular
page and so I definitely recommend hot
jar they also do funneling they also do
forms polls lots of other tools
available in hot jars so hotjar.com is a
tool I would recommend as well so one
final tool and I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention it and that's Google optimize so
Google optimize is a Google platform
that allows you to a B test and so a b
testing means that you have an original
page and you're changing one element on
that page to see which one performs
better and so with Google optimize it's
just very easy to set up to run and the
whole point of Google optimize and a b
testing is to improve website
performance so here you can see I have
an account set up and optimized you can
see we're running one test here and
we're just testing one element versus
the original so we move photos to the
top of the page the original didn't have
the photos to the top of the page and so
we can go in a report in here Google
optimized does all the heavy lifting and
so here you can see we can look at
bounces or we can look at you know
basically a measure the test up against
the metric that's important to our
business and again the whole point is to
improve website performance and so
definitely take a look at Google
optimize we'll have another webinar in
the future on the topic but you know to
me Google optimize is free you can run
up to five tests okay and if you can run
up to five different tests and that
means you have the ability to really
improve website performance okay so
Google optimize is a tool that I would
recommend
call has a website on cake recipes
unfortunately his website on Google is
not ranking well
moreover when searching for cake recipes
keyword his website ranks way below than
his competitors
this can be due to various reasons but
one that sticks out is SEO to solve this
issue I have a few important tracking
factors that Carl needs to know and
apply if he wants his website to rank
well before we get started with the
ranking factors let me first explain
what SEO is SEO is the practice of
getting traffic from organic search
results on a search engine like Google
Bing Etc depending upon the keywords
search engines rank websites based on
what content they consider most relevant
to users
without further Ado let me tell you the
top 5 ranking factors which can help
Carl to rank his website
first is content quality then its page
speed of a web page after that its
website structure next is SSL
certificates and finally it's backlinks
which is the most important ranking
Factor let's have a look at good content
quality a good content quality is an
essential factor that helps a website to
rank on Google Google ranks content that
completely answers a user's query in our
case cake recipes
also longer content rank higher on
search engine results
apart from longer content you can also
optimize your content with few
techniques such as you can start with a
comprehensive introduction this article
on the best vanilla cake I've ever had
is a good example of having a
comprehensive introduction
ensure to write content relevant to the
chosen keyword
for example if your keyword is cake
recipes ensure to write a content on how
to bake a cake rather than focusing on
cake decorating ideas
always create a click-worthy title and
include LSI keywords in your content
Co LSI stands for latent semantic
indexing they're used to drive content
traffic and create more visibility on
serps an easy way to look for LSI
keywords is on Google serp some of the
LSI keywords for cake recipes are easy
cake recipes vanilla cake recipes
chocolate cake recipes and a lot more as
shown on the screen
ensure your heading and subheadings
consist of keywords for example all the
heading and subheading for this article
have the keyword cake
build a comprehensive internal linking
structure of web pages it helps in
spreading link Equity across the site
important to create a simple internal
website link structure in the below
example a bot crawls on webpage 2 by
following internal link of the web page
1. next add suitable images with
descriptive alt text here using relevant
images can help search engines
understand what your content is about
and this method helps in site ranking
for example for Carl's website on cake
recipes he should use suitable images
like wedding cakes birthday cakes Etc
incorporate call out boxes as it will
highlight the important information and
increase the dwell time for example if
Carl wants to sell his cake he should
place call out box with contact details
immediately after the cake recipes
ensure your webpage is completely
crawlable for Bots as it will enhance
website ranking here as you see this
website is high up on the Google serve
because every web page in it is
crawlable by Bots
next opt for mobile friendly designs it
will result in good user experience for
a mobile-friendly design always prefer
short and crisp sentences for easy
reading
a poor example and a good example of
mobile friendly designs are shown here
importantly update the content regularly
by doing this search engine rearranges
your site's ranking for example the
Sally's Baking Addiction cake recipe
blog ranks at number one on Google the
reason it updates content regularly
next we have page speed
page speed defines how fast the content
of a web page is displayed on the screen
it is important to ensure that a paid
speed isn't slow otherwise it will
result in high bounce rate
page speed can be optimized through
improving your server response time
this can be done by fixing major issues
like slow database queries slow routing
or a lack of adequate memory
use a simple website design and reduce
the image size that is larger than 150
bytes
next use a Content distribution Network
as it distributes the load of delivery
content and multiple geographical
locations
you can also optimize your code Minify
files if your website has numerous CSS
and JavaScript file you can Minify and
combine them
Google says slow page speed results in
high bounce rate as you can see here
next comes optimizing title tags and URL
a title tag summarizes the website's
content and URL is a web address
title tags are displayed on serps it is
a clickable headline for a given result
for example chocolate cake recipe cake
recipe callcake.com is a title tag of a
website where chocolate cake recipe is
the primary keyword cake recipe is a
secondary keyword and carcake.com is the
brand name
backlinko recommends writing a relevant
keyword in the title tag is important as
it gives an overview of what your
content is about
now talking about URLs always refer a
well-structured short and simple URL
according to backlink co-analysis short
URLs tend to rank better than long URLs
moving on to our fourth ranking Factor
let's talk about SSL certificate
websites using https server have a
higher chance of boost and rankings
https is used for secure communication
over a computer network
as you can see here Google confirms
https as one of the rattling factors
there are two ways to improve site
security you can protect your domain by
enabling DNS SEC protocol or use hsts to
add an extra layer of security over
https whereas hsts protects from
hijacking the next ranking factor is
website architecture the famous digital
marketer Neil Patel says the better your
site structure the better your chance of
ranking higher in the search engines
also backlinko confirms that an
optimized website architecture helps
Bots to find and index all of the web
page a good site structure results in
good use experience
some of the ways to optimize your site
structure are creating a logical
hierarchy structure which means a good
site architecture not only makes content
easier to find but also helps to gain
traffic
site Maps so that the Bots can easily
access and index the content
code your site navigation in CSS or HTML
because these two languages are easy to
code and understand
build a comprehensive structure of
internal linking as it improves indexing
of a website and helps in spreading link
juice
coming to our last rifling factor that
is backlinks
backlinks is an online navigation of
hyperlinks from other websites to your
own website
in this way we can drive referral
traffic and increase the website's
Authority
in SEO the more backlinks in a web page
receives the better it will rank in
Google
backlinks enhances search engine
rankings brand awareness and referral
traffic
backlinks can be gained through
influencer marketing
engaging with audiences on multiple
social media platforms like telegram
LinkedIn Etc participating in high PR q
a sites like quora and post answers to
the questions related to your business
today we're going to talk about why you
would want to rank using SEO and SEO as
search engine optimization also known as
organic search you also May us here a
say organic listings where we're going
to talk a little bit about why you'd
want to rank your website in organic
search okay what is search engine
optimization then we're going to follow
that up with how does Google rank
websites so why does it rank one website
over another and how do we get our
website to rank number one then we're
going to talk about the different types
of SEO or search engine optimization
techniques so you can get your website
ranked number one and then we're going
to finish that off with the do's and
don'ts of SEO so let's get right to it
and talk about why SEO so we're going to
use a basic example and let's just say
you have a Blog you're a food blogger
you're passionate about food and your
Niche is ice cream and let's just say
you have a lot of ice cream recipes you
want to get traffic to your blog you
want people to read your blog and you're
curious why am I not ranking for my blog
why when people type in ice cream
recipes and say Google my blog posts
don't appear at the top of organic
rankings and there's a number of reasons
why you wouldn't be ranked for your blog
post or your ice cream recipes and the
main reason would be your competitors so
there could be somebody else out there
who is also passionate about ice cream
and has been blogging along longer than
you and they have more content and more
blog posts and more pages for Google to
rank so that's usually the number one
reason the other reason is improper
usage of keywords and we're going to
talk a little bit or actually a lot more
about you know keyword usage in your
content so what kind of keywords do you
want to rank for that's really what
we're talking about when we talk about
usage of keywords what keywords do you
want to rank for and how do we work
those keywords into the content another
reason is poor link building practices
and really that means our other blog
posts or other websites linking to you
also are you linking to other pages on
your website and so it's all about link
building and with link building it's
internal linking so are we linking from
one blog post to another and it's
external linking are other websites of
high quality linking to us and so that's
what we talk about when we talk about
link building and then another reason is
web page load time so you could be
running your blog post on say WordPress
for example and your blog post isn't
loading fast enough well if you look at
it this way think about it if you're
Google would you really want to rank a
website site or blog posts in this
example number one on Google rankings if
that particular page loaded very slow no
you wouldn't because when somebody
clicked on that link in organic search
and went to your website they're going
to have a bad experience because the
page is going to load slow so Google
doesn't want their users to have a bad
experience you don't want your users to
have a bad experience and so that's why
web page load time is a critical factor
for ranking so we need to make sure that
our web pages load fast and then your
user experience is not good enough so
Google again based on my example about
the web page load time Google wants
people to have a good experience when
they go from their search engine to your
website and there's a lot at play there
specifically web page load time but also
you know Google doesn't want any spam
content Google doesn't want any pop-ups
or overbearing ads on the web page they
want people to are searching for
something in particular let's just say
ice cream recipes and they want to find
a relevant website that has ice cream
recipes they want to be able to click on
that link and read some good content
about ice cream recipes it's that simple
and that's really what Google's trying
to create in their environment and
that's you as an end user as a website
owner you want your users to have a good
experience and then last but not least
your website is the indexed by mistake
and really what we mean is the indexed
is Google needs to be able to index all
the pages on your website so if you have
a Blog with a hundred recipes you want
Google to have access to all 100 recipes
so we're going to talk a little bit
later about how to get your pages ranked
or indexed on Google organic search so
let's move on to what is SEO so sticking
with our ice cream Blog theme really SEO
search engine optimization really is the
practice of increasing your pages that
Google has indexed up the rankings so
the end result result is we want all our
pages to be ranked number one for
particular keywords so if you want to be
ranked for ice cream recipes well
there's certain things you need to do so
that's generally how it works we need to
apply search engine optimization to
increase a page for keyword we want to
be found for so let me give you an
example so let's just say there's a
hundred students that participated in an
essay competition and so the competition
in this particular case is evaluated on
the basis of is the content relevant are
they using suitable titles for their
essay do they have structure when
they're participating in this essay or
talking about the essay and do they have
a suitable synopsis and is the content
neat and readable these seem all logical
for an essay competition well guess what
they seem logical for SEO because that's
exactly how SEO works it's exactly all
those points I just mentioned about
structure logic readability organization
title all those things are what's
important in SEO and so we need relevant
content we need titles for our Pages
Google needs to be able to see structure
we need to have synopsis of what the
page is about and that's called The Meta
description and then again that the
content needs to be readable and that's
important and so in order to be readable
again we're going to talk more about
site speed because site speed is
important okay and when we talk about
responsive design when I say responsive
design that means your site your page
needs a load both on desktop and also on
mobile and so all these things are
important just like an essay competition
Google is the judge and they need to be
able to determine what page is best to
rank number one number two number three
Etc on Google Search and then link
building remember I mentioned link
building a moment ago we'll link
building internally and externally also
plays a vital role and so we're going to
talk about that a little bit later in
the class when we talk about off-page
SEO how does Google rank website and
basically Google follows three basic
steps to rank a website they need to
crawl your website they need to take
what they call back to their servers and
when they take it back to their servers
your your web pages they need to you
know have them available for indexing so
when somebody actually types in a
keyword into google.com it'll be
available to be found on organic search
so that's what indexing is all about and
then Google's job when somebody does
type in a search query is to basically
rank those pages that they've indexed
from number one to Infinity depending on
how many pages are relevant to that
search query so really it's about
crawling indexing and ranking so
crawling is simply a process done by
which Google has Bots and what these
Bots do is they go to your web server
and they're going to crawl every page
that they can find and how do they find
these Pages well so they basically
follow links you might have heard the
term spidering but that's what they call
search engine spidering so basically
what Google's doing is they're building
a web so to speak all the links that
they're following and so when they can
follow all these links on your website
they're going to be able to crawl them
and when they crawl them basically
they're going to take that content and
store it on their servers so it's
available in their index So based on
this method Google finds out which
websites have relevant content and which
ones don't based on certain keywords
that are typed into Google because if
they can't crawl your website you're not
going to be found and if you can't be
found they're not going to show up for
Relevant keywords so we need to make
sure your site's available to be crawled
and we'll talk about that a little bit
later okay but let's show you an example
so let's just go to Google Search and if
I type in the keyword simply learn okay
I could see I have one way in 10 000
results okay and that's how many results
are showing up for simply learn okay now
they may not all be simply learned pages
but nonetheless simply learned is ranked
number one here organically and there
are 1 million 10 000 Pages related to
the keyword simply learn now when it
comes to organic search we don't want to
get it confused with paid search so
anytime you see paid search you're going
to see something that says add next to
it okay so we could see that there are
paid ads here but when it comes to
organic search those are generally below
paid ads and so that's where Google
counts the one million 10 000 results
and so that's the whole idea behind
crawling and indexing Google's able to
cross simply learns website and based on
all the pages that they gather they're
going to make those pages available in
organic search so if you type in a
keyword and your web page is not
available for indexing then you're never
going to show up for that keyword so
that's why it's important to make sure
your website is available available for
crawling and indexing and so when a user
types a query on search Google search
the most relevant websites that are in
Google's index are going to pair in the
search results so in the example I gave
was simply learn well simply learn is
the brand name of the company simply
learned so there's a lot of relevancy
there so that's why you see simply learn
show up here organically number one like
we mentioned about what is SEO and why
SEO we talked about that user experience
so there's a lot of factors that go into
ranking relevancy being one of them so
in the simply learned example simply
learn is relevant to a lot of the simply
learned Pages because that's who they
are simply learn however simply learn
also needs to make sure that you know
for their Pages the page load time is
fast meaning these Pages load very fast
for the end user and Google also takes
into account other factors like how long
someone is staying on a website or are
they bouncing meaning are they going to
one page that they land on and then
leaving the website okay and so the user
experience is very very important there
are other factors also like language and
location and so for example location if
you do a search say in India the results
are going to be a little bit different
than say the results in the United
States why because Google is indexing as
many web pages as they can find so if
somebody's doing a search in India their
results may be a little bit different
than the results show up in the U.S
because Google has different Bots and
these Bots are crawling different pages
at different times and so Google's index
is updating continuously but it's not
real time syncing so if you do a search
in India you may not say exactly the
same thing because both search engines
the Google in India and the Google and
the US are may not be exactly synced up
so an example would be you know if
you're looking for Cafe so if you search
a cafe and say San Francisco you're
going to see different results now if
you do a search for cafes in Mumbai
you're going to see different results
there's going to be local search here at
the top there may be some paid search
but again you may see different results
because one location but two Google
search engines in India and United
States google.com aren't exactly synced
up exactly at the same exact time you do
that search so location is important
language is important and relevancy is
important along with user experience so
all those are important factors in how
Google ranks websites okay so we're
going to talk about the types of SEO now
so if we want to rank for a particular
keyword on Google we're going to have to
apply search engine optimization and so
there's two strategies to search engine
optimization on-page SEO and off page
SEO so first we're going to talk about
on-page SEO so on page SEO is nothing
more than optimizing your own website
and so when we say optimizing your own
website there's certain elements on your
website and on your web pages that we
need to take into account and so some of
those elements are headers meta
descriptions title tags linking so all
of those elements are something we can
control as an end user who wants to rank
our web page and our website on Google
and before we do anything with our
website the first thing we need to do is
understand what keywords we want to rank
for in order to understand what keywords
we want to rank for we need to do
keyword research and if you do anything
in SEO keyword research is the most
important activity that's the most
important thing you can do for SEO and
why do I say it's the most most
important because you need to understand
if you choose a keyword that you want to
rank for you need to understand how much
traffic you're going to get from that
keyword if you're ranked organically say
number one on Google so how much traffic
will you get if you're ranked number one
on Google so you need to understand what
the volume is and then number two we
need to understand what the competition
is for that keyword that you want to
rank for so if you choose a keyword and
there's not much competition for it then
chances are you can rank for that
keyword for a web page on your website
quicker than say a keyword that has a
lot of competition so we need to
understand those two basic factors
volume and competition before we choose
a keyword and it's it's simply the
practice of going through the motions of
getting your volume and getting your
competition data so you can choose the
keywords you want and then once you
choose the keyword you want then you can
go and apply on page SEO you can change
the title tag the data descriptions the
headers all those elements can be
changed but first you need to choose
your keywords and so again the primary
components we're looking for are how
much traffic you can get or the search
volume how much competition there is for
that keyword and of course relevancy
okay you need to be able to choose a
keyword that's relevant to the web page
you're trying to rank for and so let me
show you example how to go through this
so the first thing we want to do is we
want to use a tool and the tool I would
recommend is Google Keyword Planner and
why do I choose Google Keyword Planner
because if we're trying to rank on
google.com or Google search engine we
want to be able to get the data right
from the source so Google's going to be
able to give us information about how
much volume a keyword has and how much
competition it has so let me show you an
example so if I want to use Google's
Keyword Planner and I want to rank for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist then I'm going to
type that keyword into Google's Keyword
Planner and what Google is going to do
is they're going to give me some Trends
about how much volume this particular
keyword gets over the course of a year
and so for that particular keyword I can
see that there are trends that that
appear for both desktop and mobile so
mobile is important because people start
their search process a lot of times on
their mobile device so we want to be
able to get data from mobile as well as
desktop and so we could see a trend here
that for each particular month over the
last 12 months we can see how much
volume this particular keyword how to
become a digital marketing specialist
gets per month and so on average on
average over the past 12 months I could
see how to become a digital marketing
specialist is averages 30 searches a
month and this is on google.com and so
Google gives us the volume what they
also give us is the competition and so
here I can see Google says for that
particular keyword the competition is
medium and so in the Google's Keyword
Planner what they also do is give me
other relevant keywords that I might
think about optimizing for because you
don't want to optimize for just one
keyword so how to become a digital
marketing specialist they're going to
also offer up other types of keywords
that are relevant so just digital
marketing Specialists social media
marketing specialist so for those
keywords I can see the volume so for
example digital marketing specialist I
can see the average volume is 1000 per
month on average of the last 12 months I
can also see the competition is medium
but for some other keywords I can see
the search volume being high like
digital marketing course at 2900 per
month but also the competition is high
and so what I would recommend is a best
practice is to collect all your relevant
keywords okay and put all your relevant
keyword words in a spreadsheet and when
you put all these relevant keywords in a
spreadsheet you want to get the data on
those keywords and the data I'm
referring to is the volume and
competition so in this case we have
volume from Google planner Google's
Keyword Planner and I have competition
from Google's Keyword Planner and so if
I go into a spreadsheet and I put all
that information in here I'm going to be
able to see the volume and competition
and so that's important however one
thing to note here is that Google's
Keyword Planner if I go back just gives
us low medium and high and if I want to
compare numbers to numbers maybe I want
to be able to get exactly the
competition number for the keyword how
to become a digital marketing specialist
what I can do is go into Google and I
can type in that keyword so if I type in
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist I can see there's
76 Million results so I could see 76
Million results 76.1 actually and for
the keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist now that's a whole
lot of results for this particular
keyword especially when the volume is
only 30 per month on average and so what
I want to do is get a more clear picture
of the competition and so what you could
actually do is type in the syntax all in
title and then colon and then your
keyword how to become a digital
marketing specialist and when I do that
I get a different result here I can see
only
136 listings for how to become a digital
marketing specialist but that's not just
136 that's 136 with that particular
keyword that we want to rank for in the
title tag okay so the title tag is what
you see when you type in a keyword or
search query in Google search and the
title tag is what you see at the top of
every search result and so now I can see
I typed in how to become a digital
marketing specialist with the all
entitled syntax and now I can see every
listing every one of these 136 results
have that particular keyword in it so I
could see every one of them how to
become a digital marketing specialist
and why is that important because now
that tells me I only need to climb over
136 listings to rank for that keyword
how to become a digital marketing
specialist and so the idea here is you
want to get your volume from Google's
Keyword Planner but you want to get your
competition from Google search and again
that's simply typing in the syntax all
in title and then your keyword in this
example how to become a digital
marketing specialist once you get those
two numbers you're going to plug them in
to your spreadsheet and then once you do
that for number of different keyword
queries and these keyword queries again
have to be relevant once you do that
that then you can go in and pick the
keywords you want to optimize for and
that's important because again if you're
not sure about a keyword then you want
to do the keyword research so you can be
sure of how much traffic you can get and
how much competition there is those are
two important three important factors in
starting the process for on-page SEO so
again you want to
create content for say a keyword like
digital marketing
but digital marketing may seem a little
bit broad so you want to probably stay
away from broader keywords because
broader keywords tend to have a lot of
volume which is great but they may also
tend to have a lot of competition but
that's the whole point of doing the
keyword research maybe it doesn't maybe
there's more volume than competition
that's what you need to find out when
you do the keyword research you need to
find those keywords that are relevant to
your content that have a lot of volume
and low competition and then once we
identify those keywords then we are free
to go in and start optimizing our web
pages for those keywords and the first
place we want to start is the title tag
so if you remember my example going back
here to our search how to become a
digital marketing specialist we saw that
every one of these listings had that
keyword in the title tag and the title
tag is important because that's what
users who use Google search see first
when they talk type in a query and get
results so they're going to see the
title tag so the title tag is the most
important element for on-page SEO it's
the most important factor because that's
what people see and so ideally when we
choose our keyword we want to make sure
that keyword is in the title tag because
that's what shows up in Google search
and that's what makes that particular
web page relevant for that keyword query
so the idea behind a title tag it's
between 50 and 60 characters and so we
want to make sure we stay within that
limit no more than 60 characters because
what happens if it's beyond that then
Google will truncate the title tag so if
I go back to my search you can see here
on this particular title tag Google
trunk handed it meaning they added the
ellipses after the title tag because it
exceeded the 60 character limit so you
want to stay within those character
counts and so the title tag is the first
place you should start when optimizing
your website because when we have the
right keyword in the title tag and
somebody types in that keyword then
chances are it's going to be relevant
they're going to see it and they're
going to click through to your website
and that's the whole idea behind ranking
we want to get clicks so that's how the
title tag appears so when you optimize
it you're going to update the title tag
and this is how it shows up it's going
to show up at the top of your listing
okay and it's going to be bigger and
Bolder than anything else Google
displays so the second thing you want to
optimize is the meta description and The
Meta description is simply just a brief
description up to 155 I would say about
155 to 60 160 characters but probably no
more than that and so the meta
description is nothing more than a
summary of the web page itself so if I
go back to my Google search results I
see my title tag and I see the page that
this particular listing belongs to and
underneath that is where I can see my
meta description so in this particular
keyword query how to become a digital
marketing specialist I see the meta
description an ultimate guide on how to
build a career in digital marketing and
the skills required to become a digital
marketing specialist note that it's a
well-written meta description within 155
characters and it includes the keyword
digital marketing specialist so we're
trying to rank for how to become a
digital marketing specialist and here
you can see become a digital marketing
specialist so there's a lot of relevancy
between not only the title tag and the
keyword but the meta description and the
keyword so when you're optimizing a
keyword you want to start with the title
tag but you also want to update the meta
description because if you don't update
the meta description and you leave The
Meta description blank then you're
leaving it to Google to add in copy that
they deem relevant and so for on-page
SEO we want to take control of the copy
and we want to optimize it for the
keywords we want to be found for so the
meta description is a powerful tool at
our disposal it gives us more characters
to work with it gives us more to talk
about so for that particular page and so
if the title tag is only 60 characters
maximum it's not a lot of information to
try and get somebody to click so the
meta description helps us in identifying
what that page is about in order to get
the click so the two working in tandem
will hopefully increase your
click-through rates so when you're found
organically we want to get the click and
then the third element that's important
is the URL and URL stands for uniform
resource locator and why is the URL so
important because that's what people see
so if I go back to my search result how
to become a digital marketing specialist
notice that the URL also includes how to
become a digital marketing specialist
article okay so it's very relevant the
URL is very relevant one we can see it
in the search results but two you know
it's is relevant to the keyword query
and that's important for the end user
and Google Google wants to know hey is
this the page that's relevant to the
user's query and if it is then this user
is likely going to have a good X user
experience after they click on the
listing so the URL is an element that
helps not only with the click-through
rate but with ranking and having a poor
URL structure doesn't help at all
because not only does Google not
recognize the URL as being relevant but
the end user may not want to click on
that page given the the way the URL
looks so you want to try and avoid a
poor URL structure so the rule of thumb
is this if you don't understand what the
URL is then Google is likely not going
to understand what the URL is and so we
want to try and keep our URL structures
clean and when I say clean ideally you
want to make sure that whatever keywords
you're trying to optimize that's the key
word that's going included in the URL
nothing included that is not
understandable so again going back to
our example how to become a digital
marketing specialist it's very clean the
title tag is the keyword The Meta
description is cleanly written has the
keyword and then the URL is the other
element that the end user can see and
that URL includes the keyword in it so
after we've done those three elements
the title tag The Meta description and
the URL then we want to start optimizing
the page itself so ideally when we say
optimize the page itself the page
remember needs to be structured and when
we say structured it needs to be
structured in terms of you know headers
and subheaders and organized in a manner
in which the end user can read the
article read the content clearly and
concisely without being confused and so
that's the job of headers they add they
add basically an organism structure to
the content and with headers there's a
hierarchy so you have anywhere from H1
which is the top of the hierarchy to an
H6 and so you're free to use any one of
those headers when building on a page in
order to organize the content but
ideally you probably want to stick with
an H1 or an H2 because those are at the
top of the hierarchy and what those do
is they actually stress to Google that
hey this header with this particular
keyword in it is important so if you use
an H6 with the keyword in it it's
telling Google hey this is an H6 but
it's not as important so an H1 and an H2
tag show importance and so let's look at
an example of what that is so here you
could see an H1 is going to be at the
top of the hierarchy so that means it's
going to be bigger and Bolder then you
have an H2 which is going to be bigger
and Bolder than an H3 but not as big and
bold as an H2 so with headers not only
are you organizing the con content
accordingly but you're also signaling to
Google how important that particular
header is and of course the header needs
to include the keyword we're trying to
rank for so let's take a look again at
that example so if we go to how to
become a digital marketing specialist if
I click on that page I can look at the
content and I can see that there are
headers in here so the headers are there
to organize the content and that's what
we want we want to be able to organize
the content and if you look at the other
example I'm showing here how to become a
digital marketing specialist a learning
path Explorer you can see that's an H1
but below it's a subheader the growing
digital marketing job market so that's
an H2 and so we're not stressing to
Google that that's more important than
nh1 but nonetheless we're stressing at
Google that it's important nonetheless
so we want to be able to use headers we
want to be able to use keywords in our
headers in order to stress to Google
what's important and also to organize
the content because Google likes content
organized okay the next element we want
to focus on is internal linking and so
internal link and if you remember
earlier in the presentation it's
basically links from one page on your
website to another and so here we can
see on this particular article how to
become a digital marketing specialist
there's also links to other pages on
simply learns website and so for this
particular content it also links to SEO
specialist PPC specialist social media
marketing Specialists and digital
marketing specialist so the whole idea
behind internal linking is to link from
one page to another where it's relevant
and in this case it's relevant because
we're talking about how to become a
digital marketing specialist that's what
the whole content is about and so what
simply learns doing here is offering up
other pages on their web website that
are relevant to becoming a digital
marketing specialist and so this is a
best practice when you're optimizing a
web page so you want to be able to have
internal linking on your site and the
whole idea behind internal linking is it
also allows users to navigate through
the site naturally so when I say
naturally they don't always have to
refer back to the top navigation
thinking naturally and seamlessly go
from one relevant article or page to
another and so that's the whole idea
behind link building and internal link
building it allows Google to identify
you know pages that they want to crawl
and index because they're linked to one
another but it also helps the end user
because it allows the end user to go
from one page to another and it's
signaling to Google hey this particular
page is linked to this page so we're
going to also index that page and so
that's the whole important part of
internal linking it's about the end you
user experience and it's about allowing
Google to find the pages on your website
so they can crawl them and index them so
you can be ranked for them and so also
in addition to internal linking we want
to be able to use natural language and
so what do I mean by natural language or
natural language processing so what
Google does is in terms of natural
language processing they're looking for
the content and the keyword it needs to
be relevant so when your website is
about digital marketing you don't
necessarily want to rank or try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing one
it's too broad two there might be some
competition but three you're probably
not going to write something as broad
like digital marketing so ideally what
you want to do is you want to choose
other relevant related keywords that's
going to be more natural and so that's
what we mean on natural language
processing we want to choose keywords
that are more natural to the content
you're writing so instead of the key or
digital marketing maybe we want to talk
about the types of digital marketing or
digital marketing examples or what is a
digital marketing strategy or how to
become a digital marketing specialist so
those are all relevant keywords to
digital marketing and more relevant to
the content because if you try to rank
for the keyword digital marketing again
it's probably going to be a little bit
broad probably more competition and not
as relevant to your content and as a
result probably not a good user
experience so think about some other
keywords that you could optimize and
rank for and that goes back to the
keyword research that's why the keyword
research is so important because it
allows us to identify other keywords and
the natural language process what
keywords are more relevant for the
content and then another element to
on-page SEO is the sitemap and so with a
site map it's basically a list of all
the pages on your website and the whole
idea of listing all the pages on your
website in one document is it helps both
users and search engines understand the
structure of your website so there are
two types of sitemaps one's an HTML
sitemap and that's designed for humans
so if you have a website with a lot of
content at the footer or the bottom of
your web page you probably want to have
a link to sitemap so if somebody clicks
on that side map they're going to be
able to see all the pages on your
website structured in an organized
manner well an XML sitemap an XML is
just a different format it's designed
for crawlers and so the whole idea
remember is Google likes to crawl
content when they crawl content they
bring it back to their servers and index
it and so we want to be able to create a
sitemap for Google or other search
engine crawlers and so XML is the format
so let me show you example of how that
looks so if I go to simplylearn.com and
simply we type in say sitemap.xml just
as an example I'm going to get this
particular page in this particular page
displays two XML sitemaps so these site
maps are there for Google to go ahead
and crawl and nothing more than a list
of all the pages on your website and so
this is a quick and easy way for Google
to get a hold of all those pages so that
they can index them and that's the whole
idea behind SEO you want to be able to
have Google index all the content you
want to be found for for the keywords
you want to be found for so it all
starts with the sitemap so let's go from
on-page SEO which in recap is basically
optimizing certain elements on your
website so that you are relevant for a
particular keyword and that meant
updating the title tag The Meta
description the URL the headers choosing
the right keywords to put into the
content having internal linking gain and
also updating the sitemap well those are
elements that you can do on your website
so we're going to switch gears and talk
about a different strategy off-page SEO
because without on page or off page you
can't have a page ranking so the two
work together so you can do as much as
you want on on page but you still need
off-page SEO and you could do all the
off-page SEO you want but you still need
on page so both of these strategies have
to be in full effect in order for you to
rank so let's now switch gears to
off-page SEO and so off-page SEO is
simply the process of linking or
promoting your website using link
building and so if you remember I talked
about this earlier on there's two types
of links internal and external linking
and so for on-page SEO we used internal
linking for off-page SEO we're going to
talk about external linking and external
linking allows us to improve our website
sites recognition or relevancy or
credibility and why do we want to
improve our relevancy and credibility
and trustworthiness and Authority
because we want Google to know that our
web page is trustworthy it is recognized
by other websites and it is relevant for
a particular keyword and so if we can do
that using off-page SEO methods then
Google's going to rank our web page for
the keyword we want to be found for so
it's really off-page SEO is synonymous
with link building and there's plenty of
opportunities to do link building it
just comes down to creating a strategy
so again some of the benefits to off
page well we talked about you know being
credible and trustworthiness and
relevant we need to do that in order to
rank but there's some other benefits
there so if we're have a link on another
credible website then it's likely going
to increase the traffic to our own
website it also creates high domain
Authority and so what I mean by high
domain Authority is if we have basically
links to other web pages pointing back
to us then basically our domain
Authority is going to improve and when
our domain Authority improves other
websites are going to want to link to us
so the higher authoritative we are for
our website than other web pages are
going to want to link to us and so the
more external linking we have the higher
the domain Authority so it all starts
with linking to other high domain
Authority websites so linking to a high
domain Authority website for example
having a link on Wikipedia that points
back to our web page creates high domain
Authority for us and it helps Drive
traffic so some of the other benefits of
off-page SEO are incredibility so if
we're linking from Wikipedia to our web
page it does create credibility for us
it also helps us increase our page rank
so remember that external linking helps
build domain Authority helps build
credibility
trustworthiness and it's going to in
turn help us rank for that particular
page and then certainly not last having
a good off-page SEO link building
strategy increases our brand awareness
because if we're on other high Authority
websites Wikipedia or say a social
platform it's going to increase our
brand awareness and increasing our brand
awareness increases our trustworthiness
and so if somebody is looking to say
become a digital marketing specialist
then likely instead of typing in digital
marketing specialist on Google they may
type in our brand name in this case
simply learn and so these are all the
benefits to off-page SEO so it's nothing
more than having links on other websites
that are pointing back to ours and again
there's lots of benefits its drives
helps Drive traffic and increases our
Authority so those are things that we
want to take advantage of when we want
to rank and the key behind off-page SEO
or link building is always going to be
content so from an on-page SEO
perspective having quality content
allows that content to be optimized for
Relevant keyword and ranked but also
from an off-page SEO strategy having
high quality content allows us to have
other sites and it doesn't necessarily
have to be a website it could be a
social platform or it can be another
blogging platform or blogging website
link back to ours why because the
content is original it's natural it's
well structured it reads well and so
that's the whole idea behind off page
you can't have links on other websites
if you don't have quality content so one
of the ideas behind off-page SEO is not
only do you want to create good content
but you probably want to spend a lot of
time or a bit of time on others websites
so remember the example I used earlier
in this presentation about about having
an ice cream blog and ice cream recipes
well it probably wouldn't be a bad idea
to say spend some time on other blogs
related to desserts related to cakes
related to food in general related to
vegetables or other items that people
could link from so the whole idea is
understanding who else is out there who
has relevant content that you could
share so you could share your content
with them they can share their content
with you and generally that's how it
works naturally anyway in the web sphere
if somebody likes your content they're
going to link to it they don't
necessarily have to wait for you to ask
them but it might not be a bad idea to
understand who else is out there that
has content someone or yours so that you
can you know get a link on that
particular website or blog post and so
some other ideas behind having external
links pointing back to your website is
social media so social media is not just
Facebook or Twitter her but it expands
beyond that there's there's core there's
media there's all sorts of content
generated websites like Reddit so the
list goes on and on you just need to
find what's relevant for your content if
it's relevant for your content then it's
worth putting or trying to get the
external link on that social media
platform and then again going back to my
ice cream blog recipes blog post yeah if
you find a particular blog that you want
to have an external link on there's
nothing wrong with reaching out to that
particular blogger you know in some
cases very flattering but in other cases
if the content is relevant then why not
it's only going to help your end user
experience if you add somebody who has a
say a Blog about cakes having their link
on your blog post so there's nothing
wrong with it because it also adds to
the user experience and if you're going
to ask somebody to put an external link
on theirs you might want to be
open-minded and May make sure that
you're are able and willing to put an
external link on your blog post or
website pointing to their content that's
how the web Works especially if the
contents of quality relevant and of good
nature okay so let's move on and finish
up with the do's and don'ts of SEO so we
talked a lot about why SEO what is SEO
how do we rank for SEO what is on page
SEO what is off-page SEO and so let's
just wrap up with some of the things you
again want to do to rank your page for a
particular keyword and some of the
things you don't want to do so the first
thing on the list is optimize for white
hat techniques and what I mean for
opting in for white hat techniques is
basically everything I just mentioned
today you want to do keyword research
you want to choose a natural language
processing form format so you could
choose keywords that are going to be
relevant natural to the content and you
don't want to opt for black hat
techniques and blad hat techniques are
probably not even worth going into
detail but one example is choosing a
keyword arbitrarily like say digital
marketing and just stuffing that keyword
into the content so that's probably not
something you want to do because again
it's not going to be good for the end
user so stay away from black hat and
focus on some of the techniques we
talked about in today's presentation the
other do we want to do is get backlinks
from relevant sites so that's off page
SEO again it's what I mentioned earlier
it's about linking your quality content
to another person's website that also
has quality content we don't want to
have a backlink from an irrelevant site
why because it's not going to be
relevant and it's also going to hurt our
Authority because if it's on a site
that's not of good quality then Google's
going to look at us and say well this
site is linking to your site but it's
not relevant so therefore you know we're
not going to look at you in this same
way as if you were on a quality website
we do want to use our keywords naturally
because title tags are what people see
first on organic search but you don't
want to use the same title tag on every
page of your website so we want to stay
away from doing that so you want to have
a unique title tag for every web page on
your website and ideally what does that
mean that means using our keyword
research to choose one of two keywords
per page and optimizing your web page
for those one to two keywords so you
ideally what you want to do is have one
or two different keywords for every page
on your website we definitely definitely
definitely want to write engaging
content so the content should be
engaging remember user experience we
want users to stay on our website we
want them to enjoy the content that
they're reading and we want them to go
from one page to another naturally we
definitely don't want to leverage or or
plagiarize or just copy content from
others websites because it's not one
probably going to be relevant to what
you're writing about two it's duplicate
content and it's somebody else's so
that's a black cat Technique we want to
stay away from I can't emphasize this
enough we need to do keyword research
first before you do anything else you
need to find relevant keywords and not
only that you need to understand the
volume and the competition for each of
those keywords okay you don't want to
choose a key word that has low volume
High competition you want to choose a
keyword that has high volume low
competition but above all you want to
choose keywords that are relevant to
your content we want to avoid keyword
stuffing so don't take a keyword and
just stuff it everywhere on the page
it's not going to be natural and
Google's going to be able to pick up on
that so we want to maintain some level
of quality with our content and quality
with the key words that we choose so
reminder when you have quality content
it's always going to link internally to
another page on your website with
quality content but it's got to be
natural and don't just build site-wide
backlinks meaning don't just have an
internal link to the home page or don't
have every page on your website linking
to just one page so internal linking
should be natural naturally linking from
one page to another not only does it
help Google understand and crawl all the
web pages on your website but it's good
for the end User it's good user
experience and certainly last but
something I didn't talk about it does
take time to rank your content so
remember the process you're going to
write your content you're going to
choose keywords you're going to change
the elements on that page for those
keywords and all the while you're going
to make sure Google can crawl that
content and when they crawl out they're
going to index it the process this takes
time especially if you choose a keyword
that's competitive so just be patient if
you have quality content and you've
optimized for on-page SEO and off-page
SEO then you will rank for that keyword
and then make sure your website's user
friendly and mobile friendly so we
talked about responsive content earlier
so remember most users today start the
process of search on mobile so we want
to make sure your websites are mobile
friendly search engine optimization
starts with the keyword because we want
to be found for Relevant keywords and so
the first step in search engine
optimization is always going to be
keyword research so it is the most
important step and so what is keyword
research all about well it's process of
identifying keywords we want to be found
for on the search engines so millions of
people use search engines on a daily
basis we want to be found for those key
words that people type in that are
relevant to the content we want to be
found so going back to the Italian
restaurant example if we're writing a
blog post about Italian restaurants or
somebody types in the best Italian
restaurants or Italian restaurants in a
specific City we want to be found for
that content if it's relevant to what we
wrote about so keyword research should
be done based on two factors really it's
based on the factor of how much traffic
or volume a particular search engine
query has and it's based on competition
and really the underlying Factor here is
that all keywords in your keyword
research should be relevant so you need
to understand what those keywords are so
are they relevant to the content that
you want to be found for if they are
then really the two factors you want to
look for is the volume how much volume
or traffic each keyword has associated
with it and then the competition how
many other websites are trying to be
found for the same keyword so those are
the factors involved with keyword
research you always want to choose
relevant keywords and then once you find
or choose those relevant keywords you
want to be able to find out exactly how
much volume and how much competitions
associated with each of those keywords
and so when you look at keywords you're
always going to choose relevant keywords
but there are two types of keywords
there are short tail keywords and there
are long tail keywords and we're going
to talk about both of these here so
let's start with short tail keywords so
short tail keywords are generic keywords
generally they're less than three words
in a keyword phrase for example Italian
restaurants so short tail keywords
generally have very high search volume
that means that if somebody types in
Italian restaurants then there's going
to be a large amount of volume with that
meaning that generally a lot of people
type in the keyword Italian restaurants
however with high volume always comes
High competition so if you want to be
found for Italian restaurants know that
if you are ranked number one or number
two or even on page one of Google you're
going to get a lot of traffic however to
get to page one of Google or even
position one or two it's going to take
you a while because they're probably a
lot of websites who are in front of you
who want to be ranked and found for the
same keyword so the whole idea with
short tail keywords is it's a lot of
visibility it's a lot of traffic a lot
of volume but also a lot of competition
and generally the underlying Factor here
is that if you are ranked for a very
broad or short tail keyword like Italian
restaurants then chances are it's not
going to be as relevant so if you get
the traffic to your website then chances
are the conversion's not necessarily
going to happen because we don't
necessarily know the mindset of somebody
typing in a very short tail generic
keyword like Italian restaurants they
could be doing research on Italian
restaurants they could be a chef who's
trying to get recipes for Italian food
it could be a tourist looking for
Italian restaurants in a different city
or it could be a person just looking for
Italian restaurants near their location
or where they're living and so there's a
lot of different factors with short tail
keywords so you just don't know because
it's so generic and because it's so
generic if you do get the traffic for
that generic keyword then the chances
that conversion are going to be lower
than say if it's a more specific
relevant keyword so let's take an
example of a short tail keyword let's
just stick with Italian restaurants so
I'm gonna go to a tool called Moz and
while Moz has a tool called the keyword
Explorer and within Moz so if you go to
moz.com and then use the keyword
Explorer you can get an idea of how much
volume and competition are associated it
with a particular keyword so in this
example we're using Italian restaurants
it's a very broad keyword we could see
that the monthly volume is between
seventy thousand and a hundred and
eighteen thousand per month okay so that
means for a particular keyword in the
United States on a search engine you're
going to get about 70 000 to 118 000
people who type in that keyword and so
if we were look at the difficulty of
that keyword you could see that it's
fairly difficult because out of 1 to 100
it's got a score of 43 so it's fairly
difficult however if you notice the
click-through rate is very high so Moz
estimates that we'll have a forty
percent organic click-through rate for
that keyword if we're ranked for it so
if it's relevant to us and we want to
get some visibility to our site then
yeah we want to use that generic short
tail keyword however if we're interested
in conversions then we really want to
turn our attention to longer to tail
keywords however if you want the
visibility then you want to use short
tail keywords if you want the conversion
then you want to switch over to longer
tail keywords so longer tail keywords
are more specific they usually consist
of more than three keywords so tie in
restaurants very generic if we add a few
more keywords that keyword phrase it
then becomes longer tail so compared to
short tail keywords longer tail keywords
are generally less competitive and the
search volume is not as high okay some
point so if we go back to Moz and then
we look at the keyword Explorer and we'd
actually type in Italian restaurants and
let's just say Orlando Florida
Moz is going to generate some monthly
volume for us and they're going to allow
us to understand how difficult that
keyword is and so here you can see very
very little search volume in fact so
little volume there's 11 to 50 okay so
that means on average that this keyword
generates 11 to 50 queries a month so
very low compared to our short tail
keyword Italian restaurants the
difficulty here didn't necessarily
lessen but it is less uh competitive so
if you're interested in conversions and
you have an Italian restaurant in say
Orlando Florida then this is the keyword
you may want to use so there's a
trade-off between longer tail and
shorter tail but when visitors land from
longer tail keywords they're usually
ready to make a purchase they're usually
more specific intent there's more intent
involved with a longer tail keyword so
best restaurants in Italian in Florida
Florida branded shoes in Florida
something very specific is going to
generate probably a higher conversion
rate than something more generic so
that's the trade-off and so I went to
use long tail keywords well we want to
use long tail keywords and for targeting
pages with a product or specific article
so for interested in that particular
conversion then longer tail keywords are
likely more the way we want to go versus
something more generic which means if
you're using a generic shorter tail
keyword you're more interested in the
visibility and the traffic not
necessarily the conversion when you're
setting up your brand and you need to
make sure it reaches the Right audience
and provide the best results there's
really only one place to turn to it's
one of the largest online advertising
platforms really in the world and that's
on Google and so today we're going to
talk about how to advertise on Google
and let's get right to it and talk about
Google ads and its effect with
advertising so we're going to start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google AdWords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid Pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percent
tile of its Revenue comes from Google
ads and when we say Google ads we mean
people who pay for advertising on
google.com so Google ads really what it
does is it provides services that fall
under the category of PPC which stands
for pay-per-click UA Also may hear
Google ads or PPC referred to as cost
per click or CPC or sponsored search
really what it comes down to it's a
model so when you advertise on
google.com calm and somebody clicks on
your ad basically you're paying Google
for the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an Advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google place my ad
on google.com and then if my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as I pay Google a
fee so Google ads is just an online
advertising platform developed by Google
with which advertisers can pay to
display ads that can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobiles involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if I go to Google Search you
even if I type in you know what is
Google ads here I could see a total of
1.8 billion results for what our Google
ads as my search query so in search you
got a lot of different things going on
here you have organic results you have
videos that are being pulled from
YouTube you got a Knowledge Graph here
you got feature Snippets you got an
organic listing but really at the top
this is what we're going to focus on
today we're going to talk about
sponsored search so you can see here for
this particular keyword query that I
typed in what are Google ads really two
sponsored search or pay-per-click ads
appeared now if I happen to click on any
one of these two and go to that
particular advertisements website
they're going to pay Google a specific
cost per click so that's how it looks on
google.com it really depends on your
query and what ads show up but the great
thing about you know Google ads is they
make it known for the user who's doing
the search query what the ad is so here
I can easily pick out what's an ad a
sponsored search or pay-per-click ad and
what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an Advertiser
advertising on google.com I'm going to
be able to see this little box here that
says add next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an Advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
Okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organic search here or even down here
doesn't have a little ad box next to the
listing so you know if it doesn't have
the little ad box you know it's a paid
search ad now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because because you're meeting
the consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required of them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for basically your
ads going to show up somebody clicks on
it you pay Google for the click and you
get quality traffic and return so the
other great benefit to being on Google
ads is increases brand awareness so it's
a great way to get your product and
brand out there Google has a vast
network
uh also known as the display network but
even on google.com the search Network
itself the search engine itself means
that people use it every day in fact
here in the United States it's been said
or study that you know people over the
age of 18 use search at least once a day
at least once a day here in the United
States so you can figure that's millions
and millions of people so it's a great
way to get your brand in front of a
large captive audience okay so top of
Mind awareness refers to a brand of
product being the first one that comes
to a customer's mind when thinking about
a particular industry or category so it
really does provide top of Mind
awareness another benefit to being on
Google ads is retargeting so when we say
the word retargeting in marketing that
means you know showing our ad to
somebody who's already been to our
website so we can use Google's Display
Network or we can run remarketing lists
for search ads right on google.com to
ensure that we're targeting those folks
who have already been to our website and
have not performed a function that we
want them to perform such as converting
or buying something or downloading
something or just subscribing to a
newsletter or visiting a certain page
okay so if somebody doesn't do what we
want them to do it's okay maybe they're
ready to commit to our product or
service and that's why Google offers up
retargeting so it allows us to reach
that audience a second time so they're
going to be familiar with their product
they're going to be familiar their
website because they've been there and
so we can offer up a very unique
specific ad to that audience so that's a
really good benefit to being on Google
ads so some other benefits here
increased intelligence so you know we
can certainly get data about who is
coming to our audience so we can look at
what device what you know browser Etc so
we can really gain some information
about who's coming to the website we
could certainly measure our performance
so with Google we're paying cost per
click and So based on that model you
know we can certainly measure what
keywords what ads are generating traffic
to the website and how much we're paying
for that okay and if that traffic turns
out to be a lead we can measure that
against that specific keyword or ad or
campaign so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the keyword
level and can we can measure up against
how many conversions or what we're
paying for those conversions so Google
ads is a very highly quantitative
approach to advertising because there's
lots of numbers involved and you're
constantly collecting information about
your advertising on google.com and its
Network and another benefit really is
high flexibility so Google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads Dynamic
responsive ads video ads display layout
so Google ads has very flexible options
in terms of advertising and we're going
to talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
ads because as we've shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are Google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help in
advertising on Google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you could bid on it
so it definitely is a good option if
you're not ranking for particular
keyword organically so it serves as
almost an option I always say that you
know search is like a frupal okay you
have apples and oranges in that fruit
bowl well all the Orange is organic
search and the apple is paid search
they're different approaches but they
share the same fruit bowl the same real
estate so you can really really help
yourself by using Google ads to
complement what you're doing organically
so if you're not ranked organically for
keyword you can certainly use Google ads
if you are ranked for specific keywords
and it's a highly competitive industry
then you can use Google ads to help you
leverage the amount of clicks you get
from that app so it's okay to be
organically listed and have a paid
search listing at the same time so if we
go back to our example here we could see
wordstream.com has a paid ad and here we
can see just two spots below organically
they're showing up with an organic
listing so you could certainly be in
both positions to try and maximize your
clicks so it's definitely a good
strategy to run with Google ads on top
of everything we mentioned in terms of
measurement flexibility Google ads does
offer up a really good incentive to
advertise and let's not lose focus that
again search is really the only medium
in which you're meeting somebody halfway
based on what they're looking for and
when I say halfway meaning your ad is
going to appear for somebody who's
looking for something whether that be
food a cafe a plumber a doctor or
directions search is there to serve that
that person needs there's no other
advertisement platform or another
Channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps OR also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift Focus now and talk about the
various formats and Google ads on Google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on Google Search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about Google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we we
call AD extensions so here you can see
shop by category in-ear headphones
on-ear headphones those are all site
link extensions meaning they're going to
link to something on your website and so
the purpose of the extension is to help
get the click so the reason why you're
running Google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad I'll help you get
that click yes you're going to pay
Google for the click but that's the
whole purpose is to generate the click
from search because remember search is
there to respond to somebody's need or
query and so if you get the click on
your ad chances are it's going to be a
highly relevant visitor to your website
so Google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text that on google4 google.com so
Google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean Google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are all responsive they
adjust their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like Amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let Google do the
heavy lifting why not let Google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows Google to
you know show the particular that's most
relevant to that user so it's a really a
great option when you're advertising on
Google you have image ads as well so
image ads are as we mentioned part of
responsive or they can just be static
and so here you can see an example from
slack okay you can see just an image app
but the great thing about image ads is
you have a lot of different size options
so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160 by 600 all
these are pixel sizes so you have a lot
of different size variations when you
run image ads okay so you don't have to
run a small image ad let's just say in
comparison to Facebook where you have a
thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook versus
Google you have multiple multiple sizes
that you can choose from in terms of
running image ads so image ads are
really a great option if you're going to
advertise on Google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for Uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns YouTube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be Standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say pre-roll meaning people are going to
look at your ad before actually watching
the actual video they went to YouTube
for so you have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
YouTube so the other AD format you have
on Google are shopping ads and shopping
ads are really a great way to get your
product in front of the right user so
somebody's looking for shoes or running
shoes it's an opportunity for you to run
shopping ads so you could put that
particular shoe with a description with
the price with your brand name in front
of that user and so with a cost per
click model if a user clicks on your
shopping ad then chances are they're
probably going to convert because they
could see the product they could see the
price they could see the product name
they could see the brand and so it's an
opportunity for you to really drive high
quality traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google Search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here I could
certainly scroll around and see all the
different brand names I could see the
price point if I hover over it I can
actually see you know some other
information about it like reviews return
policy so so if I actually click on this
ad chances are I'm going to buy it
otherwise why would I click on the ad as
an end user and so that's the great
thing about shopping ads it gives you
the advertiser an opportunity to really
get your products in front of people who
are looking for your product or service
and given that you're listing the price
if they like the price and they click on
your ad they're probably going to go
ahead and follow through with the
conversion so it doesn't necessarily
have to be running shoes it could be
anything that you have to offer a user
so running shopping ads on Google is a
good strategy if you have products okay
so you can showcase these these shopping
ads on Google search by certainly really
giving Google access to your product
inventory connecting in some reviews
connecting in some information
connecting in the pricing points and
voila it's really very fairly easy to
set up Google shopping ads within Google
search and the great thing about
shopping ads is it also pairs under
images and also pairs under shopping so
if I'm on Google search you know I can
go to shopping or I can go to images and
I'll see those same image ads show up
here at the top and I will certainly see
those under shopping as well so shopping
ads allow you to really showcase your
products on Google search to those
looking for that particular product so
it's really a great option with Google
okay you also have call ADS so when we
say call ADS really call only ads are
great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and Google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion in for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the ad because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so Google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
Google showing your ads I showed you an
example of Google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
Google search networks so Google search
Network really allows you to advertise
on Google search so with Google search
if I go back to Google search and I go
to all I typed in running shoes okay
here I can see shopping ads here I can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show up the top and and if you're
not at the top then Google will place
you at the bottom so it really depends
on the keyword that somebody's querying
in Google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what Google does if I didn't have any
shopping ads here Google will list a
maximum of four text ads at the top and
at the bottom any other ads that weren't
shown at the top will get placed at the
bottom so ideally if you're running text
ads on Google you want to make sure
you're always at the top and I would say
between positions one and three you
always want to make sure you're at the
top okay so you can certainly measure
that remember Google had has measured
performance so you can measure
everything about your ad so if you're
going to advertise on Google with the
text ad you want to make sure you're
always at the top so let's have a look
at the different types of search
networks that Google ads is affiliated
with so the first is Google search Okay
so let's focus on Google Search and so
basically when we say Google search or
search sites we really mean google.com
or all Google search engines for that
matter so if you want to advertise to a
mass audience you want to probably start
with google.com because again millions
of people use it on a daily basis and so
if you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a Google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswald so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured Snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again I've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if I scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again I can see the
logo add here okay so I can see simply
learn using three headlines I can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and I can see simply learn
using some other extent tensions with
the ad now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on Google search if you're
on Google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different I'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to Google my business not Google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on Google search so Google my business
is tied to local listings or Google Maps
and again and with desktop which is what
I'm showing you the search result on
you're going to see likely Google local
listings above organic results okay and
if I go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing I'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to Trump any other type of
results on Google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called Google search Partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in Google ads you have the
option to choose Google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
Google search partner sites and so some
of their search Partners can range so
basically these are sites that that have
partnered up with Google that's allowing
Google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between YouTube
to Amazon to New York Times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if I go to say
ask.com and type in classes on digital
marketing it's a completely different
search engine but I can see the same ad
for simply learn so I can see same I
could see a different headline here
actually but I can see the description
and I can see some site link extensions
and so notice the ad is still at the top
in this case it's in position one and I
can see multiple companies running
advertisements why because I could see
ad next to it and I could see those over
over organic listings so these are
Google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be be on other partner
sites that Google or other sites that
Google has partnered up with so you have
options outside of Google search and
that option is Display Network so
Display Network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of Google
search and if you're going to advertise
on Google's Display Network you have
more ad formats Available to You
including image and including a video
for example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the newyorktimes.com or
WebMD or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey this is the site I want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the form
I'm out of the ad okay so putting your
ads in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity to get your product and
service in front of a lot of people
because this way the display network
works is it's a millions of websites who
want to have advertising on their site
and so you can really pick and choose a
specific site where your audience is
going to be and get your ad in front of
that audience so you can really retarget
to potential customers so retargeting as
we said earlier is really reaching out
to people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you want wanted them to
perform meaning somebody came to your
website from Paid search on google.com
and they went to page a and then they
left so you really wanted them to go to
page B add a product to a shopping cart
and check out and purchase that product
however if they didn't do that you could
certainly run ads knowing that they've
been to page a and Page B and you can
offer up that specific ad to that person
who's been to your website and so that's
what retargeting really is all about and
you can retarget on Google's Display
Network so remarketing your product to
people who previously visited your your
website or even your app allows you to
really get your ad in front of a
qualified audience and so you could take
advantage of analytics so Google's ads
has all the information you need so
let's actually take a look at some of
these options in Google ads for the
Display Network so if I actually go to
Google ads and I actually go to display
campaigns I can see I have a lot of
different options available to me so if
I click on keywords for example okay I
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what Google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
Display Network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the Display Network
you can say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and So based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose choose
topics so if there's a specific topic
that you want your ad to be associated
with you can certainly do that so Google
has a number of different topics at
their disposal so here if I just choose
a particular ad group now I have
specific topics that I can choose from
arts and entertainment food and drink to
news to pets and animals and so under
each one of these topics I can get
really specific so if I go under science
I could see sub categories under the
topic science I can see chemistry and
physics and scientific institutions and
equipment so I can really pick and
choose specific topics where I want my
ads to be shown as I mentioned already
you can pick and choose specific
placements okay so if you have a
specific website that you want your ad
to be shown on you can certainly let
Google know okay you can also advertise
on Gmail you can also advertise on
YouTube so you can really pick and share
choose where you want your ads to be
shown so you have all these different
options available to you to me that one
of the best options for advertising on
the Display Network because when you
tell Google you have a specific audience
you want to Target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an app so the
display campaign is very powerful with
Google because you have all these
different options available to you so
with Google ads you can also determine
how well you're reaching your goals
which websites you're running your ads
on which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
in Google ads so when I actually pick
and choose how I want to Target I can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or or demographics for example
if I go back to demographics I have all
this data data that Google's collected
on my advertising so I can see for
example by age range based on my
campaign how many clicks how many
Impressions Impressions or how many
times my ads been seen click-through
rate meaning the rate at which people
see my ad and are clicking on my ad how
much I'm paying per click CPC is cost
per click total cost and conversions how
many conversions am I getting so I could
see all this data available to me in
Google ads so it's a very powerful
platform for measuring performance
imagine it's the year 2004.
this is Phil Phil's looking to release a
book and set up a Blog he's sure that
it'd be successful but he's only worried
about one thing he doesn't know how to
ensure that his book reaches the right
target audience who could enjoy his book
during that period of time however there
were only a few forms of advertisement
available like print ads Billboards
radio Direct Mail direct sales and the
television all of these options were
pretty expensive their effectiveness
couldn't be accurately determined and
they didn't let him advertise his
content to the appropriate audience
Phil's book would never find the
audience it deserved now let's have a
look at the same scenario in the present
day alongside traditional forms of
advertising Phil would have access to
digital marketing the form of marketing
that's a lot more lucrative inexpensive
and configurable marketing that would
enable marketers to advertise Their
audience digitally using channels like
search engines websites social media
platforms emails Etc among these types
social media marketing cotfield's eye
social media marketing would give Phil
the opportunity to take advantage of
social media platforms to advertises
content to a highly targeted audience it
would help more people learn about this
book increase the interaction with his
audience It's relatively inexpensive
unless he goes into advertising and will
help him get Marketplace insights that
might help in understanding his audience
preferences better Phil started by
taking up a certification to learn about
social media marketing since he was
already familiar with the concept of
social media marketing his next step was
to learn about the different types of
content he could post on social media
some of the most common forms of content
that Phil could post would be images
text posts polls and videos
but over time Phil begin to notice that
not a lot of people were being exposed
to his content Phil needed to advertise
his content for that he would need to
use the advertising options provided by
the social media platforms like Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn and Twitter
most advertising platforms offer users
with a number of different options like
image ads these ads involve the use of
single or multiple images that are
attractive and have the optimal amount
of text they also have a call to action
that encourages user interaction Phil
could use images from his book advertise
websites that sell his book and more
then there are text and post ads these
ads could advertise posts or excerpts
from Phil's blog or his book further
garnering interest from an interesting
audience
you could also use video ads Phil could
use video
that each are favorable reviews and
customer testimonials to advertisers
books Phil could also use lead ads
through which he could collect
information from users who are
interested in a Weekly Newsletter or
regular updates from his blog but that
wasn't the only thing Phil could do with
social media platforms he could create a
brand for himself and drive audience
interest to it engage with them create
an identity engage with content finding
content that works for him social media
platforms also allowed him the
opportunity to Target audiences based on
demographics like their age location
gender and much more and in time Phil
began to see an increase in the number
of viewers coming to his social media
page and by extension his blog he also
saw an increase in the number of people
who bought his book greatly increasing
his audience here are some things he
learned one to set goals that were
quantitative smart and follow a constant
deadline two to understand his audience
by engaging and connecting with them
three to set up a social media calendar
to plan competitions polls surveys
videos and more
4. using tools like buzzsumo IFTTT
buffer and more for lead generation
creating email lists setting buyer
personas and more
5. to perform visual storytelling with
the help of images and videos but how
did Phil get so good at Social Media
Marketing Phil taken up simply learns
digital marketing course it was thanks
to this course that Phil had the skills
and training to get good at social media
marketing and now you can too by
clicking on the top right corner and
with that we've given you an
introduction to all the major concepts
of social media marketing the world we
live in now it's highly digital place
but that wasn't always the case until
four years ago so if we rewind letting
people know about your products was a
little harder then so even if you go
back say five or ten years promoting
your products wasn't as easy as it is
today I mean people had to resort to you
know good old-fashioned newspapers
putting in an ad or those big thick
books called The Yellow Pages that
usually sat in your closet and wait a
ton I mean those were the ways to get
your product a message out there a lot
of advertising in those Yellow Pages
then you have Billboards you know
driving down the highway you see that
billboard on the side of the road you
wonder who are those people that are
actually advertising this stuff of
course you have television that's been
around for decades a good source of
advertising but costly and then facts
facts ads uncommonly known way to
advertise by the way who has faxes now
but people did advertise via fax just a
few decades ago so these were all the
ways in which people had to get their
product and service out there it seems
like so archaic looking at it now but
back then that was legitimate that was
the way to do it and then one thing made
our lives a lot easier so if you're a
marketer you're thinking to yourself man
I'm glad I'm a marketer in today's day
and age because it's social media
marketing social media marketing has
made everyone's lives better from the
company that's selling the product or
service to the marketer promoting the
product and service to the end user who
wants to see that product or service and
engage with that product service so
social media is a good source of getting
your product and service out there and
it just makes everybody's lives a heck
of a lot easier so we're going to answer
that million dollar question and what's
that million dollar question it's how
can you Rise Above the Rest and so
today's session is going to be how to
start with social media marketing so you
can Rise Above the Rest leveraging this
great platform that we all take
advantage of today so let's start by
asking the question what is social media
marketing social media marketing
involves increasing website traffic it
centers around engagement it offers you
the ability to increase your brand
awareness and it has other marketing
goals you know so you can create various
forms of content for different social
media platforms so that's really in a
nutshell with social media marketing is
so again if we want to increase our
traffic or we want to increase our
engagement like likes or comments then
look no further than social media
marketing if we want to engage with our
users our customers our potential and
prospective customers we can really put
a personalized experience in place using
social media marketing we want to create
different forms of content like videos
and blogs and infographics and other
types of graphics with the potential to
actually go viral what we mean by viral
is spreading like wildfire one user
sending it to another as rapidly as can
be and before you know it you get you
know millions of views and millions of
likes I mean that's the power of social
media marketing so why do we want to do
social media marketing and I think we
just answered some of those questions
but let's dig a little bit deeper we
mentioned in our definition of social
media marketing that we have the
opportunity to really build our brand
awareness and that is no more truthful
well then with social media marketing
more so than any other digital marketing
channel social media marketing allows us
to really put our brand in a good light
in a good position in front of the right
eyeballs so it allows us to really
improve our brand by pushing out the
appropriate content in front of the
appropriate people social media is a
great channel for that we can look to
conversion rates so if we are pushing a
product and service in front of the
right eyeballs and we are building up a
funnel of prospective customers who then
turn into customers who then turn into
loyal customers who then turn into
lifetime customers we could see at every
step in the process that our conversion
rates may increase we can certainly
leverage social media marketing for SEO
for search engine rankings it's about
off-page SEO it's about posting content
on social media platforms to build up
some link juice okay so there there is
some inherent benefits to working SEO
and social media side by side it's cost
effective well if you're posting content
on Twitter or Facebook it doesn't cost
you anything it just takes a little bit
of time and creativity now if you want
to go ahead and do some advertising on
these platforms yes it's going to cost
you but you'd be surprised not going to
be as costly as say other search
platforms like say Google or Bing where
you're actually paying for keywords and
paying per click for those keywords so
social media marketing can be very cost
effective and then increase top funnel
traffic so it goes all the way back to
Brand experience and brand awareness if
you're putting yourself in position to
get seen by your target audience okay
your target audience goes from senior
brand for the first time to getting to
know your brand a little bit more to
maybe buying a product or service from
your brand then returning to buy another
product inside service and then
continuing to buy that product or
service I mean that's increasing the top
funnel traffic and not just the traffic
but the conversions so at every step in
the process social media allows you to
build that funnel depending on where
somebody is whether they're seeing your
brand for the first time or actually
returning to purchase the product or
service again so that's the inherent
benefit these are the inherent benefits
of social media marketing today we are
going to talk about all the different
ads that Facebook has to offer so
introduced back in 2007 the Facebook ads
platform has grown tremendously over the
last few years almost four billion
dollars of Revenue in one year so what
does that mean that means there's a lot
of advertisers why is there a lot of
advertisers because a lot of people use
Facebook it's a popular platform so not
only is it popular but it's popular with
advertisers because if you're
advertising on Facebook book you have
the opportunity to share your product
and your brand with users who you think
are going to buy your product or
associate with your brand and on
Facebook you can do that a number of
different ways specifically in
somebody's news feed and specifically
that person's new feed that again is
interested potentially interested in
your brand your product so there's a lot
of ways to advertise and a lot of
reasons why you want to advertise so I
just mentioned one of the reasons hey
it's an opportunity for you to reach out
to people who are targeted who are
specific to your product and your brand
so not only that but you combine that
target audience with the amount of time
that people spend on Facebook okay
people spend a lot of time on Facebook
in fact not only do people spend a lot
of time on Facebook there's a lot of
people on Facebook in fact 2.27 billion
in the third quarter of 2018. and so
when we say spent a lot of time we mean
going to that Facebook profile at least
once a day okay so a lot of eyeballs
throughout the day checking their news
feed on Facebook Facebook also enables
you the advertiser to find the perfect
audience and so that's the great
combination a lot of people on Facebook
and targeted audience so it's a platform
that allows you to put your product in
front of people based on specific
interest specific demographics specific
location so you're really really putting
your product out in front of the right
people at the right time and so the
other positive and pro about Facebook is
it's lesser spend greater reach and what
do we mean by that well traditionally
Facebook is a little bit cheaper than
other online advertising models it is
definitely a lot cheaper than your
traditional advertising models and
Facebook has been known to have good
return on investment because it's cost a
little bit less than other advertising
models and other advertising platforms
so that's the other benefit to being on
Facebook so if you're into building a
brand you want to be on Facebook why
because it helps you increase your brand
awareness it's going to help you allow
users to know what your brand is all
about because remember you're putting
your brand in front of like-minded
people or people you think that are
going to associate with your brand that
are going to associate with your product
so you put your brand out there you
incorporate your your advertisement in
somebody's news feed it's going to add
value it's going to establish trust and
credibility especially if that person's
friend is associated with that brand so
instant credibility if friends and
family members of a person on Facebook
are associated with your brand so it has
the opportunity to really lend a lot of
credence to somebody who is on Facebook
active on Facebook and is your targeted
demographic and the great thing about
Facebook is it also has other features
other advertising features such as
retargeting so you could Target people
who've already expressed an interest in
your service of product but if they
didn't go through the conversion process
meaning they didn't go all the way
through and and buy your product you can
certainly reach out to them again just
like your traditional retargeting
options on say Google or some other
advertising platform Facebook works the
same way we want to be able to reach out
to people who aren't fully committed at
a point in time but we can reach out to
them at another point in time and so
Facebook's advertising platform allows
us to do that so it's a great feature
that we could take advantage of that
will talk about more throughout this
session and then it helps increase
Revenue sales and leads and and that's
primarily what most advertisers are
after you know more Revenue more sales
more leads so Facebook allows us to
educate our audience again a target
audience about a specific product we
have to offer so the more our audience
knows about our product especially for
their friends and family members and
colleagues are using the product then
the more likely they're going to
purchase so if you go back to the other
feature higher Revenue less spend this
is the primary reason because you have a
chance to influence somebody who's very
targeted who's very active on the
platform and who may have like-minded
people in their life associating with
your brand and product so it's a perfect
combination for advertising perfect
combination and so today we're going to
talk about all the different types of
Facebook ads and we're going to start
out with the single image ad in the
single image ad or just single image
advertisements that have an optional
text on top and a link description that
links to the website so single image ads
are probably the most popular you can
see them on probably your own Facebook
feed if you look so in fact I'll just
jump over to my Facebook feed right now
and if I go there what do I see I see a
single image ad here and it's from
Shopify Partners so become a Shopify
partner at eCommerce to your list of
qualifications so Shopify must be you
know a brand that is trying to woo my
business okay so they know that somebody
that I'm associated with or maybe I fit
their demographic so they're targeting
my newsfeed with a single image ad so
that's what a single image ad looks like
it's simply just one single image with
some description and the great thing
about this single image if you ever
noticed is the pixels are pretty large
it's 1200 by 628 so it kind of stands
out little bit it's not your traditional
thumbnail it really pops when you look
at the news feed so again if I go back
to my news feed here you can see it just
really stands out within the news feed
so I can't miss it if I'm a targeted
part of their targeted audience it's
hard for me to you know not see the sad
interact in some way especially again if
I know somebody in my network on
Facebook or either that be a friend or
family members associated with that
product okay in addition to the single
image ads Facebook also has
multi-product ads or also known as
Carousel ads and so what the carousel
ads do is allow you and in Carousel form
allow you to rotate different ads with
different messaging and different call
to action and so here you can see simply
learn has a example of a carousel ad
where they're showcasing their different
courses so this allows users to view a
range of all your different products and
services if you have multiple products
and services to offer then the carousel
ads would be a good option for you so in
addition to the Carousel ads and single
image ads it gets a little bit more
sophisticated in terms of Technology
where Facebook allows us to offer up
video ads and so video ads are
interactive it's a good way to really
showcase your product your brand your
service and the great thing about the
video ads is they can go from just a few
seconds all the way up to you know two
minutes or excuse me all the way up to
120 minutes and so you can really really
put a lot of time and effort into the
video ads to really put your brand out
there and so the one thing about video
is it is interactive most people engage
with video and they tend to get about 10
to 30 percent more views than other
forms of ads so the video ads are really
a popular way for you as an Advertiser
to put your brand or product out there
so you can put your brand and product
out there and not just a few seconds but
you know really tell a nice complete
story to get the engagement to get the
person to take the action you want them
to do so that's why video ads have
become very popular because they tend to
get more engagement more interaction
than your traditional single image ad or
say your Carousel ad so Facebook also
allows us to advertise something called
lead ads and what lead ads allow us to
do is obtain user details okay so we can
acquire or get an email address or phone
number from somebody whose interest in
our product or service and that person
doesn't even have to leave Facebook so
if you look here on the example here we
have the ad somebody clicks on sign up
and they get this form submission and
the great thing about the lead at is
that it can sync up with any CRM or most
of your popular serums I should say for
example Salesforce as a good example of
a CRM where somebody fills that out the
information goes directly to Salesforce
and so lead ads are really good if
you're trying to generate you know leads
for your business and the form itself
the interaction stays right in Facebook
and so that's the great thing about it
they don't really have to leave the
platform another form of advertising on
Facebook are slideshows okay so unlike
the carousel ads which rotate and the
carousel ads remember rotate and
showcase different products or Services
these ads are are interactive but
they're rotating different imagery so it
allows you to really put your best
images out there with a really strong
call to action just like you see here
with the simply learn example okay so
they're showcasing you know their
different classes us and then they have
the get started today call to action to
really punctuate the slideshow ad so
what's interesting is you can really
gauge a person's interest by throwing
different products or images out there
you know you can really immerse a user's
experience here by showing different
different images and then the last type
of ad on Facebook is called The
Collection ad and so these ads combine
basically your video your slideshow or
your product images taken from your
product catalog okay so if you're an
Advertiser who wants to advertise
several products at once then this could
be a great option for you the collection
ad so here you can see the simply learn
example here they're showing you know
not only you know some some good
slideshows and imagery with some good
messaging below that
Instagram is a social media platform
that needs no introduction with nearly 1
billion monthly active users and 500
million daily active users Instagram is
a platform Rife with marketing potential
more than 7 billion dollars Revenue has
been generated from Instagram mobile and
it's home to more than 2 million
advertisers
not only that marketing on Instagram has
the following advantages too
you have increased conversions according
to research more than one-third of the
people using the app have used it to
purchase products which means by
marketing your products on the app
there's a higher chance of conversion
you also have advanced targeting options
this is in part thanks to Instagram's
parent company Facebook Instagram has
access to just about all advertising
features offered by Facebook ads with
this you can advertise to People based
on their age location gender interests
and much more
you can also build better brand follower
relationships you can stimulate
conversion with your followers and build
a connection with them you'll also get a
greater understanding of what your
followers like and dislike based on
their engagement this enables you to
make content they enjoy more and
increase the chance of converting a user
to a consumer
so let's have a look at how marketing is
done on Instagram
let's start with number one optimize
your bio
your bio is the first thing people
notice when they get to your page that's
where they make the first impression of
your brand and that's why it's important
for your bio to be informative
captivating and engaging
use your bio to provide a brief
description of your brand or product the
type of content you'll be posting brand
hashtags links to other social media
platforms and more
your bio should also include a URL to
where you want to drive traffic to be it
your Brand's website or a page for a
particular product make sure to track
this link as well to see how much
traffic it brings
here's an example of how Samsung uses
its bio effectively
you can see it's a very straightforward
it's got a branded hashtag it talks
about all the services Samsung offers
there are links to other pages and a
link to the website as well it's to the
point and covers everything you need to
know about it
next up at number two we have create a
Content calendar
now if you ask anyone who works with
social media one of the most important
things they'll tell you is to have a
Content calendar
a Content calendar enables you to keep
track of your posts it'll help you plan
ahead and automate the process of
publishing your posts when your audience
is most active a calendar helps you
decide what content caption hashtags
videos goes live on what day date or
time a consistent post schedule will
enable you to make the most out of
Instagram it'll also keep your audience
engaged and also give you access to
historical posts if you want to repost
your older content
next up we have number three get greater
reach with ads
paid ads can enable you to get more
followers engagement leads and
conversions
the caveat here being that you will need
to pay for it too the ad options are
pretty similar to what you have on
Facebook like audience segmentation
based on likes interactions buying
habits and more you also have a variety
of AD formats to choose from like story
ads image ads video ads collection ads
and more
moreover they can also be set up from
Facebook ads manager here's an example
from an ad from body shop in which they
are using a single image ad the
advertising works because of its
interesting creative and attractive ad
copy that attracts the customer to
interact with the post and click on the
link let's go to number four have a
visually consistent feed Instagram is a
platform in which people gravitate
towards aesthetically pleasing content
two authentic expressions and diverse
perspectives the objective is that your
feed needs to match with your Brand's
identity and must appeal to the audience
within your industry what works nowadays
are candid shots muted Earthly tones
with a low key editing style your
content must feel down to earth and your
brand approachable
as you can see in the images all of them
have aesthetically pleasing images and
are somewhat blue or underwater theme
and that's the kind of thing you should
aim for your content following an
understandable and interesting aesthetic
depending on the product you're trying
to sell now for number five tell a story
the images videos and stories you post
need to tell stories that can Captivate
your audience and establish a connection
with them this makes it more likely that
they feel closer to your brand and buy
your products your captions can tell
stories that can help your brand appear
more human and build deeper connections
with your audience
your content needs to align with what
your audience cares about or solves
problems they face
here's an example of how the page
Patagonia talks about forests in America
each of their posts tells stories about
a different tissue that affects nature
their brand on Instagram revolves around
bringing awareness to such issues that's
the kind of stories you should tell with
your brand
next up number six use the right
hashtags
using the right hashtags can make the
difference between your post showing up
on the explore tab for everyone to see
and it getting lost in a sea of content
your hashtag shouldn't be too generic
like hash New Year or hash style since
they'll have too much competition
instead mix up trending and Industry
specific keywords to connect with your
followers
research on successful hashtags and
limit yourself to less than seven in
each post
the more the hashtags in your post the
more likely it seems spammy untargeted
and unprofessional
find out what and how many hashtags your
competitors use and how you can do
something similar
you could also create a hashtag for your
brand these need to be short easily
memorable and involve your brand name in
some way
let's now go to number seven take
advantage of ugc
ugc or user generated content gives your
followers to further involve themselves
with your brand
ugc also buy them as well regardless of
the field your brand belongs to ugc can
be used to convert followers into
Advocates of your brand
here's an example of how Starbucks uses
user generated content and takes
advantages of Their audience to
advertise their products
in this post here they are attracting
customers with an image of happy
children dressed in products stalled at
Starbucks
the post posted by another user would be
appreciated by the audience and improve
brand loyalty
next up number eight
take advantage of video ads most
instagramers state that users have
visited websites searched or told a
friend after being influenced by posts
even though photo ads are still the more
popular form of advertising we do
advertisements aren't too far behind
there are three key video formats when
it comes to Instagram ads single video
ads that can create 60 second ads
carousels are a combination of images
and videos and Instagram stories that
enable you to combine images and videos
to create visually attractive ads
here's an example of the brand Pizza 73
using story ads to advertise their
pizzas
it's successful because you're showing
off the product they are advertising
with well short videos and captions now
for number nine partner up with
influencers
connecting with influencers will enable
you to connect with thought leaders
within the industry and enable you to
show off your brand to a larger audience
by connecting with them your brand will
have greater authenticity and Authority
influencers need to be given new tools
resources and guidance to carry out
their role effectively and to work
together as partners
micro influencers are also considered to
be more affordable and they have a
closer connection with their audience
here we can see how raslauren have
collaborated with an influencer to
advertise their products the influencer
showing off the latest Ralph Lauren has
to offer this encourages his interested
followers to check out the page and buy
something for themselves
next for number 10 host contests and
giveaways contests enable your audience
to engage with your brand with 3.5 times
more likes and 64 times the comments you
can give away a product or a service
which enables you to boost engagement
and brand awareness
contests and giveaways need to be
planned Brands need to be partnered with
Contest rules need to be identified
posts need to be created and much more
monitoring the contest and then running
it is also really important you would
need to track your contest performance
and promote the results on other social
media platforms as well here's an
example of a contest run by Domino's
Pizza which encourages people to
contribute their own short stories and
connect better with the brand
number 11 take advantage of stories and
igtv
stories enable you to create a
combination of photos and videos that
disappear after 24 hours
stories can greatly influence your reach
and engagement rates even giving your
story the chance to show up in the
explore section it can also help make
your brand seem more approachable and
authentic adding links to the Instagram
stories can also help with driving
traffic to your website
igtv on the other hand although now
seemingly on the decline still has a few
advantages to offer to The Savvy
marketer igtv provides you a unique
mobile-friendly layout that serves as an
evergreen content very well like
featurettes and interviews another new
tool they have introduced is Instagram
reels Instagram's answer to tick tock
Instagram released reels through which
users would be able to upload 15 second
clips and since it released very
recently it's a Rife with marketing
potential
finally we have number 12 track and
learn identify effective hashtags visual
Styles and the best times to post doing
this you can develop the best practices
for your brand social listening and
analytics will help you fine-tune your
marketing strategy and increase
Instagram engagement so let's talk about
how to create a YouTube ad so this is
going to require some access to Google
ads and we'll go over that in a few
minutes here but first we need to think
about setting up a campaign and setting
up a campaign goal okay what's the goal
of our campaign to get eyeballs you know
we want to pay cost for 1000 Impressions
or we want to run some actionable type
ads to get people over to our website so
that really is step one we need to
identify what the goal of our campaign
is then we need to create the ad so we
want to be able to create a video ad
here that is going to show on YouTube
and to our target audience so or whether
it be a bumper ad that's only going to
be 6 seconds long we need to be able to
figure out what type of AD we want to
run so here I am in Google ads if we're
going to run a campaign on YouTube we
need to make sure that we're choosing a
display campaign and so remember the
first step is you know setting up that
campaign setting up that campaign goal
so we're going to go ahead and select a
new campaign here we're going to run a
new campaign and so what's the goal of
our campaign so if we're just out to
generate brand awareness and reach
that's certainly fine if it's all about
sales or if it's all about leads then
you know the type of video run is going
to be a little bit different so if we
select brand awareness and reach okay
here we're going to select the campaign
type and so if we select video basically
what we're doing is we're going to tell
Google we want to go ahead and set up
some video ads on YouTube and so here
you can see the different types of video
as we discussed today you know we got
your bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our outstream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types and
so we're going to click continue and
then once we do that you know we're
going to get prompted to you know move
forward with selecting our ad so you can
see here after I set up my campaign now
I'm just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting our audience so here we
got demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
YouTube videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember in this
example we're going to Bumper ads and
we're looking at about six seconds and
once we do that then that's pretty much
the campaign but I just want to stress
here that when you're setting it up a
ahead of time you want to make sure you
identify what the campaign goal is and
then that's going to align with the type
of video you're going to run and then
once you choose that type of video then
it just comes down to where you want
that ad to be and who you're targeting
so it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the Right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
YouTube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
Channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose use the type
of goal for your campaign that can be
brand awareness it could be a sale it
could be a lead so to me that's the you
know a very critical step one so you
want to make sure you align your goal
with your video and then the second is
track low performing ad placements so if
we just ask Google to place our video
ads anywhere they want then it's up to
us then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I can see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or adverb so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
Replacements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ad is all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive you can always perform a b
testing on your ads so if you have one
ad version you can create another one
just to see what it which one performs
better testing is always a positive okay
so if you're paying too much maybe think
about reducing your bids so if you
remember we said a 10 CPM bid that may
be too much maybe we don't need to pay
ten dollars so we can always reduce our
bids at the ad group level so reduce
bids in areas where you see lower
performance so in other words you don't
want to pay a lot for poor performance
you can also use remarketing to
re-engage with customers so if somebody
views your ads and doesn't take action
you can always retarget that person uh
to show your ad another even another ad
format it could be text ads or display
ads but if somebody looked at your video
and they didn't take the action you
preferred them to take then you can
always retarget them with another ad so
that's a good way to optimize okay so we
want to make sure the ad has content
that what viewers would find relevant
okay that really you want to make sure
that your ad is you know is with the end
viewer you don't want to put out an ad
that isn't going to give somebody you
know a good feeling after they've
watched it okay so you want to make sure
viewers find the content relevant so if
they don't find it relevant then that
means your engagement rate and your
engagement is probably going to be low
so you want to take a look at those
metrics that we viewed earlier
engagement rate engagement and if
they're low then you probably need to
look at the content of the ad so try to
make make sure your ad conveys your
Brand's message in the first six seconds
so that's why bumper ads to me are so
critical because you got to get the
entirety of the ad and make it impactful
and so with any AD you run any video ads
you're on you really want to make sure
that that message is conveyed at the
very beginning early as possible
otherwise you know people are going to
be turned off or not engaged and just
going to go ahead and skip it anyway so
you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include Visual
and auditory components in your ad that
can make it more memorable to the
viewers okay meaning music or other cool
visuals okay so again you want to be
able to play around and test different
ads yes I mean click-through rate
engagement rate all of those are
indicators whether the ad is of good
quality or not with the end user and
when I say good quality I mean do they
find it do they find it interesting or
so they're going to click and if you
don't have good click the rates or good
engagement rates then you definitely
want to try doing something different to
the ad like adding those audio
components or other visuals that could
be appealing to the end user so go ahead
and and test some of those out with a B
because you have nothing to lose but
higher or lower engagement rates or
lower click-through rates so you want to
be able to improve those metrics
improving those metrics means trying
some different components on different
ads so let's take a look at a case study
if you will and let's focus on super dry
so they're a good success story on
YouTube it says super dry leaned on some
YouTube advertising to help lift
products so in September last year 2018
talk about how you can optimize your
YouTube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
Channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step F1 so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask Google to place our video ads
anywhere they want then it's up to us
then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I could see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or adverb so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get that sales or leads if
you're that placement is not converting
sales or leads then you need to remove
or exclude that placement so it's all
done within the Google ads platform and
then you know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image and your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed caption
option in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ad is all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive you can always perform a b
testing on your ads so if you have one
ad version you can create another one
just to see what it which one performs
better testing is always a positive okay
so if you're paying too much maybe think
about reducing your bids so if you
remember we set a 10 CPM bit that may be
too much maybe we don't need to pay ten
dollars so we can always reduce our bids
at the ad group level so reduce bids in
areas where you see lower performance so
in other words you don't want to pay a
lot for poor performance you can also
use remarketing to re-engage with
customers so if somebody views your ads
and doesn't take action you can always
retarget that person uh to show your ad
another even another ad format it could
be text ads display ads but if somebody
looked at your video and they didn't
take the action you preferred them to
take then you can always retarget them
with another ad so that's a good way to
optimize okay so we want to make sure
the ad has content that what viewers
would find relevant okay that really you
want to make sure that your ad is you
know is with the end viewer you don't
want to put out an ad that isn't going
to give somebody you know a good feeling
after they watched it okay so you want
to make sure viewers find the content
relevant so if they don't find it
relevant then that means your engagement
rate and your engagement is probably
going to be low so you want to take a
look at those metrics that we viewed
earlier engagement rate engagement and
if they're low then you probably need to
look at the content of the ad so try to
make sure your ad conveys your Brand's
message in the first six seconds so
that's why bumper ads to me are so
critical because you got to get the
entirety of the at and make it impactful
and so with any AD you run any video ad
you're on you really want to make sure
that that message is conveyed at the
very beginning early as possible
otherwise you know people are going to
be turned off or not engaged and just
going to go ahead and skip it anyway so
you want to make sure you get the
purpose of it right up front and out of
the way okay you can also include Visual
and auditory components in your ad that
can make it more memorable to the
viewers okay meaning music or other cool
visuals okay so again you want to be
able to play around and test different
ads and you want to be able to you know
measure the ad Performance Based on the
metrics we discussed I mean
click-through rate engagement rate all
of those are indicators whether the ad
is of good quality or not with the end
user and when I say good quality I mean
do they find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the at like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and test some of those out with a
B testing because you have nothing to
lose but higher or lower engagement
rates or lower click-through rates so
you want to be able to improve those
metrics improving those metrics means
trying some different components on
different ads so let's take a look at a
case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on YouTube so super Drive leaned
on some YouTube advertising to help lift
one of their products so in September
last year 2018 super dry if you're not
familiar with the brand they're you know
centered some Asian markets European
markets and they focus in on clothing
all different styles and sizes and
genders from jackets to jeans to
t-shirts and so they're a global brand
they really wanted to take a different
approach here and their approach was
they wanted to focus in on sales they
wanted to see if video can help lift
them with sales and so what they've done
is they set up some campaigns on YouTube
and their focus here was on jackets and
jackets to specific ages across the
board all genders and interests and so
what they did was they wanted to Once
take advantage of all the different ad
types that YouTube had to offer and
let's take a look at one of those ads
here so if we go to YouTube and let's
just take a look at this one minute ad
here 53 second ad by super dry
um
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raising the jacket you're waiting the
Jackie you're pulling the jacket You'll
Play how I'm posing you'll take five in
this jacket you'll want to find this
jacket I washed the jacket
our mates take away 3am plates catch
your breath not your death in this
jacket it's the jacket your cream is
to jacket you're hiding you're vibing
love live and praises
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known so
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on super dry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the air they had
different jackets both female and male
different gender types so they were most
oxygen a very broad audience of gender
uh some younger people is who they were
targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a 138 percent increase in brand lip
I mean the jacket ad so it's a pretty
successful campaign see as well
choreographed good audio good video just
well professionally done and they
probably were able to now get a few more
loyal customers under their belt because
of this ad alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and Target them with a cool video and
given that YouTube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
there's true view in stream ads with a
cost per view through a skippable video
ad format and they they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to Target the
length of the ad and given that their
product or selling a product or
promoting a product they all take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video ad
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
today we're going to talk about how to
increase Instagram followers today's
webinar we're gonna have some tips and
and best practices for you to take
advantage of to increase Instagram
followers so let's get started and talk
a little bit about Instagram so
Instagram is not really an up and coming
platform it is already up and coming a
lot of users in fact 500 million daily
active Instagram users 500 million daily
May the user base growth of more than
300 percent year over year so it's
growing and growing and growing it's
become more and more popular ever since
it's launched back in 2010 and then
there's more than 100 million photos
uploaded daily so it's a platform where
you can upload photos tag those photos
even use and Implement videos and photos
have become very popular with the Advent
of mobile technology that the Instagram
app makes it easy for you to post your
photos so there's no surprise there's a
growth there's no surprise there's a lot
of users there's no surprise is that
there's a hundred million photos plus
uploaded daily and then there are 400
million stories posted daily so when you
post something you can create a story
out of it and there's 400 million of
those per day and then there's more than
50 billion photos shared to date so
since 2010 platform Nat which is now
owned by Facebook has become really
really popular a good place for you if
you have your own company if you have
your own brand if you have your own
product it's a good place for you to
really showcase that service that
product that brand because of the user
base how easy it is to use and the wide
reach it has for you in which to tell
your story so imagine there are lots of
photos shared today close to seven
billion dollars revenue generated
through Instagram mobile so on top of
everything I just said there's a lot of
e-commerce going on here too so
Instagram is a platform in which there's
e-commerce integrated within the
platform so as a business who offers of
products you can actually generate
revenue for yourself on the flip side
Instagram which is owned by Facebook has
an opportunity to sell advertising space
on Instagram so Instagram is an
e-commerce platform to say the least in
fact Instagram is because it's so
popular because it's part of Facebook's
advertising platform they're more than
two million advertisers on Instagram so
amongst all those stories videos and
photos and hashtags you'll see some ads
and then because you'll see ads because
you'll see users you're going to see
businesses it's just good place to
really set up shop and really tell your
story through the world of photos and
videos so 25 million plus businesses
have already migrated over to Instagram
and that's growing and growing and
growing so it's an opportunity for you
to work with other businesses so the
arrow is definitely pointing up on
Instagram there's a lot going on here
easy to use application especially when
it comes to photos and videos so we're
going to go through some tips and tricks
today and we're going to talk about
everything there is to know about
Instagram and how to increase your
followers so let's take a look at tip
one here so because Instagram is an
application everything you do on it is
through the application now you could
certainly view a web page version on it
but you really can't do much out of that
so if I go to my Instagram accounts for
example using my desktop I could see my
profile and I can edit my profile to a
degree but everything you're doing is
through the application so when it comes
to that tip one here is take advantage
of your bio so regardless of what
industry you are you're in who you are
you really want to have a clear and
concise and compelling bio why because
this is your introduction to the world
you want people to know who you are and
because if you don't really become very
clear to people they're not going to
follow you so this is where it all
starts you need to take advantage of
your bio have a clear and concise bio
and have a link to your website or some
contact information so to me this is
where it all starts you gotta have a bio
because that's what people are going to
look at and they're going to decide
whether to follow you or not based on
primarily that bio that's where it all
starts so make sure you have a good bio
that's tip number one so you have to
make sure that your landing page is also
mobile optimized since most Instagram
users are on mobile so if you're going
to put a link to your website and
somebody's on the Instagram app and they
see your bio and they like it and you
have a link to your website make sure
that Lanny pays they go to is mobile
optimized so tip number two everything
you do on Instagram when it comes to
posting evolves around hashtags so
that's the backbone of the platform just
like most platforms out there social
media platforms like Twitter or Facebook
Pinterest you're gonna have hashtags
accompany those posts so Instagram's no
different but in this case you really
really want to take advantage of the
hashtag so hashtags are there to help
users find your content so you want to
start out by using hashtags that are
relevant to your business so if you're
in the food industry you're going to
post something related to food do the
appropriate amount of research to find
hashtags to describe your brand and also
are being searched on Instagram so what
does that mean that means do a little
bit of homework on Instagram you know
see what searches or see what other
brands in your industry are using for
hashtags don't be afraid to use the same
hashtag but mix it up hashtags are
important so don't be afraid to put a
hashtag in there that really defines
what your business is about but if it's
relevant use other hashtags that are
popular or people are using to find
information so mix it up but the key
here is relevancy you want to make sure
you align your Hashtags with your
content and making sure the connection
between the #and the content is
relevancy so using the popular tags on
your photos or videos might get you some
immediate engagement but it may not help
with future goals like long-term
engagement new interested followers and
sales so here really what I'm trying to
say is look pick and choose your
hashtags carefully because if you use
something broad or something
non-relevant yeah you may get that click
to your Instagram page but that doesn't
necessarily mean somebody's going to
follow you or that doesn't really mean
somebody's going to be interested in
what you have to offer so if you use
something really popular and Broad yes
you're going to get short-term
gratification but not long-term interest
tip number three post your content at
the right time so according to sprout
social which is a social media
scheduling platform among other things
so they deal with a lot of people using
their platform and posting content via
their platform they have data and
they're telling us based on the data
they've collected that the best time to
post this between 2 and 3 P.M and the
best day to post is Thursday now that
may be all fine and true according to a
sprout social study and so you may want
to go with this 2 to 3 P.M and this is
probably local in case you're wondering
what time zone you're referring to so
this is all local to you so go ahead and
try that out try 2 to 3 P.M on Thursday
the thing is what you're gonna have to
do eventually is figure out what the
best time to post is okay so if you're
pointing out a lot of content and you're
putting out content throughout the week
at certain times of the day or
throughout the day you're gonna have to
determine which time of day and what day
is generating the best engagement for
you who's looking at your post at what
point of the day what day of the week
and so you're gonna really have to lean
on a social media platform to help you
determine that because they're going to
have the data that you need to determine
what the best time of day to post is
okay so we'll talk about social media
platforms here shortly we just know that
when you post post with some rationale
in mind ask yourself before you even
push that publish button or before you
even schedule that post this time of day
in this day of the week makes sense so
you always want to post at the right
time because you could be missing your
audience so remember when you do this
you're going to be working with some
platform and Instagram also has some
analytics for business accounts so
Instagram will also give you some
feedback as to how you're supposed to
perform it and we're going to talk about
that here shortly as well so let's move
over to tip four here so steal followers
from your competitors okay so if you're
dealing in a very competitive industry
and your competitors have a lot of
followers it's very very easy to see
who's following them so the easiest way
to do this is just interact with your
competitors followers you could follow a
user like or comment on their photos and
so the more more you engage with people
the more you stand to gain from them so
you could see who your competitors
followers are and you can add them as a
follower just by following them so start
engaging with them if they're liking
your competitor's brand then what the
chance of them like in your brand could
be great so check out who your
competitors followers are if they seem
like somebody who you would want to be
following your brand then go ahead and
interact with them and how you interact
is again you can like something that
they post or you can comment on
something that they posted okay engage
with them okay it doesn't take that much
time it's a good way to gain followers
so if we're on Instagram we can simply
just click on the Brand's followers so
here I can see the Sprint has 127
followers and here I can see all the
followers and what I could do is simply
just click on one of the followers and I
can go to their profile and from there I
could see what they've posted in terms
of videos and images and I can like or
comment so just doing something as
simple as this gets you an opportunity
to engage with somebody who can then
turn around and follow you so tip five
pay for sponsored posts and product
reviews so a number of ways you could do
this here so pay for a sponsored posts
so you can find an influer satisfies a
couple of requirements they have large
following and an email address in the
profile so you can connect with them and
ask them for sponsored post pricing so
it's as simple as that as reaching out
to somebody who has a large following
okay so if you do this then it's going
to put shoe in front of a large number
of people and so by doing this it'll
help expose your brand to that larger
audience and help build your credibility
because you're connecting with somebody
who has a large audience as well so do a
little bit of homework find people out
there in your industry who has a large
following and make sure they have that
email address in their profile so you
can contact them and when you contact
them you know ask them for sponsored
post pricing so if the influencer has an
email address then they're open to
sponsored post or shout out so that's
the key so they gotta have that email
address and when they do then it's all
about asking them and connecting with
them on being a sponsor to one of your
posts okay you want to get yourself out
there in front of people this is the
quickest way to do that okay so tip six
we want to use geotags for easier
discoverability okay so tag your images
videos or stories by tagging the
location City or venue where it was
posted from so very easy to do as you're
posting just go ahead and and there's an
option in there to say hey where are you
located or what city are you located in
so locations have their own feed and
stories which you can contribute to so
go ahead and add that extra element to
your tags so if somebody's in that
location the chance of them engaging are
going to be great and it's good for
local businesses because if you're local
and you're posting your location then
again somebody in that location is
likely to engage with you tip 7 use
Instagram stories to track followers and
grow your user base so stories of really
big feature on Instagram so what stories
could be used for is just show footage
of an environment so it could be your
office it could be your home it could be
you know the playground it could be the
golf course it could be anywhere that
you want to show vintage of so you want
to post new relevant to your industry so
if you're in the food industry hey why
not go in the back into the kitchen and
post a story about how a particular
bread or cake is made okay show off your
products so if you are in that food
industry and say you're in the pizza
making business perfect opportunity to
show people via an Instagram Story how
to make that pizza and how you make that
pizza what ingredients you use how
unique is your particular product and
that's really what you want to get
across when you do a story you want to
show something unique and relevant
that's going to grasp people's attention
you can promote a company event so if
you're celebrating say 200 000
subscribers create a YouTube video or
you can create an Instagram story it
works just as well so you can endorse
your company's blog posts you can post
positive user reviews so these are all
features of a story increased
interactivity with polls sliders Etc and
then you can also mention other
companies that work with or follow you
so great use of Instagram stories is do
a shout out to somebody else so
Instagram stories is a really big
feature with Instagram check it out you
know you just do a search for Instagram
stories in fact let's get some of you
users involved what best practices do
you have when creating Instagram stories
why don't you go ahead and share your
Instagram story with us by putting that
Instagram story in the comment section
below so we want to get everybody
involved here because there's a
thousands upon thousands of great
Instagram gram stories out there to be
shown and viewed and engaged with so go
ahead and share your Instagram story if
you have any other tips or tricks then
go ahead and put those in the comments
section so that everybody can benefit
from them so the only thing to keep in
mind when you're creating these stories
is what are your followers interested in
seeing so your stories could teach or
promote something to your user base so
always keep that in the back your mind
you know for me I always go back to what
industry are you in if you're in the
food industry hey you know people who
are following you are interested in food
if you're a pizza company you know show
off that pizza if you're a bakery show
off how you make your Breads and goods
baked goods whatever it is you have show
it off because if somebody's following
you that's what they're interested in so
tip number eight highlight important
stories so you want to highlight
highlights serve as the easiest way to
create a first impression for a
potential follower so with highlights
can be used to tease what your content's
about create a trailer for what your
brand offers promote mode and promote
your product so highlights are there
it's a good feature it's a first
impression for potential follower so it
teases what the content's about it
creates a trailer so to speak for your
brand and promote your product so use
highlights and again any users out there
who have good examples of highlights go
ahead and put those in the content
section or comment section right below
this video so remember stories have only
a 24-hour lifespan so highlights can be
used to give them a second wind okay so
highlights serve a purpose it teases
what the content's about it promotes the
product and it really kind of
accentuates that story tip number nine
ask for followers so sometimes people
need a little push before they can
follow you on Instagram even if they
enjoy your content so you can ask users
to become your followers in the caption
the comment section or even work it into
your content so in other words when
you're posting something don't be afraid
to say hey follow me you know I got some
good stuff here be confident you don't
want to do it for for every post of
course but you know pick and choose if
you feel you have a really good post you
know really good image that you think is
going to gain a lot of followers and
engagers then you don't necessarily need
to put a caption in there but if if it
is popular then go ahead and say hey
this is a popular post you know think
about following me or put something in
the comment section you want to do it
kind of succinctly you don't want to be
begging but just working into some
degree okay but don't be afraid have
some confidence in asking for followers
so when you do this it's very similar to
how we do it on YouTube so you can ask
viewers to subscribe to their channels
at the end of the video so it's if on
YouTube basically you're saying hey if
you like what we have go ahead and
subscribe it's no different on Instagram
if you have something you've posted just
go and said hey you like this you know
go ahead and follow us so that's simple
so tip number 10 take on the latest
trends to get more followers so align
your content to cater to trendy topics
or hashtags to improve engagement and
discoverability so really what we're
trying to say here's your competitors
follow influencers what are the latest
trends and you can get an idea of the
latest trends by you looking at hashtags
so what hashtags are trending which ones
are people using the most so really what
you want to do is whatever's trending in
your industry you know ride that wave so
to speak now it doesn't have to take on
your entire profile but there's nothing
wrong with one or two posts if
something's really taking on popularity
then go ahead and post about it as well
you know for example in the wine
industry if there's a new wine that
really came out that's really gaining
some popularity go ahead and post about
it with the same hashtag and with the
unique hashtag so don't be afraid to you
know ride the wave of popularity so to
speak because it shows that you know you
know what you're talking about it adds
some credibility and it's going to get
some you know viewers over to your
Instagram profile so keep in mind you
need to keep your content relevant
because because if your audience is
interested in what you have to offer
then they're going to be engaged however
you know if you're joining the
discussion in a relevant manner keep it
in mind whether your audience would
interact or not is important but just
always keep in mind you always want to
stay within your industry and relevancy
for your target audience so tip number
testing giveaways and so just like on
YouTube just like on Facebook I mean
Instagram is no different you can
increase reach and exposure by running
contests since most followers would tag
their friends to let them know about it
it's a good idea to run contests and so
it's an idea of a contest well again if
you're running a pizza parlor you know
you could say hey what's your favorite
pizza or give me your favorite pizza
ideas and you can run a contest and you
know you can have people even create
their own pizza and post an image of it
you can have people create stories on
the best ways in which they create pizza
or their experience in another pizza
parlor there's lots of things you can do
to create a contest and you don't always
have to give something away you could
just do something for fun especially if
you have a lot of followers if you have
a lot of followers and somebody's going
to take part in it so don't be afraid to
run contests just to make it fun and
light it up a little bit so each tag and
bring you a new audience member who
could be a potential follower so anytime
you run a contest people are gonna tag
their friends to let them know about
that contest so those friends are gonna
come over and likely engage so that's
the beauty of running a contest or
giveaway is chances are words gonna
spread and it's going to get you some
new followers so that's the the end
benefits so to speak but the real
benefit is keeping your audience engaged
so tip number 12 we want to stay
consistent with posts so having a
consistent pace and theme for your post
can have a huge impact to convert
visitors so when we say consistent you
know if you're again that pizza parlor
stay within Pizza you could Branch out a
little maybe and talk about salads or
talk about beverages to you know as a
complimentary factor to the pizza okay
but don't talk about hamburgers if
you're focused in on pizza so we wanted
to stay consistent with your theme this
method involves less effort with a
faster production of Instagram content
so than me what we're really trying to
say here is focus stay focused on who
you are if you do that if you're
consistent and you're gaining some
followers and that's what people are
coming to you for the content that
you're good at for the industry you're
in okay so if you start varying it and
branching out then it's going to muddy
the water supposed so to speak and
you're probably going to get less
engagement so set a theme on Instagram
by maintaining consistency and your
personality filters colors and layouts
and really what I'm referring to is post
and when you have post something you're
you're really creating a personality for
yourself okay so if you're in fashion
for example and you're in the jeans
industry well jeans jeans jeans right
that's your personality accentuate it
with different outfits related to jeans
but you know when you start talking
about dresses and shoes and and that
kind of blurs your your personality a
bit so if you stake it consistent within
jeans and outfits that go with jeans
then I think people are going to start
to pick up on that personality so tip 13
keep track of your Instagram following
so you can analyze the growth of your
Channel with tools like socialblade I
could tell you how many followers you
lost over time and how engaged they are
okay so you can use data gather from
here and from Instagram business account
to diagnose where you're faltering so
let's take a look at socialblade as an
example here so if I go over here I'm
going to go to socialblade here I can
enter in basically any account after a
register and I could see how that
account has performed you know where
they rank you know how many uploads they
have what country they focused on one
industry and the beauty here is I could
see and I'm looking at YouTube as an
example I could see you know how my post
to perform well you could do this for
Instagram you could do it for Facebook
so you can really get an idea of how how
your account's performing so socialblade
is a great platform for measuring and
again you do also have Instagram
business insights so with Instagram
business insights basically what you're
going to do is you're going to go to
your app right and then from the app you
could basically look at your insights
from there so in the app itself you're
going to click on the upper right three
lines and from there you're going to see
insights and when you go to insights
you're also going to see you know what
your reach is how many Impressions and
some engagement metrics terms of your
audience where they're located the age
range okay you're gonna also see some
content related information so there's a
lot you could see from the the Instagram
insights analytics insights but you can
also see additional information from
socialblade so the key here is when
you're looking at your data you want to
look for patterns in post what post
receive the most amount of Engagement so
if you see something working obviously
replica it you know you don't want to
replicate it immediately but make note
of it and use it for future content so
tip 14 use Instagram ads so Instagram
ads give you complete control over
advertisements so how they appear and
who sees them so with Instagram ads you
can run photos you can run videos
carousels slideshows stories so we
mentioned this on other webinars for
Facebook advertising it's worth
repeating so if I go back into say
Facebook ads manager I can pick and
choose my placements and really what I
want to do is pick and choose for
example Instagram and so I have
Instagram feed I have Instagram stories
so and I could see with the video
requirement or the media requirement is
for running on Instagram so with
Instagram you can run stories you can
run videos single image ads you can run
Carousel so really you could put your
best forward meaning take the post
that's performing well and maybe you
want to advertise that promote it so
you're gonna run this through Facebook
ads manager and it's going to tell you
you know what your audience size is your
potential reach okay what your daily
results would be so you're going to get
all that information when you run your
ads on Facebook ads manager but it's a
great opportunity for you to really push
forward if you're running a promotion
it's really an opportunity for you to
push forward that promotion other
advantages scalable pricing self-serve
and instant robust reporting and highly
refined audience retargeting so all of
that is in the Facebook ads manager you
can get all the reporting you know you
need meaning you know who saw the ad did
they click on it okay you can refine
that target audience you can go back
into Facebook ads manager and refine who
your audience is so lots of flexibility
here on advertising on Instagram but the
key here is if you want to run
advertising on Instagram you know think
about what it is you're trying to
promote if you feel something needs to
get promoted then go ahead and you know
you can either again reach out to
somebody and have them sponsor it or you
can run it as an advertisement so let's
move on to tip 15. so we want to create
visually attractive and eye-catching ads
so if you are going to run ads you know
here's some things to keep in mind okay
you want to use images that are natural
and seem native okay you don't want to
use any stock photography first off you
want to use something that you've done
okay you want to minimize the amount of
text so let the image do the talking you
want to ensure your caption relates to
the image and resonates with your
audience okay so you have an opportunity
to add some text below the image okay so
make sure it resonates and then of
course use hashtags to show your ads to
Target your audience but a wider
relevant audience so hashtags do play a
role here as well so these are some tips
if you're going to create ads you want
to take these into account the whole
point of the ad is to get people over to
either web page or to your pro profile
page okay so that they can engage and
take action so Instagram ads will help
showcase your product service or brand
in a way that's memorable and unique so
if you really want to get your vision
your brand your product out there in
front of a lot of people then
advertising on Instagram is a good way
to do that so since we've been talking
about pizza throughout this webinar this
is a good Instagram a profile here about
pizza you know I'm getting hungry just
looking at this hopefully this is an
example for all veg and non-veg pizza
consumers I mean you can see this
profile here they got the website you
know they got the handle okay so they
have a lot of followers so you know if
I'm in the pizza industry I can go ahead
and you know click on their followers
and see who who's following them who
they're following so some really good
shots of pizza here it looks like you
know a lot of people are wearing were
involved in this you could see lots of
different examples hair some cute ones
you know some funny ones some humorous
ones so you know just taking a look at
something like pizza which you know most
people enjoy you know most and you can
kind of appreciate you know how much of
an advantage Instagram can be because it
really you can accentuate photos you can
have fun with it you can really run some
contests here you know give us your best
pizza photo so here you know you could
say use daily Pizza as a hashtag for
feature okay so they're even encouraging
you to use a specific hashtag so you can
really do a lot here on Instagram this
is just a good example of what you can
do and have fun with you know with an
example like pizza just to give you some
ideas so let's move on to tip 16 take
advantage of Instagram tools so you can
use scheduling tools like later
HootSuite and buffer so I can't stress
this enough you know it comes to
measuring the engagement of your
Instagram post you're definitely need a
social media tool so you're also going
to need it if you do a lot of you know
posting on Instagram so let's take a
look at an example we'll use later.com
so if I go to later here I can see you
know I can use this to upload my images
to my profile so here you can see it's
scheduled throughout the day of the week
so that way we're not overlapping you
know we're scheduling based on the times
of the day that people are going to look
at this so you know here I could see you
know particular stories if any stories
are posted okay I can look at it from a
weekly or monthly preview I could see
what's been posted okay and more
importantly as a schedule tool I can
also see the analytics I could see you
know how many were posted how many
followers so this is really important
because you know if my profile is
growing I want to be able to see what
post perform best what the audience was
like you know by gender by age by look
location so again I can look at it by
post-performance story or hashtag
analytics as well so later really goes
into details about you know what's
driving engagement so here you can see
some hashtags could this become
particular company is using on Instagram
so here you can see how many posts with
this hashtag you know and what and kind
of Engagement did they receive do they
receive likes comments Impressions how
much reach do they get how many saves
and it really just does go into detail
so later does a good job I like this
platform especially for Instagram it's
great for scheduling but more important
you know in addition to the Instagram
analytics you can really lean on you
know this particular platform to get a
really good idea as to you know how a
particular posts are performing remember
if a post is performing you want to
reuse it at a certain point in time okay
learn from Best Practices learn from
what's working learn from what's not
working if something's not work and then
don't do it again so you can really get
a good breakdown here and later.com so
remember these tools place an emphasis
on automation okay enabling you to
automatically post at a scheduled time
so you want to lock it in at a certain
period of time and I have to worry about
it so it allows you to really hone in on
that particular time of the day and day
of the week so that you're really
maximizing your chances of getting good
engagement okay so develop your own
signature style so set up a style and
content theme so that you're able to
stand out amongst the various
competitors so you know again just going
back to our pizza example lots of good
photos of pizza you know but this is
their style this is who they are you
know they're not a particular brand
they're just you know people who like
pizza okay and they're having fun with
it okay so that's their style you know
their posting really good shots of all
this different types of pizza different
styles different toppings and just to
give you an idea of how popular pizza is
and what you can do with it okay so
again this is a good basic example
um of what you can do with something as
simple as pizza so don't be afraid to
experiment you know try something
different with your profile you know do
something different you don't always
have to follow what everybody else is
doing that's the great thing about
Instagram it allows you to be free and
creative in fact if anybody has any
styles that have worked for them you
know feel free to put something in the
comments section we'd love to hear your
thoughts so tip 18 use user engagement
to your advantage so I just mentioned
that using the later example so we want
to be able to learn from what's working
and not working so user generated
content shows off your brand to be
authentic and improves your relationship
with your followers so you know you want
to be unique with the content that
you're posting so if you do that you're
likely to build that relationship and
you know increase your followers and you
want to be able to see of that user
generated content that ugc which is
performing which is not performing okay
so basically your followers and your
audience are telling you what's working
and not working so take advantage of
that remember going back to hashtags you
can set up your own unique hashtag and
ask your users to post images or videos
relating to that which you can post in
your Brand's account so just like the
whole pizza thing they're saying hey
look you know use daily pizza for a
feature okay that's a good example of
something you can do as well so you
could set up a unique hashtag and say
hey use this hashtag and that'll help
you gain some followers that'll help you
gain some notoriety and some visibility
on your platform tip 19 use high quality
images and videos just like on YouTube
just like on Facebook Instagram's no
different images must be of high quality
authentic and original I mean again one
more time going back to the pizza these
images look to be pretty high quality I
mean if you have a decent mobile phone
that's all it takes a mobile phone with
a camera that is that's all it usually
takes you know you want to be able to
get that that right shot you don't want
to use anything that's of low quality
because it really is going to take away
from you know the story you're trying to
tell so you don't have to be
professional per se just make sure what
you're posting whether it be video or
whether it be an image is of high
quality and remember videos needs to be
fun and informational about causing the
user to lose interest so you know if
you're going to create a video you know
go ahead and you know you can make it
short make it fun okay you can see here
these guys are just showing you how
pizza's made doesn't take a long time
they're just going through the motions
they're not boring you with details
they're not talking really quick and
easy just to give you an idea it doesn't
have to be as serious it could be fun so
video content needs to be fun and
informational without causing users to
lose interest that's the key short sweet
unique authentic and fun have fun with
it so so worth repeating don't use stock
images on Instagram because you know
they don't really bode well for your
particular brand you know it's Instagram
it allows you to post original content
that's the whole purpose of it okay and
on the video side Beacon size high
quality and informational enough okay so
you have to hold the user's attention
here so when we say concise you know
don't make it a five minute video
obviously make it high quality relevant
to what you're trying to offer and if
you do that you're likely going to hold
the user's attention so tip 20 promote
your Instagram page and other social
media channels so Facebook and Instagram
are part of the same family so this
seems like a natural but you know don't
be afraid to promote it on other
channels like Pinterest or or YouTube
The whole idea is to get users to your
Instagram page and encourage them to
follow it so you know you can always put
that URL in you know other platforms
like YouTube nothing wrong with that at
all okay you can also promote your page
offline with print ads and during other
relevant events and then I would even
take those to further as you probably
see you know an Instagram logo on a web
page along with other social media icons
so you always want to help promote
Instagram on your web page as well but
you can do it for offline with print ads
so you can simply just put you know
whatever your your slug is for Instagram
whatever your ID is whatever you're
using on Instagram that's what you can
use don't be afraid to promote it
offline or online today we're going to
talk about how to increase Twitter
followers so welcome and let's get
started so with Twitter it's all about
tweets it's actually a verb now uh when
you do something on Twitter you actually
tweet and there are a lot of people out
there tweeting in fact Twitter has over
1.3 billion accounts so a lot of tweets
going on in the world of Twitter so as
of the third quarter in 2018 last year
Twitter had 326 million Global monthly
active users okay so active meaning
every day using the platform on a daily
basis so a lot of people using Twitter
it's very easy to use as you'll find out
and what you're going to find out today
is how to increase followers on your
Twitter account so they can see more of
your tweets okay a little bit more about
Twitter there are 500 million tweets
posted every single day that's a lot of
tweets so you can imagine with every
tweet is a hashtag that accompanies that
tweet so a lot of information be
disseminated across the platform so
tweets with videos so Twitter does a lot
of videos as well as images attracts 10
times more engagement than other forms
of content so if you watched our YouTube
videos and some of the other videos we
had out there regarding in Facebook or
Instagram you'll know that videos do
perform better Twitter is no exception
so if you have a video even if it's done
on YouTube or if it's not unpublished on
YouTube use it with Twitter you're going
to get more engagement so Twitter has 75
percent of its users use the platform
for news Okay so people go to Twitter to
get their news that's where they go they
don't go to a regular website
content-based website they get their
news via Twitter it's just very easy to
digest because it's so few characters 75
of B2B businesses Market on Twitter so
not only is it a b2c or business to
consume or platform it's a B2B business
to business platform so a lot of
businesses are on Twitter basically
promoting either a product service or
trying to establish themselves in the
industry using the platform so let's
take a look at Twitter and let's take a
look at some of the ways in which you
can increase your followers it all
starts with your profile you always want
to make sure you have a complete profile
your name obviously the Twitter platform
that you have is going to have a handle
okay in this example here it's a totally
real person at totally real person is
the Twitter handle and that's what
you're going to want to use to
disseminate your Twitter profile to
others so you want to make sure that you
have a good image you have a real name
and a good handle that people can
associate with and remember so you want
to be able to set up this profile with a
key word friendly bio okay a link to
your website and a picture that
represents your brand always helps so
make sure it's complete you can even
take a step further by customizing the
color scheme of your profile you can add
a header image that sticks to your theme
that will help your profile stand out
and so let's take a look at an example
here so if I go to Twitter here if we go
to Simply learn Twitter account account
to either handle is simply at simply
learn okay and they've customized the
header they use their logo now if you're
an individual you probably want to use a
nice profile pick here where they're
based a little bit about them so just uh
you know customize complete profile goes
a long way you don't have to go
overboard with an elaborate design so to
speak but just make it stand out make it
associate with who you are as a person
and a brand those are best practices in
getting that profile up and running you
don't want to use something Bland and
generic you know take the extra step
create something unique make sure your
profile is unique you have a good image
okay make sure it's complete with you
know telling people who you are and what
you're all about that's really the first
step on really any social media platform
so you want to promote your Twitter
profile to drive users from other social
media platforms so when you actually get
that Twitter account set up and you
actually do have your hand so go ahead
and share it that's the first step in
getting followers if you're already on
Facebook if you're already on Instagram
then use those platforms to announce
that you're on Twitter you can also take
that a step further and you know send
out an email to friends or family or
like I said if you're on Facebook go
ahead and set up a post say hey guys I'm
on Twitter you know come follow me so
you could also use business cards
advertisements marketing materials and
events to put that Twitter profile on
okay so it doesn't have to be within the
social media sphere it could be even on
your website it can be even in email so
you can basically promote that profile
again you want to make that profile that
handle easy to remember so totally real
person is the profile in this example
we're going to use that profile
everywhere we can whether that be
offline or online you don't don't be
afraid to use it on a business card
especially if it's easy I can just
simply go to Twitter and type in that
handle so you want to stay active on
Twitter with regular retweets replies
and favorites and that's just it's just
so easy to retweet and reply and add
favorites so let's take a look at that
on Twitter so you could just simply I'm
logged in as me and if I want to retweet
something that simply learned it I can
just simply click on the retweet button
and I can add a comment if I want to and
then I'm going to retweet it's that
simple so now that tweet is going to
show up on my profile my handle and I
could simply like it if I scroll down
here okay top 10 it Trends shaping 2019
notice a simple tweet supported with an
image so I'm just gonna like that so I
can even comment on it I can click on
the comment and click a reply here okay
and that's going to show up in this
tweet here just like if I click on this
I'll be able to see what other people
have written and so it's that simple if
I want I can just click on the email
button and even send a message to
somebody right from that tweet the point
is I can do everything I need to do
right in the platform but to get started
if you don't have any tweets you know go
and find other companies similar to you
look at their tweeting and you can
always retweet that that's a good way to
get going with tweaks that's what I
started doing when I started on Twitter
in 2008 I didn't know what to write
particularly and I didn't know how to
write it particularly well so I looked
at what other people wrote and and
tweeted and just retweeted those that's
a good way to get your Twitter account
started okay so engaging with users is a
great way to get more followers so on
simply learn I retweeted one of their
tweets I liked another one of their
tweets and it's probably going to get
their attention somebody at simply
learned is going to say okay Rob Sanders
went ahead and liked us and you know
what we're gonna go follow this guy he
seems to be somebody who's an audience
member who likes what we have to do
likes what we have to say like what
we're tweeting let's go ahead and follow
him and so that's a good way to get
going with your Twitter account is to
really start retweeting and liking other
tweets from other users so you can find
an appropriate time to post your tweets
to increase exposure retweets and
followers and you want to do this you
could do it within Twitter or as I'll
mention later you can do it in a social
media platform like Sprouts social or
HootSuite or later or buffer and there's
plenty of social media platforms out
there for you to schedule tweets point
is you want to be able to schedule those
tweets when it's the appropriate time so
you don't want to do it in the middle of
the evening because what's going to
happen is likely by the morning other
tweets are going to Bear your Tweet so
you want to be able to find the
appropriate time to post your tweets so
according to a survey conducted by
HubSpot the best time to post is between
12 and 3 P.M and why is that well most
people are usually on lunch checking
their phones yes Twitter has an app and
in fact most people use the app just
like on Instagram just like on YouTube
the app is very popular on Twitter so
it's very easy for somebody to check
tweets especially during the lunch hour
and then from 5 to 6 p.m that that in
between time when when people are
wrapping up work or heading home okay so
weekdays have shown to have the maximum
amount of Engagement so during the week
when people are working highly engaged
with whatever they're doing depending on
what industry you're in they're likely
going to check the Twitter and react
during those times okay so that was a
survey conducted by hussbopper really
what you want to do is you want to be
able to use one of these social media
platforms like a HootSuite or later and
find out exactly when are people
engaging with your tweets when I what
time of the day what day of the week are
you getting the most retweets or the
most likes okay that's what you want to
do so you can use this as a starting
point as a best practice but eventually
you're gonna have to cater to your
audience based on when you're getting
your tweets engaged so you want to
increase followers by following more
people it's that simple and so it really
is that simple let me rephrase that so
it really is that simple so if I go back
to Twitter you know Twitter's always
going to recommend somebody for me to
follow and normally those are people
that are similar as myself okay so
they're not just going to choose random
people they're going to choose people
who are following people you're
following so there's going to be a
connection to some degree or they could
be people who use similar hashtags
tweeting the same content so you want to
go ahead and follow people the rule of
thumb on Twitter is if you follow
somebody on Twitter chances are they're
going to follow you back you know I was
once told when I was using Twitter that
hey you want to give somebody about
three days to follow you back so that's
always what the rule I stuck to you know
wait about three days start following
people you can see here 833 people that
or accounts Twitter accounts that simply
learns following and over ten thousand
nine hundred followers to Simply learn's
Twitter account so for me I don't mind
having a nice balance myself I have just
as many followers as I do following and
that's a good thing so because you want
to be able to keep up with what people
are tweeting and so you can retweet at
the same time you want to be following
people as well because they're going to
follow you back okay and that's how you
can build up your Twitter followers by
following people and it's as simple as
clicking on a follow link so the key
here is to follow people who follow your
content people who are followers of your
followers and you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and upload your email
contacts to Twitter okay since they know
you they're more likely to follow you
back okay so you can use Twitter's who
to follow list and so if we go back to
Twitter here's the who to follow list
and so this is what Twitter is going to
recommend but you can click on this link
here find people you know okay so if I
click on find people I know then I can
upload my contacts from Outlook or Gmail
and they're gonna find people who are
already on Twitter based on who I'm
connected with so generally that's how
it works that's a quick way to get more
followers is to connect with people you
know by the way I'm gonna follow simply
learn because I wasn't following them
prior so now I just clicked on the
follow button now I am following so now
I'm going to see simply learns Tweets in
my feed so let's take a second to look
at a brand okay so it's time for a brand
watch let's have a look at some of the
best Tweets of 2018. now remember there
are a lot of active users millions of
active users that's a lot of tweets so
what we did we scoured Twitter from 2018
and we went ahead and picked out some
tweets that we thought were pretty
pretty good and so the first one is
Wendy's now I don't know if any of you
have actually eaten at Wendy's I used to
eat at Wendy's a while ago I know their
frosties are pretty good so what they've
done is they Incorporated that Frosty as
part of a giveaway okay so basically
they're saying hey grab yourself a free
Frosty with any purchase in our app so
they're encouraging people to use our
app and then they're following that up
by saying hey and then join us on Twitch
from two to five eastern as we unlock
all that Frosty goodness so they're
promoting something that's going to
happen on a specific point in time this
is last January they're encouraging
people to use their app and they're
using that Frosty as kind of a carrot if
you will okay it's a catch it's a
giveaway so they were able to you know
basically wrap a bunch of things into
one so get encourage people to take part
and I'm sure a lot of people went ahead
and took part of this but we could
definitely see that 206 retweeted this
to weight 302 basically commented on it
and over 3 000 liked the Tweet so the
Tweet was good and it basically engaged
with users who doesn't like a free
giveaway especially free Frosty so
that's why this particular tweet really
does some justice for the target
audience Their audience they're they're
giving something away to Their audience
just by allowing them to you know use
their app okay so this tweet combines a
lot into one and I like it apparently a
lot more people than I did 3000 plus
also like this tweet and so moving on to
how to increase your followers on
Twitter you want to mention other people
in your tweets to increase engagement so
what do we mean by that so let's look at
Twitter so go back if we look at simply
learn just take a look at some of their
tweets what they're doing if we scroll
down here they have hashtags so they are
mentioning specific hatch tags but you
can also mention handles as well so the
hashtag is always going to start with
either pound sign but if we scroll down
here if you use the at symbol you're
actually mentioning somebody so in this
case we're mentioning Matt Bailey so
Matt Bailey says is Matt Bailey's handle
and so if you get a shout out to
somebody they're gonna pick up on that
and then they're going to probably
follow you okay who doesn't appreciate
getting recognized for something
especially something as small as a tweet
okay notice I can go ahead and click
follow if I want to follow my bailey but
it's not a bad idea to add people into
your Tweet and you simply do that by
just using the ad symbol and using their
Twitter handle it's a good way to get
recognized by that Twitter follower it
also increases engagement because it's
adding validity to the tweet and it
definitely catches the attention of the
person mentioned remember if you use
that person's handle they're going to
see that that you mention them okay and
what it's likely going to do is start
some type of Twitter relation ship okay
they're gonna then follow you you're
gonna follow them and chances of them
retweeting you in the future or
mentioning you in the future is probably
going to increase and overall that
increases engagement so another
important thing you want to do is
finding use hashtags that are relevant
to your brand and audience so this is a
must this is mandatory on Twitter you
need to use hashtags Twitter's all about
hashtags every tweet that goes out
should have a hashtag okay so what you
can do is figure out what hashtags are
trending so here what Twitter does is it
trends for you so these are all specific
hashtags that are trending it's Mother's
Day Happy Mother hey Sunday morning
whatever works for you these are trends
that happen to be moving meaning a lot
of people are using them clicking on
them okay so you can use a popular
hashtag what I would also recommend is
you use a unique hashtag the rule of
thumb is usually about two hashtags in a
tweet but that's a rule of thumb but
rules are made to be broken do what's
best for you if you want to include more
than two hashtags go for it the only
thing I'm recommending is include a
hashtag so find out what's trending you
could just look right in Twitter or you
could just create your own unique
hashtag it works both ways but when you
have a hashtag in your Tweet and
somebody clicks on it then they're going
to go to that particular handle that
hashtag and so when they look at the
hashtag you're going to see all the
tweets with that hashtag in it so that's
the idea behind hashtags you want to
have hashtags okay so if somebody clicks
on a hashtag that you've used then
they're likely going to see your Tweet
in that hashtags feed okay so that's how
hashtags work you want to use hashtags
okay but you want to use hashtags that
are relevant to your brand and audience
that's really the key so hashtags help
your tweets to be found through Twitter
search thus improving your reach and
increase the visibility of your post so
that's another benefit Twitter as search
functionality so somebody can simply go
in and start searching on Twitter so if
I go back to Twitter if I can just do a
hashtag and start typing in something
like Spanish and I'm gonna get some of
the most popular Spanish hashtags or
Hashtags with the word Spanish in it and
so this is an idea for me that if I
wanted to use a hashtag with Spanish in
it these are some ideas but they're
certainly searchable on Twitter okay so
if I just click on Spanish okay I'm
going to be able to see all the Hashtags
with the word Spanish in the hashtag so
definitely use hashtags it's the most
beneficial feature of Twitter Bar None
So some reasons why using hashtags also
a good idea well you're gonna get more
engagement and you're likely to get
retweeted as well so when you get
retweeted then that means more eyeballs
because if somebody sees your Tweet and
retweets it they're retweeting it for
Their audience and so it could go viral
so to speak on Twitter and that's where
the engagement comes in so if you're
using a hashtag that's trendy well
somebody might like that okay if you're
behind a specific movement or you're
following a specific baseball or
football team or cricket team or
whatever team you're following then if
you use that team and the hashtag that
could also get you some some likes so
don't be afraid to use hashtags mix it
up play around a little use something
unique use something that's trending
just use something but make sure it's
relevant to the Tweet find out what
works for your competition what works
for them might work for you too so you
know I work with simply learn but you
know simply learn has a good Twitter
account you know they have lots of
followers they're doing a lot of
tweeting so if I wanted to be just like
simply learn well I could simply just go
to their Twitter account and see what
they're doing okay see what they're
using as hashtag so what kind of tweets
they're implementing and see who's
following them so so I can simply just
click on the ten thousand nine hundred
followers that they have and what I
could do is I can go through and start
following the people that are following
them so just mimic your competition to
some degree or mimic others in the
industry you know look at what they're
tweeting again start out by retweeting
some of the stuff they're retweeting if
it's good stuff if it's like a tweet
don't be afraid to retweet even your
competitors tweets okay use unique
hashtags use the hashtags they're using
look at who's following their brand so
you can really learn a lot from others
in your industry including your
competition because what works for them
again might work for you especially when
it comes to hashtags or people who's
following them again people who are
following them would likely follow you
if you're in the same industry so it's
as simple as looking at who's following
them and following those same people
remember the rule of thumb is if you're
following somebody they're likely to
follow you back so again you can analyze
things like the number of followers they
have have the frequency of their tweets
what their profile looks like how they
respond to the competition of customers
okay what are they tweeting about what
types of content brings them more
engagement meaning of all the tweets
which one is getting the most likes or
retweets get some sense of what they're
doing and again when I say mimic I mean
whatever what I'm saying is pull best
practices from that Twitter account this
will give you an idea what you need to
do to get more followers so it's always
a good form of flattery when you can
mimic what somebody else is doing just
like every other social media platform
following Twitter influencers who belong
in your industry is always a good idea
so if you're in the food industry and
there's these star chefs out there
probably not a bad idea to follow those
star chefs you know if you're in the
technology industry well probably not a
bad idea to you know follow Bill Gates
or Elon Musk or Richard Branson or
somebody else and that's a big
influencer has an info influence on a
lot of people okay but make sure they're
in your industry that's the key if you
can make sure they're in your industry
and you follow them chances are if they
look at your Twitter account and see
you're posting or maybe retweeting some
of their tweets they're likely to follow
you and if they're following you your
tweets are going to show up on their
handle on their feed and so don't be
afraid to go out and connect and follow
those influencers it's a good way to
boost up your followers so again this
will help you gain followers since you
can replicate what they've done with
their profile so again just like the
competition mimic what your influencers
are doing okay so people tend to follow
people who follow influencers so you're
all of one like mine so to speak okay
influencers might retweet or share your
post if they find you retweeting
favorites and replying to their posts so
remember if you're following a retweeter
or excuse me an influencer and you
retweet their post chances are they
might retweet one of your posts and
again put you in front of a large number
of people since they're influencers so
all of these are good valid reasons to
follow influencers because if you're out
to increase your reach and exposure it's
hard to ignore influencers in your
industry okay you want to use images and
videos while tweeting remember videos
get multiple multiple times more
engagement than not using them at the
very least use images but you use images
don't use stock Photography use images
that are relevant so one of these tweets
caught my eye here from Simply learn so
if I click on you know here it was
further down here it looked like you
know these are people who are engaging
in a conference and it might have been
one that Matt Bailey was at so it was a
retweet from Matt Bailey as a matter of
fact but you could see what simply
learns doing is they're including either
a video or they're including an image in
every tweet and so that's likely to
boost up engagement so according to
buffer which is a another social media
platform adding a relevant high quality
image in your tweets can help you gain
more than a hundred and fifty percent
engagement okay videos are six times
more likely to be retweeted so if you
have an Arsenal video or even one video
don't be afraid to use it my
recommendation is trying to use images
as much as you can in almost every tweet
images go a long way and again it's
going to help improve engagement meaning
more retweets more followers okay more
followers more eyeballs so it's a
Snowball Effect just by using images
Okay so let's take a look at another
brand from 2018 okay Pizza always my
good example to use on these webinars I
like pizza here this just says it all
you know they're talking about art and
they're using Pizza in the form of art
so they didn't really have to say much
else here this pretty much says it all
and they did get some retweets they get
some just some likes so sometimes you
don't have to say a lot to make your
point sometimes just the image itself
will do the job this was actually not
from 2018 this goes all the way back to
2016. so still holds true if you use an
image that image is going to get
engagement Okay so
on platforms you can promote your Tweet
so you can use Twitter ads to do that so
you can promote your Tweet and what you
do by promoting it is putting it up
above so that most people will be able
to see it okay so see if we can find an
example if I go here I could see this
person is promoting their handle but if
I go down here I can see a promoted
tweet by Constant Contact so they're
promoting their tweet here so it's not a
bad idea if you have some Media budget
to go ahead and either promote your
Tweet or advertise on Twitter so what
that's going to do is put you in a more
prominent position and get your tweets
out there and the whole idea for that is
to get people to engage here you can see
a call to action from Constant Contact
so if I click on that I'm going to go to
probably a landing page on their website
and so the whole idea when you advertise
on Twitter is really just like any other
other social media platform you want to
put yourself in front of the Right
audience and so Twitter's no exception
so with Twitter you could put yourself
in front of the Right audience so what
you could do is you could promote a
tweet you know do promoted Trends or you
could do promoted accounts say you have
a number of different advertising
options on Twitter what we just looked
at was you know looking at promoted
accounts and a promoted tweet so when
you do advertise there are advantages
you have to pay only after achieving
your marketing objective so that's a
benefit of Twitter the cost per click
it's a cost per click model so it tends
to be fairly low you could tail your
audience so again you're picking and
choosing who you want your promoted
tweet or Trend or account to be in front
of and it's targeting is based on either
engagement or it's based on keywords I.E
hashtags so really you could tailor who
you want your Tweet or your handle to be
in front of and so that's the the really
the benefit of Twitter if you have a lot
of active users on Twitter you can
really put yourself in front of those
active users if they're your relevant
audience at a low cost per click so it's
definitely worth the test so you want to
offer Twitter support to your users okay
so I can't stress this enough okay so
what you want to do is when users have
questions about your product they're
more likely to tweet you for support
hence they're likely to follow your
account so don't be afraid to use the
messaging option as well so if we go
back to Twitter okay chances are
somebody might have a question for you
here you can look at big ads it's great
connecting with PPC experts can't
believe tax season is here we've got
some great insights so what they're
doing is they're using the messaging app
but they're offering that messaging app
in the form of customer service so don't
be afraid to use you know direct
messages to reach out to people in the
form of support what you don't want to
do is buy Twitter follower chances are
you're going to get the wrong followers
so even though it may boost your Twitter
follow account these Bots cannot use or
buy your products or services so stay
away from all sorts of buying of Twitter
followers you want to build your Twitter
following naturally Twitter is also
cracking down on bot followers so a lot
of Bot accounts that were paid to follow
users were shuts down shut down by
Twitter so just my point is everything
we've mentioned today is what you want
to take advantage of okay if you want to
pay for something pay for a promoted
tweet reach out to influencers look at
what your competition is doing use
hashtags okay these are all best
practices in organic ways to build
followers so don't get involved with
anything that's going to involve Bots
and adding thousands of followers to
Twitter account because chances are it's
just going to lead to no engagement so
create useful and relevant content so
what we started out by saying is hey if
you're not sure what to do reach tweet
retweet what somebody else is doing you
know look at your competition's Twitter
account see what they're tweeting get
some ideas as to what you want to tweet
so you want it to be useful and relevant
to your industry okay you want somebody
to engage that's the whole idea behind
Twitter the whole idea is if you're
going to Tweet something you want to get
somebody to engage with it so use
Twitter polls your old recent blog posts
brand news industry news and events and
highlight customer stories I mean all of
those are ideas that you can do to put
content out there okay so for me one of
the things I do is I'm definitely one
for industry news so if I'm in the
industry of digital marketing if Google
did a recent algorithm update I'm going
to likely tweet about it or retweet it I
also am a blogger so on my particular
website if I blog I'm gonna make sure
that blog gets over to Twitter so those
are some ideas in which you can create
useful and relevant content on your
Twitter account you you definitely want
to get that content out there but you
want to make it useful and relevant
quality over quantity because you want
people to engage so bring variety to the
type of content you share so I'm in
digital marketing I deal with
pay-per-click SEO but am I gonna just do
pay-per-click and SEO no I know that
analytics I know that you know Google
tag manager I know that they'd be
testing all of those are elements of
digital marketing so I'm going to Branch
out and talk about some of those things
that support digital marketing so that's
an example of bring a variety to the
type of content you share so don't just
stick to one thing you know feel free to
reach out a little bit shake things up
by sharing other forms of updates like
engaging quotes and questions these work
best when complemented by an image and
an act as a great discussion starter so
good point here even if you want to
Branch out of your industry and just
throw in a nice useful quote it's always
a good way to gain some attention and
get some engagement okay let's look at
another brand and see what they've
tweeted about so we're looking at
Forester here so think about emotional
qualities and their implications so here
you can see customers that feel
surprised or grateful or appreciated
they're sharing that Insight with you
and so this was interesting when I saw
this so what I did was I simply you see
the hashtag here for digital basically
if you want to look at this particular
study I just went to Twitter and I typed
in that hashtag and now I'm going to be
able to see you know some of the other
studies that they've done here you can
see top 10 it Trends shaping 2019 so I'm
just following the Twitter handle that
they used so Forester does a lot of good
research a lot of good insights and so
what they've done here that makes this
tweet look so good is they've actually
put an image of the results in the Tweet
so they used an image to help help gain
engagement or increase engagement notice
they also gave a shout out to somebody
as well as used some good hashtagging so
good tweet this was back in 2016 but
again a good use of the image with the
Tweet so you want to organize tweet
chats to interact with your users and
bring in new followers so you know you
basically want to be organized when
you're dealing with with chats so tweet
chats enable you send out tweets on a
particular topic using a designated
hashtag so during a certain time to
interact with your your followers and
other users so you could do it at a
specific time to really get out a
specific topic but you want to be able
to stay organized so that you know you
what you're chatting about is reaching
the wide audience and you're getting the
right following and the right engagement
okay you can also pin your best updates
and tweets to your profile so you can
just use that pin and what that's going
to do is pin it to the top and keep it
there so that that you know people who
go to your Twitter handle are going to
be able to see that best tweet that
you've done so what you want to do here
is use the one that's most engaging so
pinning your best update or tweet
meaning the one that's really had a lot
of Engagement meaning retweets and
followers and likes you want to do that
you want to pin that to your profile and
that will enable first-time visitors to
see it and if they could see something
that other people engaged with and
that's going to encourage them to share
and probably follow you so and and
that's always what you want to do you
always want to put your best foot
forward so pin your best tweet to your
profile so I mentioned this earlier use
tools to schedule when to publish your
tweets so here's some of the most
popular platforms you know I.E Sprout
social so if we take a look at Sprout
social here I'm Inspire social I'm
connected to my Twitter account I can
simply just start tweeting about
something here so you can see it's going
to let me know how many characters I
have remaining so so to 180 to start out
with when I'm done tweeting notice I can
add an emoji I can upload media I can
tag a specific location okay I can even
you know call out a specific Twitter
profile now I can schedule this myself
or I can use the schedule below I can
pick and choose a time to schedule the
Tweet now again you want to be able to
use the Sprout social whatever social
media tool you're using to figure out
when the best time of day and the day of
the week to actually tweet when are you
getting the best engagement so ideally
that's what you want to do you want to
tweet when you're likely to get the best
engagement when those eyeballs are
actually going to look at that tweet
okay but you also want to separate out
your tweets so they're not on one on top
of another because if you actually Tweet
back to back then those tweets are just
going to get buried so if you spread
them out a little bit then you're likely
to maximize your number of impressions
or eyeballs on that tweet so if you
schedule a tweet multiple Tweets in the
same day then post them a few hours
apart or an hour apart so that way
you're always going to get that maximum
visibility so these social media
platforms really help you and not only
scheduling but figuring out what tweets
got the best engagement and when and
then that way you can replicate that
success so again it's not just Sprout
social HootSuite buffer they'll help you
determine the exact time your audience
is most active and schedule post to
increase traction so you know most of
these social media platforms do the same
thing so really what you want to do is
you really want to nail down that exact
time your audience is going to be most
active Okay that's the whole idea behind
using it and when you actually do tweet
you are going to get results and these
social media platforms are going to
share those results with you and then
when you understand based on your
audience behavior when they're engaging
when they're not engaging that's when
you're going to you fine tune your
scheduling so what you also want to do
as you're doing these tweets as we
looked at earlier with Wendy's is run
contests or giveaways remember Wendy's
gave away that free Frosty you don't be
afraid to give away something if it
means more engagement more eyeballs
which could lead to basically future
customers so contests can help increase
your reach and exposure and each new
participant can be considered as a
potential follower so it also gives your
followers an opportunity to tag their
friends who would be interested in
participating so really come up this is
a great way to be creative come up with
a good idea to get your your audience
involved because what's likely going to
happen is your audience is going to
share this contest with others that
aren't following you and so what's going
to happen is when they share it you're
going to get more followers you're going
to get more eyeballs and again
potentially more customers so embed your
Twitter updates on your website you
could simply do that uh it's very simple
but when you do then and people to your
website will be able to see your tweets
so if I just go to my website here if I
scroll down we actually have you know
Twitter embedded on our website as well
because we want you know people to see
what we're tweeting about and you can
see I just retweeted the simply learned
tweet at the beginning of this
particular webinar and it's showing up
in my feed here so that's when people
actually go to my website they'll be
able to see what I retweeted and that's
going to help simply learn out because
simply learn is likely to get some
clicks on this particular tweet from my
website so it's also a good way to keep
your website fresh and updated because
if you're an active Twitter user and
you're tweeting a lot then hey that's
going to show up on your website and
it's going to show that hey you're fresh
you're engaging you keep up to date it's
just gonna make it look good and make
your website feel fresh and not stale so
embedding your Twitter updates will help
you add new followers as well because
it's people who are coming here website
that may not even know you have a
Twitter account so you can also do this
in a blog post and a newsletter and
other forms of communication media so it
doesn't necessarily have to be just your
website but I would definitely recommend
it because it will give a boost to your
Twitter account so now let's take a look
at the final brand watch let's take a
look at another tweet that caught our
attention and this is from PlayStation
so PlayStation is mentioning hey we got
a multi-view on Apple TV today with
support for up to four live channels on
one screen okay so you know they're
promoting a new feature that they have
with PlayStation and you can see they
supported that with an image and they
got some really good engagement here so
they're basically saying hey look what
happened to us today you know check out
this new feature that got supported on
Apple TV so you never know what's going
to happen with a tweet when you tweet
good things are likely going to happen
whether that be somebody liking it
retweeting it or somebody adding you you
as a follower something's good is going
to come out of tweeting Twitter is an
easy platform to use and if you take
into account all these best practices
you are going to increase your Twitter
followers
after watching this video you should be
prepared to explain why the human
tendency to daydream can be interrupted
using a storytelling marketing approach
to list three key benefits of
Storytelling when it comes to Consumer
engagement to realize that different
consumers are looking for different
relationships with your company and to
explain the difference between
storytelling and story sharing let's
begin lesson one why storytelling is
essential in Social marketing when we
think about the way that our company or
our brand or our organization is
represented to the world it's easy for
us to be focused in on things like
quality and credibility and whether or
not someone wants to buy from us but
it's also important to understand that
for a lot of consumers the very idea of
who you are is also important it's not
always just enough for people to know
the name of your company or product
they're interested in understanding what
the story is behind your brand and that
might be something like how you came to
be or why you exist or what your mission
is or it might be something about the
person personality and sort of the
lifestyle that's represented by your
individual company now the storytelling
movement has been an area that we've
really seen a lot of growth and a lot of
improvement in the last several years in
social media with more and more Brands
moving towards this idea of sort of
humanizing their companies by telling
the stories that come out of the company
itself out of the use of the product or
even out of the consumer stories that
you know share how products benefit
their lives or again just what goes on
in that interaction and that dynamic
between the organization and between the
customer side of things now when it
comes to storytelling there's several
different ways in which this approach
offers value to a business and one of
the key ones is on the emotional side
we've talked a lot in the social sharing
dynamic in some of the other areas of
you know the the spread and the viral
concept about how emotion is one of the
most powerful things that impacts
people's decision making and engagement
with the brand so when it comes to
creating that emotional connection or
leaving people with some type of
emotional response storytelling is one
of the most powerful ways to impact that
it gives you an opportunity to sway the
emotion of consumers in terms of how
they look at or view or are receptive to
your brand now another thing that
storytelling can really do that adds a
lot of value is the idea of making you
credible because a lot of times the way
we tell stories especially when we're
incorporating in true to life examples
or you know consumer stories there's an
implied credibility that comes through
that storytelling and comes through
those third-party experiences that can
help people feel more secure about doing
business with you not just more
emotionally positive but actually feel
that security of trusting that what they
think they're going to get or what
they're hoping to get that there's going
to be enough follow-through and enough
other people have had a positive
experience for them to really trust that
that's what's going to happen now
another area that storytelling brings a
lot of value into a company is the in
the idea of making you memorable
because human beings are wired for
stories we are much more capable of
recalling broad ideas and Concepts and
emotions when they're communicated via a
story so if we give someone a list of
facts a list of selling points you know
a list of reasons why to do business
with you the ones that touch them
emotionally or that you know problem
solve those tend to stick with them but
a lot of the data gets lost but when we
put it in the format of a story and
someone is sharing what their experience
was our brains literally archive it and
categorize it differently and our recall
level goes up so again along with
building trust and along with creating
that that emotional impact the fact that
people are better able to recall the
information that's communicated to them
via that story helps make it a very
powerful marketing tool now in addition
to that it's important to keep in mind
that on average people tend to be
daydreamers in fact study after study
shows that if our minds aren't occupied
with an important task if we're not
truly focused on something we tend to
drift off and when we look at that
concept of daydreaming the average human
spends literally half of their waking
hours daydreaming we average 2 000
waking drifts per day with an average
length of about 14 seconds so you do the
math on that two thousand times times 14
seconds that's a pretty good portion of
our day where our brain is drifting off
but when they look at the brain's
ability to stay focused versus having
those drifts we stay focused during a
story if we're reading a book if we're
watching a movie if someone is telling
us an engaging Story We Are Better
equipped and better able to put those
drifts off and really stay focused on
what's Happening so that's one of the
other sort of scientific and concrete
reasons why that memorable Factor comes
into play when we present things via
stories now stories also allow us to
connect in one of the easiest ways
possible again because our brain is
going to be a little more focused on
being able to receive that message so by
using stories to spread your brand
message or to explain your offerings or
to demonstrate how they work you
increase the chance of keeping your
audience focused on you and giving them
enough recall that they can come back at
a later point to actually do some
business with you now think of
Storytelling from sort of the mindset of
how we meet and engage with other people
so in general when we're meeting up with
a prospective friend or a job prospect
maybe we're coming for an interview a
service workers even just a stranger on
the street any conversation that goes
past just hello how are you doing and
the cursory you know kind of polite
responses it tends to be a story this is
what we do when we meet we're naturally
wired to seek out insight and Common
Ground in information about who another
person is and in those interpersonal
relationships the types of questions we
ask you know the words we use they're
indicative of the type of relationship
we want to build so clearly if you know
if you're single and you see someone
else that you know you hope might be
saying well that might be one of the
early questions you ask and then based
on whether you know there's a romantic
interest there you're probably going to
ask different questions than if it's a
interview Prospect for a job or if
you're meeting up with a you know
co-worker for the first time the
relationship that we're looking for
denotes the type of information we want
and that's one of the important things
for us to keep in mind when it comes to
storytelling is we also have the ability
to tailor our story to the audience so
we can put those different features up
front we can weave them in in a
different way if we're appealing to a
group of 60-something females that love
to sew versus a group of 20-something
Millennials that love whiskey tasting
it's a different message that gets put
together with different focuses and
features there's also different things
that we're going to put forward if we're
proposing you know million dollar
contract versus a 25 impulse buy that
someone can you know click and order
online and have delivered the next day
now on the business side of this we need
to think about what the story that we
need is because a lot of times we get so
focused in business on getting the
conversion that we forget that sometimes
part of getting that conversion is
creating those emotions building that
credibility and trust you know helping
them have exposure to what's possible
and for a long time this has been done
through education we might put up videos
or articles that aim to educate and to
demonstrate the story side of it brings
that more social interaction and
environment into the mix and that's
something important for us to keep in
mind so a quote that I really love about
this concept that sort of lays the
foundation of why it's so important
comes from the chief content officer
over at digitas and he says the
challenge is clear by now intrusive
interruptive self-centered marketing no
longer works the way it once did and its
Effectiveness will only continue to
diminish in the social age because again
the way that we share information back
and forth with each other and the ways
that that messages spread it happens
differently in the social media age than
it did before when it was more
advertising focused and where marketing
really was more about you know pushing
the advertised pushing the message and
sort of the Don Draper style of you know
if you don't like the conversation
change the conversation and tell people
what you want them to hear because so
much marketing is now driven by
consumers through that conversation we
need to be able to approach it in a
different way now another side of that
is the idea there's a difference between
storytelling and story sharing and some
of it boils down to semantics but some
of it also does need to be kind of taken
into account when we look at how we
might put our message together because
semantically consider the difference
between telling and sharing so to tell
is to communicate information facts or
news to someone and spoken or written
word it's to order instruct or advise
someone to do something that second part
that I want you to keep in mind but to
share is to give a portion of something
to another to tell someone about
something especially something personal
it's a again it's a slight semantic
difference but it's a huge difference in
terms of our approach and I love this
Seth Godin quote that really pairs up
with that idea the best part of Show and
Tell has never been the telling part
it's been the showing letting someone
see and experience and inviting them
into that shared experience and that's
one of those things that makes the
social version of Storytelling really
more like story sharing especially if
you want to do it in a way that creates
that back and forth consumer engagement
story telling in its traditional sense
is more the stories that we've put into
commercials and advertising and there's
a place for that there's a place to put
that together in the social realm and
it's very important but the other area
that that we're just starting to kind of
merge into and that really needs some
exploration by Brands is that idea of
the social sharing where it really is
about engaging back and forth with your
audience and inviting them to be part of
an experience with you and with your
brand so ask yourself do you want to
tell your story to people or do you want
to share it with them and let them share
their story with you and how do you meld
those two together and what does that
look like within your particular company
or among your target audio
so now that we've laid the foundation of
why storytelling is so important and
sort of what type of impact it can have
the next thing we need to do is look at
the business side of telling your story
what does it look like to create a
narrative or something that's
representative of either your business's
story or sort of the lifestyle or
concept or ideas that you want to
promote to people now there's tons of
questions you could ask yourself to
start building your story but we can
focus in on a couple key areas as a
starting point to build from
and one of the first ones is the idea of
whether or not you have a Founder's
story now for a lot of Brands the story
of their founder is so interesting or
inspiring that it catches the eye and it
makes people take a second look at the
product so think of the companies that
are sort of iconic in terms of who their
their founder or their leader is so
whether that was Steve Jobs and the role
he played at Apple or Walt Disney and
the inspiration and the role he brought
to you know the entire Disney complex or
loads and loads of other businesses
there are lots of examples out there of
how the brand itself was so tied to the
person who was sort of leading the helm
that that became part of their story and
people were really interested in it now
we can find loads of examples of
different brands where the founder
really plays a critical role in
representing who they are now a great
example of this is Spanx the founder
Sarah Blakely has really embraced the
story but both of how she came up with
the idea which was basically she was
trying to fit into a pair of cream pants
for a party and they didn't fit quite
right and she knew that when she put her
pantyhose on everything seemed to lay
nicer so she literally cut the feet out
of a pair of pantyhose and put them on
and that's what launched the brand you
know she loves to sort of tell that
story but she also loves to tell the
story you know from her tagline of
putting her own butt on the line pays
off because the way that she made her
first sale to Neiman Marcus is that she
literally dragged the buyer into a
dressing room and she went in and she
put on a pair of white pants and came
out and said you know here's what I look
like without them and went back in and
put her pair of Spanx on under the white
pants and came back out and said now
here's what happens when I'm wearing
these and the buyer from Neiman Marcus
ended up placing a huge order and it was
the first major sale that she got that
put her in place somewhere so those
stories and sort of the yeah this is how
it happened you know this is literally
what a difference makes that becomes
part of the brand and sort of Sarah
blakely's Journey as an entrepreneur and
you know moving her way up into the you
know the Forbes list of uh you know
highest earning females in the United
States all of that plays a huge role in
how they promote the brand itself and in
sort of the
the storyline and the lifestyle line
that they want to promote to the people
that might buy the product
now on a completely differently themed
vein we have fast food chain Wendy's in
the US and Canada where Dave Thomas was
the founder and even though he's you
know passed away several years ago
he's still a critical part of the brand
and of the story because basically it
was the idea that A working class guy
makes good and continues to act like a
working class guy while building a
massive charity because it wasn't
uncommon even when he was CEO to see him
show up at a store somewhere and start
working behind the counter or sweeping
the floor somewhere he always played
that role that made it clear to his
employees that he wasn't above them that
he was one of them and part of them
and has a huge huge ongoing charity
effort for adoption because he was
adopted as a child and so all of that
plays Into The Narrative of Wendy's and
who they are and what their brand
message is and and the lifestyle that
they want to promote to customers in
fact if you if you go there now and you
buy a meal and you get your cup all of
the Cups have stories of kids when they
were finally adopted and what it meant
to them when they were adopted or you
know what their first experience was
having a new family so again that plays
into the story just because people are
interested in the start of where how it
came to be
so looking at you know what the stories
are from within your team and it doesn't
always have to be that founder story
sometimes it's just someone who works
there
um Post Cereal paired up with Burns
group and use real factory workers to
create a round of Honey Bunches of Oats
commercials and let's let's take a quick
look at what one of those actually look
like so you can kind of see the
storytelling in action here
I get out of work and I go to the store
and somebody's smelling around I smell
cookies that's all you know you just
smelled me I just got out of work that's
honey bunches oh that's all I said don't
eat me now
another short simple easy stories
there's nothing complex to them they
more just make you smile and laugh but
they're the types of stories that come
from listening to the people who work at
your company from thinking about how
your company and their experience
impacts the world around them
now another question that we can look at
is does your company or group solve a
problem
now this isn't about the reasons you
think you're great or the reasons you
think people should buy from you it's
about that unique way that you solve an
issue that consumers or on the B2B side
of things you know the the buying agent
is looking at that they're trying to fix
now great example of this is Airbnb or
you could look at Uber or Lyft on a
similar vein allowing people to
experience travel
in a new and affordable way but also
letting you know owners or drivers earn
extra money
you know from something that might have
been sitting there empty anyways you
know that idea that when you're
traveling you don't have to stay in a
bland expensive hotel in fact when I
travel for business pretty much any
place I go I always book via Airbnb
because you know if I can have a bedroom
and a living room and a kitchen
especially for traveling as a family and
there can be you know separate bedrooms
as opposed to having my kids all stay in
the same room with my husband and I it
just makes sense but there's also the
story side of that of its different
experiences and that's one of the big
things that people talk about is how the
experience changes and even on the side
of trying to recruit people to put their
properties it becomes about the freedom
and the lifestyle that's enabled and
there's tons of examples on YouTube of
people sharing how you know leasing out
that you know their vacation property
the rest of the year when they're not
there you know pays for the vacation
property and more or you know the people
who now travel full-time because they're
able to lease out you know their
apartment or their home or something
else on Airbnb the story side comes from
the problems that are solved for people
now another great example of a company
that focuses on their story from that
side is Dollar Shave Club they basically
took a problem everyone complains about
and they made it go away you know the
idea that razors costs are ridiculous
amount of money that you always forget
to buy new ones until it's too late so
you're shaving with a dull Blazer and
it's just inconvenient so all of their
messaging focuses in on that idea of we
make it cheap we make it easy and you
know it shows up right at your house and
you don't ever have to think about it
anymore
and their commercials all tell the same
story with kind of a you know funny
modern Millennial focused way so let's
take a look at one of those as an
example
as a founder of my own club I'd love to
know how does yours work Dollar Shave
Club presents what the fact it's simple
you choose from one of our three great
razors we'll give you a free reusable
handle and each month we'll send you
replacement cartridges for just a few
bucks that means you get to shave with
the fresh blood anytime you want which
feels amazing
will I be locked into a contract no we
wouldn't lock you into anything that's a
relief how long for delivering I've got
a conjugal visit next week
well what if I don't have to shave that
often no problem after you sign up you
can choose to get replacement cartridges
every other month you sound like my mom
I like that
ew
what's this I hear about Dollar Shave
Club selling more than just razors you
heard right we make all our own high
quality grooming products like Dr cover
shea butter Boogie's hair gel and fake
Cloud daily face moisturizer with
sunscreen now you know what the fact is
up with Dollar Shave Club so join the
club today
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is social media marketing
social media marketing which is one of
the most commonly used and lucrative
forms of digital marketing
is a methodology that has Brands
creating and sharing content on social
media
now if you've ever been on any form of
social media be it LinkedIn Facebook or
Instagram you've probably been exposed
to some form of social media marketing
remember that Burger King video
advertising that new whopper or about a
marketing tool that can help you
visualize your team's workload better
than any other in the market right now
these are just some of the many ways
that you've been marketed to
the objective when it comes to social
media marketing is to achieve the
Brand's marketing and branding goals
now this could be increased engagement
more clicks conversions and so on
so how do they do it
with text and image updates videos or
any other form of content that can
attract the user's attention and can
drive engagement from them now alongside
publishing quality content it also
involves analyzing your data and running
social media advertisements now some of
the more popular social media platforms
right now are Facebook Instagram Twitter
LinkedIn and so on
next let's talk about some of the
advantages of social media marketing
foreign
provides great brand awareness now with
the help of interactions with people on
social media brands are able to build up
their reputation as a business and with
each interaction each post each share
the brand is exposed to a larger network
of potential customers who might be
interested in the products or services
offered
next it gives you more traffic to your
website
marketing your products or services on
social media will also attract customers
to your website outside your usual
custom base
next it improves your Brand's search
engine rankings
now although this isn't a direct
correlation social media marketing does
have a part to play when it comes to
helping your pH rank higher up in search
engine rankings now if you start posting
high quality content people will start
liking and sharing it this will in turn
bring it to the attention of influencers
within the industry who will be willing
to write about your business
and then this gives you backlinks which
as you know will help you improve your
search engine rankings
next it will give you improved
conversion rates
now with your brand being much more
visible and interactive on social media
every text image video or comment could
potentially Drive users to your website
social media also humanizes your brand
now this leads to more customers
trusting a brand and being more
interested in your products and services
then we have improved customer
satisfaction
when your customers interact with your
brand on social media it provides you
with an opportunity to show compaction
for your customers
personal messages to customers
addressing their concerns will be viewed
in a positive light and can go a long
way when it comes to humanizing your
brand
social media marketing is also cost
effective
now compared to other forms of digital
marketing social media marketing offers
some of the most flexible and relatively
low cost options available
now this opens your budget for more
marketing and business expenditures now
if you do get into paid advertising a
good strategy will net you a great
return on investment
and finally it will help you become
thought leaders
now with your high quality posts
communicating with your audience sharing
content and promoting your Authority you
can have your followers look up to you
now this will allow you to become a
figure of expertise in your industry
now let's go into the social media
marketing tips and tricks
number one set up your goals
now what good will your actions do if
you don't have a goal in mind
the goal of your marketing strategy will
be the driving force behind every
decision that you make
now this is exactly why setting up codes
is very important moreover your
marketing efforts have to align with the
goals of the organization
now here are some things that you need
to keep in mind while setting up your
goals
first of all your goals need to be
quantitative for example you need to
have thousand conversions by the end of
the quarter or 5000 followers on
Instagram by the end of the month and so
on
number two you need to stick to a
consistent deadline this gives weight
for each of your actions
number three make sure your goals are
smart
now smart refers to specific measurable
attainable relevant and time-based
now let's go to number four like I
mentioned earlier your goals need to be
aligned with the marketing strategy
now alongside these goals there also
needs to be the North Star metric
now what is dinostar metric
this represents the main goal or a fixed
reference point that will ensure that
your team is on the right course
this not star metric will also give your
team Clarity and focus
now let's have a look at some popular
North Stars there's increased engagement
greater conversion rates more leads
generated app downloads and so on
now let's go to number two
understanding your audience
social media enables you to interact
engage and build relationships with your
audience
Now by understanding what they need want
and desire you can deliver content in a
way makes your product or service the
answer that they're looking for
now there are also other ways you can
understand them better this could be
surveys to determine the issues that
bother them the age demographics of your
Audience by conversing with them in
forums responding to their comments on
blogs and social media taking up their
feedbacks or suggestions into
consideration and acting on them and so
on
now here's an example of different
channels and the audiences that use them
now here we take in our personal example
here they simply learn now simply learns
audience is predominantly working
professionals and graduates
an academy has high school graduates and
the baidu's app has high school students
as users
now let's go to number three
determining the right social media
platform
now while performing social media
marketing choosing the right platform is
really important
now while selecting them you need to ask
questions like why you're using that
particular platform
who you'll reach with this platform what
content would work best on the platform
and is there any content that was unique
to that platform for example YouTube and
then there's videos on it
now answering these questions will help
you zero in on a platform for you
now while there are several platforms
available for you to choose from let me
tell you about some major ones this
LinkedIn Facebook Instagram and
Pinterest let's talk about the purpose
of each of these platforms
now LinkedIn is a professional Network
that's best suited for B2B audiences
now for Facebook just about everyone has
an account on it
content that's related to news or
entertainment usually finds success on
Facebook
then we have Instagram
visual content works best on Instagram
now although it works well for static
images and short form videos it doesn't
drive a lot of traffic to your website
then finally we have Pinterest Pinterest
is also limited to static images
however it's highly effective at driving
traffic to your blog
now let's go to number four
setting up a social media calendar
the social media calendar determines the
message you want to convey to your
audience
it also consists of information
regarding the different kinds of content
that will go up on the social media
platform
now let's have a look at some of the
most popular types of posts on social
media
first off we have competitions now I'm
sure all of you have seen posts like tag
a friend who does this or comment or
like to win something and stuff like
that competitions like these provide
great opportunities for engagement with
the audience now they can be used to
encourage your followers to share your
content it could be also for them to
create their own content along with the
predefined hashtag
competitions help grow your presence on
social media then we have polls or
service
polls can help you with data collection
that also encourages followers to take
action and interact phones and surveys
also provide opportunities through which
you can learn from customers to
understand what they like about the
product or service or what they don't
and to receive their feedback
then we have videos and live streams now
although we'll be covering this in a
little more detail further on visual
storytelling along with videos and live
streams goes a long way to drive
engagement among your audience now these
help get your followers attention
increase trust and capability and have a
high response rate and so much more to
offer
live stream with its live nature and
having a human face alongside your
business humanizes your brand and by
extension helps increase customer
loyalty and Trust
then there's infographics articles and
images
social media calendars are successful
because of their ability to increase
collaboration within the team help
understand what works and what doesn't
and in distributing resources in an
effective manner
next up we have number five using social
media marketing tools
social media marketing tools align to
the goals of your organization
with it you can create high quality
content attract new potential customers
and drive engagement
it also helps you with the planning
process you can plan create and schedule
posts on your social calendar
now some of the more popular social
media tools include buffer HootSuite bus
Sumo if Triple T and much more
now these tools also help with
generating leads creating email lists
finding a relevant audience to show your
content to creating buyer personas
providing you insights on what works and
what doesn't and giving you templates
for different kinds of posts
now for number six
visual storytelling
now visual storytelling involves passing
out a lot of information and the
simplest of forms visually
using pictures and videos your followers
are able to grasp the message quickly
and remember it for a long time
afterwards
visual storytelling is also not limited
by language barriers this helps it
become interesting and entertaining to
anyone watching it this can help your
audience stay interested and engaged
grab the attention of potential clients
and so much more
but it also has some other advantages it
helps you build a bond with your
audience visual storytelling connects
with your audience methods like live
streaming help humanize your brand and
help grow customer loyalty and Trust
it helps the audience quickly grasp the
intended message thanks to its simple
nature and finally most importantly
content like images and videos are what
go viral with visual storytelling you
increase the chance for your content to
be seen by more potential customers
have a look at some of our videos
so here's what is machine learning data
science in five minutes and AI in 5
minutes
now these are some of our most viewed
videos on our Channel and now you know
why visual storytelling if you guys are
interested in watching these videos you
can check them out on our Channel
homepage we also have similar videos
about blockchain devops and Six Sigma
now back to our list
let's go to number seven
paying for advertising
this is a method that helps you find
Target and reach your audience with ease
it can greatly help with achieving your
organization's marketing goals
this can help you improve your reach and
improve your Brand's visibility it's
pay-per-click model ensures cost
Effectiveness while providing great
results and return on investment it also
helps improve targeting by letting you
control who sees your app you get to
choose from a number of different
factors like interests Hobbies
personality types and so on alongside
the basic use of demographics like age
occasion gender and so on now since most
social media platforms have native
analytics you also get to assess and
Define the performance of your ad
campaigns
now as great as it sounds there are
certain pitfalls that come along with
paid advertising
first of all your audience could get
exposed to your posts too many times and
tune out your content disregarding it in
the process
second it could get really expensive for
smaller businesses or startups to manage
a campaign to its maximum effectiveness
third people could pass off your content
as irrelevant and unimportant
you'll also have to deal with a whole
lot of competition smaller companies
with lesser budgets have an uphill
battle to deal with better funded
organizations
next we have number eight news jacket
new stacking is a method that involves
using current events to promote your own
Brands products and services
now it's a popular method that's used to
improve brand awareness
newsjacking uses the popularity of the
current events and drives it to your
brand it also helps shine a spotlight on
your products it also helps you show off
that you're up to date with current
events in the industry and that your
product is relevant by extension it also
improves engagement and website traffic
now for number nine a b testing
a b testing is a popular method for
comparing copies creatives and ctas or
call to actions of the posts that you
put on social media
now since audiences would react
differently depending on the content a b
testing helps determine which of the
variants your audience engaged with the
most
a b testing can also be performed on
variations of location age gender
education your audience interests and so
on
next up number 10 community and
influencers
joining communities helps your brand
link up with like-minded people and
other companies belonging to your niche
it'll also help you establish your brand
as an authority within the industry now
actively participating in these
communities can help create your own
audience of potential brand Advocates to
group up with
on the other hand partnering up with
influencers helps promote your products
or services to a brand new audience it
helps provide an additional layer of
authenticity in YouTube which is also a
social media platform if you didn't know
here are some very very popular
influences we have Marcus Brownlee unbox
therapy Mr who's the boss and Linus Tech
tips each of them with more than 4
million subscribers
and finally we're at number 11 measuring
and analyzing results
accurately tracking and measuring your
marketing efforts are an important part
of the process
it ensures that you're making the most
out of your campaigns
now it's really important that you find
key metrics that are crucial for your
brand
now these metrics can be tracked weekly
monthly or in a quarterly basis and
based on these results appropriate
actions can be taken
on Facebook you could look out for reach
and engagement on Twitter you could look
out for Impressions clicks and
Impressions and interactions on LinkedIn
likes comments and mentions on Instagram
and engagement and Impressions on
Pinterest
some of the most popular tools used for
this purpose are Sprout social buffer
HootSuite Google analytics and so on
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a Brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts the new the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content
but what exactly are buyer personas now
these are research-based profiles that
represent your Target customer buy a
personas help you describe your Brand's
ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a Content
management system like HubSpot
Squarespace Wix and WordPress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a B test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you and finally you
can publish and manage your content now
let's talk about content marketing tips
number one remarket your content content
marketing is one of the many ways you
can spread your content to a brighter
audience you can Define the audience you
want to Market to and then tag visitors
who come to your site and using Google's
Display Network you can strategically
position your ads in front of people on
Google or its partner websites who
previously interacted with your website
and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement I would be shown if I was
shopping for a MacBook Pro on Amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually I go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on Google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry you can have
different forms of Snippets like
definition boxes where a snippet of text
gives researchers direct and concise
definitions and descriptions you could
have tables where data is taken from the
page and displayed in a table you could
have ordered lists where items are
presented in specific order and you can
also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand if you're
looking to grow a following for your
content try not to copy how already
established and successful corporate
blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your Brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
Neil Patel see how he himself is the
brand and if you've gone through his
content you know it's pretty great as
well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four ensure that
your content matches your Brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your Brand's voice by answering these
questions you can provide your audience
with a more cohesive and helpful
experience your tone of your brand can
vary on the basis of what type of
content you are planning to post and
what the goal you want to achieve from
the campaign next up we have number five
back up your Arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original Source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six we have use specific
keywords now make sure you use specific
keywords in your content this takes care
of the SEO aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found in text
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
Niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven evaluate the
success of your content with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you backup your content
with data now let's talk about how data
can help you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo Evernote HubSpot
Trello and WordPress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached Midway right now so
I've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for Content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a Content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content
this will also establish your brand as
an authority and thought leader within
your Niche it will help your audience
depend on you for quality content and
give them a reason to return tip number
nine is to make your content actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them and earn their trust it also
leads to increased engagement and a
positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from Trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email IDs to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics videos and other
forms of rich media will help you
enhance the message of your brand and
reach a wider audience here's an example
of advertising by Coca-Cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and Evergreen content
creating content that's Evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work
here's an example of one such Evergreen
article people are never going to stop
wanting to learn how to do SEO so with a
little tweaking every few months to
reflect new changes that Google may have
done you'll have an article that you can
get considerable mileage out of next up
tip number 12 is to understand content
that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms for
example you all know YouTube is the best
place for video content Instagram and
Pinterest for visual content Twitter for
smaller Snappy content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like I mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find us out by asking questions
like who you're engaging with online
their age location language Etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now ABS testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more you
can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
Niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing strategy so buckle up
and let's get right to it and we're
gonna get right into some of the best
practices some tips some methodologies
some things you should be doing with
content marketing so right out of the
gate let's start talking about knowing
your audience okay so content is all
about writing for a particular audience
so it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website so you can get
that data in Google analytics under
audience email subscribers I mean who is
subscribing to your emails who do you
already have in your email database and
you can look at social media I mean you
look at Facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interests so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it's lines that
likes a specific you know product uh
that you offer or feature that's part of
that product that you offer then that's
the segment you're going to be writing
about so you need to collect your data
on your audience ahead of time then
you're going to segment that audience
okay so you're not gonna write content
for everyone because the shoe doesn't
necessarily fit for everyone okay the
the shoe has to fit for specific foot
and in this case we're talking about an
audience we need to be able to segment
our audience out and you could certainly
segment them out by age by gender by
education level by income by interest I
mean these are just some of the examples
again it could be new returning or new
reusers versus returning users it could
be users who are purchased from you in
the past versus users who haven't
purchased from you in the past it could
certainly be an age range it could be
even going further on interest level or
a combination thereof okay so for
example you can get that demographic
information using Google analytics just
got to go in analytics under audience
under demographics you're going to see
age and age is broken out by age range
and they're going to see gender so
you're gonna see a breakdown of gender
and use that to your advantage so if
you're going to you know write some
content and you know 99 of your traffic
is female the age of 18 to 24 then you
know that contents May catered
accordingly so you could certainly go to
Facebook page insights and get some
really good demographic data there
because Facebook is all about
demographics okay so you could see
exactly you know how many fans you have
broken out by Man versus women and then
you can see again same thing as Google
analytics you could see an age range
breakout you could use Twitter analytics
I mean Twitter has share some really
good insights into education level so
you know if you're dealing with you know
highly sophisticated people who have
master's degrees or even higher or let's
just say even on LinkedIn you know that
majority of the people you're trying to
Target are sea level meaning CEOs or
CFOs or CMOS you know Chief marketing
officers or chief executive officers
then you're going to cater your message
a little bit different than say
mid-range managers or or you know even
high range managers or even VPS so use
your audience information that you
collect on these various platforms to
your advantage okay so let's jump into
number two we want to create high
quality content now I know this sounds
like a given but and I say but heavily
there's not a lot of high quality
content out there on the internet so
separate yourself first and foremost
always always always always create high
quality content it's going to result in
a lot of things are going to benefit you
you know one you're going to come across
as you know somebody who knows what
they're talking about and that's going
to help increase your brand awareness
okay when you increase your brand
awareness people know about you so it's
likely going to increase traffic to your
website diet or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are going to
share that content okay so from an SEO
perspective it can improve website
ranking meaning if you have good quality
content you know and it's really focused
in on a specific topic or a certain set
of core words keywords then you're going
to rank improves website dwell time
meaning hey you got good content people
are going to hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then certainly last but
not least you can gain a lot of leads
here meaning hey somebody likes what you
have to say whether it's a video or blog
post or or infographic you know people
are going to become more interested more
engaged spend more time and that's all
going to funnel through to somebody
taking that next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do The Upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to Google's Keyword Planner
understand how much quality and and
understand how much competition each
keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in Google's Keyword Planner or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention write a nice
headline that's going to grab their
attention Okay so give valuable content
to your creators and add resources from
well-known sites so if you you do borrow
say a data point from another source
then you know cite that Source you also
want to create engaging in
thought-provoking content get somebody
to think I mean people are going to rage
your content because they not they don't
know the subject matter their interests
in the subject matter and they want to
be able to spend the time taking
something away from that content follow
a logical structure and use relevant
images I can't stress this one enough
you know just throw things on a web page
you know put some structure to it and
you have to break it out if you feel
like you have too much content there's
no harm in breaking it into part one
versus part two get people uh tease them
a bit get them to come back and read
part two okay use different content
forms in case somebody's interested
maybe you want to capture some data you
know prefer short paragraphs to make the
content readable remember if you're
talking to c-level folks you you know
maybe you don't have to dummy down the
content so to speak but if you're
dealing with you know folks or people
that are right out of high school are
still in high school then adjust your
content and format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done I mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points changed so these are
all you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and hey
listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you just
lost a lot of credibility you know don't
be afraid to add a clear call to action
at the end of your content if somebody's
interested in reading it they're
probably going to be interested in
taking the next step whatever that next
step is okay so created content that
fulfills viewers requirements meaning if
somebody's searching for something and
your content shows up in the search
results then they're actively looking
for you what are you offering them is it
fulfilling their requirements you don't
know be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help create visually appealing content
and then get more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content I was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information you know don't withhold it
have them come back and read a secondary
blog post or secondary piece that
supports the original now we want to
move from high quality content to
running a B test maybe tests so
important why because with a B split
testing you can increase your conversion
rates okay so four elements to test in
your content marketing strategy so if
you have content say a Blog and you're
testing that blog you test out the
images shifts test out the forms do you
have a long form or short form you know
test out the content length you can have
a variation that is a lot shorter than
the original does that increase or
decrease bounce rates play around with
call to actions your call to actions do
matter you know do you want to use a
softer call to action a softer tone or
do you want to use something very direct
and strong you know test call to actions
to see what's going to get people to
move closer through the closer to
purchasing and through that funnel so a
b testing to me is something that should
be naturally done with Google optimize
it's free so with images you know you
could test a lot of different variations
of images anything from people to you
know outlandish image rates or just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low you know don't write
something very long write something that
you think is going to stick with that
time of page but on your A B test create
something maybe a little longer if it's
engaging enough maybe somebody's gonna
stay a little bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation is going to
play with that length Okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out as a baseline what amount of content
is getting people to stay on the page
then see if you could push the envelope
one way or the other okay improving the
page with sign up forms really what you
want to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to Facebook or Google so if
they're creating an account they can
create an account via Google or Facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as I
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color I mean I
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the Middle East or
the Far East Asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know Europe or the West
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitors top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so really what we're trying to
do here is and improve our conversion
rates so what are your competitors doing
what are their baselines we can maybe up
that any I mean that data is also
available in Google analytics so you can
look at benchmarking reports in Google
analytics to get some form or fashion
you can also go to Facebook and look at
your competitors Facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of Engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include Facebook as well or maybe even
LinkedIn so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag in The Meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you can certainly leverage an SEO
platform form like search SM rush or Moz
or something like that that's going to
allow you to get some good Insight on
competitor information so keep in mind
there are SEO platforms that will give
you information on your competitors and
that's what these SEO platforms are good
for so number five moving on choose a
suitable content format so now we've
done all this homework we know what we
want to say we know who we want to say
it to we're ready to do some testing but
we need to find a format because it's
not always about a web page per se
meaning content on a web page there's
not always about a blog post with
content in that blog post okay we need
to decide the type of content that's
going to fit what we're trying to say so
again you can go the traditional route
with just posting a blog post and
nothing wrong with that because with a
blog post you can incorporate video and
imagery you can also go more harder
route when I say harder more I say
official route with an e-book or case
study something that a user is going to
be able to take away with maybe download
something more official
um something more in-depth something
with a harder stamp on it so that that
shows individuals that you've taken the
time you've done this homework you've
done this research you've done some
really in-depth analysis and now the
proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an e-book now if you're into
talking like I am then you can certainly
do a podcast and podcasts are always
popular depending on the topic so you
got to be aware of the topic now videos
are always always a good option you got
the likes of video and video and YouTube
and some other you know video platforms
out there that allow you the ability to
get found very quickly especially with
the likes of YouTube you know people you
use YouTube before they go on to
purchasing a product so think about that
so if you're trying to get somebody if
you're trying to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website visitors on social so that's the
key make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer and in-depth content so and
it shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded and and
you solving that customer's problem so
the case study is always there for you
know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
Reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture hey
everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a Content management system
that's going to work for you so so you
want to be able to choose something
where you can plan appropriately produce
manage publish and measure results all
in one place there are plenty of content
Management Systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are WordPress HubSpot
binder I mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know WordPress
is the way to go if you're into building
on landing pages that you want to you
know share you know HubSpot could be the
way to go okay there are lots of
available options out there so moving on
number seven Target your audience using
emails okay so what are we talking about
well we all know what emails are emails
help us to communicate directly with our
target audience and convert them to
leads so email is a good way to follow
up with your audience so if you've done
a podcast follow up with an email you
know maybe get them to you you know fill
out a survey via email based on that
podcast or if you create a podcast about
some data that you talked about in that
podcast follow up that with with them
via email with an infographic perhaps
okay built into the email okay there's
lots of ways that all these formats can
complement themselves via email okay you
could certainly take a blog post and
package it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly you know you can
collect emails and send out those emails
with you know certain information or
what you should be doing is targeting
and segmenting your emails just like you
are your content so if you're producing
content for a certain audience then May
make sure that particular audience gets
that same email now some of the email
content that you could share with your
target audience or newsletters okay
seasonal emails promotional emails
automated messaging and what we mean by
automated messaging hey if somebody just
purchased from you send them a thank you
email maybe follow up a couple days
later with another email with a survey
or what you could do is if you know who
your lawyer customers are you know
Target them with a promotional email so
there's lots of ways to slice and dice
content via email okay just make sure
you know your target audience is there's
lots of things you can do in email again
you can compliment lots of different
formats within email as I mentioned
before with a podcast or a blog post so
keep all that in mind email is a good
way to communicate with your audience
okay the last point we want to make here
is use native ads okay so we talk about
Native ads it's one of the smartest ways
to connect your audience with your brand
so for example this is a native ad on
BuzzFeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably wouldn't exist without Led
Zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who Led Zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to Led Zeppelin okay so
you could see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet Zeppelin you know I'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who Led Zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay who is
this Led Zeppelin group and what are
these 15 bands the key here is not to
say the headline or Led Zeppelin per se
but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to content talking about music okay
so according to Forbes online audiences
are 20 five percent more likely to look
at a native ad than add a banner and so
that native ad in this case we're
talking about music needs to be sitting
or companyed alongside content talking
about in this case music you know would
help if it was rock music just music in
general might get enough to get Peak
people's interest okay so if you're
going to create content you know align
that content with something that's you
know naturally going to fit and that's
why we call them native ads because
they're native to the content that
they're associated with so finally after
all that said and done when all you've
done is create good content follow up
the emails targeting your audience and
associating that content with you know
content natively then you can always
measure your content performance so my
favorite part of it all you go in
analytics going to Facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because you want to be able
to see what's performing what's not
performing the key here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video you're not
necessarily going to look at page views
you're going to look at video views so
you know some of these basic metrics of
users and sessions and Pages bounce rate
you know dwell time that's all great but
you just need to make sure that you're
aligning the right metric with the right
asset so for example if you have a case
study and rebook you want to make sure
that you're measuring how many downloads
the ebook or the case study received
again with the video you want to measure
video views now if you're packing
cleaning up emails and sending them out
to your target audience you want to make
sure you look at open rates and click
rates okay so a lot of things you can be
looking at so make sure you choose the
right metrics because there's hundreds
and hundreds of metrics to choose from
so just be aware all the different
metrics that are available you know if
you're in it for search okay how much
traffic getting from search where are
you ranking so there are a lot of things
you need to think about so think about
the content that you're producing and
think about how you want to be able to
measure that content so let's go back
over our checklist here so what you
could do is create an editorial calendar
in fact I would highly suggest you
create an editorial calendar in order to
keep track of all the content you've
done over a period of time are you
making your content worth reading that
means are you checking the results of
that content what we just went over
measuring the content is it worth
reading have a column set up in that
editor a calendar you know performing or
not performing if it's not performing
don't do it again okay curate your
content okay you always wanna you know
make sure you're reusing or using or
adding to the content that you've
created guest post on influential
blogger websites you want to add
statistics numbers and quotes to your
content make it engaging make it look
like you've done your homework you could
share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
SlideShare now you can share it on all
social media platforms I'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a Blog okay
so get some testimonials that support
some of your content again create a
podcast you can send out an email with a
survey or trying to solicit some
testimonials or if you post something on
Facebook you know leverage the feedback
bag you get from Facebook in the form of
a testimonial okay and then you want to
promote your blog post for maximum
success and a lot of that means SEO so
make sure you do your due diligence and
get the right keywords in that blog post
okay so you can create personas for
different user audiences okay so
remember it's all about tone okay so if
you're going to create a blog post make
sure your tone is aligned with that
Right audience whether that be young
middle aged or older are you choosing
the right type of content okay you'll
know based on the results okay you want
to add H1 and H2 tags on your web pages
why because when we're talking about
content we're talking about organizing
the content and H1 and H2S help you
organize the content appropriately
customize the metadata metadata is title
tag and meta tag descriptions and even
all tags okay all of that is for search
so you want your content to show up in
search whether that's video infographic
or blog post all of it can be shown in
search results so make sure you write a
good title and make sure you write a
good meta description because that's
what people are going to see when they
search okay so you want to create a
detailed summary and title and again
that goes along with the title tag and
meta description and then you want to
make it easy for the audience to ask
questions and comment on your blog so
don't be afraid like I'm gonna do right
now in this video is if I'm missing
anything from this checklist feel free
to comment hey I've written my fair
share content but I could be talking to
an audience that is just as qualified as
I am and they may have some tips so feel
free to comment underneath this video
now don't be afraid to ask just like I
just did people are always willing to
provide constructive feedback so don't
be afraid to ask for it and make it easy
so to me every blog post needs to have
some form of a comment box because blog
posts are out there to solicit
engagement now let's recap everything we
talked about because we certainly
covered a lot and there's a lot to cover
when it comes to content marketing so
one know your audience again you can
lean on Google analytics you know
demographic data whether it be age or
gender you could do the same with
Facebook and Twitter and Linkedin you
know every platform has some data you
could take away great high quality
content when I mean high quality content
brainstorm some topics has it already
been written to death about or is this
unique you know don't write something
your competitors are writing okay don't
copy what your competitors have written
organize your content support it with
good imagery all of these are tips to
creating high quality content okay when
you create that content think about
running some a b tests you know run some
variations uh and switch out the image
switch out the call to action see what's
going to get people to react and engage
with the content conduct competitor
analysis so lean on the Facebooks of the
world to see what your competitors are
posting see what's engaging for them
okay you can also lean on these SEO
platforms like sem rush and Moz all you
got to do is plug in a domain and
they're going to give you some
information about where particular
competitor ranks for keyword or how many
backlinks and what websites are linking
to them so all that's available in these
SEO platforms okay so you want to choose
a suitable content format we listed a
few from ebooks to case studies to
podcasts to infographics to blog posts
to videos it's up to you what you think
is best for your audience just keep in
mind you need to be able to measure it
and so that's the important thing if it
doesn't work the first time out then you
might want to consider changing out the
content format choose a Content
management system
um you know plenty out there WordPress
is a good one if you're going to be a
blogger okay blogging allows you to you
know post optimize that blog post you
know you could have the ability to share
that blog post across social platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
Target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
Loyal followers or you can use
systematic emails to send an email a
thank you email somebody purchases and
then another follow-up email and again
you can repurpose some of the content
you've done in another format in the
form of an email so you know if you
created a video you know put that video
in the form of an email sent out to your
audience to make sure they're not
missing out on that video you just
created so lots of ways to use email
take advantage of email it's your ally
here okay use native ads okay don't be
afraid to put that content and hear it
with some other content on another
website it's been proven people are
going to engage in an ad that they see
based on the content they're currently
reading because the ad if it's native
it's going to be similar in nature to
the content they're currently engaged in
and then measure your content
performance I can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging Google analytics
okay with Google analytics or Facebook
insights or Twitter or LinkedIn or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it align your kpi so
if it's an e-book or case study don't
measure just traffic measure how many
people actually die downloading them
okay if it's a video you know how many
people like the video how many people
are commenting how many people are
sharing the video how many people are
subscribing to your playlist based on
that video content okay so these are all
things you can measure okay so every
platform from WordPress to YouTube to to
Reddit has some form of analytics
associated with it today we're going to
talk about how to get traffic to your
website so thank you for joining and
let's get started so let's imagine
you're setting up your own website okay
you're clicking away You're developing
using some good tools you're developing
you're designing you're doing some QA
you're testing you're sharing with
Friends and an alpha version and then
finally your website is all set up
congratulations well when you hit enter
and your website is finally published
what's going to happen well a few days
later you're checking your website and
you're looking at analytics and you
notice your traffic's very low okay well
you're scratching your head because
you've done all this work with your
website but you're not getting any
traffic so the reason is you spend all
your time developing designing the
website to make it look good but you
didn't do anything or any planning or
any strategy around bringing users to
your website so the two go hand in hand
you just can't build a website without
thinking about how to drive users to the
website and so before I tell you how to
bring traffic to your website let me
tell you why this is so important okay
why do we want to bring users to our
website I mean it has to be on equal
ground as web development and design is
somebody who goes to your site and then
does something when they get to your
site so you have users and when those
users get to your site they're
generating page views and traffic and
you want to turn that traffic into
engagement okay so each Page's traffic
is configured independently of all their
pages so when you go when somebody goes
to your website they look at a page
that's a page view and certain pages on
your website you want to turn that page
view into a conversion okay whether that
be you know looking at a video or
purchasing something so think of these
pages on your website as salespeople
they're trying to convert visitors who
come to your website but first we need
to get the visitors to your website so
when you give visitors to your website
again you can generate sales which means
revenue or you can increase brand
awareness or you can earn Revenue
through sponsored posts and
advertisements so if you have for
example a lot of content on your website
you can turn that in to revenue by
hosting ads on your website so when
somebody clicks on that ad you're going
to earn a percentage of that click okay
with that click is worth so having a
website means a lot of good things for
you but first you got to get the traffic
there and so what we're going to do is
we're going to tell you how to drive
traffic to your website so there's lots
of different ways in which you can bring
traffic to your website well the first
is paid advertising so paying to
advertise your products services with
ads is one of the easiest ways to drive
traffic to your website so some of the
options available are search ads social
media ads or display ads so search ads
or ads that are displayed in the search
engine results so when a user types in a
keyword a query you want your ad to show
up based on that keyword query okay so
an example is digital marketing course
somebody types in digital marketing
course and simply learn is the first ad
that shows up how do we know it's an ad
because you could see the word ad next
to the domain so when somebody clicks on
that link simply learn is going to pay
Google so that's how search advertising
works okay the next is social it's a
social media marketing involves
increasing traffic or engagement or
brand awareness lots of different
strategies but you're instead of doing
this on search you're doing it on a
social media platform okay so for
example you can advertise on any
particular platform and the way you
advertise could be with an image it
could be with a video so in this case
you could see cobrio is doing a
sponsored ad here how to succeed with
Google ads and then another form of
advertising is display so display means
creating ads that are placed on specific
websites so with display unlike search
you have a choice in the ad format with
search you only have text ads but with
display you have text Edge image ads
rich media ads video ads so you have
lots of different options in which you
can advertise on other websites so the
idea here is to get your ad in front of
the Right audience when they could see
your display Banner your banner ad then
it's going to be more visual more
appealing generate some brand interest
and hopefully you can get somebody to
click on that ad and over to your
website so that's paid advertising again
through search through social through
display but you can also promote your
site on social media so once your
content has gone live you could take
advantage of different social media
platforms I mean it really depends on
what you're trying to promote because
what you're trying to promote needs to
align with the appropriate social media
platform so Facebook is best suited for
Industries like food and Beverages and
news and media and if you're selling a
product so you fall into one of those
categories and Facebook could be the
right platform for you if you're
involved in again beauty or food and
beverage or e-commerce then you can also
leverage Instagram which is part of
Facebook's ecosystem so if you advertise
on Facebook you can also advertise on
Instagram and or Instagram so it doesn't
have to be and Facebook and Instagram it
could be Facebook or Instagram you also
have LinkedIn as a platform LinkedIn is
great for B2B so if you're trying to
promote industry news or or tips and
best practices or job postings then
LinkedIn is the place for you it's a B2B
platform it's great for targeting
specific Industries targeting specific
job levels or job descriptions okay so
LinkedIn is great if you're into B2B
focusing on the business side of it so
you also have YouTube now YouTube is
part of Google's ecosystem YouTube is a
video platform okay so it's great if
you're trying to promote gaming or
entertainment or if you're a vlogger
okay so YouTube's a great way to promote
your site by getting your product out
there in the form of a video and then
you have Twitter Twitter to me
encompasses a lot of different
Industries Beauty and fitness news and
media entertainment okay you have
limited number of characters but a lot
of people are active on Twitter and it's
a great way to generate some awareness
and get some clicks over to your website
so these are just some of the most
popular social media platforms of course
there are plenty more out there the
third way in which you can drive traffic
to your site is guest plus blogging so
most of you already know what blogging
is all about well if you're blogging for
your own site you can jump on somebody
else's site and blog on their behalf so
having the opportunity to guess post on
another website can be very helpful
because one that other blog could have
lots of traffic and have a a well-known
brand so if you're blogging on another
blog it's going to build your brand
awareness and potentially increase
traffic to your your blog or website so
it exposes to you to targeted traffic so
if you're going to guest blog guest blog
on a site that's very relevant to your
business or industry that way you're
targeting the Right audience okay you
can expand your personal Network so
getting yourself out there getting your
brand out there in front of a different
audience and then obviously for serves
because it generates backlink so serps
search engine ranking Pages means that
hey if you want to rank organically
you're going to have to generate some
backlinks so guest blogging isn't a way
to generate some backlinks to your site
and in effect that's going to help you
get your pages ranked higher because
Google is going to recognize the
relationship from one blog to your blog
and build up your relevancy so some
other benefits here to guest blogging is
you can grow your social media following
because you can then promote that on
social media that you're guest blogging
okay again you can improve your online
Authority okay because when you're guest
blogging and you have recognition on
that guest blog if it's a popular blog
then it's not going to help your domain
and Page Authority for SEO and then the
end result is going to improve your
backlink score so a lot of benefits to
guest blogging to me at the end of the
day it's just about reaching out to your
audience using another platform to do
that in the form of a Blog and the
results of that is going to mean more
brand awareness for you and turning that
traffic from that other blog into
qualified leads so you can also
interview industry thought leaders so
that's another way an interesting way to
generate traffic to your site so
reaching out to thought leaders for
interviews okay could generate some
credibility for you and the other person
so it's reciprocal so it means that
you're active in the industry that
you're in and it allows you to engage
with other leaders in the industry and
the indirect net result of that could be
increased traffic because if you do the
interview and you record it or if it's
via video then you can obviously post it
on other platforms and that could in
turn Drive traffic to your website
obviously just like guest blogging it's
going to increase your reach so getting
yourself out there nobody knows who your
brand is and they know who the thought
leaders are and they see you're
interviewing the thought leaders then
that's going to put you in front of
these people and so it's going to
increase your reach another way to drive
traffic to your website is just to make
sure your website's responsive and what
do we mean by responsive well we mean
does it work on multiple devices
specifically mobile so depending on the
device your website hides shows shrinks
and larges or moves content so that it
conforms to the browser that that
person's looking at on your web for your
website so if somebody's looking on
mobile at your website you want to make
sure sure that your website adjusts
accordingly so you want to be able to
you know test to make sure it's
responsive and so as content arranged
based on importance okay does it work
across different browsers on different
devices and do the images text and
everything else a line just like it does
on desktop so there are plenty of tools
out there on the web all you need to do
is just do a search for you know check
my website for responsiveness you know
so you you can use plenty of tools to
check to see if your website is
responsive towards multiple devices why
is that important because if somebody
goes to your website Via Mobile and your
site doesn't align properly or the
content's all stretched out and somebody
has to maneuver their browser just to
see your website then chances are
they're not going to come back chances
are they're not going to convert okay so
you want to be able to revise your
device browser combinations you want to
make sure that everything works
accordingly you want to be able to test
the those fonts make sure they look good
and then you also want to make sure that
people can navigate so if they're on
mobile are they going to navigate just
as easy as they can on desktop and if
you have any pop-ups you want to
probably make sure they're removed so
that way when somebody's looking at your
website they're not getting interfered
with on mobile and then of course you
want to make sure that these Pages load
okay so they load just as quick on
desktop as they should on mobile and
vice versa so this should not take a
long time to load so moving on from
responsiveness a mobile to building a
brand community so brand community
refers to a group of people who identify
your brand and use your brand as a
platform to exchange ideas and
contribute content some advantages of
having a brand Community are promoting
brand evangelism and loyalty it can be a
source of feedback loyalty and ideas so
build the community build a brand
Community who you know identify with you
okay so continue to you know treat these
people as loyal customers okay maybe
give them a promotion uh to use
specifically just for them that they can
use on your website or talk directly to
them because you know that they're
followers they're repeat customers they
purchase for you multiple times so talk
to them differently as well you know who
these people are and that's what
building a brand is all about it's about
identifying your brand with other people
okay and identify people who identify
with your brand and messaging and
talking to them as if they're part of
your own Community your own family so
you can use user generated content that
provides future marketing strategies so
the feedback you get from your own
Community could it be in turn used to
promote or used in future marketing
strategies I.E advertising I IE post on
social okay it can also provide PR
opportunities so it's a chance for you
to you know put out press releases based
on the community that you built so any
brand regardless of who it is should be
able to identify with your audience
their target audience and that target
audience eventually going to become part
of a community these are group of people
who identify with you what you're trying
to sell what your cause is what your
mission statement is what your services
they identify with you so leverage them
and reciprocate identify them talk to
them separately give them the what they
deserve the respect and loyalty that
they deserve as well because they're
communicating and they're following you
as a brand so the next thing you could
do to drive traffic is Be Active in the
comments section so engage in relevant
and thought-provoking conversations on
other blogs and sites it doesn't
necessarily have to be another blog per
se it could be other sites like Reddit
or quora or media sites that have a lot
of content that are broken out by
industry that allow you to engage in
conversation and allow you to either
upvote or share or respond okay so be
active because when you're active people
are going to see that hey you're a
leader in the industry you know what
you're talking about you have some some
brand Equity you have some thought and
some knowledge on the specific topic and
subject so it just puts you in a better
light when you can respond and be active
on these different platforms okay let's
turn our attention to search engine
optimization also known as SEO or
organic search so in order to drive
traffic to your site you're going to
have to implement an SEO strategy why do
you want to implement an SEO strategy
because it can help you improve your
overall searchability ability and
visibility on search engines and
obviously that comes with advantages one
of those advantages is obviously more
traffic to the site search is still King
in terms of volumes of people using
search on a daily basis so you have a
great opportunity to be found it also
builds trust and credibility because
still a majority of the people who do a
search click on an organic search list
in and so if you're found organically
and you're ranked number one then
chances are somebody's going to click on
your listing and it provides increased
engagement and traffic and so what that
means is more traffic more engagement
and engagement is something you define
it could be again a download of a
document or the clicking on the play
button of a video or or submitting a
form or signing up for a newsletter or
calling these are all forms of
Engagement so the the amount of traffic
you drive from organic search to your
website is only going to improve
engagement okay so you can also provide
an improve user experience and what do
we mean by that well if you're getting
lots of traffic from organic search you
have a really good opportunity to do a b
testing and when you do a b testing you
can improve user experience meaning
you're showing one variation against the
other from people coming from organic
search and so this is helpful in that
you know if you're running an A B test
the variation has a chance to improve or
outperform the original and if it
outperforms the original you're
improving user experience and then it
helps Target quality traffic so SEO to
me or all search is the only medium in
which you're meeting somebody halfway
you're you're addressing what they're
looking for so somebody's looking for a
pair of red women's Nike shoes the 2019
model and you have that particular
product to offer well you have a chance
of showing up via organic search
somebody types in you know women's red
Nike shoes size whatever at the year
2019 model then of course they're gonna
probably likely click on your listing
because you have what they're looking
for and and that goes with any keyword
any industry any business any segment
any type of product you're selling so
again you have a chance to really be
visible for what people are looking for
and so that's the beauty of search
engine optimization you have a really
good opportunity here to meet people
halfway to drive quality traffic to get
them to enjoy a good user experience all
the while generating engagement and
along with SEO we want to be able to
build backlinks so SEO is a two-pronged
approach meaning you have two strategies
in one on page and off page and so off
page involves backlinking so back
lengths are just links that direct users
from other websites to your own website
so with that inherently it's going to
drive traffic qualify traffic to your
website because if somebody's on a
relevant website that's linking to yours
and they click on that link and go to
your website it's likely going to be
qualified meaning they're going to be
relevant and so back linking because
it's an off-page strategy why isn't an
off-page SEO strategy because if Google
crawls that other site that has a link
to you then that's going to give you
credit because Google say hey this
site's getting some links from some
relevant sites we must think they're
relevant and therefore we're going to
trust this site so by Google trusting
your site it's going to improve your
organic ranking and with the organic
rankings being improved meaning it's
going to mean faster indexing so what
does that mean so you want to be indexed
by the search engines and so the quicker
Google can find your pages even if it's
on somebody else's site then that means
they're gonna follow that link go to
that page on your site and take that
page back to their servers to be indexed
okay so the quicker you can get index
the quicker you can get found and then
it helps with referral traffic so again
we noticed that our efforts are on SEO
organic search but if you're getting
traffic from another website hey that
still counts that's referral traffic
okay so that's a side advantage to
having backlinks is good traffic from
other sites okay so those those are
inherently the some of the reasons to do
backlinking okay never hurts I mean
there's brand awareness reasons to being
on other sites as well there's industry
leadership meaning if you you post
content on Reddit okay you're coming
across as an industry leader but yet
generating a backlink which helps with
SEO and referral traffic so there's a
lot of benefits to building backlinks
and the opposite of backlinks are
internal links so you want to do
internal linking and that just means
connecting one page on your site to
another and why is that beneficial
because it can help direct visitors to
other Pages they wouldn't normally
otherwise find via your navigation so if
you're active on a Blog don't be afraid
to include multiple internal links you
want to move people through your site
you want the flow of traffic to go from
one page to another to another and so
when you do internal linking just like
with backlinks it's going to improve the
indexing of your website Google's going
to follow those links and index those
pages and Google does give credit from
an SEO perspective from an internal
linking perspective so if one page is
linked to another and that page has
really good relevance in the eyes of
Google then the other page is probably
going to benefit from that the other
reason you want to do internal linking
again you want to move people from your
one page of your site to the other and
when you do that it's going to reduce
bounce rates so bounce rate is simple
the rate at which people land on a page
and then leave so if I have a hundred
people land on my home page and only one
person went to another page and the
other 99 left the site then that's a 99
bounce rate so by putting internal links
in place you're helping people move from
one page to the other and thus reducing
the bounce rate and that's what you want
you want to keep people on your site you
want to be greedy it also drives traffic
to older posts so again when we say
older posts we're really referring to
blog posts so if you have a relevant
blog post and you're writing a new blog
post then link the two together if it's
relevant link it I don't you know
regardless of how old it is you know you
want to show Google that these older
blog posts just because they were
written a year ago doesn't mean they're
outdated and old-fashioned okay or
useless you want to keep them alive by
linking to them so to me that's a good
strategy for internal linking link to
older blog posts you know show people
you're an industry expert you've been
doing this for a while and then you have
lots of content to share okay so the
longer you can keep somebody on your
website the more likely it is they're
going to engage and convert and some
other inherent benefits improves page
rank so what we mean by pagerank is
simply just a rank that Google gives
pages so the more internal linking you
have the better off you are and then it
helps spread link juice across websites
and what we mean by link juice again
just like backlinking it builds
relevancy so just keep all these
inherent benefits in mind to internal
linking the end result is keeping the
flow of traffic on your site and all
these other benefits will fall into
place okay so another way in which you
can really hone in on traffic to your
website is long tail keywords and long
tail keywords to me are more than just
one or two keyword phrases okay so there
are usually three or longer keywords in
a phrase okay it's a long tail keywords
really nowadays account for most web
searches people really take the time to
even pose questions as a search query
it's a likely somebody it's unlikely
somebody's going to go into search and
just type in the word shoes they might
type in red shoes but that's unlikely
but they're probably going to type in is
you know red Nike running shoes 2019 or
some variation of that okay that's a
long tail keyword and some of the
advantages of using long tail keywords
to be found for are less competition so
if you're using broad keywords like red
shoes then who doesn't want to be found
for Red Shoes well you don't necessarily
you don't want to be found for red shoes
because it's too broad you don't know
what type of shoes somebody's looking
for you just know they're looking for
Red Shoes it could be running shoes it
could be work shoes it could be you know
boots it could be slippers okay it's too
broad so long tail keywords oh narrow it
in and the more narrow and focused a
keyword is the less competition is going
to have and when something's not
competitive in the form of a keyword
then that means your chances of ranking
for that keyword are going to be greater
and the chance of you ranking faster are
going to be greater and then of course
if somebody's looking for exactly what
you have to offer then you have a higher
chance to convert that person so if you
have exactly those 2019 red Nike women's
running shoes and somebody does a search
for that and that's a long tail keyword
and they click on your organic listing
if you have the right price then they're
probably going to convert so you have a
really good chance of converting
somebody using long tail keywords so my
point here is if you're looking for
keywords to use focus on longer tail
don't focus on one or two keyword
phrases what it also does is brings
targeted traffic so even if somebody
doesn't convert hey they could be back
because it's exactly what they're
looking for and if you're focusing on
longer tail keywords like I just
mentioned stay away from the shorter
ones it's just easier to optimize your
page for SEO so remember SEO is a
two-pronged approach on page and off
page we talked about off page with
internal linking and backlinks on page
is all about making sure there's
keywords you choose are integrated in
with the page you want to be found for
and so if you're using a long tail
keyword it's just easy to work that
keyword in so it enables easier on-page
optimization okay let's switch away from
SEO to email marketing so let's focus on
email marketing as a form or method of
driving traffic to your website so email
marketing has been around a long time in
terms of digital marketing why because
it provides an effective way to convert
leads into sales why because you can
send personalized emails to a target
audience so when you send an email to
somebody on a regular basis you know who
that person is so what are you doing in
the email you're writing is specific
message to that person well email
marketing is the same thing except
you're just sending an email to a larger
group of people and when you send an
email to a larger group of people you're
still going to personalize the message
right you're not going to send a generic
email to 1 000 people okay nobody's
going to do that so make sure your email
is targeted if it's targeted it could be
cost effective why because sending large
amounts of emails or let's just say an
email to a large amount of people or a
large group of people is going to be
cost effective it's not cost per click
you know it's not cost per open okay so
email usually depending on the the email
provider you're using really is a flat
fee so just really depends on how many
emails you're sending or how how many
people you're sending the email to as
well so but email generally tends to be
more cost effective than other forms of
marketing so look at the email content
provider you using and just get a sense
of what they charge but if you look at
it and do a comparison email generally
is cheaper than say doing pay-per-click
because with pay-per-click you're paying
for each click okay so that could be
expensive depending on the keywords so
email marketing is also time saving okay
meaning it's a one-time thing and done
so once you send the email it's just a
matter of
you know watching and looking at the
metrics and learning what's going on so
you don't make the same mistakes again
but it is time conducive meaning you
send out one email and that's it with
pay-per-click you're constantly
measuring and managing the campaigns and
it provides real-time marketing so when
you do send an email more than likely a
majority of the people on day one or the
day you send the email are gonna be able
to view it open it click on some of the
links and convert so that's normally
what happens in email majority of the
people open it on day one and it kind of
tails off from there so think about it
as real time so when you send that email
and if you have a thousand people on
your email recipient list break it up
send the first 500 first with a
different subject line and then you can
see the data come in and if you don't
see the good results from the subject
line or the body of the email or you
know the page they're going to then make
adjustments before you send the other
email to the next five hundred so that's
a great thing about emails you can break
up the email into two groups the first
group and then the second group with
different subject lines and you can
probably send them a little bit of time
apart that way you can learn from the
first email because with email you are
generally going to get results right
away okay within the first 24 hours so
that's a great thing about email okay so
the other thing about email it's less
intrusive so normally people who are
going to get the email are the ones who
sign up for the email so they're almost
expecting your email so when they get
your email again as long as you're not
sending an email on a daily basis
normally most companies send it monthly
or bi-weekly it's not going to be as
intrusive okay and then it also helps
build credibility increase visibility
and brand awareness meaning you're going
to build your brand in that email you're
going to put content in that email
that's going to show off your
credibility meaning you could put some
testimonial in the email you can put
some good affiliations you can put a
good article to an industry article you
just wrote so email is going to
inherently continue to build brand
awareness for you okay and it's an easy
way to track Roi so if your e-commerce
it's pretty clear you send the email
somebody opens it clicks on it checks
out and purchases something it's easily
trackable because you could track it
right from that email so one thing I
want to say there is just if you do send
an email make sure you're tracking that
campaign and you want to be able to use
an analytics program like Google
analytics if you use Google analytics
you're going to be able to track when
you send the email who clicks on it and
who converts so you want to be able to
measure an Roi for these emails and you
can and that's the beauty of email
marketing okay let's move away from
email marketing to webinars so webinars
great method for Effective social media
promotion it's a great way to bring
traffic to your website so why why do we
recommend webinars well because it
provides direct content contact within
your target group what do we mean by
contact with your target group well
you're going to host a webinar and
you're going to invite this targeted
group of people who are interested in
your product or service so if you have a
Facebook Community you can do a Facebook
live event or you could do a YouTube or
you know you can even set up a webinar
on another platform but promote it on
social media and if you're pronouning
something on social media you're
probably promoting it to people who are
already following you or like you and so
that's what we mean by direct contact
with your target groups you're going to
be able to create a webinar and talk
directly to that group and that's going
to help build brand awareness and
credibility and the great thing about
webinars is you don't need some fancy
software I mean I'm talking to you on a
webinar right now and so webinars are
free all you need is a video camera and
a recorder that's all and that's all
built in with software so there's plenty
of software out there that allows you
just to do a webinar really quick and
easy there's lots of opportunities in
software so and a lot of them are very
cost effective so if you want to build
create a webinar you can do that by
spending very little money in webinars
again allow you to talk to your your
targeted group your community maybe
prospective clients it helps build
credibility and in effect Drive traffic
to your website and when somebody does
attend a webinar they're likely going to
be highly engaged because you're
inviting them they're going to opt into
the webinar and the great thing about
webinars is even if they don't attend
the webinar the day you have it it's
going to be recorded so they can always
go back and watch it so whoever watches
the webinar is going to be engaged
because it's going to be a topic they're
interested in and then users are likely
to become prospective customers so
having a webinar talking about something
inherently and interesting to maybe a
larger group of people you can promote
that on social media and potentially get
prospective customers to sign up and
watch the webinar and if you do they're
going to be engaged and then take the
next step oh I like what this guy this
person has to say they seem to be
credible I like their personality I like
their brand I like their product I'm
gonna go check their web out their
website okay so webinars allow you to
kind of pull in more people as well as
just your community because you can
promote the webinar and you can promote
it in advance and you can leverage
social media for that okay so something
related to webinars incorporating video
content so videos have been proven to be
a really good way to attract new
visitors and it just it makes your
website very engaging when you have
videos on your website as well so if you
create video you have an opportunity to
post it on various video platforms like
YouTube or Romeo okay there's plenty of
video platforms out there or just
embedded in a blog post or embed it in a
Facebook post or a tweet okay so you can
do a lot with video and having video on
your site is going to increase
engagement okay when you increase
engagement good things happen that's
going to lead to increased conversions
and sales or or Roi or just like we
mentioned the webinar can help build
trust with your audience even that
webinar you could post on your website
so you want people to engage by watching
this video they watch the video they're
going to gain trust in you because
you're talking directly to that person
that user that audience that visitor to
your website and when you get Bell trust
it's going to increase engagement and
that's the beauty of video unlike text
or imagery videos really do engage with
the audience and so the more video you
could do the better off you are because
again you can leverage social to draw
attention to your brand and product and
service and then you can have that video
on your website to increase engagement
which in turn increases conversions and
sales and improves Roi so always think
video there's plenty of video software
out there that you can leverage and the
great thing about video two is hey most
people are using mobile phones these
days smartphones and so video works just
as well on mobile as it does on desktop
so keep that in mind you know video is
going to be engaging regardless of what
device somebody uses and then of course
if they're watching the video on
Facebook or YouTube then chances are
they're going to share that particular
video which is going to bode well for
your brand and traffic okay so video if
somebody likes a video it's very easy to
share video especially from a mobile
phone so YouTube just makes it so easy
to share or like or subscribe to a
channel it just it becomes that much
easier things can go viral and chances
of them going viral with video are going
to be greater okay so other ways to
drive traffic to your website is submit
your content to content aggregators so
what's a Content aggregator well a
Content aggregators like Reddit that
provides a great platform for you to
post your content so that's what a
Content aggregate is really a site like
Reddit or medium or quora where you
could post content to a large number of
people okay so with Reddit people are
either going to upvote it or downvote it
so the more upvotes you get are thumbs
up or likes or people who encourage that
content the more of a chance it has to
be found and so first thing out of the
gate if you do provide content to a
Content aggregator like Reddit make sure
it's good quality content that's
interesting and that should be a case
the case around across the board whether
it's a social post or blog post make
sure the content's unique professional
and interesting and then if you do say
put something on medium or you do put
something on Cora and it is professional
and interesting and thought provoking
then people are going to react to it and
then that again could lead to traffic
but even if it doesn't lead to traffic
it helps build brand awareness so if you
have content just like videos leverage
it put the content out there okay and
when you put content out there it's only
gonna especially if it's good content
put it's going to put you in a good
light so don't be afraid to share your
content on the likes of Reddit or medium
or core or some of these other content
aggregator websites because good things
are only going to happen and again
referral traffic SEO brand awareness
conversions so all these are inherent
benefits of just sharing your content
okay and then finally we want to learn
from analytics okay so what do I mean
learning from analytics so there are
plenty of analytics platforms out there
one of the most popular is Google
analytics so you want to make sure sure
you're tracking traffic on your site
with Google analytics so I have to do is
just go to Google analytics via search
sign up add the analytics code to your
website and voila they're doing all the
heavy lifting they're going to track
traffic coming your website and not only
they're going to track traffic but
they're going to tell you how that
traffic engaged and so the benefits of
it Google analytics is hey you can
figure out where users are coming from
are they coming from that email campaign
that I sent out to a thousand people are
they coming from YouTube based on that
video I posted or are they coming from
Reddit based on the content I just
posted there or they're coming from
organic search it is so Google analytics
can help us understand how much traffic
we're getting from organic search so
it'll help us measure our SEO efforts
and then with Google analytics you could
segment so we could segment by mobile we
can segment by desktop returning user
new user by campaign by Page by language
by city by region I mean there's so many
ways in which to segment your audience
and segmenting simply is breaking up the
entire group of people who come to your
website into different segments based on
what you want to say so if you want to
look at you know females between the
ages of 18 to 24 who come from mobile
via organic search that's a segment and
you can look at that information and
analytics if that's your target audience
then you could see how they're
performing okay so Anna there are a lot
of benefits to Google analytics
definitely wants to take advantage of
segmenting in Google analytics you could
look at your competition so there's a
benchmarking report the great thing
about Google analytics you can also look
at content and how your content is
performing once somebody lands on your
website are they what page are they
spending time on what page are they
engaging on the most okay what pages
have the highest bounce rate or the
lowest time on page so you can really do
determine what pages work best and then
of course the end result in analyzing
all this data is you want to be able to
fine-tune your website so take advantage
of the data that Google analytics or any
other analytics platform is giving you
by learning once you learn what's going
on with your website you can make
adjustments to your website to improve
user experience okay so we went over a
lot of different ways to drive traffic
okay you can incorporate all this to
your website immediately welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
Linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the lead she's collecting
per day per month and convert them into
custom
okay so customers sign up but they don't
buy her product so she's left scratching
her head wondering what to do so how's
she going to solve the problem of
converting the lead she gets into paying
customers well look no further than
email marketing so you can boost your
sales funnel with the help of email
marketing so email marketing leads to
email campaigns it leads to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so Linda thinks
this is too good to be true your telling
me is a very efficient way to generate a
return on my investment how expensive is
email marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so Linda is now very interested we've
piqued her interest she wants us to
explain email marketing to her in detail
and that's exactly what we're going to
do we're going to talk about email
marketing in detail so for everyone out
there listening what's in it for you why
are you going to invest your time in
listening to Simply learn and me talk
about email marketing because we're
going to talk about everything there is
about email marketing in today's webinar
so what is it for those that aren't
really familiar with the intricacies of
email marketing we're going to talk
about how to set up email marketing
we're going to discuss all the benefits
of email marketing we're going to get
into a b testing we're going to get into
the automation of emails the types of
emails how to engage New users and we're
going to give you a demo so there's a
lot going on in this webinar like I said
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about what what is email marketing so as
I mentioned to Linda it's an efficient
way to convert leads into sales why
because we can send personalized emails
to a specific audience a targeted
audience if somebody's interested in our
product we can reach out to them via
email it can also be used to remarket
pre-qualified leads so anybody who's
pre-qualified we can go ahead and
communicate with them as well so email
marketing is a very effective at
different stages in the funnel okay so
when I say funnel customer life cycle so
we have awareness consideration purchase
retention and advocacy okay so let's
talk about each one of these parts of
the final or customer life cycle if you
will so let's start with awareness at
the very top so email marketing allows
customers to recognize their problems
after which you can educate them on how
your brand can solve them okay just like
any other marketing channel somebody's
looking for something a need of
something and we can come to the rescue
in this case we're going to come to the
rescue with email and we can go ahead
and educate them on on what their need
is and how we can collaborate with them
help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay so that's
what email is going to do we're going to
communicate with them via email and
we're going to bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so if we're running a
Cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for Relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer Smooths hydrates and
contains SPF 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
let's talk about purchase the next step
in the life cycle well purchase well
with purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off a moisturizer is pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products they were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
life cycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay they've already purchased how do we
get them purchased again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in
their inventory so what do we do we're
going to send an email we're going to
see an email to active customers okay
we're gonna give them an offer just for
them exclusively just for them in this
example we're gonna give them a combo
pack a facial kit at just 39 and get a
sunscreen worth ten dollars for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers he is
the offers exclusively just for those
who you want to Target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer then what
we want to do is advocacy last step in
that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
Advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those kind customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite non-profit could be educating
for children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our non-profit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy our product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with Friends it
can be that extra incentive of giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends buy okay so
this is the customer life cycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the life cycle so let's talk about the
benefits of email marketing so what are
some of the benefits well we've already
mentioned to Linda that it's cost
effective it's time saving real-time
marketing less intrusive builds
credibility increases visibility and
brand awareness and it's an easy way to
track Roi these are all the benefits for
email marketing we're going to go talk
about some of these now so basically
when we talk about cost effective you
know some email marketing platforms
charge based on the number of users who
you send the email to time saving well
you saw how quick it took me to set up
that email campaign the key is figuring
out who you want to send it to when we
talk about real-time marketing you know
we're sending this email out basically
in real time trying to meet our
customers needs at the right time it's
less intrusive because we can customize
the emails okay we can as you saw I can
put first name in there to make it more
personal so when something's more
personal it's less intrusive especially
if it's a segment that already knows
your brand okay builds credibility hey
we gain credibility when we offer
exclusive offers to repeat customers or
you know try and build advocacy by
working with non-profits okay it
increases visibility and brand awareness
why because you know we could send our
email out to a large group of people and
that's a good way to generate brand
awareness and as you saw we can easily
measure you know not only open rates
click rates but Roi so how how many
people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email today we're
going to talk about affiliate marketing
so let's jump right into it and take a
look inside an office environment right
now we have Chuck here Chuck's doing a
little bit of pacing John walks in the
office hey man what's with all the
pacing everything all right Chuck
responded hey I'm just worried that I
might have exhausted every way we can
advertise our product I mean I've done
SEO I've done paid search I've done
email I've done social man nothing's
working I gotta come up with something
new ASAP well John responds hey don't
worry I think I've got your solution for
you man hang tight relax take a load off
here's my solution affiliate marketing
first off before you ask the question
what's affiliate marketing let's talk
about why we need affiliate marketing so
let's dig into affiliate marketing so
John's just taking over now and he's
gonna let Chuck know everything there is
to know about affiliate marketing so the
first question John answers for Chuck
what is affiliate marketing so affiliate
marketing is a form of digital marketing
that involves a merchant it involves a
merchant paying commissions to a website
or other entities so if I'm selling a
product basically somebody else sells
that product for me I'm gonna pay that
person a commission for selling my
product it's that simple that's what
affiliate marketing is okay so basically
what these margins are doing or other
entities they're advertising your
product so they're advertising your
product with a referral so they're
passing on their own customers to you so
that they can buy your product and again
the exchanges you give that website or
other entity a commission that's more or
less what affiliate marketing is so
John's gonna have us take a look at each
of these components of affiliate
marketing in detail take it away John so
John says first we have the merchant AKA
The Brand the seller the Creator the
founder the owner the inspiration the
innovator hey this is the person who
came up with this brilliant idea This
brilliant idea has to get out there
we're the merchant we're trying to get
this brilliant idea out to the masses so
this is the component of affiliate
marketing that creates the product the
merchant could be anyone okay so it
could be startups it's a large
multinational companies International
companies non-profits for-profits
individuals independent contractors
Freelancers a group of people who have a
passion for something okay it could be
anybody there's no limit the affiliate
aka the publisher so the affiliate is
basically that third party website or
entity which promotes the merchants
products and tries to give invents
potential customers of the merchants
products value so this affiliate going
to represent the merchant on their
behalf and try and get their clients to
basically purchase that particular
Merchant's product so the affiliate
could be incentivized based on you know
registrations email sign ups sales and
subscriptions so it doesn't always come
down to you know sales you know if I'm
just trying to get you know build my
email list then hey I can incentivize
that affiliate to push email signups if
I'm got this big you know offline you
know promotion that I'm doing at this
particular mall and I want to get people
there well I can get an affiliate and
incentivize that affiliate to drive and
help me drive registrations for this
event so it doesn't always have to be
sales per se so in effect you the
merchant and the affiliate work out some
type of commission deal based on what
you're incentivizing so the relationship
between the affiliate and the merchant
is made possible with the help of an
affiliate Network so that's the third
component here we need somebody to bring
the two together that Merchant who has
This brilliant idea and the affiliate
who has potential customers that could
potentially Drive registrations sales
signups Etc to the merchant so the
affiliate network is the one who brings
the two together so the affiliate
Network in effect acts as the middleman
the person in between the merchants and
Affiliates it allows Merchants to find
and collaborate with not just any
affiliate but the affiliate best suited
for their particular brand and product
because you want to find somebody who is
going to be passionate who's relevant
who has your prospective customers in
mind because they're the ones that are
going to help those protective customers
purchase your product so that's what the
affiliate network does it helps bring
the merchants and Affiliates together so
that the affiliate can help advertise
and sell on behalf of the merchant so
with the affiliate Network Merchants can
use tools for tracking and Reporting and
processing payments for Affiliates so
really that affiliate network is the
glue that holds it all together they're
not just one to introduce a merchant and
affiliate they offer it all so as a
merchant you want to be able to manage
your Affiliates so you're not going to
have one affiliate you're going to have
multiple Affiliates so you want to be
able to use the appropriate tools
available to you in the affiliate
Network to see and track how sales are
going and when sales happen okay or
commissions happen you want to be able
to use that affiliate Network to
compensate that affiliate appropriately
and then finally the customer customer
aka the consumer is the most important
component of all of this take it away
John so the consumer is the final and
most important component without
customers to buy products the merchant
would not have any revenue and the
affiliate would not get any commission
so we need customers so John what is the
process of affiliate marketing well John
says let's have a look at the process so
it's affiliate marketing time so we're
going to use a tool or platform like
Commission Junction Commission Junction
is a popular you know platform that
affiliate Network platform that brings
merchants and Affiliates together so the
merchants can use those Affiliates to
advertise their product so let's take a
look at Commission Junction as a good
digital marketing tool for affiliate
marketing so we're going to use
Commission Junction as an example here
remember at affiliate marketing it's an
ecosystem between Publishers and
Merchants so remember Merchants are
selling products Publishers are selling
those Merchant products on their site
and so Commission Junction is the
middleman Center to speak okay so
Commission Junction just known as CJ now
is the middle person they're introducing
the publisher and the merchant and so
let's go ahead and log in here so when
you log in like any other digital
marketing tool any other platform you're
going to have your own settings and
whatnot so really the whole idea behind
any affiliate marketing tool is really
there to manage your Publishers who do
you want as a publisher who do you want
selling your product you obviously want
somebody who's relevant somebody who's
going to be able to sell the product
somebody who has a targeted audience
that's similar to yours okay so we go
into cj.com we're going to log in and
here you can see a Publisher's link so
we're going to click on the Publishers
link and remember when you sign up
Publishers you have to have program
terms and so if we click on Publishers
program terms we're going to be able to
see all the different program terms
available so here we could see the
different program turns we have set up
for certain Publishers so we just click
on that we'll be able to see that's the
default program term so remember you
could set up your own program term for
any publisher so as a best practice if
you have Publishers who are actually
performing well who are selling your
products maybe you want to offer them a
little bit more on the commission side
maybe you want to sweeten the deal maybe
you know These Guys these Publishers get
better program terms versus say other
Publishers who don't and so here we can
see the program terms basically you can
see what the terms are the action and
the different policies here so
everything you need to do to manage that
publisher in terms of payment is done
under the program terms now if the
program terms are met the publisher
actually sells your products CJ is the
broker they're the the ones who are
going to initiate the payment based on
the program terms so be careful in the
program terms you want to be able to set
them appropriately CJ has templates CJ
has some default program terms that you
could use and offer up to different
Publishers So based on the program terms
that's how your Publishers are going to
get paid and so here you can have as
many different program terms as you want
There's No Limit here you want to be
able to align and reward program terms
again based on performance and so here
we can see what Publishers are under
what program terms so again if your
publisher is performing well sweeten the
deal offer them a better program terms
and so you can align Publishers with
different program terms and so that's
the whole idea behind program terms is
you want to be able to align Publishers
with that so when you sign sign up a
publisher they're going to get a line
with a program term meaning what are
they going to get paid for selling your
product now if we want to manage by
status instead of by program terms we
could see all the different
organizations we have in our Network
these are our Publishers we're the
affiliate we're the ones selling the
product we want to know who's selling
who's not selling and so we can look at
all our Publishers by program terms or
by status okay so basically you can see
here the term status whether it's active
or not earnings basically what they've
sold over the last basically seven days
or three months so you could look at
basically how your Publishers are
performing just by clicking on manage by
status here in cg.com so when you're
looking at reports in cj.com or really
any other affiliate a program you might
see the acronym EPC this stands for
earnings per click actually it's a
little misleading it's actually earnings
per 100 clicks so basically CJ
calculates you know how much are
publisher is actually making per click
you know just like paid search for
paying Google X amount per click it's
the same thing here we can't or these
Publishers can't make any money if they
don't generate clicks so that's why you
have an EPC model or metric so to speak
so you can measure earnings per click CJ
does it over seven a period and over a
three month period so you could sort
based on seven day or three months to
see who's earning the most per click in
terms of Publishers now you can select
under Publishers groups now you can
group your Publishers okay so if you
have say a group of Publishers in a
specific region like the United States
or India or if you're just focused on
the United States and say you have
Publishers in different states like
Texas California Missouri Arkansas well
you can group those Publishers into
different groups and you can look at
your different group names here so here
we could see Canada and so we have our
Publishers grouped into a group called
Canada why because they're based in
Canada makes sense so you want to be
able to organize your Publishers because
the whole idea Beyond affiliate
marketing CJ is you want to be able to
get the best Publishers available for
your network and so as you get more
Publishers for your network you'll be
able to basically start grouping them
where it makes sense now the example I
gave you is by geography you could do by
geography or you could do by publisher
status meaning my best performing
Publishers go into a group if they're in
a group then they get a line with a
certain program term so you could group
your Publishers Any Way You Want by
status meaning they're selling more
these are our best performing Publishers
or by region or you know by promotion I
mean how you group your Publishers is
totally up to you however take advantage
of the option to create publisher groups
because the whole idea again I'm going
to repeat it is you want to get
Publishers and you want to start
building your base of Publishers because
the more Publishers you have the more
chance you are to sell your product
remember if nobody clicks on your
product then nobody's going to buy your
product so if you have Publishers who
are promoting your product for you then
you have a good opportunity to sell it
so the more publishes you have on board
the better the opportunity so now once
you have Publishers you can start
grouping these Publishers accordingly to
whatever make sense it's a business
decision just know the options available
in CJ to group Publishers now when
you're in CJ and you're starting out
okay you want to start recruiting your
publisher so you click on recruit and
based on your settings based on what
you're selling CJ is going to try and
put you in front of some good Publishers
and so here we could see if we click on
recruit we're going to get a list of
Publishers and this search results list
of Publishers that we can recruit into
our Network are all listed here and you
can actually see what's interesting you
can see the name of the publisher and
you can see the URL and then you can
actually see if they're a good performer
or not so you could actually see their
history as a publisher just by looking
at their Network earnings and then also
looking at their seven day earnings per
class effect or three month earnings per
click and so if a publisher has a very
high earnings per click EPC then they're
probably a good publisher somebody
you're probably going to be interested
in so if I see a publisher with you know
three months earnings per click of 105
then that means say if that's my
publisher I'm paying 105 or 106 over
seven days you know they're generating
some clicks for me and they're
generating sales you can't deliver
commission if they don't sell and so to
me I want to be able to look at the
seven three month earnings per click for
these Publishers and so I can just click
on any one of these Publishers here and
get some more insight about that
publisher right here in CJ so here I can
see the particular URL the company some
other URLs that they have associated
with them in CJ I could see the category
that they're in again I can see the
seven three month EPC here you can see
description okay you can see some other
promotional methods that they'd use when
promoting products and you get some
program performance from this particular
publisher just by pulling down the pull
down menu here I'm going to look at this
year and see what the performance is and
why I'm waiting for that to load I could
see hey they're also in other countries
as well so I can get a good snapshot of
a particular publisher by recruiting
Publishers seeing what their
performances over a period of time and
potentially you know recruiting that
publisher would be part of my network
because if they're part of my network
then hey if they're selling products if
I'm selling products and I want my
product on their site and they're doing
a good job of selling other products
then I want them to be you know part of
my ecosystem part of my network now
remember remember CJ is doing the
introducing here they are introducing
you to recruits so you want to be able
to again take a look at the site does do
any of the sites that a particular
publisher has interest you you know
again we can just click on it go to the
specific site take a good look hey
Virgin Atlantic okay do we want them
selling our product maybe maybe not
um so you want to take a look at the
website make sure it's not spammy make
sure it aligns with your business goals
it makes your lines with your product
your target audience remember a lot of
things you want to make sure the website
aligns with because they're representing
your brand okay very important here very
important and so that's what you want to
be able to do and you could do all that
just by looking at the publisher detail
in CJ and then again take a look at that
earnings per click if they're selling
products for other merchants and they're
doing a good job maybe you want them
selling your product as well okay so you
can also you know sort by country you
can also do Network earnings and you can
really filter here so we want you know
choose High Network earners in a
particular country a particular State
you know we could definitely filter in
on a particular type of publisher okay
so you want to be able to hone in on
somebody to line with your geography or
you know definitely you want to align
with somebody who's a high Network owner
now when you get all your Publishers set
up you're going to need to provide them
with some good promotional materials
some good banners some you know it could
be text links some messaging okay so
you're the one who's going to provide
the Publishers with you know the
information they need now as a best
practice remember you can get on the
phone with these publishers have monthly
calls or quarterly calls see what they
need you know reach out to them via
email or reach out to them via the CJ
platform figure out hey you know how's
your banners working for you do you need
new banners so you want to be able to
constantly you know push new content out
and so if I click on links here and
manage I'll be able to see everything
that I have available for my Publishers
to use okay and then you can actually
look at banners that have actually
produced for you in terms of EPC or you
know if it's a specific promotion okay
you could set that up here so you could
be able to see it here you can see all
the banners you can see some text links
in here so all the you know advertising
that you want these Publishers to have
is going to be situated under links and
so you can see what the active ones are
you can look at archived you can look at
again text links content links or
banners and as a best practice if I
click on a banner as a best practice
ideally what you want to do is use UTM
tracking okay so you want to have some
type of tracking in place however CJ
does a lot of the tracking for you so
they're going to be able to tell you how
many times a Banner's been clicked and
how many times have Banner's been seen
okay they'll also tell you more
importantly Not only was that Banner
click but did it generate a sale and so
here I can see that I have three
Publishers using this particular banner
I could see over this period of time 412
Impressions meaning 412 people viewed
the banner and I received one click on
it so you can get some in-depth detail
about your different marketing materials
and how they're performing okay you can
also see what Publishers are using them
okay so the key here is you want to be
able to communicate with your Publishers
give them the promotional material and
that they need to promote your product
now you could set up specifically you
could set up a unique Banner for a
publisher or you could set up a banner
for a group of Publishers that's where
the group comes in so you have some
options here and then as a best practice
what I would try and do as you can see
here is come up with different Banner
sizes so you can see here we got a 728
by 90. okay you gotta have 160 by 600.
you got a 300 by 250 okay so you want to
have different Banner sizes and you also
want to mix in some text ads as well
okay you want to be able to give your
Publishers some options in terms of what
to use on their websites so that's the
whole idea because a publisher may not
have space on the home page they may
only have enough space for you know a
text ad or a 300 by 25 50. so you want
to be able to mix it up and then also
mix up the messaging as well so you can
have the same 300 250 Banner but you can
have different messaging just like you
see here 300 by 250 got this messaging
here and we got a different set of
messaging with the same Banner size so
the more options you present for
yourself the more of an opportunity you
have for the publisher to use that
messaging that Banner that text that on
their website and then that gives you a
better opportunity to get the click get
the conversion that you seek out so that
is links so you want to be able to
continue to push out different banners
and text ads now CJ also has a great
feature in here if you're selling a lot
of products you have a large inventory
of products you could actually upload a
product feed to CJ so you can see in
this example we don't but but if you did
let's just say you have a hundred
products that you want to sell you can
go ahead and upload that fee to CJ and
then the publisher will be able to use
that entirety and it's of the feed or
pick and choose different products to
use and sell so let's jump over to
reports and CJ you have reports so this
is really the bulk of where you want to
be spending your time because you want
to be able to you know not only recruit
those Publishers but after you recruit
them you want to be able to see the
performance how are things moving are
are Publishers moving product are they
generating clicks are they selling your
products so go no further than reports
right here at the top navigation we're
going to click on performance reports
and so we want to be able to see over a
period of time you know are we selling
our product and here you can see over
the last 30 days you can see how much
commission was paid out remember CJ gets
a fee they're the broker okay so that's
part of the program terms okay so it's
based on program terms who's selling
okay what program term are they
associated with CJ gets their commission
okay so you can see the total commission
and then the sale amount okay so we
could see how many sales were generated
how many items were sold how many clicks
were generated how many Impressions so I
can get a good sense here day by day
over who's selling who's not selling and
it's all broken down at the very end to
earnings per click so that's my
performance report so we want to be able
to see over a period of time you know
are we selling now I can go into detail
if I click on transaction here from the
pull down menu I can look at a specific
order I can choose a specific publisher
or website and I can get details about
that specific order publisher website
Etc just be look by choosing transaction
so I can get really granular about the
data I see for specific transaction
that's just by clicking reports
transaction now you can also click on
promo codes and if you're running a
promo codes for your Publishers you'll
be able to see how many conversions
those promo codes delivered and the
total sale amount over the last 30 days
so building a network is all about
recruiting the right Publishers giving
them the materials they need measuring
the performance of the Publishers and
then communicating it's just so key so
CJ has a nice message Center built in so
you can actually you know look at the
messages you're getting from your
Publishers and turn around and
communicate with them so communicate
seamlessly and efficiently write in CJ
here so I just clicked on mail and we
could see see the messages we have so
you can also click on email campaigns
and if you have any email campaigns that
you want to run you can look at them
right here in CJ so CJ offers up some
email campaigns then we can see how many
people we targeted you know how many
people opened it and how many people
joined in this case joined our Network
so here we have you know a breakdown of
each of the email campaigns that we've
run over a period of time and their
status and how many people were
targeting and opens deliveries Etc so if
you want to run an email campaign right
in CJ it's available to you as part of
the platform so if we move over from
mail to placements we have an
opportunity to place some promotional
material on a Publisher's website and so
here we could see a breakdown of
different publishers who basically will
offer up some promotional material that
we can leverage okay so here you got
this particular promotional placement
it's a one month placement and review
page with your ad so we can actually you
know take advantage of what Publishers
are offering up on their own website so
the whole idea here is if it's in a
prime position on their website then we
can take advantage of that so then what
we want to be able to do is if we like
what they're offering up you can see hey
this particular publisher is saying they
have a creative the placement is a home
page Banner or full page review provide
an email with a copy of the ad that
you'd like to be displayed and we're
going to email this person here so if we
want to take advantage of a specific
promotional placement on a Publisher's
website then we can do that just by
clicking on placements and we'll be able
to see who's offering up what notice
there's a fee involved so it just gives
you an opportunity to reward a publisher
that's performing well for you and if
they turn around and offer you a better
placement for a little bit more money it
might be worth it so the whole idea is
to take advantage of placements because
if your product isn't placed properly
then nobody's going to see it if nobody
sees it then you know they're not going
to click on it and then you're not going
to get sales so that's a whole idea here
is take advantage of what Publishers are
offering up in terms of promotional
opportunities so CJ also has a pay per
call click model as well pay model so
basically your paper performance is
based on calls so basically the whole
point here is a CJ points out you want
to promote more High ticket and
consultative products and services you
want to expand your reach and you want
to get more qualified sales then you can
offer up a pay per call and the beauty
here here is CJ tracks the calls so you
will be able to see the actual phone
number and calls so instead of offering
up say you know Banner with a click you
can offer a you know promotional number
and have CJ track the calls from the
publisher and that just opens up another
opportunity for you to give your
Publishers an option to have people call
if they call then great you know it's
another way for somebody to get in touch
and purchase the product so the
pay-per-call method is available under
CJ as well so if we want to get more
insights about how our program is
performing we just click on the insights
CJ is going to take us to this overview
this dashboard if you will with some
really good data based on a time frame
okay so we're comparing July through of
July of 19 through July of 2018. we're
able to see Revenue and commissions paid
out and how many clicks average order
value so it's kind of an overview
dashboard if you will about how our
overall program is performing there are
other similar tools and resources to
include you know Max Bounty trade
doubler Amazon Associates there's plenty
of networks out there you want to find a
network where you're going to have
Affiliates that are going to be
passionate and going to be relevant and
have the prospective audience that you
need to sell your product so do your due
diligence on the number of different
platforms out there and with that we
have come to the end of this digital
marketing full course for 2021 I hope it
was informative and interesting if you
have any questions about the topics
covered in this video please ask away in
the comment section below our team will
help you solve your queries thanks for
watching stay safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here